hello everyone and welcome to the
complete android app development master
class my name is masam i'm a
professional android app developer and
i'm going to be your instructor for this
course before starting the course let's
talk about it for a few minutes this
course is about 15 hours and by watching
it you are going to learn a lot about
android app development but it is
impossible to cover everything in just
15 hours for that i've recorded an
extended version of this course which is
about 60 hours and in that you are going
to learn everything that you need for a
successful career in android app
development you can find the extended
course by clicking on the link down
below this video let's see what we are
going to cover in this video in this 15
hours you will start from the very
beginning that means that even if you
don't have any prior experience in
programming you are going to do just
fine we will cover everything in the
course in the first section of the
course you will set up the environment
that you need for android app
development that includes installing
java development kit android studio
software development kit for android app
development and the emulator for testing
your applications besides setting up the
environment in the first section you
will create a small application to get
familiar with android app development
and each piece in an android application
in the second section of this course you
will learn java language java is the
most popular language for making android
applications and in this section we will
take a deep look at that you will learn
about different variables and operators
loops and conditional statements
different collections in java
concurrency and trading handling
exceptions singleton pattern and a lot
more you will also learn about object
oriented programming in java that
includes things like classes and
interfaces inner classes and abstract
classes inheritance and polymorphism and
a lot more we will end this section with
a challenge so to make sure that you
have learned everything we have talked
about in the next section you will learn
about user interfaces you will learn
about how to design modern layouts for
your applications in this section we
will talk about things like buttons and
text views different layouts working
with images and fonts showing a list of
items with list view and recycler view
we will talk about snack bars and card
views adding animations to your
applications and last but not least we
will talk about material design in
android once again we will end this
section with a challenge so to make sure
that you have learned everything after
learning java and designing user
interfaces you have the ability to
create a lot of applications in the
final section of this course we will
create one real world application from
scratch we will combine all of our
knowledge about android app development
and we will create this application
together in this section beside
practicing everything you have learned
so far you will learn about a lot more
topics for instance you will learn about
persisting your data with shared
preferences and also you will learn how
to show different websites in your
application and of course a lot more you
can also include this application in
your portfolio if you want
we are going to set up the environment
that we need in order to create android
applications we are going to install few
things first of all we are going to
install java development kit or as some
might call it jdk after that we are
going to install android studio and
after everything we are going to create
a virtual device in order to test our
android applications as you can see i
have already downloaded jdk and android
studio let's also see where we can get
them from for jdk you can simply search
for java jdk and a link from oracle
website should pop up the first link
from the oracle web page is probably our
needed link as you can see we are going
to download and install jdk version 8.
it's going to be enough for our purposes
in this course
down in here first of all we need to
agree to the license agreement and after
that depending on your operating system
you can download one of these versions
i'm on windows so i'm going to download
and install this windows x64 version if
you are not sure about this x86 or x64
you can right click on your my computer
on your desktop in properties and here
you can see the architecture of your cpu
mine is 64 bit for you it might be x86
depending on that select one of these
two files just click on this download
and the download should be started
sometimes like here it might ask you to
log into your oracle account let's do
that creating an oracle account is free
and you won't be charged okay let's
select sign in and as you can see the
download has begin
i'm going to select canceling here
because i have downloaded the jdk
previously let's select that it's going
to be a really simple
installation process let's select next
once again next
once again let's click on next
and as you can see we have successfully
installed jdk let's click on this cloud
if you want to make sure that you have
installed java jdk successfully you can
always go to your command prompt by
going to start menu and typing cmd in
here you can type java
dash version
as you can see we are seeing some
information about the version of java
installed on our system as long as it's
1.8 and higher we are good to go let's
close our command prompt next we are
going to download android the studio for
that we can go to developer.android.com
let's see
developer.android.com
during the course we will come back to
this website a lot because this is the
official website for android developers
okay for downloading android studio just
go to this android studio tab
and from here you can download one of
the versions
if you don't see your version of
operating system you can click on this
download options but in here i'm just
going to
click on the download let's say download
android studio
we need to agree to the terms and
conditions
and as you can see the download has
started once again i'm going to select
cancel in here because i have already
downloaded android studio after the
download is finished just click on that
once again this is going to be a simple
installation process let's select next
in here make sure to check this android
virtual device let's select next in here
you need to select a path to install
android studio notice that installing
android studio and all of its sdks and
also emulators sometimes might take
something like 20 or even 40 gigabytes
so make sure to have at least 20
gigabytes on the drive that you are
going to install your android studio
after that let's select next and install
after the installation is finished just
click on this next and let's start our
android studio
don't worry about these three projects
that i have in here basically these are
the recent projects that i was working
on i have android studio installed on my
system previously and i uninstalled it
for this video but for you this list
should be empty also along the way of
installing android studio you might see
some windows about selecting a theme or
other preferences i didn't see them
because i have installed android studio
previously on my system
those are not important depending on
your preferences select one just if you
see something like installing sdk
uncheck that because we are going to
install it in here together in order to
install sdk you can come to this
configuring here and you can select this
sdk manager
sdk stands for software development kit
and for developing android applications
you need to install at least one sdk
once again as you can see i have
installed two sdks in here android 10
and android 9 apis but for you this list
should be empty and none of these should
be checked first of all let's check this
show package details in order to see the
package details for every sdk by the
time i'm recording this video the latest
version of android is android 10 or api
level 29 to be precise i suggest that
you always install the latest version
but sometimes there might be some
preview versions in here i don't suggest
installing those because those can be
buggy and
those are not yet released on a stable
channel so make sure to install the
latest stable version if you want you
can install the complete sdk but i don't
suggest that because these can be memory
and hard drive consuming and these can
occupy a lot of storage on your device
but the necessary things in here is
first of all android sdk versions
whatever the version of your api is so
the first one also the sources for that
version of sdk the second option also i
suggest that depending on the
architecture of your system select one
of these two version of atom mine was 64
architecture so i'm going to select this
one if you are going to work with
different google apis for example if you
are going to work with
google map or youtube apis
and check one of these for example
this google apis for
atom 64 and also check one of these two
google api versions this is going to
install at least one sdk on my system
the android 10 or api level 29 but if
you want you can select and install
multiple sdk versions basically this sdk
versions and apis means that in what
version of android are you going to run
and test your applications later on we
will see that when we are going to run
our application on a virtual device we
are going to need at least one sdk
installing multiple sdks can be memory
consuming and also hard drive consuming
but if you have the resources i suggest
that you at least install the latest
version after that
install this api level 29 because there
were a lot of changes specifically in
the data storage structure also
installed api level 28 down in here
install api level 26
and after that level 21 and also 19.
because
in this version of sdks there were a lot
of changes and i'm just saying this
because of my experience in android app
development but if you don't have the
proper resources selecting one of these
is going to be just fine after selecting
what you need in here just click on this
apply make sure to have a stable
internet connection because it's going
to download some stuff
let's click on this apply in here you
can see a dialog that will show you some
information about the stuff that are
going to be downloaded and also the size
of the download file let's select ok in
here and our download should be started
i'm going to skip the video in here
until the download is finished after the
downloading and installing all of the
components that you have selected before
is finished just click on this finish
and let's see what else do we have in
here okay we have successfully installed
at least one sdk let's switch to these
sdk tools and let's see what we need
from here
first of all once again check this show
package details install one of these
android sdk build tools i suggest that
install the latest version as you can
see mine is installed in here
29.0.2 at the time is the latest version
also down in here and you need to
install android emulator mine is not
updated so i'm going to update that the
next two things that are mandatory are
these sdk platform tools and sdk tools
make sure to select those two also down
in here we have this documentation for
android sdk this option is not necessary
but
it's going to help us a lot during our
journey in android app development later
on we will see that these documentations
will help us a lot when we want to debug
something or when we face some errors so
i strongly suggest to install these
documentations as well the other thing
that is not necessary but i suggest to
install is this hacksam installer it is
going to be an accelerator for the speed
of your emulator the native emulator in
android studio can be very slow
especially if you have a low memory ram
for that reason i suggest you to install
this hacksam installer but there is one
thing that i need to mention in here
i've seen a lot of students having
problem with this hacksam installer i've
seen them that they cannot install this
hacksam successfully this hacksam cannot
be installed on all of the cpus and
depending on the structure of your cpu
this hexa might not be installed but
there are some cpus especially intel
cpus that they have a special option in
the devices bios specifically for this
emulator accelerator if that's not
enabled you may want to enable that in
the bios settings as well and also if
for any reason you couldn't install this
hacksam installer this emulator
accelerator and also for that matter the
android emulator itself there is no need
to worry there is another way as well
beside the native android emulator you
can install external emulators as well
for example the one that i know that is
working very well is called genymotion
in here i'm not going to install that
but i will put a link to download
genymotion in the description of this
video and also beside all of these you
can always install and test your
applications on the real device that you
have later on in the course we will see
that how we can install and test our
applications on our mobile phones okay
after selecting everything from here
just click on apply once again once
again we are seeing the download
information like select ok and let the
download begin once again i'm going to
skip the video in here until the
download is finished once again when the
download and installing is finished just
click on this finish and we have
successfully installed sdk platforms and
sdk tools just before i close this
window let's switch to this appearance
in here from here you can change all of
the preferences
that you want for example you can change
the theme dracula is a the dark team
also we have this high contrast theme
the intellij theme is the light team i'm
going to stay with that because it's
good for recording purposes if you want
you can use custom fonts for the fonts
of your windows from here you can also
change the size of your font i'm not
going to do that also down in here you
can change the font size also for the
presentation mode if you want to change
the size of your codes you can search
for font in here i believe it's in this
editor tab in here in this font you can
see that mine is 18 you can increase or
decrease that if you want okay let's
delete this one
and also let's minimize this editor i
have another suggestion for you in here
as well in this appearance inside the
system settings inside the updates make
sure that your updates are being checked
from a stable channel we have other
channels like developer channels and
beta channels as well make sure that you
have the stable channel others can be
buggy okay that's it for installing sdk
we will be coming back to this setting
menu later on let's select okay okay now
it's time to install at least one
emulator for that we can once again
select this configure this time we can
click on this avd manager avd stands for
android virtual device
as you can see once again i have two
devices installed in here pixel 2 and
pixel 3. this list should be empty for
you but because i had android studio
installed on my system i can see them
let's select this create virtual device
in order to create a new virtual device
first of all you can create your own and
customize the hardware by selecting this
new hardware profile
from here you can name your device
you can select that if it's a phone or
tablet you can set the screen size and
resolution also then in here you can
specify some ram to it and all sorts of
sensors and hardwares
i'm not going to create my customized
device instead i'm going to install
one of the predefined devices as you can
see i have pixel 2 and pixel 3 in here
let's select another device from here
also from this left panel you can see
all sorts of devices like tv veriz and
tablets let's select one device from
here i don't even know all of these
devices let's just select this pixel xl
select next okay from here you need to
specify the android version that is
going to be installed on this device i'm
going to install android q or api level
29 on this device so we need to download
that first let's select download once
again i think it's going to be a large
file so i'm going to skip the download
in here until the download is finished
yes it's 1.1 gigabyte okay the download
and installing is finished just click on
finish now we can select the downloaded
api sometimes you might not see the
version of api that you are looking for
for that first of all you can always
refresh this list after that you can
check the second tab and also the third
tab
but we are going to install
android queue on our device let's select
next in here we can customize our device
for example we can change the name of
our device we can also change the
default orientation for example the
landscape and portrait i'm going to save
it portrait
in this show advanced settings we can do
some more customization for example you
can change the camera the network
also down in here you can change the
size of ram and sd card and all sort of
customization i'm not going to change
any of these i'm just going to click on
this finish
and as simple as that we have installed
a new emulator on our device okay let's
close this window okay i think it's a
good point to finish off this video in
this video we have installed jdk we have
installed android studio after that we
have installed sdk and we have done some
customization on the appearance and
after everything we have installed a new
virtual device
we are going to create our first
application you can do so by opening
android studio and selecting this start
a new android studio project
first of all in this window we can see
some templates these templates are just
some small applications that have some
codes written to some level for example
in this basic activity you can see that
we have a small button and also a menu
above in here we can see other templates
in here for example a template for
google maps we have a template for
navigation drawer
don't worry about all of these because
we will learn how to create all of these
elements ourselves later on even we
select this add no activity template but
the android team are nice guys and they
have provided us these templates in a
lot of these templates you can see the
word activity don't worry about this
activity yet if you remember from the
content videos i said that we are going
to have an entire session which we will
talk about activities and fragments but
for now you can think of activities as
different part of your application for
example if your application has
different pages an activity is one of
those pages this definition is not
accurate it might not even be correct
but
for now we can think of an activity as a
page of our application in our first
application i'm going to save it this
empty activity which has no element it's
just going to create some files for us
but if you want to save it at no
activity you can do so as well once
again later on we will see that how we
can create all of these templates
ourselves okay let's select empty
activity and let's hit next in here we
need to provide some information about
our application for example the name of
our application
i'm going to change the name of my
application to let's say hello world
as it's a custom among developers to
name their first project hello world
just for no reason the second part you
will define the package name for your
application this package name should be
unique to every application that is
being released into the world later on
when you want to publish your
application to play store
your application will be identified with
this package name the convention in here
is to provide the name of your website
in backward for example my website is
called mako.org so my package name is
org dot mako dot the name of my project
don't worry if you don't have any
website if you don't you can use
something like com.example
let's say com.
example.the name of my project but since
i have a website i'm going to use that
in here i'm going to say org.maker
once again this package name should be
unique to every application
after that you need to define the path
that you want to save your project if
you want you can change this path by
selecting this folder in here and select
the path but in here i'm not going to
change that
after that you can select the language
that you are going to work with
android applications can be written with
java language and also kotlin language
in this course we are going to save it
java but if you want i am currently
recording a new course about uh
developing android applications with
kotlin and feel free to check that if
you want but
let's select java in here
after that you need to define a minimum
api level this minimum api level in here
means that how many older android
devices can install your application for
example if you click on this drop down
in here you can see the list of
different api levels right now the
minimum api level that i can select is
14 but i can go up to api level 29 or
android 10 to be precise there is a
balance in here if you select your
minimum api level very high you can work
with a lot of newer functionalities in
android but fewer devices will be able
to install your android applications for
example if i select api level 29 which
is the latest version only less than one
percent of the devices can install my
application if i select something like
you can see that 95 percent of devices
by this time can install my application
you as the developer should decide this
balance for this course probably we are
going to stay with api level 19 for most
of our projects because i think it's a
good balance and
95 is a good number leave this check
empty for now
also using android x artifacts is
mandatory uh since few months ago we
will talk about it later on in the
course let's hit finish and let's create
our first project
if it's the first time that you are
creating your android applications uh
this process can be very slow because
android studio is going to download some
stuff for example the gradle file
from internet so for that reason this
process can be slow if it's the first
time that you are creating your
application the first thing in here that
is noticeable is that android studio
have created two files for us this
activitymain.xml file
and this mainactivity.java file these
have been created because we have
selected that empty activity template
when we have created our project inside
each of these files there are some codes
once again we can create all of these
codes if we don't select that empty
activity but
if you select that
you can have some codes written to some
level the other thing in here is this
build pane down in here this build pane
in here will show the progress of
building your android applications
whenever you want to run your android
application
whether that is in the debug mode which
we will be working in our entire course
or whether it's in the production level
this building here will show the
progress of building your android
applications i'm going to minimize it
for now and let's talk about all the
other stuff that we are seeing in here
first of all let's talk about this
project painting here i can minimize and
maximize that
also topping here we have multiple
options for example we have this project
option
this project option will exactly show
the structure of files on your system
for example you can maximize
every folder if you want to have access
to this mainactivity.java file you can
go to app folder inside the sources
inside the main folder inside the java
folder you can see that we have a folder
in here
in which contains the main activity java
file this is the exact hierarchy of
files on our system if you want to make
sure of that you can right click on the
name of your project
and select showing explorer this option
in here it will open the explorer on
your windows you can see that we have a
hello world project don't worry about
the others
inside this project as you can see
in the hierarchy we have this app folder
inside this app folder we have a source
folder main folder java folder
org make code and load and this is the
java file that we are seeing in here so
this project view will show the exact
hierarchy of different files on your
system there is another view in here and
that's called android view we are going
to save it android view for the most of
this course because it's much more easy
for eyes to follow as you can see we
have this app folder
inside that we have this java folder
we have this package name and inside
that we have this main activity that's
java file it's much more easy for eyes
to follow different files also beside
this app folder we have these gradle
scripts down in here as well before i
talk about these gradle scripts i need
to talk about the structure of every
android application so in most android
applications there are at least two
different kind of files the layout files
which will define the looks of your
application
the layout files in android are called
xml you can see this
activitymain.xml file if you click on
that
you can see
the layout of your application right now
it has only one simple text the other
part of every android application
is the java file if you are developing
in kotlin language there are kotlin
files the java or kotlin file in most
cases will define the logic of your
application for example what happens if
you click on a button or what to do with
the user's inputs all of those will be
handled in the java or kotlin files
beside the layout files and java files
in every android applications there
might be some other files for example
you may have some images and also some
audio files as well those will be inside
this resources folder for example inside
the mipmap folders right now we have uh
an icon for our application which is
this simple android icon other images or
other files can be put inside this
resources folder as well basically this
resources folder is for the static
variables or static files on your
application so these are the three main
components of every android application
we have layouts we have the java file
and also we have the static files beside
this we have this manifest file inside
the manifest folder this manifest file
will
specify some general properties for your
application for example you can see the
icon of your application in here also
you can see the name of your application
which is hello world in this case
and some other properties or features
about your application we will talk
about this manifest file later on in the
course but for now let's close it we
have all of these different files in
every android application but
for example when you are going to
download some application from the
player store you will see that we have
only one file one apk file that's the
final application that will be released
how are we going to generate that apk
file well in that case this gradle tool
in here is going to be useful gradle is
a build tool that will combine all of
these files and other files and will
create
an apk file no matter if you want to
release your application or if you want
to test your application on an emulator
you are going to need grader for that
reason we are going to work extensively
with gradle the other use of gradle is
that if you want to use other people's
code in your project as well for example
if you want to use youtube player in
your project you will add its dependency
inside this build.gradle file down in
here just by writing one line of code
gradle will download the code for
youtube video player as simple as that
gradle will add the youtube player code
to your project and after that you can
use it so gradle is a build tool that
will handle the combination of every
file and also other codes and will
generate an apk file we will talk about
different gradle scripts later on in the
course okay let's close all of these
extra files okay this was the project
pane we can minimize or maximize this
pain from here let's minimize that and
let's talk about other pains available
in android studio down in here you have
some useful panes as well for example
this to do is very helpful when you are
creating or when you are developing
android applications to those are some
works that you don't want to do at the
time but you don't want to forget those
works for example inside this main
activity
i can add a to-do as simple as that i
can say to do let's say complete this
it's just for the developers to remind
themselves or other colleagues to do
something later on as you can see this
studio has been added inside this to-do
pane as well
if you want you can check that it says
that it's inside the main activity later
on we will talk about how we can define
to-do's and also other kind of comments
so this is one of the other paints the
other one is this terminal down in here
this terminal is like the command prompt
in windows or let's say terminal in
linux or mac and it's very helpful if
you are working with something like adb
or android debug bridge later on we will
see the use of atp in our projects also
it's very useful
for working with sqlite databases we
will work extensively with this terminal
in the database session after that we
have this build tooling here we have
seen it when we have created our project
you can see the progress of every
application when it's going to be built
in a lot of cases there might be some
problem when we build our project and
from here you can
exactly locate the problem after that we
have this logcat in here it's going to
be very helpful when we are going to
debug our android applications
in fact we are going to work a lot with
this logcat okay let's minimize all of
this for now above in here we have some
menus uh we have file edit view and all
of these and we will work with
most of them i believe in the course but
it's impossible to work with all of them
also there is one thing that i need to
say in here when you create your first
application you may get some warnings
for example a rendering warning or some
other kind of learning if you get those
probably there isn't something wrong
with your application you just need to
rebuild your project for that you can
come to this build option in here and
make your project once again in case if
you get some errors at the first time
that you create your application
sometimes newer versions of android
studio can be buggy and
creating your project once again simply
can solve your problem also there is
another option from here from fine you
can close your project and reopen it
that can be useful or in some cases you
may want to invalidate your cache and
restart android studio so if you get
those warnings or errors you can try
these three different ways in order to
overcome
the problem there is one very useful
tool that has been added to android
studio recently in the past few months
and that's called android profiler let's
add that to this pane down in here as
well we can add that by going to this
view
tool windows and profiler it's going to
be helpful for monitoring the resources
that your application is using for
example the amount of ram the cpu that
your application is using or even the
amount of network that your application
is using if we run our application we
can track the live amount of different
resources that our application is going
to use let's run our application and see
it for ourselves you can run your
application by clicking on this green
triangle from here but before that make
sure to select the current app that you
are working and also beside that make
sure to select the device in the
previous video we have created a virtual
device and we can see the list of
different virtual devices available
i'm going to run my application on pixel
3 api level 929
for no reason
let's just run it if we click on this
building here you can see the build
progress i said that even if you are
going to
debug your application or even if you
are going to
run your application at the production
process you can check the
progress of build as well
as you can see
this
emulator has been opened and we will see
our application in a few minutes also
from down in here you can see the
current status of running your
application right now it has created or
built my application successfully and
it's waiting for the device to turn on
also if you check this logcat in here
you can see that there are a lot of
things going on in here we will be using
this logcat extensively later on in the
course for different debugging purposes
let's minimize that
also if you open this profiler
you will see the live tracks of
different resources that your
application is using
let's open our emulator right now we
have this simple application
in which has a predefined text called
hello world
and if you want you can check the amount
of cpu or other kind of
resources that your application is using
it's going to be helpful when you are
not sure how much resources your
application is using
let's minimize that for now if you want
you can close your application with this
uh red button in here you can stop it
and also if you want you can turn off
your device by long pressing this
turn off button you can say power off
and your device will be shut down
as you can see we are getting some
warnings in here right now these are not
important
but if you want to check them and you
can click on this event log
and everything that happens since uh we
click on the screen triangle will be
logged in here okay let's minimize that
and let's switch back to our activity
main.xml file and we have a lot of
options in here as well right now you
can see two different views of your
application
this white one is called the design view
and this one in here is the blueprint
view there are some slight differences
between these two for example
if you have some invisible item inside
your activity that might not be visible
inside this design view but you can keep
track of that inside the blueprint view
for now i'm going to disable this
blueprint view because we are not going
to work with that just for now in order
to disable that you can click on this
stack icon
and you can say just design you can also
minimize and maximize that by pressing
this plus button in here at the left
panel in here you can drag different
elements different user interface or ui
elements
for example if you want to add a button
to your application you can simply drag
it
like this
and this button will be added to your
application as you can see right now
because this element is clicked we can
see different attributes at the right
panel we have a lot of attributes for
every user interface element the most
important one is this id above in here
this id is the unique id of your element
in which we will use it in order to have
access to this button for example from
inside our java file later on we will
talk about that if we click on our text
view you can see that we have different
attributes as well these are just a few
attributes if you want to check the list
of all of the available attributes you
can click on this all attributes and you
can see that there are a lot of them we
are going to get familiar with different
ui elements in the ui session we have
that
i think in two sessions from now after
the java session we will be talking
about user interface
in specific details also when you are
inside your xml file you have two views
design view and text view design view is
this view that we are working right now
and if we switch back to text view you
can see the exact value of every ui
element in xml code xml is a markup
language if you are a web developer you
know the concept of a markup language
html is also a markup language markup
languages are just for defining some
elements that user is going to see for
example a button or text view you can
see that there are a lot of attributes
in here that we don't know anything
about them yet we will be talking about
them later on in the course so there are
two ways of defining ui elements one is
that you drag simple items for example a
button to your design view or from the
text view you can type it you can see
that we have a button in here we can
select the whole button
and we can simply press delete and that
button will be deleted you can see that
we no longer can see that also if you
don't have this preview enabled you can
enable it from here let's just press
ctrl z in order to get back our button
and let's switch back to our design view
i'm going to define an id for this hello
text because later on inside my java
file i'm going to identify that and i'm
going to work with that so by clicking
on hello board you can see the list of
attributes at the top we have this id
we can set an id for our text view also
if you don't know the difference between
a text view edit text and all of these
don't we worry text view is just a fancy
way of saying a simple text you can
define the id whatever you want for
example in here i'm going to say txt
message but notice that there are some
conventions in here you can't use spaces
when you are going to define an id also
beside that you can't use some weird
characters like a dollar sign or a
hashtag sign the other convention in
here is that you type the first letter
in lower cases for example this t in
here is layer cases and also after the
first word you type the first letter of
the second word
in capital letters for example we have
this m in here there are some just basic
conventions among programmers by
pressing enter we now have an id for
this hello world if we switch back to
our text view from down in here we can
see that for this text view an attribute
has been added the id attribute so no
matter what you do inside your text view
or design view they are basically the
same but as you can see right now we
have some warning for this button the
warning says that this button is not
constrainted to anywhere that's because
we are using this constraint layout for
this whole xml file don't worry about
this constraint layout yet we have other
layouts like relative layout and linear
layouts as well but for now just know
that when you are using constraint
layout which is the default case when
you are creating an android application
you need to constraint or change your
different elements to somewhere for
example if i don't constrain this button
to anywhere it's going to be floating at
the runtime because of the different
screen sizes we cannot know the exact
position or exact place of this button
and right now if we run our application
probably this button will be moved to
the place 0 and 0 which is exactly this
corner in our layout in order to
overcome this warning we can simply
add some constraints by
clicking and dragging as simple as that
i'm constraining this button to the both
edges of my
screen also for the top and bottom i can
constrain that as well for the top i'm
going to constrain that to this text
view and for the bottom i'm going to
constrain that to the bottom of my
screen as you can see whenever i add a
constraint an attribute will be added to
this text view in here as well now we
don't have that red warning also it's
worth mentioning that by default when we
have created this button when we have
dragged that into our design view an id
has been added to it as well the id of
this button is just button you can
change that if you want for example i
can say btn let's say hello
or whatever you want but in an xml file
the id should be a specific to every
element
right now this button doesn't do
anything in this video we are going to
make our application a little bit more
interactive for example we are going to
change the text of this text view by
clicking on this button for that we need
to define this text view in our java
file so that we could have access to its
attributes but before i go further to my
java file i'm going to switch to full
screen so that you won't be distracted
with all of my icons down in here if you
go to this view option in here down here
at the bottom you can see that we have
few options i'm going to go to for the
screen
for the rest of the course i'm going to
stay with full screen okay let's switch
to our main activity.java file as i said
in the previous video you can see that
we have some code written in here and
that's because when we created our
project we have selected the empty
activity project for that now we have an
empty activity which has an activity
main.xml file and also
mainactivity.java file in future we will
see that we can create all of these
files if we select no activity at the
time of creating our project but in here
we have these codes written to this
level also we have this plus sign in
here beside this import if you click on
that you can see that we have imported
some packages to this class if you want
you can always minimize and maximize
that import and for that matter you can
minimize and maximize all of your
methods for now i'm going to leave these
imports like this so that we can see
what we are importing into our java file
don't be worried about all of the new
keywords that you are seeing in here for
example this public class extends
protect that void we will talk about all
of them later on in the course but for
now just know that this uncreate method
is going to be the start point of our
application it means that when we run
our application the codes inside these
two curly braces is going to be the code
that will run first once again don't
worry about the term method that i used
we will talk about that later on in the
course so inside this uncreate method
two things are happening we have this
super dot on create we are not going to
talk about that right now and after that
we are setting some content views by
setting content views we are accessing
to the activity main file you can see
that we have this activity main in here
basically it means that this java class
is somehow related to this activity main
layout file we will talk in more depth
about this later on in the course but
for now just know that up until this
point in our code we have said that this
java file is related to this layout file
after that we can write the codes that
we need for example in here i'm going to
access to that text view that we have
created in the previous video for that i
can say text view as you can see when i
type something intellij the id behind
the android studio is suggesting me some
options there are a lot of options in
here but the one that i need is going to
come from
android.widget package so in java we
have classes equivalent to the ui
elements or user interface elements in
our layout file if we are going to
define a button we have that class in
java file as well in here we are going
to use text view so we can import that
in our project as well as you can see a
new line of code has been added to our
imports this line of code is importing
the text view from the widget package
into our java file next i need to name
my text view the name is optional and
you can name it whatever you want for
example in here i'm going to say txt
hello this is just a basic convention
you can name your class whatever you
want but we will talk about conventions
later on in the course after naming your
text view you need to locate the text
view from inside the layout file and the
way to do that is like this you can say
is equal to there is a helpful method in
every activity that is useful for
finding different views by their ids and
that method is named find view by id
once again this method is useful to find
different views different user interface
elements from your layout files by their
id inside the parentheses of this method
we need to pass the id of our textview
from inside our layout file and the way
to do that is like this we can type r r
is a special class in java which will
give us the access to all of our
resources our static files in our
project once again it stands for
resources let's select that we can say r
dot id
dot after that we need to add the id of
our text view which was txt
message i believe this id in here should
be the exact id that you have put inside
your layout file for this text view you
can see that the id is txt message and
we are using that to have access to our
text view so this way by using this find
view by id method and after that passing
the id in this shape now we have access
to our text view but you can see that
there is one more error in here and
that's because in java every time you
write a sentence you need to finish your
sentences with a semicolon that's just
syntactical and it really doesn't matter
some languages does not require this
semicolon but in java you need to put a
semicolon at the end of every sentence
okay now up to this point we have our
text view in our java file now we can
use it for example if we want to change
the text of our textview we can say
something like this we can type the name
of our textview which is txt hello after
that we can say dot don't worry about
this dot operator we will talk about it
in the next section in the java section
but for now just know that when you are
typing dots on an object you have access
to all of its methods and attributes for
example in here i can say set text once
again you can see that we have multiple
options let's import the first one
inside the parentheses of this method we
need to pass a text and whenever you are
going to pass a text aesthetically
whenever you are going to hard code the
text you need to pass it inside double
quotations let's pass a double quotation
inside this level quotation i'm going to
say hello this way now we have changed
the text of our text view let's run the
application and see if it's going to
work remember that inside our activity
main layout file the text is hello world
inside our java file we are changing it
to hello let's run the application as
you can see in here the text of our text
view has been changed to hello still our
application is not interactive we want
to change the text when we click on this
button not when we run the application
for that we need to define an event
listener to be precise and on click
listener for this button so that when we
click on this button the text of our
text view changes there are multiple
ways of defining an unclick listener for
our button the simplest one is to do
that inside your main activity layout
file if you come down in here inside
your button element inside the anchor
brackets of your button if you type on
click you can see that we have an option
in here let's pass a name in here for
example i'm going to say on btn click
this name in here is going to be the
name of a method in our java file as you
can see right now we are getting a red
warning it says that there is no such
method in your java file let's copy the
name from here and let's go to our main
activity and create that method so in
order to create a method we need to do
that outside of the scope of this
oncreate method and inside the curly
braces of this class i'm talking about
these two we need to define our method
inside this class and the way to do that
is like this we can say public
void after that the name of our method
which is on btnclick a pair of
parentheses
because it's going to be the
onclicklistener for our button we need
to accept a viewing here don't worry
about this viewing here we will talk
about all of these in java session let's
name this view after that we need a pair
of curly braces for our method and in
here we need to put the code that we
need to execute when the user clicks on
our button if you switch back to your
activity main.xml file now you can see
that the red error has been disappeared
okay let's go to mainactivity.java file
i'm going to change the text of our
textview to hello when the user clicks
on our button so for that method i'm
going to move this to line of code
to inside this method you can probably
guess the behavior of our application
right now let's run it once again and
see how is it going to work you can see
that the text still says hello world if
we click on our button the text will
change to hello this is ok but this is
not entirely what we want it's just
saying hello right now we want to say
hello to the exact user for example we
are going to get the name of our user
and by clicking a button we are going to
say for example hello mason hello tom
and something like that we are going to
get the user's input the way to get the
user's input is by using some element in
our ui called edit text let's switch to
design view you can add an edit text
into your project by going to this text
option in here you can see that we have
multiple options the first one is for
text view we have seen the text view
it's this hello world text after that we
have other options plain text password
email and all of these these are all
helpful for when you want to get
different kind of users inputs but for
our purpose in here we are going to use
plain text plain text is just a simple
text that we are going to get from the
user let's drag that into our view if
you take a look at the attributes in
here you can see that its id is edittext
let's quickly change that let's say edt
txt name
because we are inside the constraint
layout we also need to constraint this
edit text as well but before that i'm
going to change
the top constraint of this button i'm
going to change its constraint from the
bottom of this text view to the bottom
of this edit text for that i am going to
drag the top constraint of this button
to the bottom of this edit text now
let's add some other constraints for
this edit text as well for example for
the top i'm going to constraint it to
the bottom of my
text view and also for the edges i'm
going to go to the edges of the screen
right now it's too close to our text
view if you want we can add some margins
for example in here i'm going to say 17.
that seems to be better the other
attribute that every edit text has is
this text in here i'm talking about this
attribute in here you can see that right
now it says name if you want you can
change that but in here i'm going to
completely delete that instead i'm going
to define some hints you can see this
hint attribute in here
the difference between hint and text is
that when you click on your edit text
the hint will be deleted it's just a
hint for the user to know that but he or
she is going to enter inside this edit
text for example in here i'm going to
say name
you can see that it's somehow grayed out
okay now we have an edit text inside our
layout file inside our java file we need
to have access to this edit text so that
we could get the user's input once again
the start point of our activity and our
application is this oncreate method so
we can do that inside this uncreate
method we can have access to our
edittext like we did for this textview
we can say edit text once again you can
see that we have an equivalent class for
this edit text as well also if you take
a look at in here you can see that this
line of code has been added to our class
as well let's say edit text edttxd name
like before we can say is equal to find
view by id and once again we need to
pass the id of our edittext which i can
say
r.id.edtxt name to this point we have
the find our edit text now we need to
get the text of our edit text for that
we can say edit text name
dot get text you can see that we have
this option but this is not enough we
also need to do another level of
conversion and we do that by saying dot
to string don't worry about this two
string method yet we will talk about
that later on in the course it's just
for converting whatever the text is
inside our edit text to a text that we
can use in our java file don't worry
about that we will talk about it later
on but there is a problem with our code
in here we are going to get the user's
name and we are going to say hello to
the user when we click on the button for
that we need to have access to this edit
text inside our unboxing click method
but if you try to do that for example if
you say edit text name you can see that
everything is in red it means that you
don't have access to that edit text
inside this method and that's because
something called scope in java the scope
of this edit text is this uncreate
method within the curly braces of this
uncreate method we can't have access to
this element from inside our on button
click method in order to solve that
problem we need to move these two line
of code to inside our on button click
method let's quickly do that
inside our on button click method let's
paste them but right now we are not
doing anything with the user's input we
are getting the user's input but we are
not doing anything with that we need to
pass this line of code to the settext
method let's quickly delete this line of
code and inside the parenthesis of this
settext method
i'm going to pass that i'm going to say
edittextname.gettext.2string
this way we are setting the text of our
textview to whatever the text is inside
our edittext let's quickly run the
application and see if it's going to
work this is how our application and
this edit text looks right now if we
click on that you can see that we can
type something for example let's type my
name and if we click on our button the
text of our textview changes to mesa
this is not entirely what we wanted we
wanted to say hello to mesapp in order
to do that we need to make some changes
to our code also notice that i didn't
put any double quotation in here and
that's because we are passing this text
dynamically to our settext method if we
wanted to pass our text aesthetically we
need to put that inside double quotation
but in here we don't need to double
quotation if we want to say hello to the
user we can say something like this we
can say double quotation let's add a
plus in here
and inside these level quotations let's
say hello also let's add a space so that
we could see everything better this in
here is called concatenation in
programming adding the two texts
together let's run the application once
again and let's type something in here
let's say mesa by pressing button this
time you can see that the text has been
changed to hello mesa our application is
now much more interactive
okay this is our challenge we are going
to create a registration form like this
we are going to get the user's first
name last name and email and by pressing
this register button we are going to
show them inside these text views let me
quickly show what i'm talking about so
if you have a first name a last name
and also an email
if we click on this register button we
are going to show them inside these text
views to the user it's just a simple
application so that we can practice
everything that we have learned so far
okay i want you to pause the video in
here and create this simple application
after you have created it come back to
the video and we are going to create
this exact application together
i hope you solve the challenge but if
not that's totally okay we are going to
create that in here together also notice
that whenever you run android studio you
can see a list of recent projects in the
left panel in here okay let's move on
and let's create our project we can say
start a new android studio project
once again we are going to select this
empty activity let's name our project in
here i'm going to name it first
challenge or let's name it registration
form
you need to specify a package name mine
is fine
change the save location if you want and
also i'm going to stay with api level
19. okay let's create our project
let's start by creating our layout file
i'm going to close this java file for
now and let's also minimize this project
pane first of all let's delete this
hello world text you can click on it and
by pressing delete you can delete that
in our registration form we need the
three edit texts let's add them quickly
in text we need to add three plain texts
in here let's quickly add them we will
constrain them later on don't worry
about that right now three edit texts
and also we need a button let's add that
as well we also needed three text views
for the edit texts let's also change
their ids for the first one i'm going to
say edit text first name
and let's also delete this text and also
add some hint
let's say first name
let's do the same thing for the other
two edit texts
sometimes when you are defining a hint
or maybe a text attribute for your
elements you can see some annoying
dialogue like this in here you can avoid
that by pressing the escape key on your
keyboard okay for the button first of
all let's change its id to let's say btn
register
you can name it whatever you want let's
also delete this text and let's say
register
also you can see that we have this
onclick attribute in here we can define
an unclick attribute for our button from
here or like we did in the previous
video in our text view i'm going to
define that right now in here let's say
on register btn click
later on we will create this method for
the text views first of all let's change
their ids for example for the first one
let's say txt first name
also let's change the text to first name
similarly for the other two
okay let's quickly constraint all of
these elements we can click on them for
the first one i'm going to constraint it
to the top edge of my screen
and also both sides of my screen let's
also add a margin top of maybe
100 that seems to be better for the next
one i'm going to constraint it to the
both edges of the first name edit text
and also to the bottom of my first name
edit text add a margin top of 24. i'm
going to do the same thing for this
email
for the button i'm going to do the same
thing but i will probably change the top
constraint also if you did a mistake
when you are constraining your elements
you can click on the constraint
by pressing delete key you can delete
the constraint
let's change the top one string to maybe
something like 90db for the first name
i'm going to constraint it to the both
edges of my button sometimes it may not
work just try once again and also the
top constraint to the bottom of my
button for the top constraint once again
let's say 90 i think 90 is fine
let's delete this top constraint because
right now we are not seeing our last
name textview
and let's add it once again
for the last name
i'm going to do the same thing
let's change the top constraint margin
to let's say 24.
same thing for the email
okay this is going to be the look of our
application and now that we have defined
our layout file let's switch to our java
file and define the behavior of our
application i'm going to close this
activitymain.xml just before everything
let's just copy this unclick attribute
so that we don't make any mistake when
we define this method in our java file
in our project pane inside java folder
inside our package folder inside our
mainactivity.java file i need to create
my onclick method
once again i can say public void the
name of my method which i've copied from
my layout file inside the parentheses i
need to save view of its capital v after
that view with the lower v
and now i have created my own button
click listener once again don't be
worried about the syntax of this method
we will talk about it later on when we
have talked about java in here first of
all i'm going to define my text views if
you remember we can do something like
this we can say text view for the first
one let's say txt first name
is equal to find viewboy id
or dot id dot
txt firstly i'm going to do the same
thing for email and last name
after you have defined your text views
it's time to define your edit texts you
can do that like this we can say edit
text for the first one let's name it
edit text first name
is equal to find view by id r dot id dot
once again i'm going to do the same
thing for edit text email and also edit
text last name
okay now we have access to all of the ui
elements that we wanted now let's change
the text of our text views for example
for the txt first name i can say
something like this let's say txt first
name dot set text we have seen this in
the previous video nothing new in here
let's say first name
plus the text of our edit text first
name we can say edit text first name
dot get text dot to string as simple as
that now we are setting the text of our
text view to the text of our edit text
let's do the same thing for last name
and email edit text last name dot set
text
let's say last name first of all
plus edit text edittextlastname.gettext
dot to string and it takes email
dot set text
sorry i have put
the wrong element in here this should be
and txt last name not edit text last
same thing for the email txt email
dot set text
let's say email
plus edit text email dot get text dot to
string
that's all we need from our application
let's just run it okay it seems like we
have done a good job with the layout of
our application i think it's just better
to decrease the margin top of this
register button and also this first name
edit text so that we could see all of
them better let's also test its behavior
for the first name let's say emma for
the last name let's say watson for the
email emma watson gmail.com
let's click on this register button and
as you can see we are seeing the text
that we wanted it seems like our
application is working perfectly
in this section of the course we are
going to talk about java for writing
java applications we are going to need
an ide ide stands for integrated
development environment android studio
has been built upon an ide called
intellij until few months ago you could
have write and drawn java applications
on android studio but i think it was
around july 2019 that you can no longer
do that and that was because of a new
release in grader i have recorded a
video on that exact problem at the time
and it's on my youtube channel if you
want to take a look at that just search
for maycode on youtube and you will
probably find the video let me quickly
show that this is the video that i'm
talking about android studio does not
support playing java code anymore what
to do now and you can also see my
channel name so make sure to check that
if you need but basically what i was
talking about in that video was that
instead of android studio you need to
use another ide the most famous ideas
that are available for writing java
applications are eclipse and intellij in
this course we are going to use intellij
because it's a lot like android studio
and also it's free in that video i have
talked about how to install intellij ide
make sure to check that if you need but
it's a lot like installing android
studio beside intellij you are going to
need jdk java development kit which we
have already installed on our system you
can get intellij ide from jetbrains
websites let's say intellij id
the first link from the jetbrains
website probably is our needed link just
one thing that worth mentioning in here
is that there are two versions a
community version and also an ultimate
version the community version is free
and also it's enough for our need in
this course so make sure to download
that and after you have downloaded it
and also installed it come back to this
video to write java applications i have
intellij installed on my system and i'm
going to
open it right now you can create a new
project in here by saying create new
project as you can see the process is a
lot like android studio i have the
ultimate version of intellij id and for
that i can see all of these options
these might not be available for you if
you are using community version but no
matter what version you are using you
should see this java option in here
select that in here you need to specify
the path to your jdk if you have
installed jdk with me at the beginning
of this course you should be good in
here you can just select the version of
your jdk my version in here is 13 but we
are not going to use all of the features
of java 13. because oracle does not
support this version of java for long
term we are going to stay with all of
the features of java 8. okay after you
have selected the java and your jdk
let's click next we are not going to
create our project from template so make
sure to uncheck this option after that
click next in here we need to name our
project and also specify a location for
the name of this project i'm going to
say hello world
also if you don't see these
settings in here you have this more
settings option down in here make sure
that your module name is exactly your
project name also feel free to change
the project location if you need i'm not
going to change that in here let's just
click finish and let's create our
project
as you can see intellij id is a lot like
android studio and the reason for that
once again is that android studio has
been built upon this ide let's just
close this tip dialog and let's switch
to full screen mode and let's go to full
screen mode
once again in intellij id you can see
this project pane you can minimize and
maximize that you can also move through
the folders right now because we didn't
use any template our folders are empty
we can create our project like this by
clicking on the source folder by right
clicking on that selecting new package
we can specify a package for our
application in this case i'm going to
say org.maycode
dot let's say hello world
and inside this package we can create
our java classes don't worry about the
term class that i used we are going to
talk about that in object oriented
session but for now just know that we
are going to need at least one java
class in order to run our java
applications by right clicking on our
package and selecting new java class we
can create our class let's name this
class hello as you can see a new java
class has been created in our package
and also we have few lines of code let's
minimize our project pane and let's
focus on this hello.java class basically
what we have in here is the package that
we are currently in which is
org.mako.helloworld
and also we have the declaration of a
class once again we are going to talk
about classes later on in future videos
in order to have a start point for our
application we are going to need at
least one method and that method is
called the main method in order to
create that method we can type psvm by
pressing tab or enter we can have that
method as you can see this green
triangle has been added in here it means
that now we can run our application from
this point we will talk about the
meaning of all of these new keywords
later on in the course but for now just
know that in order to run your java
applications you need at least one java
class in which has one method called
main this main method is like the
oncreate method of our activities now we
can write our codes inside this main
method for example in order to print
something to the console we can say
something like this we can say s-o-u-t
or south and by pressing tab or enter
you can see this line of code
system.out.printline
or alternatively you can type this
manually instead of using the shortcut
you can say system notice that the s
should be in upper cases make sure to
use the upper case for s
let's say system dot out
basically this out means output in here
it means that we are going to add
putting something in this case we are
going to print something later on we
will see that we have an in as well in
which we will get the user's input let's
say system.out.printline
you can see that we have print and print
line for now we are going to use the
print one we will talk about the
difference later on in order to print
something to the console you need to
pass it inside the devil quotation you
can say something like this for example
let's say hello world
now we have the simplest java
application that can be written let's
quickly run our application in order to
run our java application for the first
time we need to right click inside the
curly braces of our main method and
select run hello.main let's do that as
you can see we are printing hello world
into our console sometimes if it's the
first time that you are running java
applications you may get some errors in
here in the most cases those errors
would be gone by rebuilding your project
you can come to this build tab above in
here and rebuild your project after the
rebuild is finished you can run your
application once again by right clicking
and selecting run hello dot main in most
cases the error should be gone but if
you had any other problem please ask
them in the q a section of the course
also notice that for the rest of this
section we are not going to have any
user interface it is possible to have a
graphical user interface gui for your
java applications but because this is an
android course and later on we will talk
about user interface in android
applications we are not going to use any
user interface for our java applications
we are just going to understand the
language okay now let's minimize our run
pane from here and let's talk about the
difference between print and print line
the difference between print and print
line is that when you are using print
line after printing your text the cursor
will move to the next line that is not
the case with print in order to see the
difference let's say system.out.print
once again let's pass our hello world
text
and let's run our application to see the
difference also if it's the first time
that you are going to run your
application you can right click inside
the main method and click on this run
hello dot main or if it's not the first
time you can click on this green
triangle at the left or the green
triangle on the top of your screen you
can also see the shortcut for windows is
shift plus f10 if you are using mac or
linux you can hover over this green
triangle and see the shortcut let's run
the application and see the difference
between print and print line you can see
that the text has been printed but the
cursor never moved to the next line if
we switch these two line of code we can
see the difference better let's switch
them
now print line is the first line and
print is the second line let's run the
application once again this time you can
see that the two text has been printed
in two separate lines okay now that we
know the difference between print and
print line let's talk about variables in
java but before i do that i'm going to
comment this two line of code you can
comment them by pressing ctrl slash when
you comment some code in java it means
that you are telling the compiler to
ignore this to line of code the use of
comment is for developers to remind
themselves or other colleagues of
something important for example in here
i can say slash slash let's say do
something
this line of code will be completely
ignored the other kind of comment in
here is like this we can say
slash to do after that we can say do
something
if we use this kind of comment with to
do at the beginning of your comment you
can see that first of all the color will
be changed to blue and also if you click
on the to do tab in here you can see
that you have one to do in your file
it's very helpful when you are working
with multiple programmers by clicking on
this to do everyone can see the list of
different to-do's there are more to
comments we will talk about them later
on in the course part for now just know
that when you are commenting something
that line will be completely ignored
okay now let's talk about variables
variables are useful for when you want
to store simple data in your java
application for example if you want to
store a number or a text variables are
useful for when you want to store some
small data in your java application for
example if you want to store a number or
a text if you want to store a number you
would do that like this you can say int
it stands for integer basically inside
an integer you can store whole numbers
for example negative and positive
numbers plus zero and the way to define
them is like this first level you type
int after that you need to name your
variable for example in here i can say
number this name in here is optional and
you can use whatever you want after that
you can assign a value to your variable
for example i can say 5. in here this
int is the data type of my variable this
number is the name of my variable and
this 5 is the value of my variable
beside positive numbers you can also
have negative numbers
after you have stored your variables you
can do some operation on them for
example you can print them and the way
to do that is like this you can say
system.out.printline
and after that you can pass your number
or whatever is the name of your variable
notice that in here i haven't used
double quotation basically whenever you
are passing some text explicitly you
need to pass the devil quotation but
whenever you are passing your variable
you shouldn't pass any double quotation
let's run the application and see if we
can see our number you can see that the
value of our number is negative 5 in
this case but inside integers you cannot
have decimal values for example in here
i can't say 5.3 we will see other kind
of variables in which you can use in
order to store decimal numbers but
more on that in a few minutes the other
kind of variable that you can use in
order to store whole numbers is long
let's see that as well we can say long
we can name it my long is equal to once
again let's say five let's also print
that let's say
system.out.printline and let's pass our
rung if we run the application we can
see five down in here the difference
between long and integer is that you can
store larger numbers inside a long and
also a long variable will store more
spaces in your device's memory ram to be
exact inside an integer you can store
numbers as large as the number of 2 to
the power of 31 but inside a long you
can store numbers as long as the number
of 2 to the power of 63 that's the
difference between long and integer but
what if you want to store decimal
numbers floating point numbers for that
you have other kind of variables the
first one is adobo let's see that we can
say double let's name it my double
let's assign it the value of 4.5
like before we can print it
let's pass our double if we run the
application we should see the number of
4.5 printed you can see that down in
here so double is one kind of variable
in which you can use in order to store
floating point numbers the other option
is to use float
let's see that as well you can say float
let's name it my float once again the
names are optional you can name your
variables whatever you want you can say
4.5 in here once again but right now you
can see that we are getting a red error
in here and that's because floating
point numbers by default are double in
java it means that if you want to define
a float number you need to cast your
number to float the way to cast your
number is like this after the equal we
can open and close a parenthesis and
inside the parenthesis you can say float
by casting you will explicitly tell the
ide that this is going to be a float
number and not a double number okay
let's quickly print this as well
let's pass our float and let's run the
application you can see that once again
4.5 has been printed once again the
difference between float and double is
that inside a float you can store
smaller numbers and also the other
difference is in the space that each one
of these are going to occupy in the
device's memory round basically double
will occupy more space we won't be using
float that much in this course i just
wanted to show you that float does exist
in java okay now we have seen numbers
but what if we want to store different
characters in java for that we have a
special kind of variable which is char
for example we can say char my char
is equal to
let's say m
notice that when i've assigned this
character to my char variable i have
used this single quotation that wasn't
the case when we have worked with
different numbers when you are assigning
a character you need to use the single
quotation like before we can print our
character let's pass our character
and let's run the application you can
see m printed in here when you are using
char variable you can't have multiple
characters for example in here i can't
have m a you can see that we are getting
an error in order to store multiple
characters we have another kind of
variable in which we will talk about
that in a minute but before i do that
i'm going to show you just one more
thing you can also store something like
this in your character you can say
backslash u 0 0 a e this is the special
unicode value for registered symbol
let's run the application and see what
would be the result you can see that the
registered trademark has been printed
into our console when you are using hr
variable you can also assign unicode
values as well you can search for
different unicode values for example if
we want to show the copyright symbol we
can say something like this we can say
backslash
u00a9 if you run the application we
should see the copyright symbol feel
free to search for other unicode values
on the internet okay now let's talk
about a string if we want to store
multiple characters we can use a string
we can say a string with capital s after
that like before we can name our string
let's say my string or let's name it
name
is equal to
mesa my name like before if we want we
can print our string
let's pass the name and let's run the
application we can see that mesub has
been printed into our console but you
may have noticed that there is a
difference in here the color of this
string is not blue like the other kind
of variables that's because of a very
important difference between a string
and other kind of variables the other
kind of variables that we have talked
about so far are primitive data types
but string is a class in java we will
talk about classes and objects in java
but for now just know that when you are
using a class you can have some
operations on that for example if you
type name you can say dot and you can
see a list of different available
methods we will talk about few of them
later on in the course spot you can see
that there are a lot of them so the
difference in here is that a string is a
class but others are primitive data
types there is one more kind of
variables that i'm going to talk about
in here and that's called boolean let's
see that as well we can say boolean
my boolean
let's say is equal to true
when you are using a boolean that
boolean can have only true or false
values these are the only two values
that a boolean can have once again like
before we can print our boolean let's
pass my boolean in here and let's run
our application you can see that true
has been printed as i said our boolean
can have false values as well let's run
the application
false has been printed boolean is very
helpful when you are working with
conditional statements we will talk
about conditional statements in the next
video okay this was our talk about
different variables in java there are
few more of these in which you can check
at the oracle documentation but probably
you are not going to need the others
these are all that we are going to use
in this course okay now that we have
talked about variables let's quickly
talk about arithmetic operators as well
but before that i'm going to comment all
of these lines of code because these can
be distracting the reason that i'm
commenting these lines of code and not
deleting them is that i'm going to
upload the source code so that if you
need you can check the source code okay
let's move on down in here let's quickly
define two new integers i can say int a
is equal to six
after that let's say int b
is equal to let's say two you can use
operators in java in order to perform
some kind of operation on your variable
we have different kind of operators the
first one that we are going to talk
about in here is called arithmetic
operators let's quickly see them for
example in here i can say int answer
is equal to
a
plus b this plus is the first arithmetic
operator that we are going to talk about
in here this is going to add the value
of b to a let's quickly print our answer
and let's run our application
you can see that the answer is eight it
has added b to a the other kind of
arithmetic operator that i'm going to
talk about in here is minus which you
can guess its value it's going to deduct
b from a the answer in here should be 4
you can see that 4 has been printed the
other one is star which is used for
multiplying the two values together in
here the answer should be 6 times 2
which is going to be 12. let's run the
application
and you can see 12 in here the other one
is slash which is used for division we
are going to divide 6 by 2. let's run
the application
we can see that the answer is 3. the
thing that you need to be extra careful
with this slash operator in here is that
the second number b in this case should
never be zero let's quickly change the
value of b to zero and let's see what
would be the result let's run the
application
you can see that we are getting a red
error in here we are getting an
arithmetic exception we will talk about
exceptions later on in the course but
for now just know that whenever an
exception occurs our application crashes
certainly we don't want that behavior in
our application so be careful about the
second number or alternatively you need
to catch the exception that you think
that might occur we will talk about
exceptions later on in the course we
have one more kind of arithmetic
operator in java and that's called
remainder let's see that as well it's
the percent sign the remainder operator
is going to give us the remainder of a
divided by b in this case if we divide
six by two the answer is three
and its remainder is zero so right now
if i run the application i should see
zero
you can see that zero has been printed
down in here but if i change the value
of a to let's say five now the remainder
of five divided by two is one let's see
that if we can save one yes it has been
printed from time to time this remainder
operator can be useful as well there is
one more thing that i need to talk about
the slash operator the division operator
right now we can expect that if we
divide 5 by 2 we should see 2.5 let's
run the application and see if we can
see that
we can see that we are getting 2 as the
answer and that's because we have saved
the answer inside an integer if you
remember at the beginning of this video
i said that integers can only contain
whole numbers if you want to have
floating point numbers you can use
something like double
but this in here is not going to work as
well because the answer itself is an
integer if you hover over the highlight
you can see that a divided by b is an
integer if you want to cast your number
to a double after the equal sign you can
open and close a parenthesis and inside
the parenthesis you can say double this
way you have casted an integer to a
double now if we run our application you
can see that we are seeing 2.5
so if you want to see the exact value of
a division use doubles let's just talk a
bit more about the plus operator and
after that finish off this video so
right now if i use a plus in here you
can guess the answer five plus two is
seven let's run the application
we can see seven down in here we can
also use these plus with different texts
for example if i have two text in here
let's say string first name
is equal to let's say emma
let's also define another text
let's say last name
is equal to watson
we can use the plus operator to add
these two texts together for example
let's say string full name
is equal to first name plus our last
name
if we print our full name
you can guess what would be the result
in here we can see emma watson let's
also add a spacing here in order to see
everything better
and my watson has been printed this in
here is called concatenating in java
adding two texts together so you can see
that this plus operator have two usages
it can be used to concatenate two texts
together or whenever we use it with
different numbers it will act as the
addition operator
[Music]
we are going to talk about more
operators in java specifically we will
talk about relational and logical
operators before doing that let's
quickly create our project by selecting
create new project by selecting java
and clicking on next and next once again
we can name our project let's name this
project operators
let's create our project
and inside the source folder let's
create our package let's say new package
let's name it org.maycode
dot operators
inside our package let's create our main
class let's name this class main
inside our main class we are going to
need our main method let's type psvm by
pressing tab we have our main method
before i talk about relational and
logical operators let's quickly talk a
bit more about arithmetic operators if
you remember from the previous video
when we have to find a new integer for
example a
and we assign a value to that we could
have say something like this we could
have said int answer
is equal to a
plus two or instead of defining a new
integer we can say
a is equal to a plus two it means that
increase the value of i by two let's
print a and see what would be its result
let's run our application because it's
the first time i'm going to say run
main.hello
you can see that the value of a is 7. we
can simplify this line of code we can
say something like this i'm going to
comment that
and in here i can say a
plus equal to
let's also add some spaces
these two line of code are exactly the
same we can use plus equal in order to
simplify the line six let's run our
application once again
you can see that the result is the same
also if we want to
increase a by one for example if we want
to say a is equal to a plus one we can
do something like this we can say a plus
equal one or alternatively we can say a
plus plus
that is possible as well this a plus
plus is going to increase the value of a
by one if we run our application we
should see six as the value of a
you can see 6 down in here alternatively
we can use minus as well we can say a
minus minus it will deduct 1 from the
value of a if we run our application
we can see 4 in the console similar to
that we can say a
minus equal to let's say 2 for example
in this case if we run our application
we should see 3 as the value of a
like minus equal you can also have
multiply equal and also divided by equal
it means that divide a by 2 and store
the value or store the answer inside a
this sentence in here is the simplified
version of this line of code that i'm
going to write we can say a is equal to
a divided by 2. both of these lines are
the same if you want to make sure of
that you can delete this line and you
can run your application
5 divided by 2 is 2.5 because we are
saving that inside an integer the answer
should be 2 so we showed c2 as the value
of our a and you can see two down in
here before talking about logical and
relational operator i just wanted to
talk about these simplifications okay
now let's talk about relational and to
be specific comparison operators in java
comparison operators are useful for when
you want to compare two things for
example two numbers before that let's
quickly define two numbers i'm going to
say int a is equal to five
after that let's say into b is equal to
let's say three
after that we can say boolean
answer is equal to the first comparison
operator that i'm going to talk about in
here is greater than operator and the
way to define that is like this we can
say a greater than b
i have saved the result of this
comparison inside a boolean this left
anchor bracket in here means greater
than operator it means that if a is
greater than b assign the value of true
to this answer right now if we print our
answer we should see true let's quickly
do that
let's say answer and let's run our
application
you can see that answer is true because
a is 5 and 5 is greater than 3. the
other kind of comparison operator is
less than and that's this right anchor
bracket right now a is not less than b
so the answer should be false if we run
our application we should see false in
the console and we can see that the
other kind of comparison operator that
i'm going to talk about in here is
useful for when you want to compare the
equality between two integers and that
operator is these two equal signs right
now a is not equal to b so if we run our
application we should see false into our
console let's run our application
and here we can see false remember that
when we are using two equal signs it
means that we are checking for the
equality of two number but when we are
using a single equal sign like in here
and above in here we are assigning a
value to our variable let's change the
value of b to 5
to see that if this is going to be true
let's run the application
now you can see that the answer is true
we have other kind of comparison
operators as well one of them is greater
than equal when we use this left anchor
bracket and also this equal sign it
means that check if a is greater than b
or if a is equal to b right now a is
equal to b so this answer should be true
if we run our application we should see
true
you can see that down in here we see
true also if a is 5 and b would be
something like 3 if we run the
application we should see true once
again we can see through but if we
change the value of a from 5 to
something like 2 because none of this
condition is true right now we should
see false let's run our application
and we can see false the other
comparison operator is less than equal
and we use that like this we can use
this right anchor bracket and equal sign
this in here means that check if a is
less than b or if a is equal to b
right now a is less than b so the answer
should be true if we run our application
we should see through
but if we change the value of a to
something like 5 we should see false
and we can see faults beside this we
also have another kind of comparison
operator and that's this explanation
mark plus the equal sign this in here
means that check if a is not equal to b
this explanation marking here adds a
negative meaning to our equal operator
right now a is not equal to b so the
answer should be true if we run our
application we should see true
and true has been printed okay these
were the comparison operators that i was
going to talk about feel free to
practice them because we are going to
use them a lot in our course next i'm
going to talk about logical operators in
java but before that let's quickly
comment this to line of code
down in here let's define a new boolean
let's say boolean answer
is equal to let me write the syntax and
i will talk about it we can say a is
equal to five or
let's say b is equal to
something like two this is our first
logical operator this in here means or
you can add these two pipelines by using
shift plus
backslash backslash is somewhere above
the inter in english keyboard so in here
this or operator means that if a is
equal to 5 or if b is equal to 2 assign
true to this answer if none of this
condition is true so assign false to
this answer right now a is equal to 5 at
least one of our conditions are true so
the answer should be true so if we print
our answer
we should see through let's run the
application
and you can see through down in here if
we change the value of a for example to
six
because none of these conditions are
true we should see faults let's run the
application
and down in here we can see false the
other kind of logical operator that i'm
going to talk about is two and signs
let's quickly see that as well this in
here is and operator it means that
assign true to answer if both of these
conditions are true if a is equal to 5
and also if b is equal to 2 if one of
these conditions is not true so assign
false to answer right now none of these
conditions is true so we should see
false as our answer let's run the
application
and as you can guess we see false if we
change the value of a to 5 and run our
application once again we should see
false
because the second condition is not true
but if we change the value of b to 2 and
run our application this time we should
see true and we can see through them in
here and these were the two kind of
logical operators that i was going to
talk about or and and now that we have
talked about the operators that we
wanted let's talk about conditional
statements i'm going to comment this two
line of code the first kind of
conditional statements that i'm going to
talk about is called if statements we
can type something like that we can say
if
a pair of parentheses inside the
parentheses we need to provide our
condition for example we can say if
a is greater than 3 after the
parenthesis we need a pair of curly
braces inside the curly braces we can
put our code for example let's say a is
greater than 3.
so in here we are saying that if our
condition is true execute the code
inside the curly braces if it's not true
jump to after the curly braces for
example in here let's say continue
right now a is 5 and it's greater than 3
so we should see this text printed let's
run our
application we can see that a is greater
than 3 but if we change the value of a
to something like 2 and run our
application
we can see that we are no longer seeing
this text in if statements we can also
have multiple conditions for example in
here i can say
else
and i can provide another pair of curly
braces inside these curly braces i can
say something like this i can say
a is less than 3.
right now a is 2 a is less than 3 so we
should see only this text printed let's
run our application
you can see that a is less than 3. as
for the condition you can provide your
condition like this directly inside your
if statement parenthesis or you can
define your boolean
before your if statement for example in
here if i say boolean
answer is equal to
a greater than 3
now i can pass my answer inside this
parenthesis i can say if answer
is equal to true let's minimize this run
pane for now this is going to work the
same but if you hover over the
highlighting here the intellij id is
warning me about something the first
warning is that answer equals equals to
true can be simplified to answer it
means that i can delete this part this
is going to work exactly the same if we
run our application we should see the
same result a is less than three let's
run our application
and you can see a is less than three if
we want to negate this answer we can add
an explanation mark before our variable
for example in here we can say if answer
is not equal to true if we run our
application we should see the first line
you can see that a is greater than 3.
this is not true because a is 2 but in
here we have changed the meaning of this
boolean we have added a negative meaning
let's delete this for now and let's run
our application once again
beside else you can also have an else if
as well let's quickly comment this if
statement and let's write another one
down in here i'm going to say if inside
this if statement let's check that if a
is positive or negative i can say if a
is greater than 0 inside the curly
braces that sprint a is positive
in here instead of else i can use
something like this i can say else if
now we need to put another condition in
here we can say if a is less than zero
once again we need a pair of curly
braces
inside the curly braces we can say a
is negative
you can have as many else if cases as
you want for example i can add another
one in here but of course in here i
don't think this if statement would mean
anything but you can have as many as you
want
but in every if statement you can have
at most one else case
let's delete all of these
for example i can have only one else
case this else is going to be the
default case in this case if we use this
else it means that a is not greater than
zero and also it's not
less than zero so it is zero and here we
can safely say a is zero
this is going to be the default case for
our if statement right now a is 2 so we
should see a is positive let's run our
application
and as you can see a is positive let's
change a to -2
if we run our application you can guess
it we should see a is negative and we
can see that down in here if we change
the value of i to zero
we should see a is zero
and as you can see we can see that down
in here so if statements are one kind of
conditional statements we have another
one as well let's comment all of these
the other one is called switch statement
let's see that as well we can say switch
inside the parentheses of this switch
statement we need to provide the
variable that we want to switch on for
example i can pass a in here
after the parenthesis i can provide a
pair of curly braces inside the curly
braces i can define different cases for
example i can say in case a is equal to
1 after that we need a column and in
case a is 1 we can print something for
example we can say
a is 1.
also it's very important to provide a
break after every case let's do that i
will talk about this break in a minute
but for now just know that after every
case you are going to need a break we
can define as many case as we want for
example in here i can say in case a is 2
let's print something
let's say a is 2.
after that we need a break we can define
another case
for example for 3
let's say a is three
in every switch statement we are going
to need a default case as well and we
can pass that like this we can say
default
and we can print something like a is not
one two or three
in the default case we need the break as
well let's quickly add that
right now the value of a is zero let's
change that to two
and you can guess it we should see a is
two let's run the application
and you can see a is 2. if we change the
value of a to once again 0 and run our
application
you can see a is not 1 2 or 3. let's
also talk about this breaking here but
before that let's quickly change the
value of a to one
this break in here will cause our switch
statement to break for example if we
don't have this breaking here at the
first base which is a is equal to one
and if we run our application
you can see that even though a is one we
can see both sentences we can see a is
one plus a is two in here because we
don't have any break we didn't break out
of the switch statement and we have
jumped to the second statement so don't
forget to have a break after each case
in your switch statement
we are going to talk about loops in java
but before that let me just say that i
have created my project i have added
this package inside my source folder
inside this package we have only one
main class in which has this one main
method i hope that you can come to this
point by yourself if not please watch
the previous videos on how to create a
project and create your main class and
your main method
in programming loops are useful for when
you want to do a repetitive job for
example if you want to print something
10 times like this in here
if you want to print this hello 10 times
you can just copy and paste it 10 times
but in general it's a bad idea that you
copy and paste yourself whenever in
programming you are copying and pasting
know that you are doing something wrong
instead of copy and pasting we are going
to use loops in this video the first
kind of loops that i'm going to talk
about are for loops let me write it and
we will talk about its syntax
this is the general syntax of a for loop
first of all we write four after that we
have a pair of parentheses inside the
parenthesis we have three statements in
the first statement we are defining a
new integer called i you can name your
integer whatever you want and also we
are initializing our i to have a value
of zero the second statement is the
condition of our for loop we are going
to continue this loop until this
condition is not met and the third
statement is just a statement for
changing the value of i every time that
we look we will see in action what all
of these mean
after the parenthesis we have a pair of
curly braces in which we can contain our
code inside them for example if we want
to print something like hello in here
we can include that inside this pair of
curly braces
so what this for loop is going to do is
that first of all we are defining a new
integer called i and we are assigning
the value of 0 to that integer after
that we are checking our condition we
are checking that if i is less than ten
in the first time that we are going to
loop i is zero so this condition is met
if this condition is true we are going
to execute the code inside the curly
braces in this case we are going to
print hello after printing hello we are
going to execute the third statement in
this case we are going to increase the
value of i by 1. for the next time that
we are going to loop first of all we are
going to check our condition we are
checking that if i is still less than 10
or not for the second time i is 1 i
still is less than 10 so we are going to
execute our code this circle in here is
going to continue and continue until our
condition is false
when it's false we are going to break
out of the foredo so in this case we are
going to print hello 10 times let's run
our application and let's see if we can
see hello ten times
you can see that we have printed hello
10 times it seems to be perfect
instead of 10 you can put any number
that you want in here for example you
can save 5. if you execute your program
you would see that hello would be
printed 5 times instead of this five in
here you can pass a variable for example
if you had a variable before this for
loop if we had int a is equal to five in
here later on we can pass a instead of
five to this photo for example in here
instead of 5 we can say a if we run the
application we should see the same
result
inside our for loop we can also have
access to the i itself for example
instead of printing hello we can print i
let's quickly print that as well and
let's run the application
you can see that we are printing the
numbers 0 to 4. okay for loop is one
kind of loops in java the other point is
while loop let's quickly see that as
well once again i'm going to write the
syntax of while loop and we will talk
about it after that
this is the general syntax of a while
loop first of all we type void after
that we have a pair of parentheses
inside the parenthesis we have our
condition in this case a less than ten
after that we have a pair of curly
braces and inside the curly braces we
have our code in this case we are going
to print hello notice that we are not
changing the value of a so this
condition is always true and if i run my
application right now we are going to
stuck in an infinite loop let me quickly
run the application and see what an
infinite loop looks like but before that
let me
comment this for loop
you can see that no matter what happens
we are inside an infinite loop we are
printing hello
in some cases this might be our desired
behavior but in most cases we probably
do not want that we can exit our
application by pressing on this red
button we can also check our exit code
which is negative one in a normal
application we would get zero okay but
how can we exit a while loop
there are multiple ways for that the
simplest way is to change the value of a
inside the white loop for example after
printing hello i can say a plus plus in
order to increase the value of a so that
it won't be the same every time that we
are going to loop through this while
loop so for example for the first time a
is 5 so our condition is true so we are
going to execute this two line of code
we are going to loop through this cycle
until a is 10. when that's the case this
condition is no longer met and we are
going to break out of the while loop
let's run the application one more time
this time you can see that we have only
printed hello five time and also this
exit code is zero which means that we
have exited our application successfully
without any error the other way that
break out of a while loop is to add a
break let me quickly add that
this time after the first loop we are
going to break out of the while loop it
means that we are going to print hello
only once let's run the application
and in here you can see that we have
printed hello only once
inside while loops we have another
keyboard called continue let's quickly
see that as well
i'm going to delete this break and
before this print statement i'm going to
put an if statement let's say if a is
equal to 8
then let's continue
discontinuing here means that go to the
next record of your while go to the next
round of looping it means that no matter
what is the rest of the code inside the
while loop break out of the while loop
and go to the next record so for example
in this case if a is 5 6 or 7 we are
going to print hello
but if a is 8 we are not going to print
hello after that we are going to print
hello in case if a is 9. if we don't
want to stack in an infinite loop we
also need to change the value of a
somewhere inside the white loop for
example before this if statement
i can say a plus plus right now if i run
my application i should say hello only
four times because if a is 8 we are
going to continue the loop it means that
we are going to jump to the next record
and we are not going to print hello
let's run the application and see if we
can see hello four times and as you can
see we are seeing hello four times so
continue is a useful keyword for when
you want to jump to the next record
okay now that we have talked about while
loop let's also talk about another kind
of loops in java the value of a in here
is five if we change our condition to
let's say a
less than 5
we know that this condition is no longer
true so we are not going to go inside
the while loop it means that we are not
going to run the code inside the while
loop let's run the application we
shouldn't see any hello printed into our
console
and as you can see we can't see any
hello but in some cases you may want to
go inside the while loop at least once
no matter what the condition is
for those situations you can use do
white loops let me comment this while
loop and let's create a do white loop
it's a lot like while loops you need to
type do
inside the curly braces you need to put
your code for example you can say
system.out.printline
and you can print hello
after the curly brace you need to save
while
and inside the parenthesis you need to
specify your condition for example
we need to say a
less than five after the parenthesis you
need a semicolon of course in this case
because a is equal to five this
condition in here is not true but even
with that condition we should see this
hello at least once because we are using
two white loops
let's run the application and let's see
if we can see hello
as you can see we can see hello only
once
so do white loops are useful for when
you want to execute your code at least
one no matter what the condition is we
also have another kind of loops in java
called for each loops but i'm not going
to talk about that in here because i
think that if we know about different
arrays and collections and in regard to
that if we know about object oriented
programming we will understand it much
better so i'm going to talk about for
each loops after we have learned about
all those stuff okay i think that's
enough for loops
now we are going to have a quick
challenge but before we have our
challenge we need to know about two more
things we need to know how to get the
user's input and also we need to know
how to generate a random number
later on we will see that how these two
are going to be useful in order to get
the user's input you can use something
called a scanner the syntax in here
might not be familiar to you because we
haven't talked about object oriented
programming but we are going to need
that in our challenge because we want to
have an interactive challenge
if you don't understand the syntax just
copy and paste the code that i'm writing
in here in order to define a scanner you
can type something like this you can say
scanner with capital s
notice that it's coming from java.util
package
after that you need to name your scanner
which i'm going to say scanner after
that you can say is equal to new scanner
once again with capital s
inside the parenthesis you need to say
system dot in
we have seen system.out which was useful
for
outputting something
system.in is useful for when you want to
get the user's input now you have a
scanner you can get a number from user
like this you can say inked
answer
is equal to a scanner dot next int
this one down in here by saying
scanner.nextint our scanner is going to
wait for the user's input until the user
enters some number we will see that in
action in a minute but before that let's
quickly output something
for example let's say
answer was
plus the value of answer
also let's type something before our
scanner
let's save please enter a number
let's run our application and let's see
what these few lines of code are going
to do you can see that we are saying
please enter a number text and in here
console is waiting for the user to enter
a number for example i can say 5 by
pressing enter
you can see that answer was 5
and we have exited our application
successfully so by using scanner you can
get the user's input
beside integers beside number you can
also get a text from user if you want
let's quickly see that as well first of
all let's print something
let's say enter your name
after that i can say something like this
i can say the string name
is equal to scanner dot next
you can see that this next method is
going to return a string
don't worry about all of these new stuff
method scanner classes object oriented
programming we will talk about all of
these later on but for now because we
are going to need the user's input we
are going to figure out a way to receive
that
so by using scanner.next we are going to
get the user's name and after that let's
print something
let's say hello plus the name of the
user let's run our application once
again
in here first of all we need to enter a
number let's add four
after that scanner is waiting for my
name
let's say mesa
and we can see hello mesa message so
this way we can get the user's input
let's also see how we can generate a
random number i'm going to comment these
lines of code for now in order to
generate a random number you can say
something like this you can say random
it's capital r
let's name it random is equal to new
random and we don't need to provide
anything inside the parenthesis
after that in order to generate a random
number we can say something like in
number is equal to random
dot next int this method in here is
going to generate a random number
let's print that number
let's say number
plus the number
let's run our application once again
you can see that we have this random
number it's also useful to specify a
domain for your random number right now
our random number is this weird negative
number it might not be useful
it's good to define a domain
in order to define that domain you can
pass a number to this next int method
for example if i put 20 in here
and if i run my application once again
the number should be somewhere between 0
and 19. if you want your random number
to be somewhere between
1 to 20 you can simply add
one in here you can say plus one let's
run the application once again
we can see 9 this time this numbering
here is completely random it means that
every time that we run our application
we should see a different number you can
see that we are generating different
numbers okay now that we know how to get
a random number and also how to get the
user's input it's time for our challenge
here is our challenge we are going to
create a game the concept behind this
game is to generate a random number and
ask the user to guess that number
continue asking the user until you
receive the correct number also to make
everything more fun after 5 times of
guessing wrong show a game over message
to the user here is how our game is
going to work first of all we are going
to show a welcome message after that we
are going to ask for the user's name and
we are going to say hello to the user
after that we are going to ask for the
user's permission to start the game if
we received a positive answer we are
going to generate a random number
and we are going to ask for the user's
guess if the guess is correct we are
going to show a congratulation message
and quit the game
if the guess is wrong we are going to
ask again until we receive the correct
number also as a hint to the user beside
the first time every time that you are
asking for a number tell the user to
guess higher or lower
for example if the random number is 10
if the user has guessed 7 for the first
time tell him to guess higher if the
user failed after 5 times show a game
over message and quit the game
this challenge in here is the
combination of everything that we have
learned so far so make sure to practice
before watching the next video it's
going to help you a lot okay go solve
the challenge and after that come back
to the next video so that you see my
solution for this challenge see you in
the next video
i hope you solved the challenge but if
not that's totally okay after all it's
your first encounter with java and it's
the first application that you're
writing
in this video we are going to solve the
challenge together let's start by
creating a new project
like before i'm going to select java
next once again next let's name this
project guess me gain
let's create our project
and inside our source folder let's
create our package and java file
let's name this package org dot
org.maycode.gizmygame
new java class let's name it main
inside our main class let's type psvm
and now we have our main method
okay first of all we are going to show
some welcome message to the user so
let's say
system.out.printline let's say welcome
to wonderland
after that we are going to ask for the
user's name so let's say please enter
your name or may i have your name
after that we need to receive the user's
name in which we need a scanner for that
let's create our scanner
let's say scanner is equal to new
scanner
system dot in
after that let's say string name is
equal to scanner.next
and let's say hello to the user
let's say
hello plus the name after that let's ask
for the user's permission to start the
game
let's say
shall we start
in here i'm going to give the user two
option and here are my two options let's
say
one
yes
and the other let's say no
but in order to format my text a little
bit better i'm going to add a special
syntax in here in which you haven't seen
so far by adding backslash t
i'm adding a tab before this yes so
this will be formatted with a tab let's
add one in here as well nothing special
just for formatting my text a little bit
better after that i'm going to save the
user's answer let's say int
begin answer
is equal to
scanner.nextint
and after that i'm going to create a
while loop
let's say while begin answer is not
equal to 1
we are going to continue asking our
question
so let's copy this three line of code
and paste them inside our while loop
after that inside the while loop we also
need to store the new user's answer for
that we can say begin answer
is equal to scanner.nextint
this way we are not going to break out
of this while loop until the user's
answer is one when it's on we have the
permission to start the game after the
while loop it's time to generate a
random number let's say random random is
equal to new random
after that let's say in x is equal to
random.nextint for the domain i'm going
to say 20 because i want my number to be
from 1 to 20 so
i need to add a plus one in here after
that it's time to ask the user to guess
a number so let's say
please guess a number
and in here we need to save the user's
answer
let's say int user input
is equal to scanner.nextint
in here i'm going to define three new
variables and their usages will be clear
in a minute
let's quickly define them
first of all i'm going to save the times
that user has tried the game
so let's say inked
timestride
is equal to 0 initially
after that let's define a boolean let's
say boolean
has bone initially it's false
and after that a boolean
indicating if we should finish the game
so let's say should finish
once again it's going to be false
initially
after defining these three new variables
i'm going to create another while loop
let's say while
should finish is not equal to true
then
inside the while loop first level i'm
going to increase the times that user
has tried
so let's say timestride plus plus
after that i'm going to create an if
statement let's say if
time stride is less than 5
then we have the permission to continue
if it's more than five
in the else case
we need to break out of this while loop
for that i'm just going to say short
finish is equal to true
this is going to be the last line of our
while loop so if we loop once again
because this condition is no longer met
we are going to break out of the while
loop but in case the time strike is less
than 5 we are going to check that if the
user's input is equal to the randomly
generated number for that i can say if
user input
is equal to x
then we need to change the value of
husband to true because user has won the
game
and also we need to break out of this
while loop let's say short finish is
equal to true
let's add an else if case to this if
statement let's say else
if let's say if user's input
is greater than
our x
which is our randomly generated number
we are going to tell the user to guess
lower for that we can say
guest lower
and of course we need to wait for the
new users inputs for that we can say
user input
is equal to
scanner.nextint
we also need another case in here in
case the number
is uh less than x
if that's the case we are going to tell
the user to guess higher
and also we are going to wait for the
new user input let's say user input is
equal to
scanner.nextint
we are done with this while loop we will
review what we are doing in here but
after the void loop we need another if
statement we can say if
the user has won the game if that's true
then we are going to show a message
let's say congratulation
and also let's say to the user in which
try he or she has won the game
let's say you have guest
in your
plus time stride
plus
guess
but in the else case
first level we are going to show a game
over message
let's say game over
and after that we are going to say what
was the number
let's say
the number was
plus x
this is our entire application let's
review what we are doing in here first
of all we are showing a welcome message
to the user
after that we are asking for the user's
name we are creating a scanner and after
that we are waiting for the user to
enter his or her name
after we receive the name we are waiting
for the user's permission to start the
game we are saving the user's input in
here
inside the while loop we are making sure
that we have the permission
if we don't have the permission we are
going to ask again and again until we
have the permission
after that we made sure that we have the
permission we are creating a random
number
the random number is between 1 to 20 and
after that we are asking the user to
guess a number
we are saving the user's input in here
we have defined three new variables in
here time stride has one and should
finish
next we are creating this while loop it
starts from here and ends in here the
condition of this while loop is while we
shouldn't finish the game continue the
loop first thing inside this while loop
we are increasing the time stride so if
it's the first time because the time
strike is initially 0 we are changing
that to 1. after that we are checking
that if time stride is less than 5
we are comparing the user's input with
the randomly generated number if that's
equal to a random number we are changing
the value of this has one to true
and also we need to break out of this
loop so we are changing the value of
this should finish to true but in case
the user input is greater than our
random number we are telling the user to
guess lower and also we are waiting for
the user's input but in case the user's
input is less than
our random number we are telling the
user to guess higher
once again we are waiting for the user's
inputs in case the time stride is
greater than 5 we are just breaking out
of the loop if that's the case the
husband is still false so we are
checking that in here
if has one is equal to true it means
that user has won the game so we are
showing this congratulation message also
we are showing that in which try the
user has guessed the number correctly
but in case if the user didn't want the
game we are showing this game over
message and also we are showing the
random number
let's run the game and see if everything
is working fine
we are seeing the welcome message after
that it's asking for our name
let's put mesa
we are saying hello mesa after that we
are seeing the message for our
permission shall we start or it was
better to say shall we begin let's say
to no
once again we are seeing the message
this is our first while loop also this
format in here is because of that
backslash t that i have used when i have
created this text i'm talking about this
one
this backslash t in here also beside one
and two if you enter any other number we
should see this message once again so
let's say three for example you can see
that we are seeing the message okay
let's say yes to continue
the console is waiting for us to guess a
number let's say 10.
it says guess lower let's say five it
seems like i have won the game in my
second try okay let's run the game once
again may i have your name
let's say mesa
yes let's begin
let's guess another number
it says that guess lower i'm going to
guess higher in order to debug all the
features of the game let's say 11
15. you can see that after five try
i can see the game over message
and i can see that the number was 9.
okay it seems like our application is
working perfect just before i finish off
this video let's
change
this message in here to shall we begin
i think that's better okay this was our
challenge i hope you solved it if you
did do celebrate but if not that's okay
later on in the course we are going to
practice all of these many more times so
that we make sure that we have learned
everything that we see in the course
okay i think that's a good point to stop
the video in here just before i do that
i'm going to say that in the next video
we are going to talk about arrays in
java
see you in the next video
in this video we are going to talk about
arrays in java up until now if we wanted
to store some simple data for example a
number or maybe a text we could have
used variables for example we could have
set in a is equal to five
but what if we want to store a list of
different variables for example a list
of names or a list of students
for storing a list of variables we have
multiple options in java the first one
that we are going to talk about in this
video is called array let's see how we
can have an array of for example strings
for that we can say string
after that we need a pair of square
brackets
after that we need the name of our array
for example i can say students
next i can say new
string once again with a pair of square
brackets this new keyboard in here is
simple english it means that we are
defining a new array of strings inside
this square bracket we can define the
size of our array for example if we want
to sort 5 different student names i can
say 5 in here as simple as that now we
have an array of size 5
after defining your array you can put
some values into it for example i can
say
students
with an index of let's say 1
is equal to let's put my name in here
mesa
this way we are assigning this value to
the element in which has the index of
one in our array there is a very
important point in here and that's
indexes in java starts from zero so
in here when i set students with an
index of one it means that we are
referring to the second element in our
array if you want to assign some value
to your first element in your array you
can say students with an index of zero
let's see that as well
let's say is equal to
for example 0
we can keep doing this for all of our
elements inside our array beside
assigning values to your array elements
you can also get the value of those
elements as well for example in here we
can say print the value of a student
with an index of two
you can guess it in this case it should
be tom
let's run the application and see if we
can see tom
as you can see home has been printed
this is one way of assigning different
values to your array elements the other
way is like this
you can assign different values at the
time of creating your array for example
in here i can say a string array
let's name it employees
is equal to instead of saying new string
array i can pass a pair of curly brace
and inside that curly brace i can pass
my values for example i can say mesa
or every other value that i want
so these are the two ways of assigning
values to your array elements like a
string area you can also have other kind
of arrays as well for example if i want
to put some numbers inside an array i
can say int with a pair of square
brackets
let's say numbers is equal to
let's say a pair of curly braces and
inside those curly braces i can pass my
values let's say one two through six
when you are working with different
arrays for loops can be very helpful to
access all of the elements inside your
array for example if i want to print all
of the values inside this numbers array
i can say something like this
i can create a folder let's say for into
i is equal to zero
i less than in this case the size of my
numbers area is six so let's say six
after that let's say i plus plus
inside the for loop i can say print the
value of numbers with an index of i
this way i am going to print all of the
numbers inside my numbers array before
running the application i am going to
comment this line of goods so that we
have a clean console
as you can see numbers from 1 to 6 have
been printed into our console so for
loops are very helpful when you are
working with different kind of arrays in
here we have hard coded d6 but what if
we don't know the size of our array for
example if we get some values from our
database or from our server in that case
it might be possible that we don't know
the size of our array how can we use for
loop speed arrays if we don't know the
size of our array for that we can use a
helpful property of different arrays for
example in this case i can say numbers
dot
length this way we don't need to be
worried about the size of our array we
can just use it like this let's run the
application once again
and as before we have printed numbers
from one to six later on we will see
that beside primitive data types and
strings we can also have different kind
of arrays for different objects for
example for different classes in java
but more on that later on so using
arrays is one way of having a list of
different items but there are some
limitations to arrays for example
the size of our array after the
definition is immutable let me show you
what i'm talking about in here when we
define our students array we have set
the size to be five but what if we want
to change the size of our array for
example what if we want to define a
sixth element
for example if we say students with an
index of 5
let's say brian
if you hover over this 5 you can see
that array index is out of bounds it
means that this element in here cannot
fit in our array for example if we try
to reach to that element
we should see a problem let's say print
a student
with an index of five
before that let's comment this line of
code and let's run our application as
you can see we are getting an exception
in here once again when we get
exceptions it means that our application
crashes and the exception type in here
is array index out of bound exception it
means that the six element does not
exist in our array so arrays are
immutable after you define them you
cannot change their size this is one of
the limitations of simple arrays in java
there are others as well for example you
cannot do that much with your arrays
later on when we use other kind of
collections in java we will see that we
have all kind of operations
on our array elements but i'm not going
to talk about other kind of collections
in here because i think that it's better
to talk about them after we know about
object oriented programming later on in
the course we will talk about other kind
of collections like
arraylists and maps just before i finish
off this video i'm going to write a
simple application
in which will help us to practice what
we have learned about arrays before that
let me comment all of these lines of
codes
and let's start creating our application
down in here in this application i'm
going to simulate the contact
application on the phone i'm going to
show a list of different contacts names
on a phone for to the user and after
that by typing the contacts name we are
going to give the user that contacts
number in order to simulate that first
of all we are going to need a string
array let's say string array
names
is equal to
let's pass our names directly
let's say mesa
after that we need a list of different
numbers for that i'm going to create an
integer array
let's say numbers
is equal to
and let's initialize our array
after that i'm going to show the name of
all of the available contacts on the
phone
so let's create a for loop
for int i is equal to zero
i less than
names.length
and i plus plus
let's bring the names inside our names
array let's say print
names with an index of i
after the for loop i'm going to ask the
user to enter a name so let's say print
let's say please enter a name
after that we need our scanner so let's
create that is equal to new scanner
system.in
after that let's get the contact's name
let's say
the string name
[Music]
is equal to scanner.next
then i'm going to create a for loop and
inside that loop i'm going to find the
index of the contact so let's say 4
means i is equal to 0
i less than names
dot length
i plus plus
let's write an if statement in here
let's say if
name is equal to
names with an index of i
then inside this if statement we are
going to print the contacts number for
that i can say
print numbers with an index of i
but right now there is a problem with my
code i'm not sure that if it's going to
work fine or not and that's because of
these two echo signs in here let's run
the application and see if it's going to
work
let's enter a name in here let's say
sero
and as you can see nothing has been
printed let's talk about these two equal
signs in here if you hover over the
warning in here it says that the string
values are compared using two equal
signs not
equal with a pair of parentheses the
problem in here is that when you are
using two equal signs you are checking
for the equality of two strings by the
reference i'm talking about the
reference inside the device's memory ram
whenever you are storing a variable that
variable allocates some space inside the
device's memory ram and that allocated
space has some address and that
allocated space has some reference in
which we are comparing those two
reference in here together so even if
the value of two strings in here can be
the same but the reference might not be
for that reason it's not a good way to
compare two strings by using these two
equal signs instead of using these two
equal signs there is a better option for
comparing two strings and that's the
equals method let's see that as well in
here i can say name
dot equals and inside the parenthesis i
can pass
the other string for example i can say
names with an index of i if you remember
from the previous videos i said that
strings are not primitive data type and
they are objects in java and because
they are objects we have some properties
on our strings for example this equals
method once again we are going to talk
about a method later on in the course
when we talk about object oriented
programming but for now just know that
there is a method called equals in our
string class in which we can use to
check the equality of two strings by
their values so now if we run our
application we should get the serial's
number
let's run the application
in here once again let's say 0
and as you can see we are getting the
number let's also check that if we are
getting the correct number sarah is the
second contact in our array and the
second element in our numbers array is
this number in which we have printed
into our console it seems like our
application is working fine okay i think
that's enough talking about arrays in
java in the next video finally we are
going to start talking about object
oriented programming that's a very
important topic and it's going to help
you a lot to understand java so make
sure to don't miss the next two or three
videos see you in the next video
as i said at the end of the previous
video in this video finally we are going
to start talking about object oriented
programming up until this point with the
help of variables we could have defined
simple data types for example if we
wanted to have numbers we could have say
in number is equal to five
or similarly we could have defined
characters texts and all sorts of
variables that we have talked about in
previous videos but what if we want to
have a more complex data for example how
can we define a car in java or a phone
or every other object that you can think
of well that is possible with the
concept of object oriented programming
in object oriented programming you
define your own objects the core
component of object oriented programming
are classes right now you can see that
we are inside the class this class is
named main but if we want we can create
our own class as well let me quickly
delete this line of code and let's
create a new class for example inside my
source folder
inside my package on the package i can
right click and by selecting new java
class i can create my class in here i
need to name my class for example i can
save phone notice that there is a
convention you need to use uppercases
for the first letter of the name of your
class also you cannot have spaces or
some strange characters as the name of
your classes so in here i'm just going
to simply name my class form notice that
there are other options in here as well
for example interface and eno later on
we will talk about them but for now
let's just create a class the one that
has the c icon by pressing enter we can
create our class this is how a class
looks like it lives inside the package
right now its package is
org.maycode.op section 1. also if you
take a look at the left pane in here you
can see that a new class has been added
into our package every class has the
keyword class in its declaration also
every class has a name and beside these
two has an access modifier we will talk
about access modifier in few minutes but
for now let's continue on every class
has a pair of curly braces in which we
can put our code inside them a class is
going to represent an object in this
case we are going to represent a phone
if you think of different objects
objects can have different properties
for example in the case of a phone a
phone can have some amount of memory ram
it can have a screen size beside that it
have a name and all sort of other
properties that you can think of when
you define a class you can have
properties for your classes as well for
example in this case if we want to give
some properties to our phone class we
can say something like this we can say
string name
now we define a property called name for
our phone notice that i'm not
initializing the property of my class in
here i'm not giving a name to my phone
and that's because when we declare a
class we can reuse that class we can
create multiple instances of that class
with different properties for example if
we define a new iphone the name would be
iphone if we define another phone the
name of that phone might be different so
for that reason i'm not initializing the
properties of my class let's add a few
more properties to our phone object
let's say int screen size
beside that let's say into memory ram
after that let's say int camera
so now that we have created this simple
class we can instantiate it we know for
sure that the starting point of our
application is this main method inside
our main class so if i need to
instantiate my class i need to do it in
here and here is how you can create an
instance of your class you type the name
of your class you can see that when i
type the name of my class i'm getting
some suggestions from intellij sometimes
you may get multiple options and that's
because different classes with different
names can live in different packages for
that reason always take a look at the
package that your object lives in in
this case i'm going to just import this
class after that you need to name your
instance for example i can say iphone
next i can say is equal to
new phone
this way with the help of this new
keyboard we can create a new instance of
our object now that we have created an
instance of our class we can have access
to the properties of our objects our
class for example if we want to define
some property for our class we can say
something like this we can say iphone
dot
let's say name
is equal to
let's name it iphone 11.
with the help of this dot operator you
can have access to all of the properties
or to be precise all of the fields of
your class similar to assigning a value
to your classes properties or fields you
can also get those properties or fields
and here is how you can get them for
example if you want to print the name of
our iphone we can say something like
this we can say print
iphone dot name
if we run our application we should see
iphone 11 printed into our console
and here is iphone 11. similar to that
you can have access to all of the fields
of your class for example i can say
iphone dot let's say memory ram is equal
to 8. beside properties your classes can
also have some behaviors for example in
the case of a phone you can play some
music with your phone or you can call
somebody if you want to define some
behavior for your class you can use
methods let's see them as well let's
switch back to our phone class here is
how you can define a method i'm going to
write the syntax and after that we will
talk about it
first of all our method has a name in
this case its name is play music after
that a method can have an axis modifier
like we did for the declaration of our
class we will talk about this public in
a minute after that every method can
have some inputs for example in this
case we are getting a string called
track name later on when we use this
method we need to pass some input to
this method if you don't want to have
any inputs for your method you can just
pass a pair of empty parentheses but if
you want you can have one or more inputs
if you want to have multiple inputs for
your method you can separate those
inputs with a comma for example in here
i can say string
album name but i'm not going to do that
in here but you can have as many inputs
as you want
beside a name an input and also an
access modifier every method can return
something in this case it's void but if
you want you can change it for example
you can say a string as the return type
of your method you can also have
integers
or other kind of primitive data types
even you can return another class with
your method but more on that later on if
you don't want to return anything from
your method you can use the keyword void
like we did before we will talk more
about the return type of every method
later on but for now we are not going to
return anything from this method so we
are going to pass void inside the curly
braces of my method i can put my code
for example in this case i'm going to
play some music or at least i'm going to
print something
in this case i'm just going to say
playing
plus the track name now that i have
created this method i can use it in my
main class where i have instantiated my
object for example in here i can say
iphone
dot play music once again you can see
that by typing dots i can have access to
my methods as well
right now i'm getting a red error in
here and that's because when i have
created my method i have set an input
for it so when i'm going to use my
method i need to pass a track name for
example let's say our wings are bearing
the name of a track
let's run the application and see what
could happen
you can see that we are playing some
music so by defining methods you can
have behaviors for your classes there
are few reasons for using methods the
first one is that you can reuse your
method for example in here after this
line of code i can say iphone
dot play music and i can pass a
different track name let's pass
lamenting is this time
if we run our application
you can see that our methods are being
executed one at a time so the first
benefit of using methods is that you can
reuse them the next one is for
organizing our code for example imagine
that you want to have some sort of
calculation you can pass
all the codes for that calculation into
a method and by calling that method you
can pass all of those calculations to a
method and later on you can just call
that method in order to do the
calculation it's going to help us a lot
for organizing our code also by using
methods you can encapsulate things we
will talk about encapsulation in later
videos but in here inside your class you
can define your methods as private and
that method will be accessible only from
your class and not from outside of your
class if you go back to main class you
can see that we are getting red warning
if you hover over the error it says that
this method has private access so by
using private methods you can
encapsulate different behaviors for your
own class okay now let's talk about this
access modifier you can have access
modifiers for your methods for your
classes and also for the fields of your
classes i can make this name private if
i want as well basically we have three
kind of access modifiers we have private
we have public
and also we have protected if you don't
use anything as the access modifier
it's equal to when you use public
so there is no difference between public
a string name or just a string name when
you use public as the access modifier
for example if i use public in here it
means that this field is going to be
accessible from other classes as well
but if i use private in here let's say
private if i go back to my main class
you can see that we are getting a red
warning it means that we can no longer
use this property so by setting the
access modifier of our field or method
that field or method is only accessible
from inside our class beside public and
private we also have protected we will
talk about protected later on in the
course but private and public are the
most access modifiers that we are going
to use in the course for the access
modifier of your class you can also have
private let me quickly type that but
usually you wouldn't do that right now
you can see that we are getting a red
warning in here and the warning says
that modifier private not allowed in
here you use private mostly when you use
inner classes we will talk about inner
classes later on in future videos but
basically they are some nested classes
inside other classes when you define
them as private classes you can have
access to those nested classes from the
parent class we will talk about that
later on when we talk about inner
classes for now let's just change this
one to public there are a few reasons
for using private as the access modifier
of your fields or methods the first one
is that you may want to limit the access
of your fields or methods to the class
itself and not other classes for example
imagine that you are writing some code
that you are going to publish for other
developers in that case you may want to
protect your classes against changes for
that reason you may want to change the
access modifiers of your fields and also
methods to private but now that we have
defined the access modifier of this
field as private how can we have access
to this name from outside of this class
there is a way to that let's quickly
talk about it we can create public
methods for example down in here i can
say public as the return type of this
method i'm going to say void for the
name of this method i'm going to say set
name as you can see when i use the
keyword set i am getting some
suggestions from intellij basically
there is a convention among programmers
to set the name of their setter methods
like this and intellij is smart enough
to know the convention but of course you
can name them whatever you want in this
case i'm going to follow the convention
so i'm going to say set name inside the
parentheses as the input of this method
i'm going to say
string
let's say name
inside this method i'm going to change
the value of this name to whatever the
name that i'm going to receive via this
method for that i can say this dot name
is equal to name
the keyboard this is referring to the
current object that we are in for
example right now we are inside our
phone object our phone class so by using
this dot name we are accessing the
property of this class called name the
second name in here is the input of our
method so we are setting the value of
this name to whatever we receive
via the input of this method now because
the access modifier of this method is
public we can use it inside other
classes for example from inside the main
class if we want to set the name of our
iphone we can say something like this
before that let's delete this line of
code we can say iphone
dot let's say set name
inside the parenthesis of this method i
need to pass the name of my phone
let's say iphone 11. so this way i don't
have access to the field directly but
by using the method i can change the
value of that field but what if we want
to get the value of this field well we
can write another method and here is how
we can create that method we can say
public as the return type of this method
i'm not going to say void because i'm
going to return this name so i'm going
to say string once again there is a
convention in here we can say get name
we don't need anything as the input
inside this method we are going to
return something and here is how you can
return something from a method you type
return
after that whatever you are going to
return in this case i am going to return
this name so i am going to say this dot
name once again this refers to the
current object this.names means the name
inside our phone object now that we have
created this method inside our main
class instead of saying iphone.name i
can say something like this i can say
iphone dot get name
if we run our application once again we
should see the name of our phone let's
run the application
you can see that iphone 11 has been
printed beside creating these kind of
methods ourselves we have another option
if we come down in here we can use the
help of our ide we can right click in
here we can go to this generate method
similarly we can press alt plus insert
you can see that in here we have a list
of options we have getter we have sether
and also we have getter and setter if we
want to create getters and setters we
can select that after that we can create
the field that we want to create getters
and setters for for example if we select
a camera and press ok you can see that
ide has created some codes for us you
can see that these methods are almost
identical to the methods that we created
above in here because creating getters
and setter methods are very usual ide
can help us with the creating of them
but why are we using getters and setters
well there are few reasons for that the
first reason is encapsulation let's
quickly talk about that a bit for
example if we don't want to give others
the permission to change the value of
our fields we can delete the setters in
that case we only give them the
permission to get the value of objects
but not set the value of objects or vice
versa we can create setter methods for
our class in that case we can set the
value of our properties from other
classes but we cannot get the value of
these properties the first reason is
encapsulation the other reason is that
sometimes in your setter and gether
methods you may want to do some other
operations as well for example if you
are setting a name for your phone you
may want to validate that name before
setting it in that case you can have
some validation before assigning the
value to your property okay that's
enough talking about getters and setters
let's quickly change the access
modifiers of all of these two private
and let's create getters and setters for
the ones that we didn't create any
down in here after everything i'm going
to press alt plus insert let's say
getters and setters and let's select
both of them you can see that intellij
has created these codes for us but
because we have changed the access
modifier of this memory ram to private
now we have an error inside our main
class in here instead of saying iphone
dot memory ram is equal to 8 i can say
something like this i can say iphone dot
set memory ram and i can pass 8. what we
did in here is one way of instantiating
our object we have defined our object
after that we have set different values
for our object there is another way of
instantiating your objects let's quickly
see that as well so if i switch back to
my phone class above the play music
method i can create something called
constructor let's use the help of ide
for creating that constructor once again
i'm going to go to generate menu the
first item in here is constructor in
here i'm going to select all of the
fields and i'm going to press ok and as
you can see this code has been generated
for us this is called a constructor in
object oriented programming our
constructor needs to have public as its
access modifier it cannot be private
after that the return type of this
constructor is a phone the exact item
that we are in our constructor does not
have any name and as the input of this
constructor we are receiving all of the
fields of our class we are receiving
name screen size memory ram and camera
inside our constructor we are assigning
different values that we have get via
the input to the fields of our class now
that we have created a constructor if we
switch back to our main class we can see
that we are getting a red warning in
here the warning says that expected four
arguments but found zero it means that
now that we have created the constructor
we need to pass the values directly to
the parentheses of this new phone and
here is how you can pass them the first
one was the name of our phone let's say
iphone 11
i don't remember the order of things but
the next one was screen size let's say
five i believe the next one was memory
ram let's say 8 and the other one was
camera
let's say 8 as well now that we have
instantiated our object like this we
don't need to directly set the fields of
our class we can safely delete this also
let's delete this as well
in this line we are printing the name of
our iphone let's run the application and
see if we can print the name correctly
as you can see iphone 11 has been
printed so when you are using
constructors you need to pass the values
of different properties at the time of
instantiating your objects your class
can have multiple constructors as well
for example if i come down in here and
once again right click and go to the
generate menu if i select constructor
this time i can select different items
for example in this case i am going to
select only name and memory run if i
press ok you can see that we have
another constructor which will only
receive name and memory run but if you
hover over this phone you can see that
this constructor is never used if we
switch back to our main class we can
create another phone and we can use the
second constructor let's quickly do that
i'm going to do that after this two line
of code let's say phone and this is the
beauty of object oriented programming
when you create a class you can reuse
that class as many times as you want for
example in here i'm going to define an
entirely new phone let's name this one
pixel
let's say is equal to new phone
this time i'm going to use the second
constructor for the name i'm going to
say pixel 3
and for the memory ram i'm going to say
16. you can see that the id is happy
with this way of defining a new form now
we have two different instances of our
phone class having two different kind of
constructors for a class is called
polymorphism in java polymorphism has
other types as well we will talk about
it later on okay i think that's a good
point to stop the video in here in the
next video we are going to continue our
talk about object oriented programming
there are many more things left that we
need to talk about see you in the next
video
in the previous video we have talked
briefly about classes what those are how
can we create them and also what are the
most usages of a class in this video we
are going to talk about some important
concepts regarding to object oriented
programming the first of those concepts
is inheritance i'm going to talk about
inheritance with an example because i
think that would make everything easier
to understand first of all i'm going to
create a class called dog
for this dog class i'm going to define
some properties for example i'm going to
define a name
let's say private string name after that
i'm going to define a color
let's say private string
color
let's also define the number of legs
let's say private int
legs
and also i'm going to define a boolean
indicating that if a dog has a tail or
not so let's say private boolean
let's name it as tail
let's also create a constructor for our
dock class by pressing alt plus insert
you can see the dialog in here let's
select all of the fields
let's also create some getters and
setters for our dog class as well once
again by pressing alt plus insert by
selecting this getter and setter you can
create getters and setters let's also
define a method for our doc class as
well i'm going to say public
void let's name this method it i'm going
to indicate the eating behavior of a dog
as the input of this method i'm going to
receive a food so let's say string food
and inside this method i'm just going to
print something let's say
eating
plus our food okay nothing special is in
this class first of all we have created
these four fields after that we have
created the constructor
we have created our getters and setters
and we have created this each method i
will talk about why i'm doing all of
this let's also create another class
called bird
let's say bird for this bird class let's
also have a name
also let's have a color
let's define two more fields one for the
number of legs private int legs and also
another one indicating that if our bird
has a tail or not so let's say private
boolean
let's say has tape
for this bird class let's also create a
constructor
and some getters and setters
i'm going to create my eat method for
despair class as well let's say public
void
eat
let's get the name of our food
and inside this method let's print
something
let's say eating that food
you probably can see the pattern in here
there are a lot of similarities between
our bird and dog class both of those
classes have four fields they have a
constructor they have all of these
getters and setters and both of them
have this eat method in programming this
is not efficient you basically are copy
and pasting yourself instead of defining
our bird and dog class like this we are
going to use another concept in object
oriented programming called inheritance
for that first of all i'm going to
create an animal class and after that i
will extend the animal class to despair
and dog let's see how we can do that
inside my package i'm going to create my
annual class
let's say animal first of all let's add
some fields i'm going to use the four
previous fields let's also copy them
from here
and after that let's create a
constructor
and getters and setters and our eat
method
don't worry we will reduce the amount of
copy and pasting in a minute let's say
public
void eat
string food as the input and let's print
the name of our food
now that we have created this animal
class creating bird and dog class is
going to be much simpler
for that i am going to delete all of the
codes inside this bird class let's
delete all of them
this time instead of defining all of the
fields and constructors and methods i'm
going to say extend
animal
this way we are saying that our bird is
an animal we are extending the animal
class and later on if we want we can
customize our birth class as well but
right now you can see that we are
getting a red warning and the warning in
here says that there is no default
constructor available in this package
basically it says that you need a
constructor let's press alt plus insert
in here and let's select constructor and
as you can see the id has generated this
constructor you can also see that even
though we don't have any fields in our
birth class we are receiving some
arguments in the constructor but this
constructor has rather a strange syntax
we haven't seen this super keyboard so
far basically this super keyboard means
that do whatever you are doing with
these parameters in the parent class in
this case our parent class is animal so
this super is passing all of these
arguments to the constructor of our
animal class it means that it's setting
all of the values to the fields of our
animal now that i have created my birth
class like this if i want to instantiate
it for example inside the main class i
can do as before let's say bird let's
name it phoenix
let's say is equal to new bird
and as you can see the constructor is
waiting for our arguments first of all
we need a name let's pass nino we need a
color let's say golden
after that we need the number of legs
which i'm going to pass to and a boolean
indicating if our bird has a tail or not
let's pass through once again remember
that in our birth class we didn't have
any extra methods but in my main class
if i want i can use some of the gether
methods of our parent class in this case
animal for example if i want to get the
name of my birth i can say something
like this i can say
phoenix.getname you can see that we have
all of the getter methods let's run the
application and let's see if we can
print the name of our bird
you can see that the name has been
printed successfully beside getter and
setter method you can also have access
to all of the other methods that you
have created for example if you remember
inside the animal class we have created
this each method let's see if we can use
it in our birth instance for example in
here if i say phoenix
dot it i don't know what phoenix is it
but let's just pass meat
and let's run our application and let's
see if we can successfully execute the
eat method and as you can see in here
nina is eating meat now that you have
created your bird class you can also
change the dog class as well for example
in here i'm going to delete all of these
codes once again
instead i'm going to extend the animal
class once again let's say extends
animal
you can see the red warning and that's
because we need a constructor you can
see that the amount of similar codes
that you were copying and pasting is a
lot less right now the bird and dog
class are basically the same but we know
for sure that a dog and a bird are not
the same they may have other fields and
also other behaviors as well if you want
you can customize your child classes as
well for example inside my birth class i
want to add another field i'm going to
say private let's say ain't
wings
you know that dogs do not have wings in
here i'm going to delete this
constructor and i'm going to create it
once again because i'm going to use the
help of my ide let's press alt plus
insert in here i'm going to select wings
and this time as you can see the
constructor has been changed a little
bit the super statement is as the same
it means that do whatever you are doing
with all of these
four fields but because inside our
parent class inside the animal class we
do not have a wings field this wings
hasn't been passed to this super
statement so we are setting the value of
links directly inside the constructor of
the spared class this way we can
customize our child classes right now
the doc does not have any
wings field but our bird does but right
now if i switch back to my main class i
should get a warning and the warning in
here says that you need to pass a wing
let's also pass that in here as well for
example i'm going to say two we can also
create getter and setter methods for
these wings as well for example inside
our bird class down in here let's press
alt plus insert and let's select theater
and setters now that we have created the
getters and setters let's see if we can
print the number of wings for example
down in here i'm going to say phoenix
dot get wings
let's run the application
and you can see that 2 has been printed
as the number of wings beside gether and
setter methods you can also have other
methods inside your child class as well
for example inside this part class if i
want i can define a fly method as well
let's quickly see that let's say public
void
fly
i'm not going to receive anything as the
input let's just print something
let's say this dot
get name also if you remember from the
previous video i said that this keyword
refers to the current object that you
are in in this case inside the bird
class we don't have any get name method
but because we are extending the animal
class we can use this dot get name
let's say it's flying
so beside using fields you can also
customize your child classes with
different methods let's see if you can
call this method from inside our main
class let's say
phoenix.floyd
as you can see nina is flying also
beside defining new methods inside your
child class you can also change the
behavior of methods of your parent class
for example if you remember inside the
animal class we had this eat method i'm
talking about this one which inside this
method we are saying eating food inside
our bird class if we want we can change
that for example right in here i'm going
to press control plus o
you can see that we are seeing a list of
different methods i'm going to overwrite
this it method so by overriding you are
going to say that i am going to change
the behavior of this eat method from
what is happening inside the parent
class once again we are seeing this
super keyword it means that do whatever
you are doing with this parameter inside
the parent class if you want you can
delete this super statement completely
but let it be for now we will delete
that later on after this super keyboard
i'm going to print another statement in
here
let's just say eating finished
so this way we have changed the eat
method inside our child class from what
it was inside the animal class right now
inside our main class we have executed
this line of code phoenix.it let's
comment the lines after that so that we
can see what's going to be the behavior
of this each method let's run the
application you can see that we are
saying eating meat and after that eating
finished if you want to completely
change the behavior of your method
inside the child class you can simply
delete this super.eat method for example
in here i'm going to say chewing food
instead of eating food
so in both child and parent class we
have this eat method but their behavior
is different let's run the application
and see if we can see the difference you
can see that we are chewing meat so what
we did so far is called inheritance in
object oriented programming we have
inherited the birth class from the
animal class you can also continue this
inheritance multiple times for example
if you want you can inherit the dog
object let's quickly create another
class in here
for example let's say shepherd
now in here i can say extend the dark
class you can see that once again we are
getting this red warning let's create
our constructor in order to overcome
that problem you can see that even
though inside the dark field we do not
have any field but inside our shepherd
class in the constructor we need all of
those arguments because the parent of
this shepherd class which is dog is the
child of another class which is animal
so you can do this inheritance as many
times as you want you can also create
another class and extend the shepherd
class but i don't think that mean
anything in here i just wanted to say
that you have that option okay i think
that's enough talking about inheritance
the other concept that i'm going to talk
about is called polymorphism we have
talked a bit about polymorphism in the
previous video but let's talk more about
it in here so in previous video i said
that one kind of polymorphism is that
for a class to have multiple
constructors for example inside our
animal class if we had another
constructor in here which will accept
different number of fields for example
the first three now that we have two
constructor this is one kind of
polymorphism now we can create this
animal class in two different ways
basically polymorphism means having
multiple forms but there are two more
kind of polymorphism but before we talk
about that let's delete this constructor
i'm not sure that if you are going to
need that the other kind of polymorphism
that we have used so far is about this
each method so inside this animal class
we had this heat method but also we had
it inside the child class which is birth
but these two eat methods have different
forms it means that we are doing
different things inside each one of
these methods this is another kind of
polymorphism two methods inside parent
and a child class that are doing the
same job differently we also have
another kind of polymorphism and that's
with the methods themselves we don't
have this fly method inside our animal
class but in here we can also have
another method called fly as well let's
quickly see how we can create another
method called flight i'm going to say
public void
fly
but this time inside the parenthesis i'm
going to receive some arguments for
example i'm going to received a speed
as you can see the compiler is happy
with this way of defining two different
methods with the same name now if i
switch back to my main class you can see
that we are not getting an error but
before that i think i should uncomment
this line of code even though we are not
getting a red warning this in here it
means that we are using the first fly
method let me close all of the
unnecessary classes inside the birth
class we are using the first method but
if you want to use the second method we
just need to pass some arguments in here
for example let's pass 100. we can have
methods with the same name when we have
different number of arguments or
alternatively when we have different
kind of arguments for example in this
case we are passing integer
but if we had another method for example
in which we pass a string that method
can have the fly name as well let's see
that quickly let's say public void fly
and inside the parenthesis i don't know
let's pass a string let's just say name
you can see that the compiler is happy
with this way of defining a method with
the same name so beside the difference
in the number of parameters the kind of
parameter is also important this in here
is also called polymorphism using
methods with the same name in different
ways okay let's delete these two i don't
think we are going to need them and i
think it's a good point to stop the
video in here in the next video first
thing we are going to start talking
about composition in object oriented
programming see you in the next video
in the previous video we have talked
about inheritance and polymorphism in
this video we are going to talk about
composition in object-oriented
programming in previous videos i said
that classes are useful for when you
want to define your customized data type
for example imagine that you are going
to create a car in that car you have
multiple systems for example you have a
system for a stereotype your car also
may have some engine it can also have a
fuel system if you want to simulate a
car in programming you can create
different classes for example for engine
for a stereo system and also for fuel
system and after that inside your car
class you can compose all of those
classes to have a car let's see how we
can use composition in java in my
package i'm going to create a class
called engine
for this engine i'm going to have two
fields first of all i'm going to define
a model so let's say private string
model and after that let's have an
integer private int i'm going to name
this integer rpm rpm stands for round
per minute it's just a property of
different engines i'm going to keep it
really simple so i think these two would
be enough after that let's quickly
create our constructor and getters and
setters let's create a car class and
let's see how we can use this engine
inside that
let's say new java class let's name it
car for this car class i'm going to
define four fields first of all let's
pass a name private string name
after that let's have an integer for the
number of doors
after that let's define the color of our
card private string color
and after that i'm going to include or
compose an engine in here for that i can
simply say private engine with capital e
and in here you can see that in my
package i have an engine class i can
import that into this class let's name
it engine for the sake of simplicity i
have composed only one class inside this
class but if you want you can create
another class for a stereo system and
fuel system and everything else that you
want but i think you would get my point
if i use only one class after that like
other classes i can create my
constructor
you can see that this engine has been
passed to our constructor the same way
that we have passed other data types
like integers and strings we can also
have getters and setters the same way
that we had for
previous classes now that we have
created this card we can instantiate it
for example inside our main class for
example if i want to have a car object
in here i can say car let's name it
mercedes
is equal to new car
as you can see the constructor in here
requires four fields a name doors color
and also an engine for the name i'm
going to pass mercedes amg
for the number of doors let's pass two
for the color let's say silver but what
should we pass as the engine in here
well we can pass our engine in two ways
first of all we can create our engine
before this car class for example in
here i can say engine
let's name it engine is equal to new
engine
and i can pass a model and rpm for this
engine to instantiate it for example i'm
going to say
green out
for the rpm let's say
after creating our engine objects we can
pass it to the constructor of our car
for example in here i can say engine and
like that we can create our car but the
other way is to
pass your engine directly to the
constructor of your car for example i
can say new engine in here
and i can instantiate my engine objects
directly inside the constructor let's
say renault
and let's pass 8000 now that we have
passed it directly we don't need the
first line of course we know that
mercedes wouldn't use renault engine but
i think it doesn't matter in here now
that we have instantiated our car object
we can have access to all of the fields
like we did before for example if you
want to print the name of our card we
can say something like this we can say
mercedes dot name or dot get name to her
size but what if we want to get the
model of the engine of this car well for
that we can say something like this
let's print
engine model
plus we can say mercedes dot
get engine this method in here after
that we can once again say dot get model
so this get engine method will return an
engine object in which we can perform
another dot operator on that let's run
the application and see what would be
the result first of all you can see the
name of our car and after that you can
see the engine model which is renowned
also instead of using the methods of
your engine you can get the engine
object directly for example in here
before the printer statement i'm going
to say
engine let's name it engine is equal to
let's say mercedes dot get engine you
can see the return type in here but
whenever you are not sure about the
return type you can press down the
control key and by hover over in your
method you can see the return type you
can see the declaration of your method
which says public engine get engine it
means that this method is going to
return an engine object now that you
have your instance of engine you can
perform all kind of operations on that
instead of pressing down the control key
and hover over your method there is
another option to get the return type
and for that matter the declaration of
your method and here is how you can do
that you can click on the name of your
method and you can press down the
control q this way you can see some
information about the declaration of
your method these kind of documentations
are especially useful for when you are
using a third-party library or some
built-in methods for example if we click
on this print line method and press ctrl
q you can see that the documentation is
giving us much more information for
example in this case it says that this
method is printing a string and then
terminate the line you can see some
information about the method itself also
if you want you can have this kind of
information on the methods that you
yourself create for example on this get
engine method if we switch to our car
class we can create some sort of
documentation let's find that method and
here is how you can do that you need to
add a comment in here in previous videos
we have seen how to create a new comment
by using two slashes we could have uh
create our comment but these kind of
comments are not useful in here instead
we can use a single slash and after that
we can have two stars by pressing and
enter you can see that we have these
sort of comments as well these kind of
comments are useful for when you have
multiple lines and in here you can have
some sort of information in which later
on will be shown when you press control
q on the name of your method for example
in here let's say it returns the engine
of our car
now that we have provided this
information in here if we switch back to
our main class on the declaration of our
method on the name if we press ctrl q
you can see that in here we can see that
information sometimes this kind of
commenting can be useful as well but
there are more to this kind of
commenting for example we can provide
some links but more on that later on in
future videos so this way of using
different classes inside other classes
is called composition in object-oriented
programming once again if you have
created some other classes for example a
stereo system class and also a fuel
system class you could have add them one
by one in here as well but for the sake
of simplicity i've just included this
engine this way we can compose different
objects inside one class okay i think
that's enough talking about composition
let's talk about a keyboard in java
called null before that let's close this
car class and let's comment all of these
lines of codes
there are some times that you don't want
to instantiate your objects immediately
for example down in here i can say car
mercedes
is equal to i don't want to instantiate
my car object in here like we did before
instead i want to postpone that to few
lines after this for that you can pass
null values for your objects let's see
null in here as well this null keyword
in java means nothing it means that this
car mercedes is nothing when the value
of an object is null you cannot perform
any kind of operation on that for
example in here i cannot say mercedes
dot get name for example we are not
getting a compile time error it means
that our application is going to be
created but if you take a look at the
highlight in here it says that this
method is going to produce null pointer
exception if you remember from previous
videos i said that whenever null pointer
exception happens your application is
going to crash so the error in here is
going to be a runtime error and not a
compile time error let's run our
application and let's see what would
happen you can see that in here we are
getting a red warning in our console
says java.lang.nullpointerexception
in general we should always avoid
exceptions in our application later on
we will talk about how can we do that
but for now let's just assume that we
know whenever an object is null we
cannot perform any operation on that for
example we cannot use the methods inside
that object so whenever you are not sure
about null values for example whenever
you are retrieving some data from a web
server or from your local database first
of all you need to check that if your
object is null or not and here is how
you can do that for example you can
create an if statement before this
mercedes dot get name i can say if let's
say mercedes is not equal to null
i'm going to put an if statement in here
in case
our object is not null we are going to
call this method but in the else case
i'm going to print something
let's say the car was now
let's run the application once again
this time you can see that we are not
seeing the exception which is good but
right now we are not doing anything
helpful
with our value being now we are just
printing something sometimes this is the
desired behavior but sometimes you may
want to check that what was the cause of
your object to be known so null means
nothing in java okay let's comment all
of these
and let's talk about another keyword in
java called final so up to this point
when we wanted to instantiate our object
or variable we could have said something
like this we could have set int a is
equal to phi for example later on we
could have changed this a for example
because i have said a is equal to
five plus one or a plus one
this way we could have changed the value
of our variable but there are some times
that you need to be sure that the value
of your variable wouldn't change in
those cases you can use the final
keyword and here is how you can do that
before the type of your variable you can
say final final int a is equal to five
now if i try to change the value of my
variable for example like before if i
say a is equal to a plus one you can see
that we are getting a warning in here
the warning says that cannot assign a
value to a final variable so whenever
you are declaring your variables and
classes as final you cannot change the
value of that variable or class let's
also check the case when we define our
classes as final i'm going to comment
this to line of code
and down in here i'm going to say final
let's say engine let's name it engine is
equal to new engine
let's pass a model and rpm
now if i try to change the value of this
engine for example if i say engine
is equal to new engine
with other parameters
for example let's change the rpm let's
say 7000 once again you can see the
error the error says that cannot assign
a value to final variable but there is a
point in here when you declare your
objects as final you cannot change the
whole instance of that object but you
can change the properties of your object
for example
in here if you remember inside our
engine class we had two setter methods
which with the help of them we could
have changed the value of two properties
for example if we wanted to change the
rpm
we could have said something like engine
dot
set rpm to let's say 10 000. you can see
that even though we declared our engine
as final
we can change its properties we just
cannot change the whole instance we can
change its properties using final
keyboards can be useful from time to
time okay i think that's enough for this
video in the next video we are going to
have a quick challenge to make sure that
we have understand the concepts of
object oriented programming see you in
the next video
this is our challenge
imagine that you are a doctor and you
want to check on your patient
in this application first of all you are
showing the name and age of the user to
the doctor
and after that you can see a list of
different organs in which the doctor can
select the first organ is left eye let's
select that
in here you can see that we are seeing
some details about the organ for example
the name the medical condition and also
the color of the eye
after that we gave the doctor the option
to close the eye and also if the eye is
closed we are going to open that let's
select one in here to close the eye you
can see that left eye closed once again
we are seeing the list of our organs
let's select two in this case
this time if i don't want to close or
open the eye i can put any number beside
one for example if i put two in here you
can see that once again we are seeing
the list of different organs
let's select three to see the heart
once again you can see that we are
seeing some details about the heart
after that we have the ability to change
the heart rate in a normal doctor
patient situation this wouldn't be the
available option but
in here we just want to demonstrate some
behavior for our heart organ so if we
select one in here
the scanner is asking for our new heart
rate which i can put 75
and you can see that heart rate changed
to 75.
let's select a stomach
once again you can see the details of
the stomach we have one behavior in here
which is digest
if we select that you can see that
digesting has began once again this is a
hypothetical situation and in a normal
situation
you cannot order the patient to digest
the food
let's also select five in here to see
the scheme
this time for the skin you can see that
we are not seeing any behavior instead
we are just seeing some details
after that once again we have our list
in which if we put six or for that
matter any other number
we will close the application let's put
six in here and as you can see
application has been exited successfully
by solving this challenge i want you to
practice the object-oriented programming
concepts that we have talked about in
the past three videos
so make sure to use them okay pause the
video in here and go solve the challenge
after that come back to the video and
let's see my solution for the challenge
as well
here is my solution for the challenge
first of all i'm going to create a
package inside my source folder
let's name it org
org.makeout.opchallenge
inside this package i'm going to create
my organ class
inside this organ class i'm going to
have two fields
let's say private string
name and also private string medical
condition
i'm going to keep it simple so i think
these two would be fine
after that let's create a constructor
and after that let's create all of the
getters and setters
i'm not sure that we are going to use
all of these getters and setters
later on if we didn't use them we just
simply delete them beside these i'm
going to have another method inside this
class
named get details let's see that as well
let's say public void
get details
and let's print some details about this
organ
first of all let's say
name
plus this dot get name
after that let's print a medical
condition of this organ as well
medical condition
plus this dot get medical condition
that's all we need inside this organ
class let's quickly create our organs
one by one
first of all i'm going to create an
organ called i
let's say i
inside this eye class i'm going to have
a string called color
and after that let's have a boolean
indicating if the i is open or not
so let's say private boolean
is opened
after that it's time to extend the organ
class
let's say extend
organ
in here we are using inheritance
now it's the time to create our
constructor let's select both of these
two fields
and after that let's create all of the
getters and setters once again i'm not
sure that we are going to use all of
these getters and setters
later on if we didn't use them we just
simply delete them
okay let's override the get details
method i can do that by pressing ctrl o
by selecting get details method now we
can change this method
for example in this case let's also
print the color of the eye
let's say color
plus this dot get color
inside this i class i'm going to have
two other methods as well let's see them
let's say public void
open
inside this open method i'm going to
change the value of this boolean to true
so let's say this dot
set opened and let's pass through
after that let's print something
indicating the i has been opened
let's say
this dot get name
you can see that we don't have any get
name method inside this class we are
using the get name from the parent class
which is organ
let's say plus
opened
let's have another method called close
i'm going to say public void
close
once again first of all i'm going to
change the value of the boolean to false
let's say this dot set opened and let's
pass false
after that let's print something
let's say this dot get name
plus closed
that's all we need inside this i class
let's quickly create another class for
the heart
let's say heart
for this heart class i'm going to add
another field called rate let's say
private int rate
it's time to extend the organ class
extends organ
and after that we need to create our
constructor
after that we need to create our getters
and setters
i'm pressing alt plus insert to get that
dialog in case that's confusing for you
after that it's time to
overwrite the get details method by
pressing ctrl plus all
and by selecting get details method we
have that
in here i'm just going to print the
heart rate
let's say
plus this dot get heart rate or get rate
that's all we need to do inside this
heart class let's quickly create a
stomach class
let's say stomach
inside this islamic class i'm going to
have a boolean let's say private boolean
is empty
indicating if the islamic is empty or
not
after that it's time to extend the organ
class
extends organ
and after that we need to create our
constructor
let's create our getters and setters
and after that let's override the
getdetails method
inside this getdetails method first of
all i'm going to check that if the
stomach is empty or not so let's say if
this dot
is empty
i'm going to use the method in here
if the stomach is empty i'm going to
print something
i'm going to say need to be fed
but in the else case
let's just print stomach is full
let's also create another method for
this class called digest
let's say public void
digest
let's just print something
let's say digesting begin
okay we are done with our stomach class
let's quickly create a skin class as
well
for this skin class i'm going to define
two more fields first of all i'm going
to define a string for the color of the
skin
after that i'm going to define an
integer for the softness of the skin
let's say private int softness
this integer is going to be some number
from 0 to 100 indicating the softness of
the skin after that it's time to extend
the organ class
and after that we need to create our
constructor
next we need to create our getters and
setters
and after that let's overwrite the get
details method
inside this method let's also print a
skin color
let's say skin color
plus this dot
get color
that's all of our organs now we can
create our patient class
inside my package let's create a patient
class
for this patient first of all i'm going
to have a string for its name
after that we are going to have an
integer for the age of the patient
after that we can create our organs for
example i'm going to say private eye
let's say left eye
let's do the same for the right eye
let's also have a heart
after that maybe a stomach and a skin
okay that's all of our fields for the
patient let's create the constructor
and let's create all of the getters and
setters
we don't need any special method inside
this patient class
inside our main class which we need to
create we can instantiate it
let's create our main class
first of all in here we are going to
create our main method
after that we can create our patient
object but before that let's minimize
this project pain
let's say patient let's name it patient
is equal to new patient
first of all we need a name in here
let's say brad
after that we need the age let's say 28
after that we need the left eye which i
can say new i for this eye first of all
we need a name let's say left eye
after that we need the medical condition
which i'm going to say
shortsighted
for the color let's say blue
for the is open boolean let's say true
we need the same thing for the right eye
new i
let's just change the name to right
eye
also let's change the medical condition
to normal
after that we need a heart
let's say new heart
for the medical condition let's say
normal
and for the rate of the heart let's just
say 65
i think the next organ was a stomach so
let's say new stomach
the name would be stomach
the medical condition i'm just going to
enter a name of some medical condition
i'm going to say pud
public ulcer disease in case if you're
wondering
and for the is empty let's say false
after that we need a skin let's say new
skin
for the color of the skin or first of
all we need the name
let's say skin
[Music]
for the medical condition let's say
burnt
after that what do we need
we need the color and also softness for
the color let's say
white
for the softness let's say 40 out of 100
okay that's our patient object now we
need to create the logic for our
application
first of all i'm going to print the name
and age of the patient so let's say
print
name
plus patient dot get name
after that do the same thing for the age
we are going to receive the user's input
so we need the scanner
let's say a scanner scanner is equal to
new scanner
let's pass system dot in
also now that we know about object
oriented programming we know how this
scanner is working this is just a class
with this new keyboard we are
instantiating it inside the constructor
of this scanner we need this system.in
whatever that is so this way we have
created an instance of this scanner
after that i'm going to define a boolean
let's say boolean
let's name it short finish
and initially i'm going to set it to
false
later on we will see that how this one
is going to be useful
after that i'm going to create a while
loop let's say while
should finish is not equal to true
continue looping
inside the while loop i am going to show
a list of different organs for that i
can say
choose an organ
in here i have two options i can use
this system.out.printlines
line after line
or the better option is to use backslash
m let's see that as well first of all
let's go to the next line in order to
have a cleaner code in here i can say
backslash n this backslash n moves the
cursor to the next line the other one
that i'm going to use in here is called
backslash t
this backslash t will add a tab to our
text later on we will see exactly what
these two are doing
okay the first organ is left eye
the next one is right eye
after showing this list to the user i'm
going to receive the user's input so i'm
going to say int choice
is equal to
scanner.nextint
we have seen this in previous videos so
i'm not going to explain in here we are
just going to receive the user's input
after that depending on this choice i'm
going to create a switch statement let's
say switch on choice
and let's create our different cases
in case the user's choice is one
first of all we are going to print the
details about the left eye so let's say
patient dot get left eye
dot get details
next i'm going to give the user the
option to open or close the eye for that
i need to check that if the eye is
opened or closed
so let's say if dot get left i dot is
opened
we need to close it or at least we need
to give the option to close the eye
let's print something in here
let's say backslash t backslash d in
order to have two tabs
after that let's say
close
or close the eye
next we need to get the user's input in
case if it's one we are going to close
the i
so let's say
if scanner.nextint
is equal to one
then we need to say patient dot get left
i dot
closed i or close
but in the else case we are just going
to continue to the next record in the
else case of the first if statement this
one in here in case the i is not opened
we are going to show the option to open
the i so let's say else we need the same
logic we can print something
backslash t backslash t one
open the i
next we need to get the user's input
let's say if
scanner.nextint is equal to 1
we are going to say patient dot
get left i dot
open
in the else case we are just going to
continue
by continue i mean once again we are
going to show the list of different
organs
okay that's our first case we also need
a break in here
let's write the second case the second
case is the right eye we basically can
copy and paste all of these logic
but we just need to change the left eye
to right eye
so for example in here let's say get
right eye
okay we are done with our second case
let's also write the case for the heart
let's say case three
first of all let's show the details of
the heart let's say patient
dot get heart
dot get details
after that we are going to give the user
to change the heart rate for that let's
say
backslash t backslash t1
change the heart rate
once again we need to listen for the
user's input so let's say if
the
scanner.nextint is equal to 1
we need to ask for the new heart rate so
let's say
enter a new heart rate after that we
need to save that heart rate so let's
say int
is equal to
scanner.nextint
after that we can say
dot get heart dot
let's say set rate and let's pass our
new heart rate but in the else case like
before we are going to continue
we also need a break in here let's
quickly add that and also after changing
the heart rate it's better to show some
message
let's say heart rate changed to
plus
patient dot get heart dot
get rate
okay that's our third case
the fourth one was for the stomach so
let's say case four
first of all we need to print the
details of the stomach patient that get
the stomach
dot get details
for the stomach we had the digest option
so in here let's show that option
backslash g backslash g let's say digest
let's say if
the scanner that next int
is equal to 1
if that's the case let's say patient dot
get stomach
dot digest
but in the else case
let's just continue
we also need a break in here let's
quickly add that
the fifth case is for the skin
let's say case five
for the skin we didn't have any option
we just need to print the details let's
say patient.getscheme
dot getdetails
of course after that we need to add a
break
in here i'm going to add a default case
and if the user enters any other number
than this five we are going to quit the
application for that we are going to
change the value of this should finish
boolean to true
after that we need a break
okay i think our application is ready to
test let's see how did we do
in here we can see the name and age of
the patient which is good we can also
see the list of our organs once again
it's good
let's select left eye
we can see the details of the left eye
and also we have this close the eye
option let's put another number beside
this one let's say two
once again we can see the list of our
organs let's see if we can close the
left eye let's put one in here
and as you can see left eye has been
closed okay let's check the right eye
it's working the same
let's enter two in here in order to show
the list of organs
and let's select our heart
we can see the heart details which is
good let's see if we can change the
heart rate let's select one in here the
console is waiting for the new heart
rate let's say 75
and as you can see heart rate has been
changed to 75.
let's check it once again in order to
make sure of that let's say three
and as you can see the heart rate is 75.
let's put two in order to show the list
of organs
and let's select four in order to see
the stomach if you can see all of the
details of the stomach let's digest some
food
and as you can see digesting has began
let's check the skin which is five
you can see that we are getting the
details of the skin but we don't have
any option
that seems to be good
and if we enter any other number than
this five we should quit the application
let's enter seven in here for example
and as you can see application has been
finished successfully
okay it seems like our application is
working fine let's just delete the
getter and setter methods that we set
that we will delete if we didn't use
them let's check the classes one by one
first of all inside the i class
everything that is grayed out it means
that we never use that for example we
never use this set color method
okay it seems to be good inside the
heart class
i think we have used all of them okay
that's fine
inside the organ class
and we didn't need this set medical
condition method and also we didn't need
this set name method
inside the patient class let's see what
do we have in there
and i think we didn't use any of the
setters of this patient class let's just
delete them
okay that seems to be good let's see
what do we have inside a screen class
and in here we never use these setters
and this get softness method
let's delete them
inside the stomach class
let's delete this set empty method
and in order to make sure of everything
let's just run our application one more
time
okay it seems like we don't have any
compile time error which seems to be
fine okay that was our challenge about
object oriented programming concepts i
will upload the source code at the links
that you can see on the screen feel free
to check them and also i'm more than
happy to see your feedback about the
code in the next video we will talk
about collections in java see you in the
next video
in previous videos we have seen simple
arrays in java for example if we wanted
to store a list of different names we
could have said something like this we
could have set a string with a pair of
square bracket after that we could have
named our array and after that we could
have initialized our string array like
this inside the square bracket in here
we needed to pass the size of our array
for example 5. the other way was to pass
our elements at the time of
instantiating our array for example we
could have set a pair of curly braces
and inside those curly braces we could
have passed our elements let's pass a
few names in here
after that if we wanted to have access
to these elements we could have say
something like this we could have said
print let's say names with an index of
let's say two for the third element
which is brad in this case if we run our
application right now we should see brad
let's run it
you can see that brad has been printed
but if you remember i said that using
this kind of simple arrays in java has a
lot of limitations for example the first
limitation is that their size is
immutable it means that their size
cannot be changed right now we have five
elements inside our names array if we
want to add another item inside this
array we cannot do that for example we
cannot say something like names with an
index of 5 which indicates the 6th
element we cannot assign a value to that
you can see that in here we have a red
warning and if we try to run our
application we get an exception let's
see the exception
the exception in here is array index out
of bound exception also when working
with simple arrays in java you don't
have that much options later on we will
see that when we use different kind of
collections we can operate all sort of
operations on our collections in which
we do not have them in simple arrays if
we want to add a sixth element to our
array we can create a new array and
after that we can copy all of the
elements from inside this array right
now for the situation that we have in
here if we want to add another item to
our array we can create another array
with the size of 6 after that we can
copy all of these elements to that array
and after everything we can add this new
item for example in here i can say
string array
let's name it new names
is equal to new string array with the
size of 6 after that i can create a for
loop let's say for inst i is equal to 0
i less than names.length
and i plus plus
inside that for loop first of all i need
to add all of the names to this new
names array i can say new names with an
index of i is equal to names with an
index of i this way we can copy all of
the elements from inside this names
array to this new names array after
copying all of the elements after the
for loop i can say new names with an
index of 5
is equal to jerry
this way we can get around this problem
for example if i comment this line and
run my application maybe after that
print the 6 element inside our new names
we have a solution but as you can see
this solution is not that much effective
let's quickly print this
you can see jerry has been printed in
here but as you can see there are a lot
of codes involved and beside that if
your array has a lot of elements for
example a million elements this process
can be really time consuming besides
that it can be resource consuming if you
are downloading this array from the
internet so this solution in here is not
effective instead of copy and pasting
the whole array we are going to use
collections let's delete all of these
codes in java we have multiple kinds of
collections the first of which i'm going
to talk about in here is called
arraylist let's quickly see that
so we type arraylist with capital a
after that inside a pair of anchor
bracket or as some might call them
diamonds we need to define the type of
our arraylist object for example i can
say a string
after that we need to name our arraylist
for example i can say names
is equal to neoarraylist as simple as
that we have an arraylist this is one
way of defining your arraylist there is
also another way let's quickly see that
so instead of saying arraylist string we
can say list you can see that the icon
in here is different it's an interface
we will talk about interfaces later on
in the course but for now just know that
there are two ways of defining your
arraylist let's see how can we use this
list to create an arraylist we can say
list of strings for example
once again let's name our list for
example let's say students
is equal to neo arraylist there is a
slight difference in here but i just
wanted to show you both ways of defining
your arraylist okay let's delete this
line for now right now our arraylist is
empty and if you want to add some
elements to this array list we can
simply say names dot add we can use this
add method in order to add elements into
our arraylist for example let's add one
you can use this add method as many
times as you want if i want to add
another element i can simply do that
so the first benefit of using arraylist
is clear now the size of arraylist is
mutable it means that we can change the
size of arraylist after adding some
elements to your arraylist you can get
those elements by using the get method
let's quickly see that for example let's
print the first element i can say
names.get
you can see that this get method
requires an index once again indexes in
java start from zero so if i pass zero
in here it means that i'm going to get
the first element right now if i run my
application i should see mason printed
into the console you can see that mesam
has been printed also when using
arraylists you can also get the size of
your arraylist for example if i want to
print the size of my arraylist i can say
something like this i can say names dot
size
let's run the application and see what
would be the result you can see that the
size of our arraylist is two you have
all sort of options when using
arraylists you can also clear all of the
elements inside your arraylist for
example i can say names dot clear
this clear method removes all of the
elements inside your arraylist after
clearing if i once again get the size of
my arraylist
this time the size should be zero and as
you can see down in here it's zero if
you want you can also remove one element
from your array list let's quickly see
that i can say names dot
remove this remove method requires an
object it means that we need to pass the
whole element
so let's say
meson for example but before that let me
quickly comment this line because we
don't want to clear our arraylist and
after removing mesa let's print the
first element
inside our array list
let's say
names.get and let's pass 0 as the index
as you can see the first element right
now is 0. it means that masam has been
removed successfully let's see what
other options do we have on our
arraylist let's type names by typing
dots we can see the list of options we
can also check that if an option exists
in our
arraylist for example if i use this
contains method once again it requires
an object let's say mesa
let's print this whole line of code this
contains method returns a boolean so
right now if i run my application
because we have removed mesa we should
see false we can see that that's good
but if we change this to 0
we should see true
and true it is you can also check that
if your arraylist is empty or not for
that you can print something for example
you can say names
dot is empty we have this method once
again it's returning a boolean
right now we have 0 in our array list so
it shouldn't be empty and as you can see
we are receiving false but if we remove
sarah before this line of code we should
see true let's quickly do that names dot
remove
and let's pass zero
this time you can see that true has been
printed you can also get the index of
some element from inside your arraylist
as well let's quickly see that before
everything i'm going to comment all of
these lines of code because i want to
have a clear console
down in here let's say print
names dot index off and in here i can
pass my object for example i can pass
mesa right now masam is the first
element so we should see zero printed
you can see that it's zero but if we
don't have that element inside our
arraylist for example if we pass brad in
here we should see negative one
and as you can see negative one has been
printed when you are using arraylists
you can only have objects as the type of
elements inside your arraylist for
example in here i cannot say integer you
cannot use primitive data types when you
are creating a new arraylist as you can
see in the error in here the error says
that type argument cannot be primitive
type
if you want to have an arraylist of
different numbers you can use the
equivalent java class for example in
here i can say integer with a capital i
and now i have an arraylist of integer
right now i am getting an error because
i am trying to add some strings to this
integer array list but you get the idea
we can use this integer class in order
to have an array list so in java
equivalent to every primitive data type
you have a class as well we have seen
this integer let's also check others we
can say boolean similar to that we can
say long we can also say double
and you can check the others yourself
but let's change this one to a string
right now the other option that you have
when you are using arraylist is sorting
different items for example if you want
to sort different elements inside your
arraylist alphabetically you have that
option and the way to do that is like
this
let's see that down in here we can say
names.sort
you can see that this sort method
requires some comparator later on in the
course we will see this comparator in
fact we will use this sort method in
order to sort different elements in our
arraylist but for now i'm not going to
talk about this i just wanted to say
that you have this option okay let's
delete this and let's move on from this
part similar to simple arrays in java if
you want to iterate through all of the
elements in your array list you can use
for loops let's quickly see that as well
we can say for int i is equal to 0
i less than
names.size this time i plus plus
inside this for loop we can say
print
names that get with the index of i this
way we can print all of the elements in
our arraylist but before that let's
comment this line and let's run our
application
you can see that we can see both of our
elements printed okay that's enough
talking about release let's also talk
about another kind of collection in java
called maps maps are useful for when you
have some key value per data let's
define a map and we will talk about what
i mean by key value pairs you can define
a map like this you can say map you can
see that map is an interface we will
talk about interfaces later on in the
course i believe in the next video but
for now let's move on you can also see
that inside these anchor brackets inside
these diamonds we have this k and v
these two stands for key and values so
in here if we say anchor bracket
for the first element we need to pass
the kind of key the data type of our
keys for example i can say string and
after that we need to provide the data
type of our values for example i can say
a string once again for the data type of
my values right now i'm getting a red
warning and that's because it seems like
the id hasn't imported maps into my
class i can press alt plus enter
and if we take a look at above in here
it seems like we have imported maps into
our class successfully after defining
the data type of your keys and values
inside your map you need to name your
map for example i can say contacts
in here i can say new maps but if i do
that you will see that there are a lot
of methods that i need to be worried
about there is a better way of defining
your maps
let's press ctrl z in order to undo the
change i can say new hash map this time
you can see that this hash map is a
class and if we want we can instantiate
our map this way this time we do not
have all of those extra methods i don't
intend to talk about hash maps in here
the topic is a bit technical it's about
the way that we are going to iterate
through our maps elements it's way above
the talk that we have in here i just
wanted to say that you can instantiate
your maps as different hash maps okay
now you have an empty map which the data
type of different keys is string and the
data type of different values is a
string as well if you want to put some
elements to this map you can say
something like this you can say contact
start put this is the method that we are
going to use in order to add some
elements to our map you can see that
right now this port method is waiting
for a key and also a value for the key
for example i can pass a name let's say
maysam and for the value let's pass his
email let's say maysam mako.org
this way we can add elements to our map
i think if i change the name of my
contacts map to let's say email list
that would be much more better in order
to change the name of some variable or
class in java you have an option you can
select the whole name you can right
click on the name of your variable you
can go to this refactor in here and you
can use this rename or alternatively you
can use the shortcut which is shift plus
f6 let's select that and in here i'm
going to delete this whole name you can
see that once i'm deleting this it's
deleting the name in both places so
let's say email list
and let's press enter i think this name
is much more suitable let's add another
element to our map let's say email list
dot put
let's say brad and let's say brad at
gmail.com
now that i have some elements in my map
if i want to have access to those
elements i can say something like this
for example let's print this statement
let's say email list dot
and once again you can see that we have
this get method which requires an object
for the object in here we need to pass
the key for example if i pass mesa as
the result i should see the value of
mesa in this case i should see the email
let's run the application and let's see
if we can print the email of mesa you
can see that the email has been printed
successfully like arraylists when you
are using maps you have all sort of
options for example if you want to get
the size of your map you can say
something like this you can say email
list dot size
let's run the application and let's see
if we can get to 2 has been printed if
you want to remove an item from your map
you can say
email list dot remove once again this
remove requires an object in this case
we need to pass the key let's pass brad
and let's print the size of our map once
again
this time after removing brand you can
see that the size is one you can also
check that if some key exists in your
map or not the way to do that is like
this let's bring that first of all you
can say email list dot
contain keys similarly we have contains
value which you can guess it will check
that if some value exist in your map
let's try the first one contains key and
let's pass brad in here because we have
removed brad we should see false
and as you can see false has been
printed but if i change this to masam we
should see true
okay that seems to work fine we can do
the same thing for the values
let's say email list dot contains value
let's pass the masam's email mesam at
makecode.org because it does exist in
our map we should see true
and true it is you can check other
options
yourself if you want you can say email
list dot once again you can see that we
have this clear option it will clear all
of the elements of your map you have
this is empty method it will check that
if your map is empty or not the other
option that you have in here is this
values
you can see that this values method will
return a collection if you want to copy
all of the values of your map you can
use these values and you can save it
inside a collection but i'm not going to
do that in here but to just show you i'm
going to say that there is an interface
in java called collection this one in
here
in which is the generic type of all of
the collections available in java but
more on that later on when we sort
different items inside our array lists
like arraylists you cannot have a
primitive data type as the data type of
your key or your values when you are
using maps for example in here i cannot
say int if you take a look at the
warning it says that type argument
cannot be of primitive data type
similarly for the values let's say int
once again you can use the equivalent
java class for these primitive data
types but you cannot just use primitive
data types okay let's roll back
everything beside maps and array lists
you have other kind of collections in
java as well i don't want to talk about
them in here because i think that for
the android course these two are enough
and you don't need to know about others
but if you are curious you can always
check this oracle web page you can see
that we have sets lists and other kind
of collections but honestly these are
not going to be helpful for our android
course maps and arraylists are just fine
as the data type of key values inside
maps and also
values inside the arraylist you can also
have different classes let's quickly see
that as well
in my source folder inside the package
i'm going to create a new class called
student let's quickly see that
inside this student class i'm going to
define two new fields let's say private
string name
and private integer
[Music]
id
let's have a constructor
and some gethers and setters
now that i have created this class i can
pass it as the data type of my arraylist
let's quickly create another arraylist
down in here i can say arraylist of
different students this time
let's name this arraylist student let's
say is equal to
new
arraylist now you can put as many a
student as you want inside this
arraylist for example let's say
students.add let's say new student
let's say may sound with the id of 15
maybe so besides strings other kind of
customized data type is agreeable with
the collections in java okay just before
i finish off this video i'm going to
talk about for each loops in here if you
remember when we talked about loops in
java i said that there is another kind
of loops called for each loop i said
that we are going to talk about for each
loops when we know about object oriented
programming and also collections in java
so i think now it's a good time to talk
about that you can create a for each
loop like this you can say four instead
of saying int i is equal to zero i'm
going to pass the data type of the list
that i'm going to iterate over for
example in this case i'm going to say a
student
after that i need a name for example i'm
going to say s and after the name i need
a column after that i need the list or
arraylist that i'm going to iterate for
example in this case i'm going to say
students
let's review everything once again in
here first of all we have passed the
data type of the object that we are
going to look into the name of that
specific object is s you can name it
whatever you want after the name you
should have a column
and after that you need to pass the
collection that you are going to look
into inside this for loop you can use
this s in order to have some sort of
operation on your object for example if
i want to print the name of my students
i can say print
s dot get name
right now our arraylist has only one
student let's quickly add another
let's say students.add
new student
let's say sarah
with the idea of maybe 18.
let's run the application and see what
would be the result as you can see down
in here maysam and zero has been printed
so this s in here is like i in a for
loop but instead of being the index of
the item it's the item itself from time
to times for each loops can be useful
and this is how you can create them okay
i think that's a good point to stop the
video in here in the next video we are
going to talk about some small concepts
for example we will talk about this
static keyboard that we have seen in the
declaration of our main method beside
that if we had time we will talk about
inner classes we will talk about
interfaces and abstract classes see you
in the next video
in this video we are going to talk about
some small concepts that we need to know
about the first of those concepts is
this static keyword that we have seen so
far in the declaration of our main
method i'm going to talk about that in
another class so let's create another
class in my package
let's name this class test class
you have seen inside the main class that
we can have this static keyboard for our
methods but beside that we can also
declare our variables as aesthetic as
well for example in here i can say
public let's say static
after that i can say string
let's say name you can see that it's
working fine as well i'm not sure if you
have noticed or not but as soon as i
declared this string as aesthetic the
style of this name has changed to italic
if i remove that you can see the
difference
but what does it mean to have a static
variable or a static method well when
you define your variables and methods as
static those methods and variables
belong to the object itself and not to
the instances of that object we will see
what i'm talking about but before that
let's quickly have other variables in
here for example i can say public int
age
maybe another one public
let's say a string
a skin color
this variable doesn't mean anything i
just want to have some variables let's
also create a constructor in here notice
that when i use the intellij generator
to create my constructor i do not see my
static variable in this list once again
that's because the static variables do
not belong to the instances of the
object it belongs to the object itself
let's select these two and let's create
getters and setters
but as you can see we do have a getter
and setter for this static variable okay
now that we have this class if we want
to create an instance of that class for
example from inside our main class if we
say test class let's name it test class
is equal to new test class the
constructor in here is waiting for an
age and also a skin color let's say 25
right this way we can create our
instance of the class but how do we
assign a value to the name variable from
inside our test class well you can use
the setter method for example you can
say test class dot set name
this method and you can pass a name for
example mesam but there is a warning in
here this highlighted warning what does
that mean is that you can set a value
for this name variable even without
instantiating your class for example in
here i can say test class with capital t
dot let's say name or alternatively
because the setter method for this name
is static as well i can say set name
let's use the first one i can say
testclass.name is equal to for example
mesa we can see that even without
instantiating this object we can assign
a value to this variable in order to
make sure of that let's move this to
line of code to after assigning a value
to the name variable i can also delete
this set name method safely now if i
want to have access to the name variable
of this test class i can say something
like this i can say name
[Music]
plus test class this time with learty
dot let's say get name
let's run the application and let's see
what would be the result
you can see that masam has been printed
even though we have set the value of
this name variable before instantiating
our object so whenever you use static
variables that variable will be the same
in all instances of your class for
example if i have another instance of
this test class for example if i say
test class
second test class
is equal to new test class maybe another
age and another skin color let's say 30
black
if i print the name variable of the
second test class the result would be
the same
let's say second test class dot
get name or for that matter we can say
name let's run our application
you can see that msam has been printed
beside variables methods can be static
as well let's quickly define a static
method inside our test class let's say
public
static
void let's name it print something
and inside this method let's just print
something
this static method like a static
variable belong to the object itself and
not to the instances of this object for
example in here once again i can say
test class with capital t dot print
something you can see that we do not
need to instantiate our object if we run
our application
you can see that something is printing
okay now we know the aesthetic variables
and methods belong to the object itself
and not to the instances of that object
but why would we want to use static
variables and methods there are few
reasons for that first of all you may
want to have a constant variable in all
instances of your class for example
imagine that you are creating a class
for simulating different employees of a
company inside that class you may have
some information about the employee for
example the age the name email and
everything but beside all of those you
may have a field called company name you
know that in all instances of your
employee class the company name should
be the same for that matter you may want
to declare your company name field as
aesthetic also some say that using
static variables and methods is very
memory friendly because there can be
only one instance of that variable or
method in all of your application so no
matter if you have a thousand employees
in your application the company name
field in all of those instances will
occupy only some spaces as a string can
so using static variables and methods is
very memory friendly but there is a
downside when you are working with this
aesthetic keyword let's quickly see that
inside our test class as well
let's quickly create another method in
here let's say public void
let's name it print
notice that this print method is not
aesthetic and because this is not static
now we cannot have access to that method
from inside this print something method
for example in here i cannot say print
you can see we have a red warning in
here it says that non-static method
print cannot be referenced from a static
context similar to non-static methods
you cannot have access to non-aesthetic
fields inside the aesthetic method as
well for example in here if i try to
print the age of this test class you can
see that we are getting a red warning in
here once again the warning says that
non-static field cannot be referenced
from a static context so you cannot use
non-static fields and methods inside a
static method okay i think that's enough
talking about this static keyboard let's
quickly delete this class
also we need to delete all of these
lines of code okay now we know
everything about this main method first
of all its access modifier is public
it's a static method its return type is
void its name is main and also as the
input of this method we are receiving a
string array called arguments because
this main method is aesthetic we know
that there can only be one instance of
this main method in our entire
application we are not concerned about
the void in here but we know that in
order to run java applications we need a
main method which is a static with this
specific syntax okay that's enough let's
move on the next topic that i'm going to
talk about in here is inner class let's
quickly see that in another class called
test class
inside our classes besides variables and
methods we can also have another class
and here is how we can define that class
we can say private let's say class i'm
going to name this class test inner
class
and here we have this inner class like
before inside this inner class we can
have other methods and variables for
example i can say private string name in
here
i can have a constructor for this class
as well let's quickly see that you can
see we can create a constructor we can
create all sort of getters and setters
and we can treat this class as any other
class in java but there are few
differences between a class and an inner
class for example if we have some fields
in our parent class
let's define some let's say private in
age and private string color
no matter what the access modifier of
these fields are we can have access to
this inside our test inner class but we
need to do that inside another method
let's say private void
print h
inside this method i can say print let's
say h
plus
h you can see that it's working fine
even though the access modifier of this
age is private we can have access to
that from inside our inner class the
same is for different methods of your
parent class no matter what the access
modifier of those methods are you can
have access to them from inside your
inner class there are some times that
you may want to use inner classes for
example when you use inner classes your
code might be much more easier for eyes
to follow the other reason for using
inner classes is that you can have this
private access modifier at the
declaration of your class if you
remember we cannot change this public
access modifier when we create our
parent class for example in here i
cannot say private you can see an error
in here and if you hover over that you
can see that modifier private not
allowed in here beside private access
modifier you can also have a static
classes that is another benefit of using
inner classes you didn't have this
option when you created your parent
class let's quickly see that if i say
static in here once again modifier
static not allowed in here so within our
classes you can have private and static
classes in this course we are not going
to use in our classes that much in fact
the first time that we are going to use
it is when we know about asynctask in
most cases we are going to define our
async tasks as inner classes we will
talk about that later on in the course
okay i think that's a good point to stop
the video in here i did want to talk
about interfaces and abstract classes in
this video but i think that's better to
have that discussion in the next video
so see you in the next video
as i said at the end of the previous
video in this video we are going to talk
about interfaces in java interfaces are
like a contract between two part of your
application let's see what i mean by
that you can create an interface like
you have created a java class you can
right click on your package
by selecting new java class
and down in here by selecting interface
you can have an interface let's name
this interface car interface
if you take a look at your package you
can see that we have created this
interface and if you take a closer look
you can see that the icon for this
interface is somehow different from the
icon of classes in java this is the
general schematic of an interface in
java like classes interfaces lives
inside the package they have this public
access modifier we can name our
interfaces whatever we want and also
they have this interface keyboard in
their declaration inside interfaces we
can define our abstract methods let's
quickly see an abstract method i can say
public let's say void after that let's
say print name
as the input of this method let's just
receive a name let's say a string name
and that's it you cannot have a body for
your abstract methods for example in
here if i put a pair of curly braces you
can see that i'm getting a red warning
and the wording says that interface
abstract methods cannot have body so i
can delete these two curly braces and i
can finish my sentence in here by using
abstract methods you are hiding the
functionality of your methods for
example in this case we don't know what
the sprint name method does instead we
are just defining some sort of contract
the contract in here is the signature of
our method we know that the name of this
method is print name we know that we are
receiving a string called name
and also we know that the return type of
this method is void the signature of
this method is a contract in which where
we implement this interface we are going
to use this signature also if you take a
look at this public keyboard you can see
that it's somehow grayed out if you
hover over that keyboard you can see
that modifier public is redundant for
interface methods it means that it's not
necessary in here and the reason for
that is because all of the abstract
methods are public inside an interface
it means that you cannot have private or
protected abstract methods inside your
interface you can have as many abstract
method as you want for example if i want
to define another one in here
i can say void let's name this one start
and i'm not going to receive anything as
the input of this method let's define
another one let's name this one move and
also let's receive an integer called
speed
i created the first method so that i can
show you how you can create abstract
methods and i'm going to delete that in
here so this car interface has two
methods start and move
but how can we use this interface let's
quickly see that as well inside my
package i'm going to create a java class
called electric car
and inside this electric car i'm going
to implement that interface that i just
created in order to implement that
interface i'm going to say implements at
the declaration of my class and after
that i need to provide the name of my
interface in this case it's car
interface but once i do that you can see
that i'm getting a red warning in here
and for this red warning we need to
implement the two methods that we have
created inside our interface in order to
implement those two methods we have
multiple options first of all we can
click on this red light bulb by
selecting implement methods we can
implement the necessary methods or
alternatively if you don't see this red
light bulb you can click on the error
and by pressing alt plus enter you can
see the same dialog or the other option
is to come inside the declaration of
your class and by pressing ctrl i you
can see the list of necessary methods in
this case we have start and move methods
also if you press ctrl o you can see the
list of all of the methods that you can
overwrite in here you need to be a
little bit careful because all of these
methods are not necessary the methods
that are necessary are these two methods
if you take a closer look at the icon of
these two methods you can see that their
icon is somehow not completed these are
the two methods that we need to
implement or overwrite
let's select them and in here we have a
body for this start and move method it
means that we can define the
functionality for these two methods in
here for example in the start case i'm
just going to print something
because it's an electrical car i'm going
to say electricity flow
started let's also define a field for
this class i'm going to say private
string name
we can also have a constructor by
pressing alt plus insert let's create
that constructor and let's also create
getters and setters
down in here let's also define some
functionality for this move method once
again i'm going to print something
let's say this dot get name
plus moves at some speed
okay now that we have created this class
in which implements our interface how
can we instantiate our interface for
that we can switch to our main class and
inside this main class we can say
car interface
let's name it car interface is equal to
in here i have two options first of all
i can say new car interface like we did
for java classes but if i do that you
can see that we are overriding these two
methods sometimes this might be our
desired behavior but in here i'm not
going to use this way instead i'm going
to say
is equal to new
electric car
this one let's also pass a name let's
say tesla you can see that we are
assigning a class to an interface but
how is it working well because when we
have created our class we implemented
this interface now java compiler is
happy with assigning a class to this
interface now that we have instantiated
this interface we can use its methods
for example i can say car interface dot
let's say start and also let's say car
interface dot move we also need to pass
a speed let's pass 60. let's run the
application
you can see that electricity flow
started and tesla is moving at 60 miles
per hour you can see that even though
inside our interface we didn't have any
body but we are printing some
functionality when we call dot start
method on our interface if you want to
make sure that this start method is
happening inside your class you can also
print something else in here for example
inside this start method
let's print the name of this class i'm
going to pass this if you remember i
said that this refers to the current
object in this case it's referring to
this class and right now if i print this
it will print the address of our class
let's run the application
you can see the address of our electric
car class it means that this start
method is happening inside our electric
car class and not inside the interface
if you remember when we have talked
about collections we have defined
arraylists in two ways one of those ways
was to define our arraylist as list for
example we could have said list which
once again you can see that is an
interface for example list of string
let's name it names is equal to new
arraylist
probably now you understand this syntax
in here it means that we have this
arraylist class in which implements this
list interface if you want to make sure
of that and see it for yourself you can
press down the ctrl key on windows i
believe it's command key on mac and by
clicking on this array list you can see
the documentation for your arraylist
class let's scroll a bit
above in here inside the declaration of
our arraylist class you can see that we
are implementing this list don't worry
about this e in here it means that we
are going to accept any kind of object
but as you can see we are implementing
list okay let's move on from here
now that we have our interface we can
also have another class in which
implements this interface let's quickly
create another class let's say new java
class
let's name this phone fossil fuel car
once again in here i'm going to say
implements let's say car interface we
need to implement two methods let's
press ctrl i and let's select our two
methods once again let's define some
functionalities for these two methods
for example let's print something in
here let's say explosion in cylinder
caused the engine to start
before i define some functionality for
this move method let's quickly add a
field above in here like before i'm
going to say private string name
let's create the constructor and also
getters and setters
after that inside the move method
i'm going to say
this car is moving at some speed
now that we have created this class we
can instantiate our interface inside our
main class
like this let's delete this line of code
in here i can say car interface once
again let's name this one fossil car
interface
like before i can say new
fossil fuel car let's pass mercedes in
here for example
once again you can see that java
compiler is happy with this way of
instantiating our interface because we
have implemented this car interface
inside both electric car class and also
fossil fuel car class we can instantiate
our car interface in both of these ways
and after that i can say fossil car
interface dot start
and let's say fossil car interface dot
move
let's also pass some speed in here and
let's run our application
you can see that both of these methods
have been called in here i have a point
by defining two classes and implement
the same interface in both of these
classes my point is that when you create
an interface that interface is a
contract between different part of your
application for example in this case i'm
defining multiple kinds of cars no
matter what kind the car is the contract
says that this car should have a start
and also a move method so probably by
now you can see the usage of interfaces
but there are a lot more to interfaces
for example we can use something called
callback interfaces callback interfaces
are extremely useful for when you create
event listeners like click listeners and
also they are useful for when you want
to create some sort of connection
between two different threads we will
talk about threads in the next video
don't worry about that we will see the
use of interfaces when we want to create
a communication between two different
threads
also it's worth noticing that you can
implement multiple interfaces at the
declaration of your class for example
let's quickly create another interface
in here i'm going to name this one test
interface for this let's just have a
method in here let's say sorry for
private the abstract method cannot be
private
let's say void print name
[Music]
and let's receive a name
after i've created this interface inside
for example my fossil fuel car after
implementing the first interface i can
add a comma and after that i can provide
the name of my second interface in this
case it's test interface but once again
you can see that we are getting the
error somewhere inside the declaration
of our class i can press ctrl i and i
can implement my method so you can have
multiple interfaces implemented at the
declaration of your class okay i think
that's enough talking about interfaces
later on in the course we are going to
use interfaces a lot and their usage
will be much more clearer so hang in
there if something is vague okay let's
delete all of these extra classes and
extra interfaces
let's also delete these lines of codes
now let's talk about abstract methods
for that i'm going to create a new class
inside my package let's say new java
class i'm going to name this one test
abstract class
if you want to make your class abstract
you need to add another keyboard between
the access modifier and the keyword
class let's add abstract in here you can
see public abstract class and
immediately after i've added this
abstract keyboard if you take a look at
your package you can see that the icon
for this class has been changed this
means that this is an abstract class
inside an abstract class like interfaces
you can have abstract methods let's
quickly see them for example i can say
public
abstract let's say void and let's name
this fun print name let's receive a name
string name once again like interfaces
when you create abstract methods you
cannot have a body for example if i put
a pair of curly braces once again i can
see the burning in here like before i
can finish my sentence with a semicolon
the use of abstract classes is a lot
like interfaces but there are a few
slight differences for example let's see
the first difference in here inside my
package i'm going to define a new class
let's name this one test class
when we wanted to implement some
interface we could have set implements
and after that the name of our interface
but when we want to use abstract classes
we can say extends let's say extends
test abstract class right now we are
getting the warning again by pressing
control plus i we can see the necessary
method so the first difference is
between this extends and implement
keyboard the other difference is that
when you want to use abstract classes
you cannot extend multiple abstract
classes for example in here i cannot add
a comma and add another abstract class
in another word abstract classes does
not support multiple inheritance so
that's the second difference between an
interface and abstract class the other
difference is that inside your abstract
class you can also have non-abstract
methods for example in here i can say
public let's say void let's name this
method print
let's receive something in here for
example let's say a string text and
because this is not an abstract method
we can have a body for this method
we didn't have this option inside an
interface we can have public
non-abstract methods inside an abstract
class like every other class we can also
have fields and maybe a constructor as
well for example let's say private
string name
let's create a constructor for this
class you can see that all is working
well so the other difference is that you
can have fields constructors and
non-abstract fields if you want to see
the use of abstract classes like before
we can switch to our main class
and in here i can say test abstract
class let's name it test abstract class
is equal to
new test class the class that extends
our test abstract class after that we
can use the methods for example i can
say test abstract last dot let's say
print name in here we need to provide a
name let's say mesa but we didn't have
any functionality inside our test class
let's quickly define some functionality
in here also know that i've switched to
this test class because we have created
a constructor inside our test abstract
class we need to create the constructor
in here as well but for the sake of
simplicity i'm going to delete all
three of these
because i just wanted to show that these
three options are available inside an
abstract class let's print something
inside our test class inside this print
method
let's just print a name
let's run the application and let's see
if we can see mesa printed into our
console
you can see mesam has been printed so
once again you can see that inside our
test abstract class we have this
abstract method which does not have
anybody instead we have extended this
class inside our test class and we have
declared the functionality inside this
test class you can see that there are a
lot of similarities between interfaces
and abstract classes sometimes the
decision for using an abstract class or
an interface can be hard for that let me
show you an oracle webpage in which may
help you to decide better you can see
the address in here i think if you check
this web page it might be helpful they
say that use abstract classes when your
classes are related to each other or the
other case is that when you think that
the class that is going to
extend the abstract class
may use some common methods or fields or
also
it may require some access modifiers
other than public such as private and
protected or the other case is that when
you want to declare some fields that are
non-static and non-final this option is
also not available in interfaces but
they say that use interfaces when your
classes are not related to each other or
in cases that you want to use multiple
inheritance we can see that when we use
interfaces we can implement multiple
interfaces once again i suggest you take
a look at this webpage it might be
useful okay i think that's enough for
this video in the next video we are
going to talk about concurrency and
threading in java see you in the next
video
[Music]
in this video we are going to talk about
concurrency in java concurrency means
doing things simultaneously
and at the same time for example imagine
that you are working with your phone and
you are reading a book at the same time
you may want to listen to some music
simultaneously you may be downloading
some files from internet this is called
concurrency or doing things at the same
time in programming in java the first
option that we have in order to create a
concurrent programming is to create a
thread a thread is a unit of execution
in your device's central processing unit
or cpu basically different threads come
together inside something called a
process all of these processes will be
handled by your device's cpu by default
when you run your java application or
for that matter your android application
a thread called the main thread will be
created also some might call this main
thread the ui thread or the user
interface thread as well later on if you
want to do some background task for
example downloading a file you will
create a worker thread inside your main
thread the first option in java that you
have in order to create a thread is like
this you can say thread let's name this
thread
is equal to new thread like defining any
other java class let's finish our
sentence in here the constructor of this
thread requires an interface and that
interface is the runnable interface we
can pass that like this we can say new
runnable you can see that this runnable
is an interface when you pass this
runnable interface this run method will
be created basically this run method is
the place that you put the code that you
want to be handled inside a worker
thread for example let's print something
in here and let's see if we can have a
complete application
for example let's say hello from another
thread
in order to start this thread we need to
calm down after the declaration of our
thread and say threat dot start let's
run our application and let's see if we
can see any result you can see that our
message has been printed into the
console but how do we see the difference
between the main thread and this worker
threat for that i'm going to write a
piece of logic in here for example
inside this run method i'm going to
create a for loop let's say 4
and i is equal to 0 i less than let's
say five and i plus plus
inside this for loop i'm going to print
the value of this i and after that i'm
going to sleep the thread we will see
how we can sleep the current thread
first of all let's say print
printing
let's say plus i
plus
let's say in a worker thread
in order to slip your thread you have
multiple options the first one and i
believe the easiest one is to say
something like this you can say thread
with capital t dot sleep inside the
parenthesis of this sleep method you
need to pass some numbers in
milliseconds for example if i want to
sleep my thread for one second i need to
pass 1000 milliseconds this sleep method
is going to cause our loop to wait one
second for the next record for example
in here we are going to print zero after
that we are going to wait one second and
after that we are going to print one but
right now as you can see we are getting
a warning in here and the warning says
that on handled exception java.lang dot
interrupted exception in the previous
videos briefly we have talked about
exceptions we will talk about them in
this video later on but for now you just
need to know that whenever an exception
occurs your application would crash so
because of that we need to do something
for this error in here the easiest way
to
overcome this error in here is to click
on the error and press alt plus insert
after that select this surround with try
catch you can see that this code has
been added and our thread.sleep method
has been moved to destroy block later on
we will talk about this but for now
let's move on from this part and let's
write the same logic inside our main
thread so that we can see that the code
inside the worker thread and the main
thread can be executed at the same time
so basically i'm going to copy this for
loop let's copy it from here and inside
the main thread outside of this run
method let's paste it but in here i'm
just going to change this message to
main thread let's run the application
and let's see if this code is going to
work
as you can see we are printing the value
of i
two times
once in a worker thread and once in the
main thread it means that the code
inside the worker thread and the code
inside the main thread are happening at
the same time in this situation we say
that our application is asynchronous or
it is concurrent so once again when you
run your java or android application one
thread will be created by default in
which we call that thread the main
thread or the ui thread after that
inside that main thread you can create
as many worker thread as you want the
simplest way to create a thread is to
say thread thread is equal to new thread
and after that we can pass a new runable
to the constructor of your threat in
which we'll create this run method that
will be executed in a background threat
but by this way of defining your threat
there are a lot of considerations that
you need to be worried about for example
you need to be worried about cancelling
your threat when the work is done also
there are all sorts of new concepts for
example threat pools deadlocks and
interrupting your threat i do not intend
to talk about all of those concepts in
here because in android we have all sort
of options available for handling
background tasks in fact later on in the
course we have a complete section
dedicated to handling background tasks
in android we have options like
asynctask services job scheduler and
work manager we are going to talk about
all of them but more on that in future
videos ok now let's talk about this
interrupted exception that is happening
in here basically whenever an exception
occurs your application will crash and
your application will be closed by the
operating system there are all sorts of
exceptions that can occur for example
the ones that we have seen previously
their arithmetic exception null pointer
exception and the one that we can see in
here is interrupted exception so in
order to avoid crashes you need to do
something about the exception let's
comment all of these and let's see what
we can do about the exceptions
let's create an application in which
we'll create an arithmetic exception in
here i'm going to define two new
integers for example let's say int a is
equal to 2
and it's b is equal to zero
let's print something in here let's say
print a divided by b if we run our
application right now we should see an
arithmetic exception you can see that
down in here the thing that we can do
about this exception is that to catch it
whenever it happens and we can do that
by using a try catch block let's quickly
see that for example i can say try
let's move this line of code to inside
our try block
we can say try this in case some
exception happens cache that exception
the kind of exception was arithmetic
exception so let's say arithmetic
exception let's name this exception e
and inside the catch block we can do
something else with our code for example
we can print something in this case
let's say b was zero
now if we run our application we
wouldn't get an exception instead we are
printing this message sometimes this
message might not be useful and in fact
in most cases this message will be
useful for debugging purposes but it's
much better than a crash the kind of
exception that we are catching in here
is arithmetic exception if we do not
know the kind of exception we can pass
the generic term exception
if we pass this exception it's going to
accept all of the exceptions if we run
our application once again we should see
the same result and here is the same
result the other kind of exception that
we have seen so far was a null pointer
exception that would occur when we do
some operation on a null object
reference for example if we had a string
in here let's say a string name
is equal to null
if we do some operation on our name
inside the try block for example if we
say name dot equals let's say mesa if we
do that we are going to get a null
pointer exception because we have done
this dot equals method on a null object
inside the catch block this time instead
of saying b was zero let's say name was
no
if we run the application it's going to
work fine because we are passing the
generic term exception but we can safely
pass null pointer exception let's run
the application you can see that name
was now the other kind of exception that
we just saw was this interrupted
exception it's going to happen whenever
we interrupt the current threat for
example imagine that inside a worker
threat you are downloading some file at
the same time you may receive a phone
call if you don't catch the interrupted
exception you may get a crash we have
all sort of exceptions for example we
have audio exception which stands for
input output exception we have class
cast exception we have all sort of other
exceptions in which we are going to talk
about them whenever we face them also on
our exception we have a useful method
for debugging purposes and that method
is called print stacktrace we can say e
the name of our exception dot print
stack trace we will talk about this
stack in future videos when we talk
about activities and fragments in
android but for now just know that this
line of code in here is going to print
something into our console that might be
useful when you are debugging your
application let's run the application in
here
you can see the stack trace of your
exception in here it says that the
exception occurred in line 34 which is
this line and you are also seeing the
name of your exception this is not an
actual exception you are just seeing
some information about your exception
this in here might be useful for when
you are debugging your application okay
i think that's enough talking about
concurrency and exceptions in java in
the next video we are going to talk
about singleton pattern in java see you
in the next video
in this video we are going to talk about
singleton pattern basically we use
singleton pattern when we want to make
sure that we have only one instance of
some class in our entire application in
some cases we may want such a thing and
here is how we can implement that
pattern for example one case of using
singleton pattern is when you are using
a database in your application don't
worry about the databases we have a
complete section dedicated to them but
in here we are just going to create a
simple java class named database let's
quickly create that inside our source
folder inside our package and we will
see how we can implement that pattern
let's name this class database for this
database class i'm going to define a
field let's say private string name
also let's create a constructor and also
getters and setters
right now because we have this public
constructor we can create as many
instance as we want from this database
class but if you want to make sure that
you have only one instance of this class
in your entire application you can
create another field in here for example
i'm going to say private static as the
data type of this field i'm going to
specify the class that we are in for
example in this case i'm going to say
database so let's say private static
database
make sure to import the one that comes
from our package
org.maycode.singleton pattern for the
name of this field it's convention to
name it instance
and that's it now we can create a getter
method for this field and here is how we
can create that field we can say public
because we are going to use this
instance inside this field i'm going to
say static the return type of this
getter method is going to be the class
itself so i'm going to say database
let's name this method get instance as
you can see the suggestion in here and
let's have a body for this method in
here instead of just simply passing this
instance i'm going to create an if
statement i'm going to say if let's say
null
is equal to our instance
if that's the case i'm going to create a
new instance i'm going to say instance
is equal to
new database
notice that we need a name for the
constructor of this database so i'm
going to receive that name via the input
of this method in here
let's say the string name and later on
let's pass this name in here so if our
instance is now we are going to create a
new instance and after creating that we
are going to return it we can say return
instance but in the other case in case
if our instance is not null in the else
case i'm just going to simply return
instance
right now if we use this get instance
method instead of this constructor we
are sure that we have only one instance
of our database class in our entire
application for example if we go to the
main class and if we try to instantiate
our database we can have only one
instance we can say database let's name
it database is equal to database with
capital d dot get instance of course we
need a name in here let's pass a name
for example let's say db music
notice that because we have declared
this get instance method as static now
we can use this database class with this
capital d it means that we are not
relying on the instance of this database
class instead we are using the object
itself but right now someone can declare
the database class as we did for any
other class for example in here someone
can say database let's name this one
test database
is equal to new database because in our
database class we have the constructor
we can pass a name in here and if we do
that we have another instance of this
database class for example let's say db
movies
in order to restrict users from using
the constructor i'm going to change the
access modifier of this constructor
inside my database class i'm going to
change this public to private so that
this constructor would be available only
from inside this class and not from
inside any other class like this main
class right now we have an error in here
and the error says that the constructor
is private so by changing the access
modifier from public to private now we
are restricting others from creating
multiple instances of our database class
but because our constructor inside our
database is private we can use this
constructor inside this get instance
method as you can see in line 10 in here
right now because of this static
keyboard and also because of this if
statement that we have put in here we
are sure that we have only one instance
of our database class but there is also
another point that we need to be worried
about and that's when someone tries to
create multiple instances of our
database from multiple threads in some
cases if someone tries to create
multiple instances of our class
asynchronously they might be successful
in doing such a thing in order to make
our get instance method thread safe we
have an option in here after this static
keyboard we can add another keyword in
which we haven't seen so far we can say
synchronized this synchronized keyboard
will make our get instance method thread
safe it means that no more than one
thread can call this get instance at the
same time so this is the whole singleton
pattern first of all you declare a
static field of the coin of your class
for example in this case database after
that you create a get instance method in
which is static once again and also
synchronized inside that get instance
method you are checking that if the
instance of your database is null or not
if it is not it means that it's the
first time that you are calling this get
instance method so you need to create a
new instance like we are doing in line
10 after that we are returning the
instance but in the else case we are not
going to create a new instance we are
just going to return the existing
instance beside this get instance method
in order to restrict others from using
the constructor you need to change the
access modifier of your constructor to
private so that it would be usable only
inside your database class we can also
make this if statement shorter for
example in here i can delete this whole
else case and i can delete this return
instance from line 11 in here and after
the if statement i can return that
instance
so by the time we reach to this line 13
in which we are returning the instance
we are sure that our instance is not not
and we are returning either a new
instance or the existing instance okay i
think that's enough talking about the
singleton pattern later on in the course
you will see that this pattern might be
useful from time to time before i finish
off this video i'm going to talk about
one more methods available in every
class in java and that method is called
tostring right now we don't have any
tostring method inside our database
class but if we switch back to the main
class and if we say print database dot
to string
you can see that we have such a method
and if we run our application we should
see some information about our database
class let's quickly run it and let's see
if we can see any result
you can see that we are getting the
address of our database class if you
want you can change this for example
inside your database class you can
override the tostring method down in
here inside the scope of our class we
can press ctrl
o and from here we can select this
tostring method right now we are
returning the super statement if you
want to change that we can delete this
whole statement and we can prepare a
string in here for example we can say
string text
is equal to let's say database class
after that let's add a line and after
that let's print the name of our
database let's say name
plus this dot name
after creating this text we can return
it for example we can say return text
now that we have overrided this to
string method if we run our application
we should see some other results printed
into our console from time to time these
two string method can be useful as well
it's available in every java class and
basically it will print some detail
about that class okay i think that's
enough for this video and for that
matter i think that's enough talking
about java our java section is done and
hopefully we have learned a lot in the
next video we are going to have a quick
challenge in order to make sure that we
have learned everything that we have
talked so far but before i finish off
this video am going to say that with
java you can do a lot of things for
example besides writing android
applications you can use java in order
to create desktop applications for
windows linux and mac os operating
systems and also with the help of a
spring framework you can use java in
order to create enterprise web
applications there are much more to java
language for example you can use java in
order to create applications for quantum
computers you can also use it for data
analysis purposes and literally
everything else that you want in this
course we have touched the surface of
java language but if you want to know
more i'm currently recording a new
course for java language and i'm sure
that you will find that course helpful
beside the java course i plan to record
a complete course for a spring framework
in order to create web applications by
the time you are watching this video
those courses may be released so make
sure to check them okay i think that's
enough in the next video as i said we
are going to have a quick challenge see
you in the next video
here is our final challenge for the java
section i want you to simulate your
phone's contacts and messages
applications
here is how our application is going to
work first of all we are going to greet
the user with some message
after that we are going to show three
options to the user
one for managing the contacts another
one for handling the messages and
another one for quitting the application
in case if the user selects the first
option which is managing the contacts we
are going to show these options
one for showing all of the contacts
another one for adding a new contact
another one for searching for a specific
contact
one more for deleting a contact and the
last one is to go back to the previous
menu
which was these three options
but in case if the user selects the
second option which is handling messages
we are going to show these three options
the first one is to see a list of all of
the messages the other one is to send a
new message and one last one in order to
go back to the previous menu
in which is our initial menu which has
three options
in case if the user selects these third
option we are going to create the
application
we haven't talked about databases and
permanent data storage but
as a hint if you want to store contacts
and messages you can use static
variables
okay pause the video in here and go
solve the challenge after that come back
and let's see my solution for this
application
okay let's quickly see how can we create
this simple application
first of all i have created my project
and i have created this package inside
my source folder
inside this package i have created this
main class in which contains this main
method
let's continue from here first of all
i'm going to create a new java class
called message
inside this message class i'm going to
have three fields
let's say private string
text another one let's say private
string recipient
this recipient in here is going to be
the name of our contact
also in here i'm going to define an
integer called id
let's say private int id
this id is not necessary for this
application in here but because in most
cases when you are working with
databases
you have a column called id in order to
identify every unique message
i want to be as close as i can to a real
world application i just wanted you to
see this id field inside a model in
which is a message
okay now that we have these three fields
let's quickly create a constructor
and let's accept all of these three
fields
after that let's create getters and
setters
i'm not sure that we are going to need
all of these getters and setters later
on if we didn't use them we will delete
them also inside this message class
let's quickly create another method
called get details
basically we are going to print the
details of every message so let's say
public void
let's name it get details
let's say print
first of all let's say contact name
and let's print the recipient
after that let's print the text itself
let's say message
plus the text
we also need to add a plus in here sorry
about that
and i think if we add a backslash n in
here it would be much better
after the text let's also print the id
let's say backslash n
[Music]
id
plus our id
that's it for our message class let's
quickly create the contact class as well
new java class let's name this font
contact
inside this contact class i'm going to
have four fields
let's say private string
name
private string
number
[Music]
you may think that this number should be
an integer or maybe a long but because
different numbers can have different
formats
for example they can have some
parentheses or maybe some hyphens
i'm saving this number as a string but
if you want you can always use integers
or long
after name and number i'm going to save
another field in here let's say private
string email
and after all of these i'm going to have
another field in here let's say private
arraylist
of different messages
let's name these phone messages
so basically i'm going to save different
messages for every contact inside an
arraylist
okay now that we have our four fields
let's quickly create our constructor
but in here i'm going to create two
constructors
because at the time of creating a new
contact that contact does not have any
messages
for that i'm going to create another
constructor in here which will not
accept an arraylist of different
messages
this time let's select the first three
items
but because if i don't do anything about
these messages this arraylist will be
null
inside this constructor i'm going to say
this dot messages
is equal to new arraylist
so at the time of creating a new contact
i am saving the messages arraylist as an
empty arraylist okay now that we have
two constructors in here let's quickly
create getters and setters
and also after that let's create a
getdetails method
let's say public void
get details
we can also use two string methods but
in here i'm just more comfortable with
this get details method
let's print all of the information about
each contact
let's say name
plus this dot name
after that let's print the number and
email
okay that's it for our contact class
let's switch to main class and let's
write the logic for our application
first of all in here i'm going to create
an array list of different contacts but
i'm not going to do that inside this
main method because
we are going to have multiple methods
and we need to have access to our
contacts are released in different
methods for that i'm going to define my
arraylist above in here in the fields of
this main class
i can say private
static because the methods that i'm
going to use later on are static methods
i need to create this arraylist as
aesthetic
so let's say private aesthetic
i really stuff different contact
let's name it contacts
but this is not a good place to
initialize our contacts arraylist
because this is not the place that our
code will be started
we can initialize our contacts arraylist
for example inside this main method but
before i do that i'm going to also
define a scanner in here because we are
going to need the scanner in multiple
methods
so let's say private
static
the scanner let's name it scanner
after that inside the main method let's
initialize our contacts arraylist
let's say contacts is equal to new
arraylist
as you can see in here i'm going to
greet the user with some message let's
just print something
after that i'm going to show these three
different options to the user
because i want to have a clean code i'm
going to show these three options inside
another method
let's name that method show initial
options
but as you can see right now i'm getting
a red warning and that's because i need
to create this method down in here
so let's say private
static void
show initial options
let's print the options in here
after that we need to get the user's
input and for that we can use the
scanner
so let's initialize our scanner right
now we have declared our scanner above
in here but we never initialized it
it's a good place to initialize our
scanner in here
we can say scanner is equal to new
scanner
let's pass system dot in
after that we can say int choice
is equal to scanner.nextint
let's create a switch upon this choice
let's say switch on choice
in case the choice is one
we are going to manage the contacts once
again let's do that in another method
let's say manage contacts
don't worry about this red warning we
will create this method later on let's
also add a break in here
but in case and the choice is 2
we are going to handle the messages so
let's say manage messages
in case the choice is tree or for that
matter any other number we are going to
quit the application
so in here i can say default
in the default case i'm just going to
break out of the application
let's minimize this project pane for now
and down in here let's create our two
methods
first of all let's manage our contacts
let's say private
static void
manage contacts
once again in here i'm going to show a
list of options so let's print those
options
once again we need to get the user's
input for that we can use the scanner
let's say into choice
is equal to scanner.nextint
notice that we are not initializing our
scanner in here and that's because we
have done that inside this uh show
initial options method
so by this time we have an instance of
our scanner
after that once again we need to create
a switch on our choice
in case it's one we are going to show
all of the contacts let's create that
method
show all contacts
and also we need a break
let's also write the rest of the cases
in the default case i'm going to go back
to the previous menu so i'm going to
once again run this show initial options
method so that we can see all of these
options once again
so in the default case i'm going to say
show initial options
after that in here we need a default as
well
i'm saying default in here because i'm
going to go back to the previous menu
in case if the user enters any other
number
okay let's create these methods one by
one
first of all let's show a list of all of
the contacts i'm going to do that down
in here
also instead of writing the declaration
of your method you can use the help of
your ide
for that you can click on the red error
in here and by pressing alt plus insert
the first option is to create this
method you can see that we have created
this method successfully the void is
fine for the return type
and down in here i can create the logic
for this method in order to show a list
of all of the contacts i'm going to
simply create a for each loop
let's say for contact let's name it c
inside our contacts area list
let's just say c dot
get details the method that we have
created inside our contact class
after the for loop once again i'm going
to show the initial options
for that i'm going to say show initial
options
we are going to quit the application
when the user tells us
that's all we need to do inside this
method let's just minimize it for now
and let's create the second method which
is add new contacts once again we can
use the help of our ide
inside this add new contact method we
are going to receive some users input
but before that let's print something
let's say adding a new contact
after that let's say please enter the
contact's name
once again we are going to use our
scanner let's say a string name
is equal to scanner.next
after we get the contact's name we are
going to get the contacts number so once
again let's print something in here
let's say please enter a contacts number
let's say string number
is equal to scanner.next
let's also get the contacts email
a string image is equal to scanner.next
after that we need to make sure that the
user enters something as the name number
and email of our contact
and don't just press enter and leave us
with empty strings
for that i'm going to create an if
statement in here let's say if
name dot equals an empty string
let's say or
if number that equals an empty string
or if email is equal to an empty string
if each one of these is true we are
going to show some message to the user
we are going to ask to enter all of the
required information
let's say please enter all of the
information
after printing this line of code i'm
going to recall this whole method i'm
going to start from the beginning of
this method
for that i'm going to say add new
contact
i'm calling this method from inside the
method
this is called a recursive call you can
see the icon at the left side in here
if you hover over that you can see the
recursive call
calling a method from inside that method
so by this way of calling our method we
are starting once again from the
beginning of this method
but in the else case we are going to
create our contact object
i'm going to say contact
let's name it contact is equal to new
contact
and after that i'm going to pass
name
number and email
if you remember inside our contact class
we had two constructors
and in here we are using the second
constructor we didn't pass any messages
arraylist to this constructor in here
after creating our contact object we can
say contacts our arraylist
dot add
let's pass our contact as simple as that
now we have added a new contact
after this if statement once again i'm
going to show the initial options
so let's say show initial options
because once again we are not going to
quit the application unless the user
tells us so
okay we are done with our second method
let's see what else do we have in here
let's create this search for contact
method
the void is fine for the return type
inside this method first of all we are
going to ask for the name of the contact
so let's print something
let's say please enter the contact name
let's say string name
is equal to scanner.next
after that we need to make sure that we
have received a name so let's say if
name dot equals an empty string
we are going to print some message we
are going to
ask for the contact name once again
let's say please enter the name
and after that once again we are going
to use a recursive call
we are going to say search for contact
once again
but in the else case
we are going to search for this contact
inside our contact array list
for that once again i'm going to create
a for each loop let's say for contact
let's name it c inside our contacts
array list
let's say if c dot get name
is equal to
the name that we just received
if that's the case let's print c dot get
details
let's also define a boolean before this
for loop
we will see why i am defining this
boolean
let's say boolean let's name it does
exist
let's initialize it to false
in this if statement where we have found
the contact first of all i'm going to
change the value of this does exist to
true
let's say it does exist is equal to true
and after the for loop
i'm going to create an if statement i'm
going to say if does exist is not equal
to true
then we are going to print something i'm
going to say there is no such contact
after all of these logics we are going
to show the list of options once again
so let's say show initial options
okay that's it for our search for
contact method
let's also create this delete contact
method
once again in here we are going to ask
for the contact's name
so let's say please enter the name
like before let's say a string name
is equal to
scanner.next next we need to create our
if statement
if name dot equals an empty string
we are going to ask for the name once
again
and we are going to start from the
beginning of this method
in the else case
we are going to look into our contacts
arraylist
so let's say for contact c inside our
contacts are at least
before i write the logic let's also
define a boolean above in here like we
did for the search for contacts method
let's say boolean does exist
let's initialize it to false
so in here let's say if
i don't know why i set s in here let's
quickly and change this one to c
so let's say if
c dot get name
is equal to
the name that we have received
if that's the case
first of all we are going to change the
value of this does exist
let's say it does exist is equal to true
after that we are going to remove this
contact from our contacts arraylist we
can say contacts
dot remove
this remove method requires an object
which i'm going to pass c
the object that we are currently looking
in this iteration
after the for loop i'm going to say if
does exist is not equal to true
then we are going to say there is no
such contact
and after all of these logics we are
going to show the list of all of the
initial options
okay that's it for this method let's
minimize this one so far we have created
the logic for the first option in our
initial options
we have created the whole logic for this
managed contacts
but right now in the logic for this
manage contacts option we have one or
two possible points for multiple bugs
we are going to fix those two and also
we are going to write the rest of the
logic for this application in the next
video
see you in the next video
in the previous video we have created
the logic for this manage contacts
option but if you remember i said that
we have some issues right now with this
manage contacts logic and in this video
first of all we are going to fix those
issues the first issue is inside this
add new contact method in here we are
adding the contact into our contacts
arraylist but before that we need to
make sure that we do not have a contact
with this name saved on our device for
that before adding this contact to my
contacts array list i'm going to check
that if i have such a contact on my
device so first of all let's create a
boolean in here let's say boolean does
exist
let's initialize it to false after that
i'm going to create a for each loop
let's say for contact c inside my
contacts array list let's say if c dot
get name is equal to the name that we
just received
inside this if statement i'm going to
change the value of this does exist to
true so let's say it does exist is equal
to true after the for loop i'm going to
check that if this does exist is equal
to true or not let's say if does exist
is equal to true
then we are going to print something we
are going to say
we have a contact with this name
after that we are going to start from
the beginning of this method so i'm
going to call this add new contact
method once again but in the else case
i'm going to add the contact to my
contacts arraylist so i'm going to cut
this line of code from here
and i'm going to paste them inside this
else case
also after adding the contacts to our
contacts area list i'm going to show
some message to the user
so let's say
name
added successfully
okay that's the fix that we needed
inside our add new contact method let's
also change the show all contacts method
a little bit as well so inside this for
each loop after printing the details of
a contact
i'm going to print another line
and this line is going to be just a
separator that will indicate the
difference between different contacts
nothing special in here
okay let's move on and let's create the
method that we haven't created in here
this manage messages method by pressing
alt plus insert we can create that
method
first of all we are going to show a list
of options so let's print something
after that we need to receive the user's
input i can say into choice
is equal to scanner.nextint
and let's create our switch statement on
this choice
in case it's von we are going to show a
list of all of the messages
so let's say show all messages
we will create that method in a minute
but in here let's add a break
and let's write the other cases
in case it's true we are going to send a
new message so let's say send new
message
and let's add a break in the default
case i'm just going to show the initial
options
after that in here we need a break as
well
okay let's create this show all messages
method
in here first of all i'm going to save
all of the messages from all of the
contacts into an arraylist
so let's say arraylist of different
messages
let's name it all messages
is equal to new array list
after that i'm going to create a for
each loop
for contact c inside my contacts area
list
let's say all messages dot at all
we haven't used this at all method but
in here we are going to do that
i'm going to say c dot get messages
so by using this add all method we are
adding all of the messages of one
contact to our all messages arraylist
after the for loop i'm going to check
that if the size of this all messages is
zero or not so let's say if all
messages.size
is greater than zero
i'm going to show the details of every
message so for that i'm going to create
another for each looping here
let's say for message let's name it m
inside our all messages area list
let's print m dot get details
and after that let's also print some
separator
but in the else case
i'm going to say that you do not have
any message
everything after the if statement i'm
going to show the initial options
okay that's it for this show all
messages method let's also create the
other method which is sent a new message
in here first of all i'm going to get
the contact or recipient's name
so let's ask the user that
let's say who are you going to send the
message
after that we need to get the name of
our contact so i can say string
name is equal to scanner.next
after that we need to check that if this
name is empty or not for that i can say
if
name dot equals an empty string
we are going to ask the user to enter a
name
so let's say
please enter the name of the contact
after that we are going to have a
recursive call so in here i'm going to
say send new message
but in the else case
i'm going to check that if we have such
a contact in our contacts arraylist
for that i'm going to define a boolean
in here boolean does exist
is equal to false
after that i'm going to create a for
each loop let's say for contact c inside
our contacts arraylist
ifc.getname
dot equals the name that we just
received
let's say it does exist is equal to true
after the for loop i'm going to check
that if does exist is equal to true or
not
first of all let's write the else case
in the else case i'm going to say there
is no such contact
but inside the if block
if we do have such a contact we are
going to ask for the message itself
so let's say what are you going to say
let's say a string text
is equal to scanner.next
after that we need to make sure that
this text is empty or not
let's say if text that equals an empty
string
if that's the case let's say please
enter some message
and after that we are going to start
from the beginning of this method so
let's say
send new message which once again is a
recursive call
but in the else case
we are going to create our message
object and after that we are going to
add it to the contact that exists in our
contacts arraylist
but if you remember inside our message
class we had a field called id
basically whenever you are receiving
these messages from a database or maybe
a web server
this id is unique to every message
in here i'm trying to be as close as i
can to a real world application so i'm
going to make this id unique
in order to have a unique id for every
message i'm going to define a
field above in here inside my main class
i'm talking about here
and after that we will increment the
number of this id by one every time that
we create a new message
for that i'm going to say private static
integer
let's name this from id and let's also
initialize it to zero
after that down in here when we create
our message object
inside this else case down in here
i can say id plus plus
so because this id is a static integer
whenever we increment its value
it's going to be unique for every
message
so right now we have the name of our
recipient which we have received above
in here
and also we have the message body which
is this text and also we have generated
this id which is unique
these are the three things that we need
in order to create our message object
i can say message
let's name it new message
is equal to
new message
we need the text
after that we need the recipient which
is name
and after that we need the id
next i need to find the proper contact
to add this message to his or her
arraylist of different messages
for that i'm going to create a for loop
let's say for contact
c inside our contacts array list
let's say if c dot get name
is equal to the name that we received
if that's the case
first of all we need to get the
arraylist of different messages of this
contact for that i can say arraylist of
messages
let's call this
new messages
is equal to c dot get messages
after that we need to add this new
message to this new messages array list
so let's say new messages dot add
new message
sorry i have used this add all method i
need to remove this all
after that we are going to save the
current contact that we are looking into
because later on we are going to remove
this contact from our contacts arraylist
and we are going to update his or her
arraylist of messages and after that we
are going to add it once again to our
contacts arraylist
so for that i can say contact
let's name it currentcontact
is equal to c
next we need to say
currentcontact.setmessages
and we need to pass our new messages
arraylist
after that it's time to remove the c
from our contacts area list
we can say contacts dot remove
and we can pass the c object
now that we have removed the previous
contact we can add the new one by saying
contacts dot add
let's say current contact
so this way we have added this new
message to our specific contact and we
have updated our contacts i released
okay that's the entire logic that we
need in order to add a new message
just after everything after we are done
with this method we need to show the
initial options once again
let's minimize this method and let's see
what else do we have
i think we have covered everything and
we are ready to test our application
so let's run the application
in here we are seeing the greeting
message which is fine
after that we are seeing the initial
list of options
if we select one
we can see the options for managing
different contacts
right now we do not have any contact in
our arraylist so if we select one
you can see that we are not seeing
anything
it's better to print some message in
here in case if we do not have any
contact in our phone
for example that says you do not have
any contact on your device but we will
write that later on uh for now let's
just see the other options
once again let's select manage contacts
this time let's try to add a new contact
you can see that the console is waiting
for a name let's say mesa
the console is waiting for a number
let's add some number
after that we need to provide some email
let's say masam gmail.com
and as you can see mesa added
successfully if you want to make sure of
that once again you can check the list
of all of your contacts by saying show
all contacts
and in here you can see the details of
mesa
let's also add another contact
let's say sarah this time
let's add a random number
after that an email
this time let's try searching for a new
contact
so in here if i say tree
you can see that the console is waiting
for the name of our contact
let's type brad in here
you can see that we are seeing this
message there is no such contact in your
phone
once again let's try searching for a
contact this time let's try zero
you can see that we are seeing the
details about zero
let's also try removing one of the
contacts
let's say four in order to delete a
contact
let's say mesa
in here we are not seeing any message
indicating if that we have deleted mesum
successfully or not but if we check the
list of our contacts
we should see only zero and as you can
see we have only sarah in our contacts
list
let's also try this go back as well
so let's say manage contacts once again
this time if i put any number beside one
through four for example if i say six
you can see that we are going back to
the main menu
also let's try adding a new contact with
empty values
sorry about that i need to go back
and select one
let's say two in order to add a new
contact
let's don't provide anything for the
name
you can see that the scanner is waiting
for some input but even if the scanner
moves to the next line
we have write the logic in order to
prevent adding an empty contact
okay that's good let's add misam once
again
[Music]
let's add some number
and some email
let's see what we have inside the
messages option
in order to see a list of all of the
messages let's press on
you can see this message you don't have
any message once again let's go to the
messages option i've entered two in here
and let's try sending a new message
who are you going to send a message
let's say sarah
what are you going to say let's say
hello
it seems like we are getting a crash and
the crash happened because of this
exception
can current modification exception okay
let's take a deeper look into our code
and let's debug our application for the
first time
it seems like the exception occurred
when we tried to add the new message
also you can see the line 99 in here if
you click on that
you will be navigated to that line
yes we have this exception inside the
add new message or send new message
inside this for loop
i think the error in here is happening
because first of all we are using this c
to assign a new value to this current
contact
and immediately after that we are trying
to remove this contact from our contacts
arraylist
so this caused the concurrent
modification exception
if you want to get over that exception
you can simplify this if statement for
example in here i'm going to delete all
these three lines of code
so by this point we have this new
messages array list
we have added our new message to this
arraylist
and after that in order to update the
arraylist inside this contact
i can say c dot
set messages
and i can pass my new messages arraylist
so no need for removing and
adding a new contact into our arraylist
concurrently
let's run the application once again and
let's see if we are seeing the exception
once again
first of all we need to add a contact so
let's say manage contact add a new
contact
let's provide a name
a number
after that some email
and now we can send a new message let's
say messages
send a new message
who are you going to send a message
let's say mesa
what are you going to say after this
line of code we got the exception let's
say hello
and this time it seems like we have
added or we have sent a new message
if you want to make sure of that you can
go to the messages option
and you can show the list of all of your
messages
you can see that we have one message in
which we have sent it to mesa
okay that seems better
once again let's go to this messages
option and let's try going back to the
main menu
so if i type 3 or any other number
beside this 1 and 2 we should go back to
the main menu for example let's say 4
and as you can see we are seeing the
initial options
for the last thing let's try quitting
our application
and as you can see we have created the
application successfully
let's just fix the few errors that we
had
in the show all contacts method
if you remember i said that we are going
to show some message in case if we don't
have any contact in our arraylist
so for that first of all i'm going to
check that if we do have any contact for
that i'm going to say if contacts
contacts.size
is greater than zero
first of all let's write the else case
in the else case i'm just going to print
you do not have any contact but in the
if block we are going to do the same
thing that we were doing previously
let's run the application one more time
in order to see that these changes were
effective or not
so right now we do not have any contact
in our contacts area list
also you may be wondering why we are
losing the contacts that we are keep
adding into our application
that's because we are not using any
permanent data storage like a database
we are using a static array list and
that array list will be cleared when we
close our application
for that reason all of the contacts are
being removed whenever we stop the
application
so let's say manage contacts and let's
say show all contacts
you can see the message in here you do
not have any contacts but it's better to
show the list of initial options once
again after we print this line of code
so down in here after this print
statement
let's say show initial options
okay this was the last video of this
section and this was my solution for
this challenge your solution is probably
different than me and that's okay
because there are multiple ways of
creating the same application
hopefully you have practiced and learned
everything that we have talked about in
this section
in the next section of the course we are
going to switch back to android studio
and we are going to talk about user
interface and how we can design a
beautiful layout for our application
see you in the next section
what's up everyone i hope you are having
fun before we start our talk about user
interface i just wanted to remind you
that there is an extended version of
this course that you can watch by
enrolling in the extended course you
will have lifetime access to more than
60 hours of videos you can ask your
questions directly from me and i will
come back to you within hours you will
have access to all of the source codes
that i write in the videos and also you
can have access to all of the new videos
that i upload just check out mako.org
for more details about the course and
don't forget to use free code camp as
the coupon code to get 20 discount if
you want to get serious in android app
development taking the extended course
is almost a necessity okay everyone i
just wanted to remind you that there is
an extended version of this course that
you can take without further ado let's
start our talk about user interface have
fun learning
hello everyone and welcome back this is
the user interface section of our course
and we are going to talk about a lot of
concepts and tools that we have related
to user interface
we are going to talk about a lot of ui
elements and their attributes we are
going to talk about different kind of
event listeners for example click
listeners on different ui elements we
will talk about how can we create
applications that is compatible with
different screen sizes and also
different languages besides that we will
also talk about material design and all
sorts of stuff in this section of the
course
without further ado let's jump into our
project and let's implement some ui
elements as you can see i'm no longer
using intellij ide and i've switched to
android studio
we needed intellij ide for the java
section of the course but in here we can
switch back to android studio just in
case if you forget how to create a new
project in android studio i'm going to
start from scratch
let's say start a new android studio
project
in here we needed to select a template
if you remember i said that these
templates are some applications written
to some level
later on in the course specifically
after we talked about activities we will
see that how can we create all of these
from scratch but for now let's just
select this empty activity
after that in here we needed to name our
project for example for this application
i'm going to say ui basics
i'm going to save it this package name i
think it's fine
we needed a save location once again the
default is fine and for the language i'm
going to say java
for the minimum api level as i said in
previous videos in the most videos for
this course i'm going to save it api
level 19. after selecting all of this
let's just create our project by
clicking on this finish button down in
here
it seems like our project has been
created successfully
now that we know about java let's have
another look at this class that we have
created in here but before that let's
minimize this run pane
as you can see this is a java class in
our package
you can see that it's a class called
main activity this class is extending
the appcompat activity whatever that is
inside this class we have this oncreate
method which is overrided you can guess
it probably because of this appcompat
activity and also above in here we have
some imports
right now we are importing this
appcompat activity and also this bundle
don't worry about this we will talk
about them later on in the course but
for now you can see the general syntax
of a simple java class in here as well
if you remember i said that when you
create an activity
a java class and also a xml file will be
created the java part is responsible for
the behavior of your application for
example
in your layout file you may receive the
user's input
in the java file you may decide to what
to do with the user's input
hopefully now that we know about java we
can understand all of these much better
this uncreate method is a part of
something called the activity lifecycle
we will talk about that in future videos
but for now just know that this uncreate
method is somehow
like the main method inside a simple
java application
this is the start point of every
activity
and right now because our application
has only one activity this is the start
point of our entire application
so this line 13 in here would be the
start point of our code
you can see this super statement in here
once again it means that do whatever you
are doing inside the parent class
in this case the parent class is this
appcompat activity for the time being we
are not concerned about that but as you
can see we are passing this save
instance state which is a bundle to this
super statement later on we will talk
about that also it's important to know
that inside activities you have some
inner methods we didn't have this option
in java
for example you can see this set content
view method
you don't see the declaration of this
method anywhere inside this class but
you can see that by using it you are not
getting any red warning
similar to this set content view we have
a lot of other inner methods inside an
activity
we will talk about them later on in the
course
okay let's move on from this part and
let's start working on our user
interface i just wanted to have another
look at our application and specifically
this java file now that we know about
java okay let's close this java file
and let's start talking about this
activitymain.xml file
if you remember in the first videos of
this course i said that xml is a markup
language
once again if you are a web developer
you know the concept of markup languages
those are just helpful for defining some
elements that are going to be shown to
the user
before everything let's quickly locate
this file in our project right now we
are inside the android view
and if you want to find this activity
main.xml file you can come to this
resources folder
down in here inside the layout folder
you can see the file
and if you switch to project view
you can go to your application folder
inside the app folder
inside the source folder
you have this main folder
and in here you have the resources
folder
once again inside the layout file you
have this activitymain.x
file
okay let's switch back to android view
and let's minimize this project pane for
now
if you remember from the previous videos
of this course i said that whenever you
want to define a layout file
you have two options first of all you
can use this design view for example by
dragging some items into your design
view
[Music]
you can have different elements and
later on you can define some attributes
for your elements
this is one way but the other way is to
switch to text view
and manually type everything that you
need
in my opinion when you are an android
developer most of the times you are
going to work with the text view
so in here we are going to start from
this text view first of all if you are
not seeing this preview in here you can
always enable it and disable it from
this preview option in here if you have
a low memory ram my suggestion is to
disable this preview because it's going
to render the layout file in real time
and that's going to load a lot of
pressures on your device's memory ram
and also cpu for that if you have low
memory ram disable this preview it will
speed everything up right now inside
this simple layout file we have this
text view you can see that when i click
on this text view
this textview inside our xml file has
been highlighted it means that these are
the same
i'm going to delete this textview for
now
let's select all of it and let's press
delete
the next thing that i'm going to do is
that i'm going to change this constraint
layout
in future videos we will talk about what
a constraint layout is
but for now for starter i think it's
better to start with relative layout
let's select that
also if you have noticed you can see
that when we have changed the opening
tag in here to relative layout the
closing tag has been changed to relative
layout as well
inside these opening and closing tags i
can have different
ui elements for example if i want to
define a text view
i can open an anchor bracket and by
typing text view in capital t
we have a list of options let's select
the first one text view
immediately after pressing enter we are
getting some attributes
so for every ui elements you need at
least two attributes a width and also a
height
the values for these two attributes can
be some numbers
but alternatively you can see that we
have other options in here as well
we will talk about this mesh part and
wrap content in a minute but for now
let's just select wrap content basically
it's going to wrap the content of this
text view for the height let's also
select draft content
if you want you can finish creating your
text view by adding a slash in here and
that's it you can have a text view but
if you want to have a more attributes
you have a lot of options
for example before this slash i'm going
to say let's say text
you can see that we are getting a
suggestion and read column text let's
select that
and in here i can pass a text for
example let's say hello world
as soon as i type this you can see the
text in the preview as well
so text is one of the attributes of this
text view
let's talk about the other attributes
found by one
for example right now this text is at
the corner of my screen i don't like
this
i'm going to change the position of this
text view to the middle of this line
for that i have multiple options first
of all i can add some margin
in which we'll add a space between this
text view at the edge of the screen for
example i can say margin
and i can pass 50 for example 50 db dp
is the unit when you are working with
your layout files
we can see that we have some margin but
we can be more specific for example we
can say margin top margin left margin
right and also margin button for example
i can say margin left
let's say 100 dp this time
margins are extremely useful but in here
they are not going to help us because
this is not accurate we want our
textview to be exactly in the center of
our line
for that instead of using a margin i
have a better option i can say
center horizontal in order to
center my textview horizontally as you
can see i can pass through or files in
here let's pass through
and this time and the text view has been
centered horizontally
if you want you can also center it
vertically by saying
center vertical and passing a value of
true
you can see that it has been centered
both
horizontally and vertically
beside these two you also have another
option for example in this case i'm
going to delete both of these attributes
instead i'm going to say center in
parent this one down in here
let's pass through as the value of this
attribute
this centering parent is going to center
our elements inside its parent element
an xml file is like a tree
we have these child elements and above
them we have the parent elements for
example in this case the parent element
is a relative layout
if we want we can have another relative
layout in here or maybe some other ui
elements
and inside that element we can have this
text view
we can do this kind of inheritance as
many times as we want
so in this case the text view is our
joint element and this relative layout
is our parent element and when we use
this centering parent
attribute it's going to center our text
view
in its parent element
okay let's move on from this part
if you want you can also increase the
size of your text for that you can say
text size
this attribute in here
and you can pass a number for example
you can say 20 sp
when you are working with the size of
your fonts and the unit is sp
you can see that it's larger now
also if you want you can have some
styles on this text as well
for that we can say text style
this attribute you can see three styles
both italic and normal for example let's
fast bold if you want your attribute to
be both bold and italic you can add a
pipeline in here
and after that you can say italic
this time you can see both of these
attributes in the same element if you
want you can also change the color of
your text for that we can say text color
and we can pass a color but that color
should be defined inside another xml
file called a color
right now we have three colors this
color accent color primary and color
primary dark basically these are the
names of some colors let's select the
first one
and as you can see the color has been
changed successfully but where does this
color.xml file locate in our project
well if you want to take a look at that
you can open the project pane
inside the resources folder inside the
values folder we have this colors.xml
you can see that we have some colors in
here
with the exact name that we just saw
don't worry about this we are going to
talk about different kind of xml files
in future videos but for now i just
wanted you to see this xml file so
instead of passing a color from inside
the color.xml file you can also pass the
hexadecimal value of that color for that
you can search the internet for
something like html color picker
let's search that
for example let's select a green color
in here
this one maybe
and in here you can see the hexadecimal
value let's copy that
and instead of passing a color from
inside our color.xml file
i'm going to paste the value of that
color you can see that the color of the
text view has been changed to the color
that we just selected
if you remember from the previous videos
of this course we have seen that when we
wanted to have access to all of these ui
elements inside our java file we needed
an id let's add an id attribute for this
text view as well let's say id
the convention is to say add plus id
slash let's select that
and let's define some id let's say txt
welcome
the id attribute should be unique inside
every xml file it means that two
different elements inside the same xml
file cannot have the same id
later on we will use this id in our java
file in order to have access to this
text view
there are much more attributes to text
views but i think if we continue we are
going to get bored for that i'm going to
move on from this text view and i'm
going to define a button after this text
view
for that once again i can open an anchor
bracket
and in here i can say button
with this capital b let's select the
first option
once again we have these two mandatory
attributes
and in here let's talk about the
difference between this wrap content and
match band
right now if i select match parent
let's also select match parent for this
fight
you can see that this button is covering
all of the screen
and that's because we have set the width
and height to match parent
if you want you can change this height
for example to wrap content
and here you can see the difference the
width is matching the parent but the
height is
wrapping the buttons content let's also
change the bits to wrap content
beside wrap content and match parent you
can always pass the values manually for
example i can say 150 dp
you can see that the vids has been
changed
but this is highly discouraged because
our application is going to be installed
on devices with different screen sizes
sometimes if we put some numbers for
this if we pass the values manually we
may not know the exact position of every
element and also sometimes our elements
might not fit in the screen in some
devices so for that matter i'm going to
change this one to wrap content in here
also now that i have talked about
different screen sizes i'm going to say
that in here inside this preview you
have this option called devices for
preview
if you click on that you can see a drop
down
and from here you can select different
screen sizes for example let's select
this one
and you can check the looks of your
application in different screen sizes
for example let's check a tablet
you can see that it's somehow different
don't worry about this and later on in
the course we are going to cover how we
can have a consistent look for our
application in different screen sizes i
just wanted to mention this option above
in here like for the text view we have a
text option for the button as well
let's say text
and let's say say hello
similarly we have the option to add some
margins but i'm not going to do that
right now
instead i'm going to move this button to
below this text view
for that we have an attribute called
below
this one in here layouts below
and we need to pass the id of the other
element for example in this case we need
to pass the id of this text view i can
say add plus id slash
and i can say txt welcome
you can see that the button has been
moved to below this text view
but this is not entirely what we want
we also need to center it horizontally
for that once again we can say center
horizontal
and we can pass through
let's also add a margin top
let's say margin top
and let's pass for example 15 db
that's much better
for both of these text view and button
you have another attribute called
background let's also see that
we can say background and for example we
can pass a color
let's pass the first color
you can see that the background color of
this button has been changed somehow
you have the same option for the text
view if you want you can apply that i
think this is an ugly color so i'm going
to change that
let's see the other colors
let's select this primary dark
no this is not my color
okay this is better you can always add
the hexadecimal value of the color that
you want in here as well
for different ui elements we also have
another attribute called on click we
have seen the use of this on click when
we have created our first android
application
you can guess it we are going to set an
event listener for this button and we
are going to say what happens when we
click on this button
so let's say on click and let's pass the
name of some method for example i'm
going to say on hello beauty and clicked
right now you can see that we are
getting this red warning and that's
because we need to create this method
inside our java file let's finish
creating our button by using this slash
and let's create this method inside our
mainactivity.java file
so let's open that file
in order to open some files i can always
switch to this project thing
or alternatively i can press the shift
key two times you can see that when i do
that i have a search menu for example in
here i can search for main activity
and if i press enter on the first option
we can open our mainactivity.java file
this is just a helpful shortcut that we
can use from time to time
okay we need to create the onclick
method inside the scope of our class and
outside of the scope of this oncreate
method
if you remember the signature of that
method it was something like this we
needed to set the access modifier to
public
the return type was void the name of the
method is going to be exactly the name
that we have passed in our xml file
let's say on hello between clicked
for the inputs of this method if you
remember we had a view object with
capital v
this view object is not important right
now we just need to know that we need to
receive it as the input of this method
let's pass view as the name of this
input
and in here we can have the logic
to handle the click listener on our
button
also if you have noticed when i added
this view a new import has been added
above in here let's also minimize this
import for now
this is one way of creating event
listeners for buttons and also for that
matter for different ui elements
we have other options in which may be
more useful from time to time
we will take a look at them in a minute
but in here let's quickly
write some logic for example in here i'm
going to change the text of my text view
for that first of all i need to have
access to my text view
i can say text view
if you take a look at your imports you
will see that
this text view from the widget package
has been added to our class
if you remember i set that equivalent to
every ui element
you have a class in java
okay let's name this text view txt
welcome
and let's initialize it we can
initialize it like this we can say find
view by id
like this set content view method this
find view by id is also another inner
method inside every activity
right now this find viewbyid method is
waiting for some integer and the integer
is going to be the id of our elements
and here is how we can pass our id for
example we can say r
dot id
once again if you remember i said that
this r in here stands for resources it's
a special class in java and it will give
us the access to all of the static
contents in our project so in here i can
say r dot id dot let's pass the id of
our text here which was txt welcome i
believe now that we have access to this
txt welcome we can do some operation on
that for example i can say txt welcome
dot set text we have seen this method
previously
and inside this method i can pass a text
let's say hello again
let's run the application and let's see
if we can change the text of this text
view i'm going to run the application on
pixel 3 api level 29 you can select
whichever device that you want
okay right now we can see the layout
that we have created so far which is
honestly ugly but don't worry about that
we are going to work on on our designing
power
if i click on this button you can expect
what would happen we are going to change
the text from hello to hello again
okay there was nothing special in this
video i just wanted you to have another
look at what we have done in the first
section of this course which was to
create your first android application i
just wanted you to have a better
understanding on what you have done in
that video also we have learned about
some other attributes in here as well
okay in the next video we are going to
continue our talk on different ui
elements for example we will talk about
edit texts
and also we will talk about different
ways that we can implement
an unclick listener for our button
okay see you in the next video
in the previous video we have seen one
way of creating an unclear listener for
our button there are two more ways and
in here we are going to see them for
example in our layout file let's quickly
create a button but before that i'm
going to change this constraint layout
to a relative layout
let's delete this text and let's create
a button
let's say wrap content and wrap content
for the bits and point
let's give it a text
for example let's say say hello once
again
let's say center in parent
and let's pass through we have seen
these in the previous video so i'm not
going to discuss them also we are going
to need an id
let's say
btn hello you can pass whatever you want
so in the previous video when we wanted
to create an onclicklistener we would
have add this on click attribute in here
we needed to pass the name of the
equivalent method inside our java file
but in this case i'm going to use
another approach and for that i'm going
to delete this
attribute
okay let's switch back to our java file
and let's define this button
inside my uncreate method i'm going to
say
button
let's name it btn hello
[Music]
is equal to
find view by id
let's say r dot id
dot btn hello
for setting an unclicked listener for
your button you can use the equivalent
method you can say btn hello
dot set on click listener you can see
that we have this method
inside the parenthesis we need to pass
an interface
in this case it can be neo
view dot unclick listener
if you take a closer look you can see
that this is an interface
ok now that i have passed this new
interface in here this unclick method
has been overrided and inside this
unclick method i can write my code for
example if i want to print something
into my console i can say print
let's just say hello let's run the
application and let's see if we can see
any result
i have opened this run panel in here and
if i click on this say hello button
you can see that hello is being printed
in here
so this way by using this set on click
listener method on our button
we can define the onclicklistener
inside the parentheses of this method we
have passed this
newview.onclicklistener method but there
is also another way let's quickly see
that
so instead of passing a new interface in
here i'm going to implement this exact
interface in the declaration of my class
if you remember from the java session we
can implement interfaces like this we
can say implements
let's say unclick listener
there are two options in here the first
one is coming from
android.view.viewpackage and the next
one is from another one we need the
first one when we implement interfaces
we also need to implement the methods we
can do that by pressing control plus i
we need to implement this onclick method
as the input of this onclick method we
are getting a view object and now we can
use this view in order to create
different cases for example we can say
switch
on view or v in this case it's his name
let's say dot get id
we are going to create our switch
depending on the id of this view object
and after that i can say case
in case it's r dot id
dot ptn hello
the exact id that we have passed in here
in case this is the idea let's write
some code for example i'm going to copy
this line of code from here
let's also add a break and also a
default case
now that i have implemented this method
at the declaration of my class and also
i've implemented this onclick method i
can remove this btnhello.set
onclicklistener method and let's write
it once again let's say between hello
that's it on clicklistener
this time instead of saying new
view.onclicklistener i can say this
if you remember from the java session
this refers to the current object right
now we are inside this class which
implements this interface
so this method down in here is happy
with accepting this as the input
so how's the flow of things in here
first of all we are setting the
onclickness nerve and we are passing the
class itself as the interface
whenever the user clicks on this button
this onclick method will be triggered a
view will be passed to this method in
this case it's a button later on we will
talk about that why a view and a button
are equivalent
we are getting the id of this view and
we are creating a switch statement
in case the id of this view is r dot id
dot ptn hello the id of our button we
are printing this hello in here if we
had other buttons or for that matter
other views
we can create different cases for them
in here as well
let's run the application once again and
let's see if we can see the same result
once again if i click on this say hello
button
you can see that hello has been printed
into our own console
also i don't like to come down in here
inside this run in order to test my
application
instead i'm going to show something to
the user in our application
for that instead of using this
system.out.printline
i'm going to use another option called
toastmessages
let's search for toast messages and
let's see what those are like
so basically a toast message is
something like this
this is not a permanent message and it
will be disappear after a period of time
let's quickly see that how can we define
this in our code
so in here i'm going to delete this line
of code
instead i'm going to say toast
you can see that i have two options in
here the first one is a java class but
the second one is a template
basically templates are provided by the
ide that we are using for example in
here if i select this template
you can see that this whole line of code
has been created so we are using this
toast class in which has this static
method
inside this static method we are passing
a context whatever that is we will talk
about context later on in the course but
for now
so we are using this toast class in
which has this static method called make
text
we have three inputs for this make text
method
the first is a context don't worry about
the context yet
we will talk about that later on in the
course but for now just know that every
activity in android is a context and
because right now we are inside an
activity we can pass this as our context
the next input is a text basically this
is going to be the text that we are
going to show for example let's say
hello button clicked
after that we have this constant in here
which is toast.length short basically
this is just a constant for determining
how long do we want our toast message
for example if you want to see the other
time periods
you can say dot
we have length long and length short
let's select a length short
and after this make text method we have
this dot shown method which you can
guess is going to show our toast message
so before this we have created our toast
message and after that and with the help
of this show method we are showing it to
the user in here we have used the
template but if you don't want to use
the template you can always create your
own toast message
you can say toast this time let's select
the first one
let's say make text for the context
let's pass this
we need the text in here let's say
second
text and after that we need a constant
let's say
toast.length long
dot show basically these two lines of
code are the same
we just can't create them with the help
of the ide okay this time let's run the
application and let's see what would be
the result
so this time if we click on this say
hello button
you can see that some toast message is
showing down in our screen and after
that it will be disappeared i think
toast messages is much better for our
testing purposes it's much better than
this run pane down in here okay let's
close the application in here
and let's talk about this view that we
are receiving in here in a logical way
instead of this view we need to receive
a button because we are creating our
switch statement based on the id of our
button
but there is a point in here if you
press down the ctrl key and if you click
on this button class once again if you
press down the ctrl key and if you
click on the class that this button is
extending in this case this text view
you can see that this text view class is
extending the view class
it means that after two times of
inheritance our button is somehow a view
we just extended the view class two
times
so at the end a button is a view
if you remember from the java session
when we have talked about inheritance
for example when we extended the animal
class and we created our dog class
we said that a dog is an animal in this
case a button is also a view for that
matter every ui element is a view
like text views edit text and also other
ui elements that we will talk about
later on in the course so this in here
proves that we can create an unclick
listener for our text view and other ui
elements as well so this unclick method
is not limited to our button
it's also worth mentioning that when you
create your onclicklistener this way by
implementing the interface in your class
declaration you just need to create one
onclick method for all of your ui
elements for example if i had another
method down in here i could have passed
the id of that button to another case
and inside that case i could have write
my logic so i can have as many methods
and for that matter as many unclick
listeners for my view elements also this
onclicklistener is one of the available
event listeners we have others as well
if you want you can take a look at them
by saying btnhello dot set
let's say set listener and you can see a
lot of these options we have on click
listener we have on direct listener
you can guess the meaning of each one of
these we have set on hover listener in
case if we hover over our button
we also have another useful one on long
click listener it means that if we long
press on the button let's quickly see
this one this time instead of
implementing the on long click listener
in my
class declaration i'm going to use the
easier way by saying new
view.onlineclicklistener
this one you can see that in here we
have a boolean as the return type of
this onlineclick method
this boolean is just a callback
indicating if
we have long pressed our button if you
want your code inside this method to
work fine you need to pass through
let's write some logic in here for
example i'm going to say toast once
again we can see this context in here
but the format is somehow different
because right now we are inside an
interface we are inside this
onlineclicklistener interface if we pass
this this will refer to the current
object which in this case is an
interface but interfaces are not context
and we need to pass our activity
for that method we can say main activity
dot this don't worry about this main
activity that this if you didn't get
that i will talk about that later on in
the course when we have talked about
activities
but for now just uh let's pass this as
our context and let's create a text
let's also change the time period in
here to length long
i think i need to delete this case from
here as well
okay let's run the application
[Music]
so like before if i click on this button
and you can see that we are seeing this
message hello button clicked
which is a simple on click listener for
our button but if i press my button and
hold the key
you can see that we are seeing this long
press message so this time instead of
this on click we have executed this set
onlineclicklistener method you can also
check the other event listeners for your
view items later on in the course we
will check a few more of them but in
general you can say btnhello.setlistener
and you can use each one of these that
you want
okay let's move on from the event
listeners and let's define another ui
element in our layout file
before this button i'm going to define
an edit text
let's say edit text
for the width let's say match pattern
this time
and for the height let's say wrap
content
you can see that it's something like
this if you click on that this is our
edit text
let's also add a text in here
let's say name
and name has been added
that seems to be better let's also
center our edit text i'm going to say
center in parent and i'm going to pass
through but right now we have a conflict
between this edit text and our button
for that i'm going to move this button
to below this edit text
but before that i need to give an id to
this edit text let's say id
let's just name it edit text name
let's finish creating this edit text
and down in here inside our button
element
i can say below or to be a specific
layout below
and i can pass the id of my edit text
before that i need this add plus id
slash
let's say edit text name
so this way we have moved this button to
below our edit text i think it's better
to have some margins let's say margin
top
and let's pass 20dp
that seems better okay let's switch back
to our edit text
i don't like the text inside my edit
text because if i run the application
and if i try to type something in here
first of all i need to delete this text
for that instead of this text attribute
i'm going to use another attribute
called hint i think we have hint at the
first videos of this course let's just
pass name this time it's much better so
whenever i click on this edit text and
if i try to type something this name
hint will be disappeared
also if we want to decrease the width of
our edit text we can
pass a number in here for example we can
say 250 dp
which is better in this case but if you
remember i said that it's never a good
idea to pass your width and height
manually because in different screen
sizes you cannot predict the size of
your different elements for that once
again i'm going to change this one to
match part i believe it was
and after that down in here i'm going to
add two margins let's say margin left
to 50 dp for example
i think it's better to change it to 100
and also let's add a margin right of
100.
adding different margins is one way but
we also have another way let's quickly
see that as well so i'm going to delete
both of these margins
instead uh at the declaration of my
relative layout inside the opening tag
as you can see this is our closing tag
and this is our opening tag
inside the opening tag i can define an
attribute called padding once again like
margins and we have multiple paddings we
have padding bottom padding left right
top
let's just use padding in here
and let's pass 100 dp so as you can see
the size of our edittext has been
changed the padding and the margin are a
lot like each other just there is one
difference
when you are adding a margin for example
in the previous case
for our edit text the margin would be
added from the end of our element for
example from here to the end of our
screen
but when you are adding a padding that
padding will add some space from inside
your element for example in this case
the element is this relative layout
itself and we have added the padding
from inside the relative layout
so once again margin adds the space from
the outside of the element but the
padding will add the space from the
inside of the element you can use both
of them depending on your need let's see
what other attributes do we have for our
edit text
like a text view we can change the color
for this edit text as well
for example i can say text color
and let's pass
this color that we have in our color
resources right now we do not have any
text inside our edit text but as soon as
we type something the color will be
changed to this color that we can see in
here we can also style the text by
saying
text style this one
we can say italic bold normal or if we
want to use
two styles at the same time we can add a
pipeline
there is another attribute that we
didn't have in text views
and that's called lines for example
there are times that you may need a
bigger input from the user you can
specify the number of lines in here for
example if i say f4 for example now our
edit text is going to accept four lines
of inputs
in this case i'm not going to use these
lines so i'm just going to delete that
the default number for different lines
is one
with edit text you can also define the
kind of input that you are going to
receive for that you can say input type
this one and you can pass one of these
for example if it's a date that i'm
going to receive i can pass a date or
maybe this date time
if i'm going to receive a number
password i can pass this number password
if it's just a simple text i can pass
this text we have other options for
example for different emails
and all sort of options that you can see
in here
for example if i select this text
password in here
and if i add some text instead of this
hint
let's say text
you can see that when i type the text it
will change it to these dots
probably you have seen this on your
phone when you are trying to log into
some application or some website this
will add some level of security also
when you define it to email
this text email address when the user
clicks on your edit text
the keyword will be prepared to type the
email address
i'm not going to define any specific
type of input so i'm going to delete
this one in here as well
and let's also change this one to hint
okay i think that's enough about edit
text we have all sort of different
options in which you can check them from
here
as you can see there are a thousand of
these attributes
okay below this button let's also define
a text view
i'm going to say text view
wrap content and wrap content let's give
it an id let's say txt hello
after that maybe some placeholder text
let's just say hello
let's also move it to below this button
i'm going to say layout below
also it's worth noticing that if you are
not using a relative layout for example
if you are using a constraint layout you
do not have this layout below option
this is one of the features of this
relative layout we will talk about that
in future videos okay in here let's pass
the id of our button let's say btn hello
also let's move it to center horizontal
and let's add some margins
margin top of maybe 30 db let's increase
the size of this text by saying text
size
and by passing i believe 20 would be
fine
i'm almost done with this layout file
let's just go talking here into this
code
and let's select this reformat code in
order to rearrange our code so that if i
publish the code you would have the same
code that i'm writing in here
okay let's switch to the main activity
and let's define all these three items
let's say edit text
let's name it edttxt
i believe it was name
is equal to find view by id r dot id dot
edit text name
let's also define our text view
let's name it txt name is equal to find
view by id r.id dot
txt name or txt hello was it i think
it's better to change the name to txt
hello
but right now there is a problem with
our code we are instantiating our ui
elements inside this uncreate method
which once again is the starting point
of our application but we are going to
need these two ui elements inside this
onclick method
because we are going to change the value
of this textview whenever the user
clicks on our button and if i try to
have access to this txt hello for
example from inside this method
if i type txt hello you can see that i'm
getting a red warning you can see that
the id cannot resolve this symbol it
means that inside this method we do not
have access to this text view i'm not
sure if i've mentioned this in the java
section but the problem in here is
occurring because of the scope in java
so right now the scope of this text view
is inside this uncreate method and
outside of that we cannot use that
if we want to have access to this text
view
inside both of these methods we can say
something like this we can declare this
text view
in the declaration of our class as
different fields
for example above in here i can say
private
let's say text view
this one
and let's name it txt hello
but right now in here if i try to
instantiate my text you for example if i
say find view by id and i pass my id
because this part in here is not a part
of this activity lifecycle
we are not going to instantiate our text
view at all we need to instantiate our
element inside this uncreate method
which is once again the starting point
of our application so this way we are
separating the declaration and
instantiating of our ui element i can
put a semicolon down in here and this
time instead of defining the whole text
view
i can use this field i can say txt hello
this one
is equal to find view by id or dot id
dot txt helder
now that i have declared this txt hello
as a field i can use it in both of these
methods
for example in here i can say txt hello
dot set text
inside this settext method i'm going to
need the text of this edit text for that
i'm going to define this edit text as a
field as well
so let's say private
edit text
let's name it edttxd name
and down in here let's remove this edit
text
now i can pass this edit text for
example to this settext method
let's say hello
plus the edittext
dot get text
if you remember from the first videos of
this course i said that we need a
tostring method as well we have seen
this tostring method in different java
classes
it's just going to generate some text
in this case if we delete this tostring
and if we just pass this
edittextname.gettext
if you press down the control key
and if you hover over this get text
method you can see that the return type
of this get text method is an editable
we do not know what that is yet but we
just know that this is not a string and
in here we are going to need a string
for that we need another level of
conversion we need to convert the
editable to a string
so we can use this to string method
okay i think after a lot of talking our
application is ready let's just run the
application and let's see if we can see
the behavior that we wanted
let's type something in here
let's say mesa
and let's press this button hello mesa
our application is working fine and
hopefully we understand each piece of
the code that we have wrote so far
few minutes earlier i said that
different ui elements extend the view
class
we have seen that for this button let's
also check the case for this edit text
and text view you can press down the
ctrl key and you can click on this edit
text class
you can see that it's extending the text
view if you click on this textview once
again by pressing down the control key
you can see that it's extending the view
class
the same is for the text view itself
if you press down the ctrl key and if we
click on the text view you can see that
it's extending the view class
now that we know both of these are
extending the view class we can create
an unclick listener for each one of them
and later on inside this unclick method
if you want we can create another case
for each one of them for example down in
here
for the edit text
i can say edit text name
dot set unclick listener
you can see that we have this option in
here
and because we are implementing the
onclicklistener interface inside our
class declaration i can pass this in
here later on inside the unclick method
i can create another case
for example let's say case r dot id
dot
let's say edit text name
if that's the case let's toast some
message
let's say attempting to type something
before i run my application i'm going to
delete this toast because i'm not going
to have a conflict between different
hosts
so this time if i click on the btn hello
the text is going to be changed to hello
plus the text inside our edit text
and if we click on the edit text itself
we are going to see this toast message
by clicking on the edit text you can see
the toast message down in here that
seems to be perfect
okay i think that's enough for this
video in the next video we are going to
talk about some other ui elements like
checkboxes radio buttons and radio
groups and also progress bar just before
i finish off this video i'm going to say
that i will upload the source code at my
website at mako.org codes
so feel free to check that if you need
to
okay see you in the next video
the first ui element that we are going
to talk about in this video is check box
let's quickly see that in our layout
file
before everything i'm going to delete
this text view and also i'm going to
change the constraint layout to relative
layout
down in here we can create our checkbox
like this we can say check box for the
widths and height let's say wrap content
you can see that this little checkbox
has been added in here if you want we
can add a text to this checkbox as well
let's say text i'm going to enter the
name of a movie so let's say harry
potter
we can have an id as well let's say id
let's name it checkbox harry
so basically a check box is a box that
we can check or uncheck
for example in here we have an attribute
called checked
we can pass through or false for this
for example if we say true you can see
the checkbox will be checked
let's quickly add two more checkboxes
basically i'm going to copy and paste
this one two more times
but this time first of all i'm going to
change the text to let's say the matrix
and also let's change the id as well
also i'm going to add another attribute
i'm going to move this new checkbox to
the right of my previous checkbox
for that we have an attribute called to
write of layout to write off
let's pass the id of our first checkbox
let's say checkbox harry
let's also add a margin left we can say
margin left
and let's pass 15dp for example
let's copy and paste this one once again
let's change the text to let's say joker
let's also change the id let's say
checkbox joker
and also let's move it to the right of
checkbox matrix
so this way as you can see we can have
multiple checkboxes you can check and
uncheck them by default by setting an
attribute of checked let's change the
value for the joker to let's say false
if we want to center this checkbox
horizontally we can add a margin for the
first one for example we can say
margin or margin left
and we can pass 25 for example
but as you can see this is not accurate
instead what we can do is that we can
create another relative layout and move
all of these three checkboxes into that
relative layout let's quickly see how we
can do that
so inside my first relative layout i'm
going to create another relative layout
let's say relative layout for the bits
and height let's say wrap content
let's also give it an id let's say id
i'm going to name this one movie's
relative layout
now if i want i can center this relative
left i can say center horizontal let's
pass through beside that let's add a
margin top
let's say margin top of 20 dp in other
ui elements normally in here we could
have finished creating our element by
adding a slash in here but in this case
i'm not going to do that instead i'm
going to finish creating my first tag my
opening tag for that i can add a left
anchor bracket and as you can see this
closing tag has been created
automatically
now i can put my three checkboxes inside
these two tags the opening tag and the
closing tag
let's move all of them to inside those
two tags
if you noticed you can see that these
three checkboxes are now centered
horizontally and also they have a margin
top of 20 db
that's because their parent layout which
is this relative layout has these two
attributes
so inside a xml file you can have
relative layout nested inside another
relative layout okay now let's see what
can we do with these checkboxes inside
our java code for that i'm going to open
my main activity.java file if you are
wondering i'm pressing double shift in
order to see this search menu first of
all in here let's define our checkboxes
once again i'm going to define them as
fields let's say private checkbox
for the first one let's say checkbox
harry
in here i have two options first of all
i can create my checkboxes line after
line for example i can say private
checkbox and for the second one we can
name it checkbox matrix or alternatively
because the kind of these objects are
the same i can add a comma in here and i
can define my second checkbox for
example i can say checkbox matrix
let's also define the checkbox joker
and later on inside our uncreate method
let's instantiate them let's say check
box harry is equal to find view by id or
dot id dot checkbox harry
similarly for the next two
if you want you can have a click
listener for each one of these
checkboxes for example i can say
checkbox hiri
dot set unchecked changed listener this
is the listener that i need
let's pass new unchecked changed
listener
once again you can see that this is an
interface
the exact name is compound button dot
unchecked changed listener
inside this interface we have this
unchecked changed method in which we
receive two elements the compound button
itself which is our checkbox in this
case and also this is checked boolean so
in here i can create an if statement i
can say if is checked
let's show a text message
let's say you have watched harry potter
but in the else case let's show another
toast message
this time i'm going to say you need to
watch harry potter
before i write the logic for the next
two check boxes let's run our
application and let's see what would be
the result
right now harry potter is checked but we
are not seeing any toast message and
that's because the onclicklistener in
here is going to react when we click on
this checkbox for example if i uncheck
this checkbox you can see that you need
to watch harry potter
let's also check it
you have watched harry potter
but what if we want to see the toast
message when we run the application
without any clicking on our checkbox for
that we have an option in here before
setting this on click listener
we can check that if our checkbox is
checked or not for example for that i
can create an if statement i can say if
checkbox hiring dot is checked
as you can see this method is going to
return the boolean and as its name
applies it's going to check that if our
checkbox is checked or not
so if it's checked i'm going to show the
toast message let's copy it from here
but in the else case i'm going to show
another toast message once again we can
copy it from down in here
let's run the application
as you can see when i run the
application without any clicking i saw
the toast message
so from time to time this is checked
method is going to be useful
i'm not going to define an unclicked
listener for the next two checkboxes
because i'm sure that you got my point
also like in the previous video instead
of passing this new compound button dot
unchecked changed listener you can
implement this listener at the
declaration of your class for example in
here
and after that you need to override this
unchecked changed method after that you
can pass this instead of this and new
listener in here into your set unchecked
change listener method but once again
i'm not going to go through that
instead let's switch back to our
activitymain.xml file and let's talk
about another ui element but before that
i am going to minimize this relative
layout
the next ui element that i am going to
talk about is radio button
let's say radio button this one down in
here
for the vidsum height let's say wrap
content you can see that this is this
circular button
let's move it to below a relative layout
i can say below or layout below i think
it was named movie's relative layout
let's also add two margins
margin left of let's say 25 dp and also
margin top of maybe 20db
like checkboxes we can also have text
let's say text for the text i'm just
going to say married
this is going to determine the marital
status of the user so that's what this
text is about
let's also give it an id
let's say radio button married
like check boxes if you want to check
this married radio button you can say
checked and you can pass through
if you want to have multiple radio
buttons you can say something like this
you can copy and paste this radio button
but there is going to be some problem
with our code
before that let's change the text and id
of this radio button for example in here
let's say single
and after that let's change the id to rb
single
let's also move this one to right of our
radio button married
let's say to write off
so the purpose of radio buttons in
programming is that among multiple radio
buttons you can only select one this is
the difference between radio button and
checkbox when you have checkboxes you
can check multiple checkboxes
but when you have radio buttons you can
only have one radio button checked
but as you can see our program is not
functioning right in here and that's
because we need to group these radio
buttons and we can do that by creating
another item in here called radio group
before that i'm going to delete these
two radio buttons
let's say radio group
this one once again for the bits and
height i'm going to say wrap content
let's move it below our movie's relative
layout
layout below id
movies are layout
a margin top maybe of 20 dp
and also let's center it horizontally
center horizontal to true
once again because i'm going to put some
radio buttons inside this radio group
i'm not going to finish creating this
radio group
instead i'm going to finish creating
this opening tag by adding a left anchor
bracket
like a relative layout you can see that
now we have an opening tag and also a
closing tag
inside this radio group i can have my
radio buttons let's say radio button
wrap content and wrap content let's give
it an id let's say radio button married
a text maybe
and also let's change its default value
to checked let's say checked through
now we can have multiple radio buttons
let's copy and paste this one
so as you can see i never moved this
radio button to below our first radio
button but it moved automatically
if we change the id to for example rv
single
you can see that even though both of
these radio buttons are checked but only
one of them
is showing the checked value so when you
are using radio buttons only one of them
and i can have a checked value
for that i'm going to delete this
checked attribute from the second radio
button
and also i'm going to change the text to
single
let's also add another one
for the id let's say radio button in
drill
and let's change the text to inner
relationship
let's also delete this checked attribute
right now our radio buttons are vertical
if you want you can have horizontal
radio buttons as well for that inside
your radio group
you can have an attribute called
orientation in which you can pass
horizontal or vertical if i pass
horizontal you can see that now we have
our radio buttons horizontally ordered
i think it's better to have some margins
between these radio buttons so let's
quickly add some margins
let's say margin left
of maybe 15 dp i guess
and let's add another one down in here
okay now let's see how we can use these
radio buttons and radio group inside our
java file
for that i do not need to define my
radio groups instead i just need to
instantiate my radio group
let's say radio
group let's name it radio group marital
status
but i believe i need to give an id to
this radio group and i think i didn't do
that yes in here i can say id
let's say radio group marital status
in our uncreate method let's also
minimize this if statement and also this
unclick listener
[Music]
and after the checkboxes let's
instantiate our radio group we can say
radio group marital status find view by
id or dot id dot
radio group margin status
we can have an on click listener for
this radio group by saying radio group
dot set unchecked change listener
so this method is going to be called
whenever we change and the radio button
selected and inside the parenthesis you
can guess i can pass new unchecked
changed listener
radio group dot unchecked change
listener
which is an interface and it will create
this unchecked change method one of the
inputs of this method is this checked id
in which we can use that for example we
can create a switch statement
on this checked id
and we can create our cases we can say
in case it's r dot id dot let's say
radio button married
so basically this checked id is the id
of a radio button whichever is selected
so in case if the user selects this
radio button married i'm going to show a
toast message
let's just say married
but in case it's r dot id dot let's say
radio button single
let's show another toast message
let's also add another case for rb in
rel
as usual let's also create our default
case
and let's add a break
let's run our application and let's see
if we can see any result
right now this merit is selected if we
select this single you can see that
the married one has been unchecked and
also we have saw the toast message let's
select another one
you can see the text message which is
perfect
right now we have an on click listener
for our different radio buttons inside
this radio group and depending on that
button we are doing something for
example in this case we are showing a
toast message but if you want to do
something without clicking on these
buttons
we can do something like this in our
code
so before this set unchecked change
listener
i can say radiogroup marital status dot
get checked radio button id as you can
guess this will return the id of the
checked radio button and i can save that
inside an integer for example i can say
int
checked button
after that i can create a similar switch
statement based on the checked button
so let's say switch
on the checked button and let's create
our cases i'm going to copy and paste
the cases from here
let's run the application and let's see
if we can see any result as you can see
we are not clicking on any of these
radio buttons but we just saw the
maritos that seems to be perfect
in some cases we might need to check for
the checked radio button before clicking
on them
i'm going to talk about another ui
elements in this video and that's called
a progress bar let's quickly see that as
well before that i'm going to minimize
this radio group
after that down in here let's say
progress bar
wrap content and wrap content let's give
it an id let's say progress bar
let's also center it let's say center in
parent and let's pass through
let's run the application and let's see
what our application is going to look
like with this progress bar
as you can see an infinite progress bar
is constantly circulating this might be
useful for example when we are
downloading something from the internet
in order to make our progress bar
visible or unvisible we have an option
for example in our xml file if we want
it to be not visible we can save
visibility
and we can pass gone
also we have this visibility attribute
for almost all of the other ui elements
if we want we can change it to gun but
by default it's visible
let's change it back to gun
later on in our java code we will change
this visibility to visible
and whenever we are done with it we are
going to change it to gun
let's see how can we do that in our java
code
before everything let's minimize all of
the extra methods and codes
and let's instantiate our progress bar
above in here i'm going to say private
progress bar
let's name it progress bar
and down in here inside the uncreate
method
let's say progress bar is equal to find
view by id r.id dot progress bar
i do not have any button in here in
order to change the visibility of this
progress bar instead i'm going to change
its visibility whenever the user clicks
on the radio button single for that
inside the
radio group marital status listener
inside the switch case in case if it's
uh rv single instead of showing the
toast message or after the toast message
i'm going to say progress bar
dot set visibility and i can say visible
instead whenever the user clicks on this
radio button in drill i'm going to
change the visibility of my progress bar
to gone
let's copy this line of code and after
the toast message
let's paste that and let's just change
this constant to gone
view.com
let's run our application
right now we cannot see any progress
part because in our xml file we have
added the visibility attribute and we
have set the gun value in case if we
click on this single
you can see that we are seeing the
progress bar in case if i click on this
in a relationship you can guess the
visibility will be changed to gone there
is also another form of progress bar
let's quickly see that as well
so in my activity main dot xml file
i can define a style for my progress bar
before that i'm going to change the
visibility once again to visible in
order to see the progress bar in our
preview
and after that let's say style
if i type horizontal you can see this
styling here widget.appcompat.progress
let's change the bits to match parents
so that we can see it better
and also in here i have another option i
can say progress
and i can pass an integer for example i
can say 30.
you can see that the progress of this
progress bar has been changed to 30.
this type of progress bar is extremely
useful when you want to show the
progress of something for example
downloading a file
sometimes you may want to show that how
much of the file has been downloaded
you can also set a maximum for your
progress for example you can say
max
and you can pass 100
let's also add some margin left and
right
margin left of 20 dp
margin right of 20 db
[Music]
okay now let's switch back to our java
file and let's see what we can do with
this progress bar before everything i'm
going to delete these two lines of code
because i'm not going to make my
progress bar visible or unvisible
let's also minimize this switch
statement and this whole listener for
our radio group after instantiating our
progress bar i'm going to create a
thread
if you remember from the java session
this is the simplest way that we can
create a thread
let's say thread thread is equal to new
thread
we needed to pass a runnable let's say
new runnable
inside this run method i'm going to
create a for loop
let's say for int i is equal to 0
i less than 10
and i plus plus
for every time of looping i'm going to
increment the progress of this progress
bar by 10. so let's say progress bar
dot
increment progress boy as you can guess
we need to pass an integer in here for
example let's pass 10.
after that let's freeze this thread for
half a second
if you remember from the java session we
have used this way we set thread dot
sleep but this way there is a
probability that we create interrupted
exceptions for example
you can see that we have an error in
here and the error says that on handled
exception
there is also another way in android i'm
going to use that in here i can say
system clock
dot sleep
so this way we don't need to create the
try catch block this wasn't available in
java this system clock is coming from
android.os you can check that by taking
a look at these imports this one in here
android.os.systemclock is the one that
we just imported
after creating our thread we just need
to start it we can do that after the
definition of our thread we can say
thread dot start
so in here we have created this worker
thread in which inside that we are
creating a for loop and for each time of
looping we are incrementing the progress
of our progress bar by 10. also after
each time of looping we are sleeping the
worker thread for half a second
let's quickly switch back to our layout
file and let's delete this progress
attribute it was just for demonstration
so if i remove this one you can see that
the progress will change to zero
let's run the application and let's see
if we can see the progress of our
progress form
as you can see we are changing the value
of this progress bar for every half a
second if you want you can also get the
progress of your progress bar at any
moment that you want for example in here
you can say progress board dot get
progress
as you can see this get progress is
returning an integer which is the
current progress of your progress bar
sometimes you may need that and here is
how you can get that
okay i think that's enough for this
video once again like previous videos
i'm going to upload the source code at
my website at mako.org codes feel free
to check that if you need and also in
the next video finally we are going to
talk about the differences between a
relative layout a constraint layout and
also a linear layout i think it's going
to help you a lot with understanding the
layout files better
okay see you in the next video
in this video we will talk about
different layouts in android
specifically we will talk about relative
layout we will talk about linear layout
and also constraint layout let's start
by talking about the relative layout
like before i'm going to switch to text
view in my layout file
let's also minimize this project thing
and let's change this constraint layer
to relative layout
i'm also going to enable this preview so
that we can see what we are doing
first of all let's delete this text view
and let's start from the beginning
so inside a relative layout all of our
ui elements are somehow related to each
other it means that the place of every
ui element is relative to another layout
or maybe it's parent let's quickly
create a text view and let's see the
relativity in action
like before i'm going to say wrap
content for the vids and height
let's also specify a text
let's just say hello world
as you can see right now the text view
is placed at the left corner of my
screen if i want i can change that for
example you have seen in the previous
videos that i can center this text view
vertically or horizontally for that i
can say center horizontal
let's pass through we can see that it's
being centered and this is the
relativity that i was talking about when
we set this layout center horizontal
attribute to true we are defining a
relativity between this textview and its
parent let's also center it vertically
or instead of these two attributes i can
simply say center in parent
let's also give an id to this text view
let's say txt hello
now if i define another ui element i can
place that related to this text view
let's quickly create a button in here
let's say wrap content and wrap content
for the bits and height let's define a
text
like before let's say say hello
also let's define an id
now if i want to move this button to
below this text view i can simply say
layout below
and let's pass the id of our text view
txt hello
i can center this button as well for
example i can say center horizontally
and let's pass through
we can also have a margin for example we
can say margin top
layout margin top and we can pass some
number for example 15 db
inside a relative layout you can also
have another relative layout let's
quickly see that for example in here i'm
going to define a relative layout and
inside that relative layout i am going
to put three text views
after that i am going to move this text
view this hello world to below that
relative layout
so i can say relative
layout for the bits and height let's say
wrap content you can say match parent
like other ui elements we can define an
id for our relative layout for example i
can say first relative layout
so up until this point when we wanted to
create our ui elements after setting the
attributes we could have used this
backslash in order to finish creating
our ui elements but in this case because
we are going to put some other elements
inside this relative layout
we need to create an opening tag and
instead of using the backslash i am
going to use the left anchor bracket
by doing that we also create this ending
tag
and inside this opening and ending tag
now we can put our ui elements for
example we can pass our text views
let's say text view
wrap content and wrap content i'm going
to fast forward everything for these
three text views
like before we can place our three text
views uh inside this relative layout
correctly for example we can move them
to right of each other so for this
second text view i can say to write of
let's say txt name
let's also add a margin left
of 10 dp
similarly for the third text view
let's say to write off our txt last name
and margin left of maybe
10 db once again
once again this whole relative layout is
placed at the left corner of our screen
if we want we can use the center
vertical or center horizontal attributes
for this whole relative layout as well
so inside the opening tag of this
relative layout i can say center
horizontal
and let's pass through
let's also add some merging top let's
say margin top
and let's pass 100 db
you can see that when i use these
attributes on a relative layout level
all of the ui elements inside that
relative layout respond to those
attributes for example in here we have
centered them horizontally and also we
have added the margin now that we have
this relative layout we can minimize
that so that we can see everything
better
and after that we can move this hello
text to below this relative layout but
before that i need to delete this
centering parent attribute
once again you can see that it moves to
the corner of our screen and because we
have set the layout below for this
button it moves as well so in here i can
say layout below and i can pass the id
of my relative left it was first
relative layout
let's also center it horizontally and
let's uh pass some margin
center horizontal true
margin top let's say 10 dp
so my point in here was that inside a
relative layout or for that method
inside any other kind of layout you can
have other relative layouts as well
some of these attributes for example
this layout below are specific to
relative layout and if you are inside
some other kind of layout for example a
linear layout and also constraint layout
you cannot use this layout below during
the course we will see that each of
these attributes are specific to
relative layout
before we move to the next kind of
layouts let's also switch to this design
view
at the left pane in here you can see
this component three
as the name of this componentry applies
this in here is showing us the hierarchy
of different elements in our ui
so for example in here we have this
parent relative layout
inside that we have this first relative
layout and also txt hello and btn hello
inside our first relative layout we have
three text views sometimes when you have
a messy ui you may use this component
tree in order to keep track of different
ui elements okay let's switch back to
our text view and let's start talking
about
linear layout before that i'm going to
delete all of these
and let's change this relative layout to
a linear layout
inside a linear layout all of the ui
elements will be placed line after line
let's quickly see that i'm going to
define a text view once again wrap
content and wrap content
let's pass a text
let's say hello world once again
let's also give it an id
let's say txt hello
so the first thing that is different
inside a linear layout is that you do
not have the centering parent center
horizontally or center vertically
attributes when you use linear layout
for example in here i cannot say center
in parent you can see that it's not
available
if you want to center your ui elements
you can have for example a relative
layout inside this linear layout
let's move on from this part and let's
add another ui element
let's say button wrap content and wrap
content
for the text let's say say hello
and let's give it an id
let's say btn hello
you can see that even though i didn't
use any attribute to move this button to
the right of our text view it
automatically place to the right of our
text view and that's because we are
using a linear layout inside a linear
layout all of our ui elements will be
placed one after another
if you want you can change the
orientation of this linear layout so
that the ui elements will be placed one
after another vertically
let's quickly do that
so in the definition of my linear layout
i'm going to pass an attribute in here
let's say orientation
and let's pass vertical
you can see that they have been placed
vertically
there is also another attribute that i'm
going to talk about in linear layout
let's quickly delete this button and
let's define another text view
for the text let's say name
[Music]
and for the id let's say txt name
like before you have the margins for
example you can say margin top and we
can pass any number that we want but
there is also another attribute
in here before i talk about that
attribute i'm going to give some
background color for these two text
views so that we can see the difference
better so i can say background and i can
pass a color for example this color
accent that we have in our color
resource
let's also set a color for the first
text view
let's say background and let's pass
color primary this time
so the attribute that i'm going to talk
about is weight let's quickly see that
you can see this layout weight in here
and we can pass any number that we want
for example i can say 20.
let's also pass a weight to this second
textview and we will talk about it
let's save weight and let's pass 80 for
example
you can probably guess the usage of this
weight attribute right now it will give
our attribute some weight according to
the numbers that we have used for
example in this case
the entire weight of our layout is 20
plus 80 which is 100
and it will give the first textview 20
of the weight of the whole layout it
doesn't matter what number you put in
here for example in here if i say 2 and
for the second one if i say 8
it will work the same also you can see
this space in here that's because we
have this margin top if we remove that
you can see that the whole layout will
be divided accordingly so this weight
was another attribute that i was going
to talk about
if i change this orientation to
horizontal
you can see that
it's working the same
there is not much to this linear layout
i just wanted to show you that there is
one linear layout with some specific
attributes for example this orientation
and this weight and in this course we
are not going to use linear layout that
much it's uh for simple layouts but you
can use it if you want before i remove
all of this i'm going to say that inside
a linear layout you can also have other
layouts for example a relative layout or
a constraint layout okay let's remove
all of these and let's talk about
constraint layout
before that i'm going to remove this
orientation because it was specific to
linear layout
okay let's say constraint layout
we have two options in here widget dot
constraint and widget dot constraint
layout this is the one that we are going
to need for this constraint layout i am
going to switch to design view because i
think
it's much better to work with the design
view first of all i am going to enable
the blueprint so that we can see the
difference if there is any you can click
on this blue stack in here and you can
select this design plus blueprint
we will talk about the difference
between this design mode and this
blueprint in a minute okay for working
with the constraint layout you can drag
your ui elements like before you can
drag for example a text view and as soon
as i did that you can see that we have
four circles at the four edges of our ui
element
let's zoom in a little bit you can see
that the four circles are at the four
edges of our ui element
let's zoom out a bit i just wanted to
show you the four circles also the
shortcuts that i'm using in here is
control plus plus in order to zoom in
and control plus minus in order to zoom
out also at any time you can use control
plus 0 in order to have a fit screen
it's also worth mentioning that if you
have a keyboard that has some numbers
and keys for the calculator
the plus minus and 0 from the
calculator keys are not going to be
helpful in here
so the shortcuts are going to be only
useful for when you are using the upper
numbers and also the upper plus and
minus
the most basic thing in a constraint
layout is to constraint your ui elements
right now you can see that we have a red
error in here
similarly we have the same error in our
component 3 it says that we need to
constraint your ui element in order to
constraint your ui elements you can
drag one of these circles to for example
the edge of your screen so right now we
have added one constraint if we switch
back to our text view
you can see that we have this constraint
in here
i'm talking about this two line of
coding here
okay let's go back to the design view
we can add another constraint for
example for the right constraint of our
ui element
we can add a constraint to the right
edge of our screen but still this
constraint layout is not happy it says
that not vertically constraint it means
that we need to at least add another
constraint in here
and now the error is gone and it has
been changed to some warning if you want
to center your ui element and into the
center of your parent you can add
another constraint for example from the
bottom of this textview to the bottom of
the screen
if you want to remove one of these
constraints you can just click on the
circle and you can press the delete key
you can see that the constraint will be
deleted let's press ctrl z in order to
redo that
if you take a look at this attributes
pane in here you can see that you have a
slider for this textview for different
constraints right now the number says 50
but if you want you can change that for
example
if you move it a little bit you can see
that the text view responds accordingly
it will move according to this slider
similar to that we have this horizontal
slider in which you can guess we can
move our ui element so constraining your
ui element to the edges of the screen is
one way you can also add constraints to
other ui elements for example if i have
a button in here
let's quickly add that
and let's delete the constraints of this
text view all of them
let's move it so that we can see
everything better
this time if we want we can constrain
this button to for example the bottom of
this text view
you can see that it moves accordingly
you can also see that when i click on
one of these
circles i can see all of the available
targets for example i can constraint it
to the right of my text view sometimes
it might not work and you may want to
add that one more time so this way we
have constrainted our button to the
bottom of this textview and also to the
right of this textview if we want to
make it center we can add another
constraint to the left of this textview
and both of these ui elements are now
somehow centered
let's also add a margin so that we can
see everything better
so by clicking on one of your ui
elements you can see that in the
attributes pane we can add a margin for
example from top let's add 32
if you take a look at this component
tree in here you can see that
we have no error about this button but
we have an error about this text view it
means that we have all of the
necessary constraints about this button
but we need to add some constraints
about this text view for example we need
to constraint it
vertically or maybe horizontally as well
like before we can add the constraints
to the both edges of our screen you can
also see that when i add the constraint
this button moves as well it means that
no matter where this textview is we want
our button to be constrainted to this
textview
let's add another one
let's also add a margin top for this
textview as well
i think 32 is not enough so let's say
100.
let's also add another textview and
let's see other kind of constraints
so constrainting in your textviews for
example from top of this textview to the
top of this textview and from bottom of
this textview to the bottom of this
textview
is one way of having two textviews at
the same line horizontally
there is also another way
i'm going to press ctrl z to time so
that we undo the constraints we can
right click on one of our ui elements
and we can select this show baseline
now you can see this baseline
instead of adding the two constraints
from top and bottom we can select this
baseline
and we can constraint it to the baseline
of this textview
this time once again they are at the
same
line horizontally
let's zoom in a little bit
in order to navigate through all of your
layout you can press down the space key
and you can drag your mouse like if you
work with photoshop you have the same
ability you can see that both of these
text views are at the same line
horizontally by adding some constraint
to the baseline once again the baseline
is not available by default you can
right click and you can select this show
baseline
let's zoom out so we have seen that we
can constrain our ui element to both
edges of our screen but what if we want
to for example have another line for
example if we want to move this text
view or constrain this text view to some
other space beside these two edges for
that we can right click on our layout
down in here inside these helpers we
have these uh guidelines add vertical
guideline and add horizontal guideline
you can guess each one of these will
create a line for example let's add a
vertical guideline
let's zoom in a little bit so that we
can see better you can see that this
line has been added to our layout we can
move it for example
we can move it to the right of our
screen as soon as i did that you can see
that we have some margin from the left
side of our screen you can see this
triangle in here if i click on that it
will change the margin from left to the
right of our screen sometimes this might
be useful as well right now the
constraint of this textview is the edge
of our screen let's quickly delete the
left constraint of this text view and if
we want we can add this constraint to
this guideline for example we can add it
in here sometimes once again it might
not work
you can see the difference the text view
now constrainted to this guideline
instead of the edge of our screen if you
want you can constrain this text view to
this guideline as well but before that
we need to delete this baseline
constraint let's quickly delete that
sorry i deleted the whole text view and
let's constraint it to this guideline
and also to the edge of our screen
if you want you can also have multiple
guidelines we will add another one in
the second so for example i can once
again right click on the layouts by
going to these helpers
i can add another vertical guideline
you can see that this guideline has been
added
and i can use it like i've used this
first guideline
we also have a vertical guideline
in our helpers we can add this
horizontal guideline we can guess it
will add a horizontal guideline
once again we have this triangle in here
if we click on that it will change the
margins from top to bottom let's also
constrain this text view to
our guideline
sometimes when you are working with
different ui elements in a constraint
layout adding some constraint might be
difficult for example in here we don't
have much space for that we can select
both of the items that we want to add
constraints for example this text view
and this guideline
you can select multiple ui elements by
pressing down the control key
after you have selected both of them you
can right click
you can go to this constraint in here we
want to constraint our takes view 2
which is the idea of this text view
to our guideline
so i'm going to say
top to let's say bottom of our guideline
tree this way we can add a constraint
sometimes where there is not much space
to work with you can use the
right click menu by selecting this
constraint
you can add the required constraints but
for that once again you need to select
the both of items that you want for
example this takes you on this guideline
or if you want to add the constraint
from this textview to this button for
example you can select this textview and
this button
right now we have set the left
constraint of this textview to this
guideline we can also move this
guideline for example we can move it
accordingly to right and left you can
see that once i move this guideline the
ui elements move as well but depending
on your system this operation in here
might be a slow because as you can see
we are tracking uh the live response of
our ui elements if you want you can
disable this live rendering you can go
to this i in here
and you can uncheck this live rendering
let's zoom in a little bit
now if i move this guideline you can see
that the ui elements themselves do not
move but we can see the outline of every
ui element
so in some cases when you do not have
all of the required resources for
example some large amount of memory ram
you can disable this live rendering but
in here you can see the difference
between this blueprint and also this
design view you can see that when i move
this guideline the ui elements inside
the blueprint view are moving
accordingly and that's because the
blueprint view do not render our ui
elements at all it's just some blueprint
of all of our ui elements later on when
we add some image view to our layout we
will see the difference much better okay
let's move on from this part
sometimes when you are creating your
layout files you may want to have some
sample data or as we might call it in
programming you may want to have some
placeholders for example right now the
placeholder for this text view is this
text view
if we want we can change that
we can right click on our element we can
go to this set sample data
and we can select some text
we can see that we have these cities for
example it will change the text of our
text view to shanghai for example
let's see others
for example another popular choice is
this date in here you can see different
formats
we can select that and we can have some
sample data about the date the other one
is lorem ipsum
if you search on the internet for sample
text you probably get this lorem ipsum
text let's select that
and we can have some sample text and
according to that we can have this text
on our layout we also have the lorem
text let's quickly see that
so instead of lorem random we can select
this lorem which is basically this lorem
text
before we finish off this video let's
also see the sample data for this image
view as well i know that we didn't talk
about image view so far in the course
but we will talk about that in the next
video
we can drag some image view to our
layout
and first thing we need to set some
sample data for our image view for
example we can select from the avatars
right now this is the avatar that by
default we have selected for our imagery
if you want you can change that
by right clicking and set some sample
data we can select another avatar or we
can select one of these for example this
background
let's select another avatar
for example this one
like before you can constrain this image
view for example to the both edges of
your text view let's quickly do that
if you take a look at the attributes
pane in here you can see that for the
layout bits we have set of bits to wrap
content
we can change that for example we can
say match constraint when we do that the
width of our image view will change
according to its parent constraint which
is this text view in this case but there
is also another difference when we
change this layout bits to match
constraint when we do that if you take a
closer look in here inside this
constraint widget you can see that we
have this
line in here let's click on that
and once i do that you can see that this
ratio in here has been added
it's useful for when you want to
show some images from the internet when
you don't know the size or the ratio of
your image
right now the ratio is one to one if you
want you can change that for example you
can save one to two
you can see that now the ratio has been
changed or let's say two to one
the ratio of our image view responds
accordingly
also you have the same option from above
in here layout constraint id which you
can change this two to one to once again
one to one
also now that you have used this image
view you can see the difference between
this blueprint and this design view you
can see that in the blueprint view we
are not rendering the image view
and in the blueprint view we are not
rendering our layout it's very useful
for when you are working with constraint
layout especially if you do not have the
required resources for example if you do
not have large amount of ram you can
always go up to this blue stack icon and
you can select this blueprint so that
you have only the blueprint okay i think
that's enough for this video in the next
video first of all we are going to work
with this image view element
see you in the next video
in this video we are going to talk about
images in android and i believe it will
be a short video
as always let's switch back to our
layout file and let's change this
constraint layer to a relative layout
you can keep working with constraint
layout i'm just more comfortable with
this relative layout
first of all i'm going to delete this
view
and let's create our image view
this time instead of wrap content or
match parent for the bits and height i'm
going to put some number for example i'm
going to say 150 dp
right now you cannot see any image in
your layout file in this preview because
we do not have any placeholder
but you can see the outline of your
image if you want to have some
placeholder you can say something like
this you can say source this src
and you can address some image from your
project
by default you have some images in your
project for example in your driver
folder you have this ic launcher
background let's select that for example
and as soon as i select that you can see
that we can see this green image in our
preview
later on we will talk about this
drawable folder and other folders that
are related to images in android
projects so this is going to be a
placeholder and if you want we can later
on change this image in our java file
let's also give an id to our image view
let's say id
let's name it my image let's also move
it to the center of our parent
let's say center in parent and true
so when we have addressed this image we
have used this add drawable it means
that this image this ic launcher
background lives in our driver folder
if you take a look at your project pane
in the resources folder
we have seen the layout folder in which
we have this
activitymain.xml file
but beside that we have this driver
folder inside this driver folder we have
some xml files as well
so if you take a look at this ic
launcher background
you can see that we have this xml file
which at the end its result is this
image or to be specific is this drawable
inside this xml file we have some
elements like vector path and everything
don't worry about them yet we will talk
about them later on in the course part
at the end the result of this xml file
is this drawable in here if you want you
can add other drivers in your driver
folder as well for example if you right
click on your driver folder
by selecting new
vector asset or image asset depending on
your need you can add new drivers let's
select this new image asset
in here first of all we can select the
type of our image right now
it's launcher icons if you want you can
change that for example you can say
action bar and tab icons so basically
this way you can add some icons to your
project first of all you need to name
your icon this is going to be the name
that later on you will pass to your
images for example your image view you
can see that we have passed this ic
launcher background
that name is coming from here ic stands
for icon it's the convention to name
your icons with this ic so let's say i
see alarm for example in android studio
you have some icons for example if you
click on this icon here this android
icon in here
you can see the clipart you can see that
there are all sorts of icons and you can
use whichever you want
also notice that these icons are
available under this apache license so
make sure to check that before you use
them in your project
because i've named this icon ic alarm
i'm going to select one of these alarms
for example this one
let's select ok
and in here you probably can see the
icon it's somehow void if you want you
can change the color by opening this
drop down
and select a custom color
for example let's pass it in black
now you can see the alarm better also
notice that there are multiple sizes of
this icon and that's because in
different screen sizes the android
system is going to select one of these
sizes for example if it's a larger
screen size with a large pixel rate it
will select one of these larger images
similar to that if your application is
going to run on a smaller screen size
device the android system will select
one of these smaller icons okay let's
select next from here
once again you can see that in your
resources folder inside the driver
folder multiple images multiple driver
files with multiple qualities will be
added and you can also see the output
file this is going to be the xml file
when you create your driver file
basically this at the end is going to
create that alarm icon
let's click finish in here
and if you take a look at your driver
folder now you can see that we have this
ic alarm which once again is presented
with five different qualities
now in our activity main.xml file
instead of passing this ic launcher
background we can pass ic alarm
so this way by adding some derivative
into your driver folder you can add some
images to your project
similarly you can add some images into
your mid map folder as well right now we
have some images in here for example we
have this icy launcher
and also we have this icy launcher round
which at the end will create a rounded
icon
if you want to add some extra images
into your project from for example let's
say your computer you can add them into
this mipmap folder for example i have
prepared this png file
i can copy that let's say copy
and in my mipmap folder i can paste that
let's select the directory and also
let's name our file it's also very
important to note that when you are
importing some images into your project
the name of your mipmap file the name of
your png or jpeg file shouldn't have any
spaces and also for that matter they
shouldn't have any upper cases so the
name in here i think is fine let's press
ok and as you can see this makeover.png
has been added to my bitmap folder
now that i have this image into my
project i can address that from inside
activitymain.xml file
for example in here instead of saying ic
alarm i can say make good
but because we have added that file into
our mid map folder we are getting a red
warning because we are saying add driver
for that i'm going to delete all of
these and i'm going to say add mid map
and i can address maker we can see that
the logo has been added into our project
successfully
so far we have added these images and
drawables in our project in this android
view let's also check the project view
and let's see if we can locate different
images in the project view as well
so you can guess that it's in our app
folder inside the sources folder
inside the main folder inside resources
folder
you can see all these drawables and
midmap folders once again each one of
these is going to respond to the quality
of the screen of the user's device
so for example if we want to locate this
mako.png because it was a high quality
image i believe it will be inside this
mid map
xxhdpi
as you can see it's in here
but if you want to have an application
that responds to each one of the screen
sizes and the screen qualities correctly
you need to create images for each one
of these qualities and add them into
your project
right now if you take a look at for
example this mdpi
you can see that inside this folder we
do not have anymaker.png
it's not going to cause any problem in
order to show the images in different
screen sizes
as long as there is some image with the
namemaker.png it's going to show
something to the user but it may cause
some bad user experience okay let's
switch back to our android view
[Music]
and let's talk about how you can change
the icon of your application but before
that let's quickly run the application
and let's see what is the current icon
for our application
right now you can see that the name of
this application is images and if you
take a look at the list of your
applications on your device
you can see that the logo of these
images is this rounded android icon this
is the icon that we have seen inside our
mipmap folder so if you take a look at
your mipmap folder
down in here we have this ic launcher
round which is this icon which at the
end will be somehow rounded
and if you want to change that you can
go to your manifest folder you can see
that we have this
androidmanifest.xml file if you click on
that
you can see some general information
about your application later on we will
talk about this manifest file and also
other xml files in your project but for
now you can see that inside this
application tags
we have two attributes this icon and
also this round icon both of them are
addressing the ic launcher icon for now
if you want you can change that for
example in the devices that you are not
going to show a round icon you can
change this let's quickly change this
one and let's address our main code
similarly for the round icon i'm going
to pass makeover let's run the
application and let's see if we have
changed the icon successfully if you
take a look at the list of your
applications once again
you can see that the icon for this
images application has been changed okay
i think that's enough for this video in
the next video we are going to
start working on the list view and also
a spinner
so in the next video we are going to
show how can we have a list of different
items
see you in the next video
in this video we are going to talk about
how we can show a list of different
items in our application
for example a list of different cities
or a list of different students
for that first of all i'm going to start
talking about list view
list view is one of the options that we
can use in order to show a list of
different options
for that first of all i'm going to close
this java file for now
and inside my xml file
first of all i'm going to delete this
text view and after that
i'm going to change this constraint
layer to a relative layout
if you want you can work with
constraintly at what i'm more
comfortable with relative layout after
that down in here i'm going to say list
view
for the vidsum height this time i'm
going to say match parent
and as soon as i do that you can see
that in here in our preview we can see a
list of different items on our screen
these are just some sample data
indicating that we are going to use a
list view
i'm also going to add a margin top let's
say margin top
and let's say 100 db let's also give an
id but before that if you take a closer
look in here i'm not sure that if you
can see this scroll bar at the left pane
in here but
it indicates that we can scroll our list
view in case if all of our items do not
fit on the screen
so if we have a large amount of items we
can scroll over our list view okay let's
give an id to our list view let's say id
i'm going to name it cities list view or
cities list
and i think that's enough for now
let's quickly switch back to our java
file and
let's initialize this list here
like before above in here i'm going to
say private list view
let's name it list view or let's name it
cities list
down in here inside uncreate method i'm
going to say cities list is equal to
find view by id
r dot id
also if you have noticed i'm using a
shortcut for this find view by id method
instead of typing all of the method i'm
using fb shortcut if you press enter or
tab you will get the whole method
we will talk about these available
shortcuts in intellij and android studio
later on in the course
okay let's pass the address of our list
view let's say r dot id dot
cities list
after that we need to create the data
that we want to show in our list view
for example in here i'm going to create
an array list of different strings
and later on i'm going to pass it to
this cities list view for that i'm going
to say arraylist this one in here
of different strings
let's name it cities
is equal to new arraylist
and after that i'm going to add some
cities to this arraylist let's say
cities.add
and let's add some items
in here i'm adding all of these cities
to my city's area list manually
but in most cases the list of your
objects will be coming from the web
server or maybe your database because we
didn't talk about those stuff yet we are
going to hard coding them and we are
going to pass them manually to our
arraylist
okay after providing your data you need
to pass this data to your list view but
before that you need to create an
adapter
the purpose of the adapter is to fetch
the data to your list view
let's quickly see how we can create our
adapter
there are multiple kind of adapters but
the one that i'm going to use in here is
this array adapter this is the simplest
one and we are going to work with that
in here
let's say array adapter of type string
let's name it cities adapter
let's say is equal to new arrayadapter
inside the parenthesis of this
arrayadapter we need three things first
of all we need a context which i'm going
to pass this
later on in the course we will talk
about context but in here because we are
inside an activity i'm talking about
this main activity and activities are
context so this one in here is going to
work fine so by passing this we are
passing our main activity as the context
don't worry about that yet we will talk
about context later on in the course
after that we need to pass a layout file
for every item in our list view so for
example if we are going to show the name
of a city we need a layout for that city
in our list view
we can create our customized layout but
in here i'm going to use one of the
built-in layouts
for that i'm going to say android
dot r dot layout
dot let's say simple list item one
so basically this is a built-in layout
file in which we can use in order to
show different cities in our list view
after passing the context and also the
layout file for every item we also need
to pass the data in this case we need to
pass the city's array list so let's say
citizen here
and now we have our adapter for our list
view
once again the purpose of this adapter
is to fetch the data in this case this
city's array list to our list view
after creating your adapter you can say
cities list
dot set adapter
and you can pass your adapter let's say
cities adapter
before running the application let's
quickly review what we are doing in here
first of all we have created our list
view inside our layout file
after that we have initialized it inside
this uncreate method in here
after that we have prepared our data in
this case we have created this simple
array list of different strings called
cities
after that we have created an adapter in
order to fetch these cities release to
our list view
and after creating the adapter we have
passed it to our list view
let's quickly run our application and
let's see if we can see these items in
our list view
as you can see we have created this list
view and also populated the data that we
have passed in our array list
also if we had more data that wouldn't
fit on the screen the listview would be
a scrollable this layout in here for
every item is this simple list item that
we have passed in here
if you want to take a look at that you
can press down the ctrl key in mac it
should be command key
and by clicking on the simple list item
one you can check the layout file you
can see that it's a simple text view
with some attributes
nothing special in here
you can also make your items clickable
right now if you click on one item
nothing happens
but you can set a listener for each one
of these items
let's quickly see that
so after passing the adapter in here i
can say cities list
dot set on item click listener this
phone
and i can pass my interface i can say
new on item click listener
notice that it's adapter view dot on
item click listener it's different from
on click listener
when we pass this interface we have this
on item click method in which uh has
some inputs
the one that we are interested in is
this uh position in here basically this
is going to be the position of our item
in our list view let's quickly see how
we can use that for example in here i'm
going to show a toast message after
clicking on each one of the items
once again when we create our toast
message first of all we need to pass a
context
because we are inside this on item click
method which exists in another interface
we cannot simply pass this we need to
pass main activity.this in order to
reference to our context
after passing the context we can pass
our text for the text in here i'm going
to say
cities
dot get
and for the index in here i can pass
this position
so this way we are going to get the city
name that we have clicked on
we are using this position as the index
in order to get the appropriate city
name from our cities arraylist
also if you have noticed when i use this
cities inside this on item click method
this final keyboard has been added to
the declaration of our arraylist
as a reminder from the java session when
you add a final keyboard at the
declaration of a variable or an object
that variable or the instance of that
object would be constant it means that
you cannot change that instance
but although we cannot change the
instance of these cities after declaring
it as final we can use all of the
methods inside that object for example
we can use this.add method because we
are using this cities arraylist inside
this on itemclickmethod which exists in
another interface the city's arraylist
needs to be constant and
this final keyboard has been added
automatically and if i remove it right
now from here
you can see that we are getting this
error down in here and it says that your
variable should be constant
so let's add the final keyboard once
again
also let's add another text in here
let's say plus
select it
okay let's run the application once
again and let's see if we have set on
item click listener successfully
so now if we click on one of the items
inside our list view for example this
new york you can see the toast messaging
here new york selected
berlin berlin selected
okay it seems like our own item click
listener is working fine once again this
on item click listener is different from
the onclicklistener if you set the
onclicklistener on your list view
it's not going to work according to
every item in your list view okay i
think that's enough talking about list
view you can work around list view if
you want but i do not suggest that
because in android we have modern
solutions for populating a list of
different options for example we have
recyclerview which has a lot of
flexibilities
if you take a look at your layout file
inside the design view
you can find the list view somewhere
inside this legacy
you can see that in here and it's inside
this legacy because these days almost no
one uses list view i just wanted to show
how can you create a list view
the reason that you may want to avoid
using listview is that listview does not
have much flexibility for example you
cannot customize the layout of every
item in your list view
you can create a customized layout for
every item but in recyclerview you have
much more flexibilities
and also the other issue is about
performance if you have a large amount
of data that you want to show in a list
for example if you have a thousand items
in those cases you will see the
performance issue when you are working
with list view recyclerview has done a
much better job when it comes to
performance we will talk about
recyclerview in one or two videos from
now but let's move on from this part
the other layout file that i'm going to
talk about is called a spinner let's
quickly see that
i'm going to define my spinner above
this list view so in here let's say a
spinner
for the width and height this time let's
say wrap content
let's enter it horizontally and also
let's add some merging top
center horizontal true
margin top let's say 50 dp
right now you cannot see your spinner
inside this preview very well and that's
because you do not have any data inside
your spinner yet
basically this spinner is going to
create a drop down menu for example if
you click on this you will see a list of
different options
we will see that in action in a minute
but for now let's just pass an id for
our spinner
let's say students list
or student spinner it's a better name
also let's move our list view to below
this spinner
layout below and let's pass the id of
our spinner
let's initialize our spinner in our java
file like before i'm going to come above
in here and say
private spinner
let's name it a student spinner
and down in here inside the uncreate
method i can initialize that
let's say a student spinner is equal to
find view by id r dot id
dot let's say student spinner
once again like the list view first
level we need to create the list of
items the data that we want to show in
our spinner
for that i'm going to create another
array listing here so let's say
arraylist of different
strings
let's call it students
is equal to new arraylist
after that let's pass some data to this
student's arraylist
similar to when we have worked with list
views after providing our data we also
need to create an adapter
once again the purpose of this adapter
is going to be fetching the data into
our spinner we can create our adapter
like we have did for the list view so in
here i can say array adapter of
different strings
let's name it the student adapter
is equal to new arrayadapter
like before inside this parenthesis we
need three items first of all we need
the context
after that we need the layout file for
every item in our spinner once again you
can create your customized layout file
if you want but in here for the sake of
simplicity i'm going to use a built-in
one
so let's say android dot r
dot layout dot
the layout file that i'm going to use
this time is this simple spinner drop
down item then we created the adapter
for list view we have used this simple
list item one but in here we are going
to use this simple spinner drop down
item
after that once again we need our data
which i'm going to pass my students
arraylist
after creating your adapter you can say
students spinner dot set adapter
and you can pass your student adapter
let's run our application and let's see
what a spinner looks like
you can see the spinner above in here
it's going to generate a drop down menu
if i click on this triangle in here
you can see the name of the students
that i have passed into my arraylist
once again these items can be also
clickable for example if i
click on one of these we can take some
action
let's quickly see that how can we create
an onclicklistener for each one of these
items
so after setting the adapter down in
here
i'm going to say student spinner dot set
on item selected listener this is
different from the listener that we have
used for the list view for the list view
we have used set on item click listener
but it's not going to work in here
instead we are going to use this set on
item selected listener
let's pass our interface let's say new
on item select listener adapter view dot
on item selected listener
and this interface is going to generate
two methods
on item selected and on nothing selected
the names are descriptive on nothing
selected means that if you do not select
anything inside your spinner you are not
going to work with this method and we
are not going to write any logic in here
instead inside this on item selected we
are going to show a toast message
once again you can see that we have this
position in here in which we can use it
in order to for example get the name of
that student first of all like before we
need the context because we are inside
another interface we are going to pass
mainactivity.this
that for the text i'm going to say
students.get
and as the index i'm going to pass
position
let's say plus selected
let's run the application and let's see
if everything is going to work
so in here you can see that even though
i never clicked on any item i see the
toast message and that's because we have
used this set on item selected listener
once again this is different from the on
item click listener i don't know why but
we cannot use an item click listener for
the spinner if you try to use that you
will get an exception
instead the other option that you have
is this set on item selected listener
let's see if we can show the toast
message if we select another item for
example sarah you can see the tools
message down in here
this is one way of showing data inside
your spinner it's useful for when you do
not know what data you are going to show
for example
if you are going to retrieve the data
from a web server or a database to be
precise in case your data is dynamic but
in case you know the data previously in
case your data is aesthetic
you can use another way let's quickly
see that
so before that i'm going to open this
project pane
inside my app folder inside this
resources folder
we have this values folder in here
in which inside that we have this
strings.xml file
we can create a string area inside this
xml file and later on we can pass it
into our spinner
basically this strings file is going to
be the place that we put all of the
static strings for example right now you
can see that we have this app name
string
in which we have used it inside our
manifest file let's quickly see that
inside this
androidmanifest.xml file
we have this label attribute if we click
on the label you can see that it's
addressing the string file
and this is the name of our string from
strings.xml file
we know for sure that the name of our
application is not going to change for
example it's not dependent on some
string from our database or the web
server
so we have passed it in here
in the next video we will talk about the
usages of this
strings.xml file and also for that
matter other xml files in our
application
but for now let's create a string array
statically in here and let's pass it to
our spinner
so inside this strings.xml file you can
create two different kind of items you
can create a string
or alternatively you can create a string
array the way to do that is like this
you can say a string array
you need to name your array for example
in here i'm going to say students
after that inside this opening and
closing tag i can create different items
let's say item
and inside these item tags i can provide
a value for example i can say mesa
you can copy and paste this item as many
times that you want
once again don't worry if you don't
understand this strings.xml file we will
talk about it in the next video
now that we have created this string
array we can pass it to our spinner item
inside our activity main.xml file
when we have created our spinner
we have an attribute called entries
this attribute in here
you can see that we have this at array
students this is the address of our
string array in our strings.xml file
let's pass that
and as soon as i pass that you can see
that we have some sample data in our
spinner so now that i have passed the
data to our spinner aesthetically i
don't need to pass them in my java file
dynamically
for that i can comment all of these
lines of code for example from here to
top in here
but right now we are getting an error
inside this on item selected method and
that's because we no longer have this
student's array
if you want to show the name of the
student when you select some item
instead of using the students area list
you can use another way
let's delete this line of code and let's
create a new toast message for the text
this time i'm going to say student
spinner
dot let's say get selected item you can
see that this method is going to return
an object
let's say get selected item after that
we can say dot to string
this to a string is just another level
of conversion in order to convert the
object that has been returned to a
string
after that let's say plus selected
once again before running the
application let's review what we have
done
first of all we have created this string
array
after that we have passed it to our
spinner aesthetically
and after that inside our java file we
have created this set on item selected
listener
inside the on item selected method we
have created this toast message
and we are getting the value of every
item by using a student's spinner dot
get selected item method let's run the
application and let's see if we have the
same behavior
you can see that we have some data in
our spinner
if i select brad for example you can see
the toast message brad selected
it seems like our spinner is working
fine
so far we have talked about different
layout files for example this activity
main.xml which is a layout file
in the next video we are going to talk
about other kind of xml files for
example this strings.xml or this
androidmanifest.xml
also we have other kind of xml files in
the next video we are going to talk
about them
ok see you in the next video
so far we have talked about different
layout files in our application placed
inside this resources folder inside the
layout folder for example we have talked
about this
activitymain.xml file
in which we have defined the looks of
our layout file for our main activity
but in android there are a lot of other
xml files for example at the end of the
previous video we have take a look at
the strings.xml file
let's close this and let's talk a bit
about that
strings.xml file
as i said it's placed inside this
resources folder inside the values
folder
you can see this strings.xml file
if you remember i said that this is the
place that you will put all of the
aesthetic strings of your application
let's quickly see what i mean by that
so for example inside my layout file if
i define a text view
we have a text view in here let's give
it an id
let's say txt hello
let's go to our java file and let's
initialize this text view
let's say private text view
[Music]
let's name it txt hello
and down in here inside uncreate let's
quickly initialize this text view
let's see what would happen if we
set the text of this txt hello manually
for example in here if we say txt hello
dot set text
and if we pass hello
you can see that we are getting some
highlights in here
and the highlight says that this string
cannot be translated use android
resources instead if you want you can
have some more information about this
warning as the suggestion says you can
press ctrl f1
and you can see a whole dialogue about
this warning basically this in here
means that this text is going to be the
same in all of the languages for example
if you have an application that has some
users around the world
this text is going to be the same in all
of the devices regardless of the user's
language
as the warning says you can define this
text inside your strings.xml file
let's quickly see how we can use this
strings.xml file in order to localize
our application
so in here i'm going to define another
string the way to do that is to open a
tag and say string
after that we need to name our string
for example in here i'm going to simply
say hello
and for the value of this string i'm
going to say hello
now i can pass this string to my text
view inside my java file instead of hard
coding this text i can say get a string
this get a string method like this find
view by id is an inner method inside
every activity
we can use that because we are extending
this appcompat activity
so inside these parenthesis we can
address our a string file for example i
can say r dot string
dot let's say hello
right now the result is going to be
exactly as before for example we are
just going to show hello to the user
but the option that we have in here is
to create another strings.xml file
inside our values folder
for example in here i can right click on
my values folder
i can say new value resource file
i need to name this new xml file exactly
strings let's say strings
the name is important in here it should
be exactly the same
and in here you have a few options we
will talk about few of them in here
but the one that we are interested in
here is this local
let's select that
and let's add it to these chosen
qualifiers so basically this locale is
going to be useful for when you want to
expose your application to different
languages
for example if you know that you have
some users from germany you can
translate your application this way for
those users as well
let's quickly see that if we can see
german in here
you can see that we have this de-german
the stands for deutsche in the right
hand side we can select a specific
region we know that there are multiple
countries that spoke german
let's select germany and let's press ok
if you take a look at your values folder
you can see that now you have this
strings folder in which inside that you
have two strings.xml file the names are
exactly the same but the second one is
for the german language users
right now this strings.xml file for
german users is empty if you want you
can define some strings in here for
example i'm going to define my hello
text in here as well
let's say a string
let's name it hello
it's very important that this name would
be exactly the same name that you have
passed inside the other strings.xml file
if you remember in here we have this a
string called hello
we are going to name it in here hello as
well
now let's pass some value for this
string
for example the german translation of
hello is hello i believe
so inside this strings.xml file for the
german users we have a string called
hello but the value in here is different
from the one that we had inside the
default strings.xml now that we have
created two strings.xml file
because inside our main activity we are
using this get a string method and we
are addressing our hello
if some german language user uses our
application
the value of this text view would be
different in different languages let's
quickly run our application and let's
see the difference
right now the language of this device is
english and because of that we are
seeing this hello text
but if we change the language of this
device to let's say german we should see
holdo
let's close this application and let's
quickly change the language of this
device and let's see if we can see the
difference
so we can go to the settings
down in here inside the systems i
believe
or system
language and input
let's go to languages
and let's add another language
let's search for german
or its equivalent deutsch
we need to select a region let's select
deutschland
and also we need to make this storage as
the default language of this phone so
let's move this to above this english
and now you can see that the language of
this phone has changed to deutsch
if we run our application once again we
should see the difference
this time you can see that we are seeing
hello instead of hello
without changing a line of code we now
have an application that looks different
in different languages
so this strings.xml file is extremely
useful for localization purposes
if you want you can add another string
file for example once again on our
values folder
we can right click we can say new value
resource file once again we can name it
strings
and once again we can select this locale
and if you want you can select another
language and you can do the same process
after creating your application if you
want to translate your application for
another language
you can pass this strings.xml file to
maybe a translator
and ask him or her to change some of the
values
for your string files
as simple as that you can localize your
application for different languages
you can see that we also have an error
in here this error is not important
basically it says that
you do not have an equivalent string
for this app name you can also change
the app name in different languages as
well but we are not going to do that in
this application
okay let's close all of these and let's
talk about another kind of xml file in
android applications
the other xml file that i'm going to
talk about is this colors.xml file once
again it's placed inside this values
folder let's take a look at that
you can see that right now we have three
colors in here
like a strings this is going to be the
place that we pass all of our static
colors
if we want we can define another color
in here for that we can come between
this resources tag and we can say color
we can name our color for example let's
say blue
and for the value we need to pass a
hexadecimal value we can get that value
by searching for html color picker let's
quickly do that
for example in here if you want a blue
color
a lighter blue maybe
we can copy the hexadecimal value from
here
and we can paste it in our project
you can see that at the left pane in
here we have this blue color
now that we have this blue color we can
use it in different places of our
application for example inside our
activity main.xml file
when we have defined this text view we
can change its color
we can say color or to be precise text
color
and we can address our color for example
i can say add color slash blue
this add color is referencing our
colors.xml file this one in here
you can see that the color of our text
has been changed to this light blue
instead of searching for different
colors on the internet you can also
define them another way for example you
can copy this color accent color
let's copy that
let's paste it in here and
let's define a white color
but for the value of this white color i
can click on this square
and i can select a white color for
example let's select this white
and as you can see now we have a white
color without searching the internet we
can get the hexadecimal values for
different colors
okay there is not much more to these
colors colors.xml file i just wanted to
show you how you can define new colors
let's talk about the other xml file in
android applications which is this
styles.xml but before that let's close
these two
and let's open this slides.xml once
again it lives inside our values folder
so basically this styles.xml file is the
place that we define the theme of our
application
right now we have one style in here
later on we will see that where we have
used this
the name of this style is app theme
but if we want we can overwrite this for
example we can change the value of some
of these colors if you want
or we can change other attributes
you can also define multiple styles for
example let's copy this holder style
and let's paste it down in here we need
to name our style differently for
example let's say a customized app team
and let's override the previous style
for example we have this parent
attribute in here which you can guess
it's implementing all of the features of
this exact theme in here if you want
first of all you can change this parent
for example let's take a look at the
other ones
let's say light dot
we have this no action bar in which we
are going to use in future videos we
have these dialogues
i'm not going to change the parent in
here instead if you want you can change
some of the values of this color
so in different part of our application
we may use this color primary for
different texts
the value of this color primary is right
now
this value in here add color slash color
primary
if you want you can change that for
example you can say blue the color that
we just created you can see that now the
color primary in these two styles is
different
for the first one is this dark green and
for the second one is this light blue
now that you have defined this
customized app theme style you can pass
it to let's say different activities in
your application it means that different
activities in your application different
pages in your application
can have different styles
for example one of them may have some
toolbar some of them may not have that
toolbar if you use another parent later
on we will see that how we can do that
also we will talk about activities later
on in the course don't worry about
activities if you don't understand them
yet so this styles.xml file is the place
that you define different styles for
your application
we will be coming back to this
slides.xml file later on in the course
specifically when we talk about material
design but for now let's move on from
this part i believe you grasped the
general idea
the other xml file that i'm going to
talk about is this manifest file this
androidmanifest.xml file i believe this
is the most important xml file in every
android application
basically this is where you defined the
general attributes the general features
of your application
you can see that we have this manifest
tag
inside that we have this application tag
we have seen this icon and round icon
previously
basically these are helpful for when you
want to define different icons for your
application
we also have this label which is
basically the name of your application
that is going to be shown to the user
you also have a general theme for your
application which as you can see is
addressing the style
the app theme style if you want you can
pass your customized app theme
it will overwrite all of the activities
in your application but in here i'm not
going to do that
right now inside the application tag you
have one activity which is basically our
main activity
so basically every activity needs to be
declared inside the manifest file inside
this application tag as well
this activity in here has been added
automatically because when we have
created our application we have selected
the empty activity template
but if we don't select that template and
one of the things that we need to do is
to come inside this manifest file and
declare our activity
inside this activity tag you have this
intent filter tag don't worry about that
yet we will talk about that later on in
the course i believe in the broadcast
receiver section of the course but
probably you can guess the usage of this
intent filter from this launcher and
main it means that this main activity is
the launcher activity when we run our
application don't worry about all of
these yet these are just some basic
properties some basic features of our
application
so beside activities you need to define
three other elements in the manifest
file as well
so in every android application we have
four main components
activities content providers broadcast
receivers and services we will talk
about all of them later on in the course
but uh these are the four main component
of every android application all of them
needs to be declared inside the manifest
file so as you can see this manifest
file is very important it contains all
of the important features of your
application we will be coming back to
this manifest file a lot during the
course so don't worry if you don't
understand all of these and new stuff
that we are seeing in here
okay the next xml file that i'm going to
talk about is menus
let's quickly see them as well
so in your project pane inside the
resources folder
you can create another directory for
different menus by default you do not
have that directory like we did have for
different values and layout files we
need to create that directory we can
right click on our resource folder we
can say new directory
it's very important to name this
directory menu
and after that you can see that we have
this menu folder in here
you can right click on that and you can
say new menu resource file
this way you can create a menu.xml file
for example let's name this menu file
main menu
let's create this file and let's see
what does it look like
let's switch to text view in here you
can see that we have this menu tag
basically menus are useful for when you
want to create some sort of menu in your
application and the way to do that is to
come inside this menu tag
and create different items i can say
item
you can define multiple attributes for
your item but the one that is mandatory
and you have to create that is this
title you can say android column title
and you can pass a title for your menu
for example we can say settings in here
you can see that some menu has been
created in here later on we will pass
this menu to for example our main
activity to have some sort of menu in
our main activity
the other attributes that i have in here
is id for example i can say
settings menu
we also can have an icon for our menu
item
but i believe we do not have any icon in
our project yet
before passing an icon let's quickly
create some icons in our driver folder
we have seen how we can create different
icons we can right click on our driver
folder by saying new image asset
we can create icons
in the icon type i'm going to say action
bar and tab icons
for example inside this clip art let's
search for settings icon
you can see that we have one icon in
here let's add that
let's change the name to ic settings
and let's change the color to black
let's add another icon in our driver
folder
new image asset like before
let's name this one iclr
let's search for lr
the color is fine let's just create this
icon
now that we have these two icons we can
pass them in our menu file for example
in this item i can say icon
[Music]
let's pass our settings icon ic settings
right now we cannot see the icon of this
setting in here
but if you want to see that you can
define another attribute that's called
show as action
so we have some values for this
transaction attributes
if we say always
it means that we always want our menu
items in the toolbar
you can see that we have other options
for example we have this if room it
means that place them in the toolbar if
there is room for this menu item
we have also this never it means that
always show the menu items like this and
never show them in the toolbar
let's change the value for now to always
and let's create another item in here
so i can say item like before the title
is mandatory
and also we are getting a warning for
the previous items title once again it
says that you need to define the title
in your strings.xml file
like before this is for the localization
purposes and the best practice is to
create this settings title in your
strings.xml file
in your real world applications make
sure to do that but in here for the sake
of simplicity i'm not going to do that
i'm going to cope with this warning
so let's pass a title in here i'm going
to say alarm
let's give it an id let's say alarm menu
after that let's give it an icon
[Music]
let's say i see alarm
let's set the show as action attribute
for this one to if row
you can create as many items as you want
but i think for this simple menu item
these two would be fine
okay now that we have created this menu
file let's see how we can pass this to
for example our main activity
let's close this file once again it was
placed inside our resources folder
inside the menu directory that we just
created
in order to show this menu in your main
activity you need to open the
mainactivity.java file
and you need to overwrite another method
in here
so because we are extending the
appcompat activity inside this main
activity we have some methods that we
can override one of these methods is
this oncreate method
if you come outside of this uncreate
method and press control plus all you
can see the list of all of the available
methods you can see that there are a lot
of them
the one that we need in here is called
on create options menu
if you type on create options menu you
can see this method in here let's select
that
and in here we have this method
first of all i'm going to delete this
statement from here this return super
dot on create options menu
and i'm going to create or inflate my
menu for that i can say menu inflator
this class in here
let's name it inflator is equal to
get menu inflator
this get menu inflator is like this fine
view by id method it's an inner class in
every activity
so basically with the help of this
inflator we are going to inflate or
create our menu
after accessing to our inflator we can
say inflator dot inflate
for this inflate method first of all we
need to address the menu file that we
just created
for that we can say r dot menu dot
main menu the menu that we just created
the second argument is the menu that is
being passed to this method
let's pass that
you can see that the return type of this
method is a boolean this boolean is
indicating that if we have successfully
inflated our menu
by this point we have inflated our menu
and after that we can return true
this is all of the logic that we need in
order to inflate or create our menu in
our main activity let's run the
application and let's see if we can see
our menu in our application
you can see that in our activity we have
these two items this settings icon and
this alarm icon
we can also set an unclick listener for
each one of these menu items
let's quickly see how we can do that so
we need to overwrite another method
outside of this uncreate options menu
method
if we press ctrl
o and if we search for on options item
selected
this method in here if we select that
we can override that this time i'm going
to keep this super statement we will
talk but i'm going to keep that
as you can see as the input of this
method we are getting a menu item
this is the item that user is going to
click on and we can use it for example
to create a switch statement let's
create our switch statement
so our switch statement is going to work
on the item
dot get item id
if you remember in our menu file for
different menu items we have set
different ids
let's quickly see that
in our mainmenu.xml file
we have set id for each one of these
items
and in here we are going to act upon
those ids
let's create our switch statement
let's say in case it's
r dot id dot
settings menu
we are going to show a toast message
let's say toast
for the text let's say settings clicked
or settings selected
after showing the toast message in here
instead of adding a break for the switch
statement for this specific case
we can return something once again you
can see that the return type of this
method is a boolean as well
this boolean indicates that if we have
acted according to this item
successfully or not
in here after showing the toast message
we are going to return true
so let's say return true
and let's create other cases
for example in case it's r dot id dot
alarm menu once again we are going to
show another toast message
let's say alarm selected
in here i'm showing a toast message but
in a real world application you may want
to navigate the user to some other part
of your application
but more on that later on when we know
about different activities and fragment
okay after showing the toast message
let's return true once again
[Music]
and also let's create a default case
in the default case i am going to return
this super statement
because i'm not interested in other
items beside these two so do whatever
you are doing inside the parent class so
basically i can cut this super statement
from here and i can return it in the
default case
before we run our application let's
review what we are doing in here
as the input of this on options item
selected method we are getting a menu
item
we can use this item id in order to
create a switch statement
in case the id is the id of our settings
menu item we are showing this first
message settings selected
in case it's alarm menu item id we are
showing another toast message but in the
default case in case if it's a another
item beside these two
we are passing the job to the parent
class
let's run the application and let's see
if we have set the listener successfully
so for example if we click on this
settings icon you can see that settings
selected
if we click on this alarm we can see
alarm selected
it seems like we have done a good job
inside this on options item selected
method
okay i think that's enough for this
video in the next video we are going to
continue our talk about other kind of
xml files available in android
see you in the next video
[Music]
let's continue our talk about different
xml files in android in previous videos
we take a look at different xml files
for example drawable files layout files
some files inside our mipmap folder we
have seen strings and colors and styles
beside this we take a look at menus and
also our manifest file let's see what
else do we have in here right now our
main activity has only one layout file
this
activitymain.xml but if you want you can
create more layout files for this
activity for example right now this
layout is for the portrait mode if you
want you can create another layout file
for the let's say landscape mode if you
don't know what the portrait and
landscape modes are let me quickly show
that so right now this is called the
portrait mode if we change the rotation
of our device and this is going to be
the landscape i think i need to activate
the rotation of this device let's go to
the notification center and from here i
believe this is the option this auto
rotate we need to activate that
and now if we rotate our device you can
see that now we have a different look
for our application sometimes this might
work but if you have a complex layout
fight that you want to show it
differently in different rotations you
need to create two separate files for
each one of these rotations one for the
portrait mode and one for the landscape
mode let's quickly see that how we can
create another layout file for this main
activity
so inside my layout folder on the layout
folder i can right click by selecting
new layout resource file i can create a
layout file or alternatively
inside this activity main.xml file from
here if you click on this icon you can
see that we have this portrait selected
right now if you want you can create a
landscape variation for the layout of
your main activity but before i do that
i'm going to add another text and also
i'm going to add some constraints to
this layout file
so i'm going to move this new text view
to below my hello world text let's
quickly add some constraints
as i mentioned before if your items are
too close to each other you can always
select both elements
and you can use the right click menu by
going to constraint
and add constraint from here okay but
i'm not going to do that instead i'm
going to add some margins up let's say
100. so for this simple application this
is going to be the look of my
application in the portrait view the two
text views are placed after each other
vertically but in the landscape mode i'm
going to put the two texts beside each
other let's quickly create a variation
for our landscape mode by selecting this
i create landscape variation you can see
that inside our layout file now we have
two files inside the activity main
folder we have this
activitymain.xml which is for the
portrait mode and the other one which is
for the landscape mode and now if you
want we can change this landscape for
example
i'm going to change the constraint of
this textview
let's delete all of the previous
constraints
i'm also going to delete the constraint
of this textview the left constraint
let's place this one in here and let's
add some constraint
also another point in here that you may
find useful is that if you want to
center your elements for example
horizontally you can select the two
items for example these two by right
clicking on the item and by going to
this center
and selecting horizontally
you can center your items horizontally
so once again this is the view for the
landscape mode the layout for the
landscape mode and this is going to be
the layout for the portrait mode now if
i run my application i should see the
difference you can see that in the
landscape mode the two texts are beside
each other but if you change the
rotation to portrait mode the two texts
are vertically after each other so this
way by coming to this icon in here and
selecting create landscape variation you
can create another layout file for your
main activity but this is not the only
option you can also create
a night version in case if you want to
activate a night theme for your
application i'm not going to do that
let's quickly see how we can create that
so in here i can go to this create other
and from here i have all sorts of
options for example if we want to create
a night mode for our activity we can
select this night mode we can pass it to
this qualifiers and for the night mode
let's say knight
let's create this one
and let's take a look at our project
name now inside this activity main
folder you can see that we have three
activity main.xml files the middle one
is for the night view if you want you
can change that for example you can
change some colors but i'm not going to
do that in here i'm just going to ignore
this layout file for the night view
let's see what other layouts we can
create for our activity so once again i
can go to this icon in here by saying
create other you can see that we have
all sort of options for example in here
we have this version
in which we can create different layout
files for different versions of the
android on the user's device let's add
this to these chosen qualifiers and in
here we can put a number for example if
we want our application to look
different in api level 21 we can put 21
in here and we can create a layout file
let's take a look at our layout folder
inside activity main folder now we have
this activity main.xml which is a
specific for the version 21 of the api
this way you can also create other
layout points and you can change them if
you want before i finish off this video
i'm going to talk about another kind of
xml files in android let's right click
on our layout file and let's select new
layout resource file and let's see what
an include is so for the file name of
this xml file i'm going to say trademark
and also i'm going to change the root
element to let's say relative layout
let's select okay
and let's switch to textview inside this
textview you can see that we have this
relative layout so basically you use
include whenever you want to reuse some
layout file for example now i have
created this trademark.xml file in which
i'm going to put an image view and a
text view inside that after creating
this layout file i can reuse this
trademark.xml
in order to show this trademark in
multiple activities of my application so
the use of include tag is to reuse your
layout files first of all let's design
this trademark.xml
in here i'm going to say text view or
before that let's define an image view
let's say 15 dp
for the bits and height
let's give it an id
and for the placeholder i'm not going to
import any image into my project instead
i'm going to use this ic launcher
background which exists in our driver
folder let's also define a text view in
here
wrap content and wrap content for the
text i'm going to say developed by mesa
[Music]
after that let's move this text view to
the right of our image view
let's say to write of
logo
let's add some margin left maybe 10 db
let's style this text a little bit
let's say italic and volt
let's also change the size of this text
view
right now the width and height of this
relative layout this whole parent is
match parent in here i'm going to change
that i'm going to change both of these
to wrap content we will see why when we
use this layout file
and also i'm going to add another
attribute for both of these elements
let's center them vertically
center vertical for both of them let's
say true it will place them at the
center vertically
so this is our simple layout file in
here we are showing a text view and also
an image view if we want to show this
layout file in multiple places in our
application we can use the include tag
include tag is very useful for when you
have a complex layout file and you don't
want to write the exact same file twice
let's switch to our activity main.xml
file and let's see how we can use that
trademark so down in here after the text
view
i'm going to say include
and i can add a layout attribute and i
need to fast the address of my layout
file in this case it's at layout slash
trademark as simple as that we can
include another xml file inside this
layout file if you want we can also
constrain this layout file you can see
that i can select this whole layout file
but right now if i try to constraint my
layout file you can see that it won't
work
you can see that it will be placed once
again at the top of my screen and that's
because we need to overwrite the width
and height of this layout right the way
to do that is to come inside this
include tag and in here for my whole
layout file i need to define my layout
bits and height once again so for
example for the layout bits i'm going to
say wrap content for the height as well
i'm going to say wrap content this way
you can see that now we can constraint
our layout while we just need to
overwrite the width and height of our
layout file let's also add two more
constraints
i can use this trademark.xml file as
many times as i want in different parts
of my application that can be useful
sometimes also where you are using
include tag you may want another tag
let's quickly see that so instead of
this relative layout sometimes you may
see merge
this tag in here so basically what this
merge is doing is that it's avoiding
redundancy let's talk about what i mean
by that so right now these two elements
have no idea about their parents they do
not know where they are going to be used
inside a relative layout a linear layout
or a constraint layout for that reason
because they don't know about their
parent you can see that our layout does
not look very beautiful in here but if
you know for sure that where you are
going to use this layout file for
example if you are going to use this
layout file inside a linear layout you
do not need to write the linear layout
once again you can use this merge stack
in order to avoid redundancy at the time
of rendering your layout file this mesh
tag will be ignored and these two
elements will be placed inside the
parent that they are going to be used
sometimes when you know for sure that
where you are going to use in your
layout file using this merge stack can
improve the performance when rendering
your layout file but in here i'm just
going to change this to a relative
layout okay i think that's enough
talking about different xml files in
android we have others as well we will
take a look at them later on in the
course but for now i think it's enough
in the next video we are going to talk
about the material design library see
you in the next video
in creating android applications
designing is an important aspect and
creating a beautiful layout will impact
the number of downloads for your
application on the play store and also
it will impact the user's feedback but
sometimes designing can be challenging
especially if you are like me if you are
more interested in the code side of the
application but luckily we have material
design as a guideline for our designing
despite being a guideline material
design also introduces some new
components that we can use in our
application let's check the material
design website and let's see how we can
use that in our projects the website for
material design is material.io
if you go to this develop tab in here
you can see that beside android
applications you can also use material
design for ios app development you can
use it for web development and also you
can use it with hybrid development with
flutter let's go to the android page
as i said material design consists of
two things first of all it's a guideline
for designing your applications also
beside being a guideline you have some
components that you can use in your
application we will take a look at those
components in a minute but before that
if you take a look at this theming in
here for example if you want to check
the guidelines for typography theming
you can click on this link and after
that if you take a look at this material
design guideline for typography
you will see some guidelines basically
these guidelines are helpful for when
you want to design and create a
beautiful application
and basically these are some to do's and
not to do
in order to
follow when you are designing different
applications so make sure to check this
web page and their guidelines in here we
are not going to talk about guidelines
instead we are going to take a look at
the components if you go to this
components link you will see that we
have a lot of components we are familiar
with some of these components for
example we have seen different buttons
and checkboxes but some of them are new
don't worry about that later on we will
see a lot of these in the course but
let's take a look at a few components
that we already know for example let's
check these buttons
down in here in this image you can see
that we have four different kind of
material buttons these are somehow
different from the buttons that we have
used already in our applications
basically the main difference is in the
styling of different buttons similar to
button we have all sort of other
components for example we have
checkboxes for some of these components
we have also some documentations and
guidelines for designing them for
example if you want to check the
guidelines for designing a checkbox you
can click on that link
and in here you can see some guidelines
so make sure to check that if you need
but let's see how we can use these
components in our applications before
that i'm just going to say that in this
video we are not going to work with all
of these components during the course we
will be coming back to this webpage and
a lot of these components but for now
first of all we are going to start with
material buttons we will also take a
look at the floating action button this
one in here we will also take a look at
the material card and things like snack
bars later on in the course we will take
a look at the top app bars bottom app
bars and also things like tab layouts
and a lot more okay instead of talking
let's implement these material buttons
in our application in order to use
material design components in your
application you need to add a dependency
in your application we haven't used any
extra dependencies in our applications
yet but let's see how we can do that if
you remember i said that gradle will
combine all of the layout files all of
the java files all of the static
resources in our application and beside
all of those gradle we'll also use the
third-party libraries that we use in our
application one of those libraries that
we are going to use in here and later on
gradle is going to handle combining it
in our application is this material
design so we need to add this material
design library in our project with the
help of gradle in order to add the
material design library you can go to
this develop tab
after that you can select this android
and inside this documentation you can go
to this getting started and from there
you can find the dependency that you
need in this page you can see a
step-by-step guide for adding the
library the material design library into
your project make sure to read this page
if you need but basically what they are
saying is that first of all make sure
that you are using google repositories
in your project let's see where that is
in android studio in android studio
inside this gradle script inside this
build.gradle this project module you
need to add the google repository google
repositories has been added by default
into our project inside this all
projects but if you don't see this
google in here make sure to add that the
next step after adding the google
repository is to add the material design
dependency you can copy this dependency
form here and you can add it to your
project let's copy that this time we
need to go to this build.gradle module
app this one in here but before that
let's close this one and let's also
minimize all these extra panes we need
to add that dependency inside these
dependencies in here for example you can
add that dependency before all the other
dependencies let's paste that in here
but we also need to change this line
because right now we have this version
tag in here and this is not the version
it's better to always check the internet
for the latest version of material
design you can also use the help of
android studio right now i'm getting a
highlight if i hover over this highlight
you can see that the latest version
available is 1.1.0
so instead of this version i'm going to
say 1.1.0
after adding this dependency you need to
click on this sync now and after that
gradle will download some files to the
specific material design library files
from the internet and it will add the
library to your project so let's click
on this sync now before that make sure
that you have an internet connection it
was somehow fast and now we can use
material design components in our
project also inside these dependencies
you can see that
by default we have other dependencies as
well for example we have this constraint
layout we have these dependencies for
testing and also we have this app compat
dependencies which help backward
compatibility but more on them later on
okay now that we have added this
material dependency let's see how we can
use them but before using them i'm going
to add a button in my layout file let's
quickly see that let's also enable this
preview and before everything let's
delete this text view so in here i'm
going to save button let's say wrap
content and wrap content and let's
define the text let's say say hello
let's also change this constraint layout
to a relative layout
and let's center our button you can see
that we are seeing the previous slide
for our button now let's implement
material theme and let's see how that
changes the style of our button so for
that i'm going to open my project main
if you remember inside the resources
folder inside the values folder we have
this styles.xml let's open that right
now we have this app theme style in
which its parent is this theme that we
are seeing in here if we want to
implement material theme we can change
these parents let's quickly do that
and the theme in here is going to be
theme.materialcomponents
we also have another theme called
theme.materialcomponents.light
this one in here we will take a look at
that in a minute but in here i'm not
going to customize this theme dot
material components so for that i'm
going to delete all these three items
i'm going to use all of the values from
inside this material components theme so
let's delete them we just change the
parent theme of this app team but right
now if we switch to our
activitymain.xml file you can see that
we are getting this dark theme somehow
we also changed the style of our button
this is good for a night theme but in
here i'm going to change the parent's
theme to a light theme so that we can
see better so let's select this light in
here and if we switch back to our
activity main.xml file we can see that
we are seeing this beautiful light theme
our button is now styled we have some
round corners the font is somehow
different and also the spacing between
the letters is different we didn't
change anything for our button element
but because we are using the material
theme as the parent theme of our
application all of these styles have
been applied automatically we can also
customize this button for example we can
change the background color of this
button but before that let's quickly add
a color to our color resources inside
colors.xml i'm going to add a new color
let's copy this one
let's paste it and let's change the name
to let's say orange for the value i'm
going to select this orange color
now in our activity main.xml file if you
want to change the background color of
this button to the orange
we can say background tint this one in
here and we can address our orange color
we can also change the text color of
this button but i don't think that's
necessary i just wanted to show you that
you can customize your buttons let's
delete this color as you saw on the
material design website we have some
styles for our button
let's see other styles as well for
example in here i can say style
let's search for material button
you can see that we have this on
elevated button style let's quickly see
that this is basically this style that
we are currently using it's the default
case let's remove that and let's see
others we have this button slide we have
this outline button if you take a look
at that you can see that the style of
your button is changed to some outline
button sometimes this might be useful we
also have a text button let's quickly
see that
and this is the one material components
button
button it will change our button to a
text button sometimes you may want to
use this i'm going to stay with the
default case
so i'm going to delete this holder style
attribute so you can see that using
material design is very easy basically
we just added the material dependency
into our project inside this like
build.gradle module app after that
inside the slides we change the parent
to this theme dot material components
theme and after that we can use all of
the elements from inside the material
design library if you add another
element into your layout file for
example a checkbox by default
the checkbox from the material design
library will be used okay let's move on
from this part and let's talk about some
of the components that we don't have in
our applications if we don't use the
material design library the first of
those components that i'm going to talk
about in here is called floating action
button let's delete this button and
let's see that floating action button so
in here i can say floating action button
we can see that we have two option we
have this floating action button and we
have this extended floating action
button
let's use the first one for the bits and
height i'm going to say wrap content and
as soon as i do that you can see that we
have this beautiful button in here this
floating action button is going to be
floating on our layout file even if for
example we scroll the page if you want
you can change the location of this
button for example you can move it to
down below in here for that i can use
two attributes that we haven't seen so
far for example i can say alloying
parent bottom and i can set it to true
you can see that as soon as i do that
its location will be changed to the
bottom of our screen we can also use
another attribute called align parent
end in order to move it to the right of
our screen let's say true and now you
can see the difference let's also add
some margins
let's say margin in here we have two
options we can add this margin right
or alternatively we can use this margin
end if i use this margin right in here i
will get a warning let's quickly use
that and let's see the warning for
example in here i'm going to say 20dp
you can see the highlight in here if you
take a look at this it says that it's
better to use margin end the reason for
this is because some of the languages
starts from right so for example if the
language of your user is arabic in that
case this floating action button will be
placed at the left of the screen and if
you add a margin right it's going to put
the floating action button to outside of
the screen for that reason it's better
to use a margin end
so let's say margin end
and let's pass 20dp you can see that we
are getting the same result in here we
also need to add a margin button
let's say margin button
and let's pass 20dp you can also add an
icon for your forwarding action button
as well let's quickly add an icon into
our driver folder and let's add it for
our floating action button
let's say new image asset on our driver
folder
and let's select action bar and tab
icons and let's select a plus sign in
here
let's search for add and let's add this
one
for the name let's say i see add
and also let's change the color i'm not
sure that if this is a white color for
that i'm going to use this costume color
and i'm going to use white right now the
selector is on white so let's say choose
and let's create our icon
and now you can add the icon for your
floating action button but for some
reason i cannot use the source attribute
which is the attribute to pass an icon
for your floating action button i think
because i've added this dependency in my
project i need to restart my android
studio or the other option is to rebuild
my project or the better option is to go
to this file and invalidate your cache
and restart android studio let's select
that
let's say invalidate and restart
now that i have invalidated my cache i
can use the source attribute so inside
this floating action button tag i can
say source
this one android source and i can pass
my ic add icon you can see that as soon
as i do that this icon will be added to
my floating action button if you want
you can also change the color of this
floating action button for example let's
change it to the orange color that we
have defined few minutes ago for that i
can say background change this one in
here
and i can pass color orange you can see
that the color will be changed to orange
also you can see that we have some sort
of border for this floating action
button
if you want you can also change that the
way to do that is like this you can say
app column background tint and this way
you can pass your new color for example
if you want to pass a white color
first of all you can create that color
inside your color resources and after
that pass that or alternatively you can
pass the hexadecimal value of that color
directly in here for example i know that
hashtag fff is for the white color so if
i pass that you can see that we have a
white color in here and also you can see
that the border of this floating action
button
is now white so this android column
background tint is for the background
color of your floating action button but
this app column background thing is for
the border of your floating action
button you can also define another color
in here let's quickly see that you can
see refill color this one in here app
column refill color and pass a color for
example once again i'm going to pass
white
this repel color is the color of the
floating action button when you click on
it let's run this application and let's
see that you can see that we have this
beautiful floating action button at the
bottom of our screen
and if we click on that you can see some
color and that white color is this repel
color beside that you may also have
noticed that the color of this top app
bar has changed as well this is because
we are using material component theme in
our application later on we will see
that we have a beautiful toolbar when we
work with material design we will
implement that toolbar in our
applications later on but for now let's
talk more about this floating action
button you can also set an unclick
listener for this button if you want as
well but for that we need to have access
to this floating action button inside
our mainactivity.java file so for
example like before i can say private
floating action button this one that
comes from
material.floatingactionbuttonpackage
let's name it fab
after that we need to instantiate it
inside our uncreate method let's say fab
is equal to find view by id
but before that we need to give an id to
our floating action button i don't think
we did that in here let's say id let's
just name it fab
let's say r dot id dot fav
after that you can say fab dot
set on click listener this one in here
and we can pass our listener
for example let's show a toast message
let's say fab clicked
let's run the application and let's see
if we see the toast message
you can see that we are seeing the those
message it seems to be perfect there are
also other ways of using these floating
action buttons for example one way is to
use a combination of floating action
button and app or navigation in that
case we will see that we can implement a
beautiful style and a beautiful design
for our application but more on that
later on when we talk about bottom up
board navigations okay i think that's
enough for this video in the next video
we will talk about two more components
in material design library we will talk
about snack bars and also card views see
you in the next video
in this video we are going to talk about
two more material components
the first of those components is snack
bar before we start implementing
snackboard let's see what does it look
like
so if you go to material.io
in this component
in this listing here you will see a
snack bar
let's see that
this is what a snack bar looks like
it's a lot like a toast message but the
style is a little bit different and also
inside the snack bar you can have a
button that will do some action besides
that you can make your snack bars to be
indefinite it means that they won't be
dismissed until the user clicks on this
action also you can style your snack bar
as well for example you can change the
color of this text and also the color of
this action button as we will see later
on in the course snack bars are
extremely useful when you are developing
android applications in order to use the
snack bars first of all you need to add
the material design library into your
project so let's go to this develop tab
in this android section
[Music]
let's go to the documentation getting
started
and let's copy the dependency
in our project inside the gradle scripts
build.gradle
let's quickly add that dependency
for the version if you hover over this
you will see the latest version which is
1.1.0
after adding the material dependency
first of all in my layout file i'm going
to do some changes i'm going to add a
button
and also beside that i'm going to give
an id to my parent layout but first of
all you may have noticed some changes in
the looks of android studio compared to
the previous video
that's because i have updated my android
studio and we have slight differences
don't worry about that we will talk
about these differences in the next
video for this video let's just
implement our snack bar
the first difference inside this new
android studio is that you no longer can
see the text and design mode in here and
if you want to go to your text you can
go to this split viewing here once again
we will talk about these differences
let's give an id to our construct layout
let's say id i'm going to name it
parents
later on in this video we will see that
why i'm giving an id to this constraint
layout let's also go back to our design
view and let's add a button before that
let's delete this text view
let's quickly constrainty
and also let's change its text
i'm going to change it to show a snack
bar
let's also quickly change the theme of
my application so that we can see the
material button
in our project like we saw in the
previous video in our values folder
inside the styles folder
i'm just going to change the planet
theme in here
i'm going to change it to this
theme.materialcomponents.light
if you switch back to your layout file
now you can see that we are using the
material buttons in my java file first
of all i'm going to initialize this
parent this constraint layout and also
this button
let's quickly do that
let's say private constraint layout
let's name it parent
and also private button
let's name it btn show sniper
down in here inside the uncreate method
let's initialize these two
parent is equal to find view by id r.id
dot parent
ptn share snack bar is equal to find
view by id r dot id dot
i believe it's ideva's button after that
let's set an unclick listener for this
button let's say beauty and show snack
bar dot set unclick listener
neon click listener
i'm going to hand the job to another
method so let's say show a snack or
let's quickly create this method down in
here
private void
show snack bar we don't need any input
and here is how you can show a snack but
you can say snack bar
dot make
without instantiating a new snack bar
you can use this static make method in
order to create your sniper this make
method needs three inputs first of all
we need to pass the parent layout the
layout that we are going to show our
snack bar inside that in this case our
parent layout is a constraint layout and
as you saw i have initialized that
constantly out in here that's the reason
i gave an id to my constraint layout
now in here i can say parent after that
i need the text that i want to show in
my snack bar for example i'm going to
say this is a snack bar
the third parameter in here is a
constant that will indicate the time
that you want to show your snack bar
and you can pass that constant like this
you can say snack bar
dot you have three constants in here
this length long
length short and also length indefinite
the long and short are descriptive but
if you pass length indefinite you will
show your snack bar indefinitely and it
won't be dismissed until the user clicks
on that action button
let's select this one for now length
indefinite after this make method you
can call dot show method in order to
show your snack bar this is going to be
a really simple snack bar and we don't
have any action yet let's see if it's
going to work
if we click on this button we should see
our snack bar and here it is
it's a really basic snack bar and we
don't have any action besides that we
haven't changed the style of our texts
also because we have passed this length
indefinite there is no way to dismiss
this snack bar
let's quickly change this constant to
length short and let's see the
difference
now if we show our snack bar you can see
that it will be dismissed after a few
moments
okay now let's see how we can add an
action to our snack bar but first of all
i'm going to change this constant to
length indefinite once again
and before the show method i'm going to
call another method that method is
called dot set action
first of all we need a text in here this
is going to be the text of our action
for example if you want you can say
retry in here
after that you need an onclicklistener
let's say new and click this name this
is going to be an interface and inside
the onclick method we can do whatever we
want when the user clicks on this retry
text
for example in this case i'm just going
to show a first message
let's say retry clicked
let's see if we can see the action
as you can see in here now we have this
retry option
remember that the length is still
indefinite but if we click on this retry
the snack bar will be dismissed and also
we will see a toast message
let's also see that how we can change
the color of these two texts this retry
and also the color of the message of our
snack bar for that once again before the
show method in here
i'm going to call another method let's
say dot set
action text color in order to change the
color of our action text in here you can
pass your colors in two different ways
first of all you can address the color
from your color resources if you
remember in your project inside the
resources folder
inside the values folder you had this
colors.xml file in which you have few
colors inside that
you can address one of these colors
inside your set action text color like
this you can say get color
and after that r dot color dot for
example color primary beside that if you
have noticed we have some colors that
are coming from the material design
libraries
you can see that we have these colors as
well but for example right now if i use
this color primary in here you can see
that we are getting this warning and
this warning says that you can use this
method in api level 23 and higher there
is also another way to get our color
without seeing this error let's quickly
see that
let's say get resources
this one dot let's say get column
inside this method you can address your
color you can say r.color
to add for example color accent
let's also see the other way
instead of using the resources in my
project i can use a java class
so for example instead of this whole
method in here i can say color
with capital c which is coming from
android.graphics
dot let's say red
this way we can get the red color with
the help of this color class
so if you don't have this red color in
your resources you can also use this
class okay now let's see how we can
change the color of the message of our
snack bar for that i can say dot set
text color this method
once again in order to pass a color you
have two options in this case i'm going
to say color dot for example yellow
let's run the application and let's see
if we have successfully changed the
color or not
let's show our snack bar
you can see that the color of the
message is yellow
and also the color of our action button
is red okay i think that's enough
talking about the snack bar later on we
will use snack bars a lot in the course
the next material component that i'm
going to talk about is material card
view let's quickly see what does it look
like in material.io
once again inside this components tab
inside these cards you can see your card
views
let's scroll down a little bit
this is what cardview looks like you can
use it to for example show different
items in your application you can mix ui
elements in form of a card beside that
you can also have some actions for your
card view also you can have some corner
radius
and also you can have some shadow or
elevation to be precise beside your card
view
in this video we are not going to
implement the actions we will do that
later on in the course but for now let's
just implement a simple card view in our
application we have added the material
design dependencies in our project so we
can add the card view without any
problem but before that let's close this
style and colors
in my layout file in here i'm going to
add my card view below this button let's
switch to a split view and let's add
that
down in here i'm going to define my card
view let's say material card view
this one
beside the material card view you also
have a native card view but the style is
a little bit different if you don't want
to use the material card view you can
always go to
developer.android.com and get the
dependency from the androidx libraries
for cardview but in here let's implement
this material card view
i'm going to enter my widths and height
manually for the bits i'm going to save
100 dp i think that's fine
and for the height let's say 200
it has an odd shape i think it's better
to change the bits to 150 db
let's give it an id
i'm going to say card view
after that inside this card view let's
enter some elements but before that
let's quickly constraint our card view
inside this card view first of all i'm
going to define a relative layout
for the vids and height let's say match
parent
their parent is this card view so we are
going to fit the whole card view and
inside this relative layout i'm going to
put my elements for example i'm going to
put a text view
wrap content unwrap content let's also
center it horizontally
for each text let's just say hello
let's also change the style of this code
let's say text style
and let's pass bold beside that let's
increase the size
let's say 18 sp
after that below this text view i'm
going to define an image view
you can see that in a card view you can
have multiple ui elements for the width
of this image i'm going to say 140 db
and for the height let's say match
parent
i'm going to move this image view to
below this text view so let's say layout
below
but before that i need to give an id to
this text view
let's say id
txt hello
let's also add a margin top and let's
enter this image view
margin top let's say 10 dp
center horizontal true
let's also give it a placeholder
let's say source
i'm going to pass this ic launcher
okay i think that's enough for
understanding the card view
beside that in the card view element you
have other attributes as well for
example if you want to make the corners
of your card view radius you have this
option corner radius
card corner radius
you can say 5 db for example
right now you may not see the difference
but if we run our application we will
see the corner radius you can also
change the corner radius if you think
that 5dp is not enough
the other option that we have in here is
this card elevation
in which we'll give some 3d shape to our
card with some shadow behind our card
view once again i'm going to say 5 db
you can also define this card view like
any other ui elements in your java file
let's quickly do that
private
card view
in here you can see that we have two
options we have this card view which is
coming from android x dot card view
and also we have this material card view
which is coming from the material design
libraries in here we are going to use
this material card view but once again
the difference is only in the style
let's name it card view and down in here
inside the uncreate method let's
initialize it
let's quickly set an unclick listener
for this card view
card view that set on click listener
beside that you can see that we have a
lot of options in here
we will talk about them later on in the
course
set on click listener
let's a new on click listener
let's just show a toast message
let's run the application and let's see
what does our card view look like
our card deal looks like something like
this which is not that good but we can
do much better with the card views we
will do that later on in the course
specifically when we talk about
recyclerview
the combination of recyclerview and
cardview for its items will create a
really beautiful layout file we will see
that i believe in the next video
but in here you can see that we have
this corner radius and also we have this
elevation which is this 3d shape for our
card view beside that later on in the
course we will see how we can create an
expandable card view that means that we
will have some button in here for
example an arrow
in which by clicking on that we will
expand our card view and we would see
some more information and maybe actions
for our item in our card view
okay i think that's enough for this
video in this video i just wanted to
show you how you can create a snack bar
and also implement this card view
in the next video we are going to start
talking about recyclerview in previous
videos we have seen list view for
showing different items but recyclerview
is a much more better option to show a
list of different items
in the next two or three videos we are
going to see how you can use
recyclerviews
see you in the next video
in this video we are going to talk about
recyclerview which as i said before is
another option
for showing a list of different items in
our application
but before that as you can see i've
updated my android studio and in here we
have some changes before talking about
recyclerview i'm going to show some of
these changes in the newest version of
android studio i strongly suggest that
you always keep your android studio
updated you can do that by going to this
help menu
down in here you can check for different
updates and if there is any update
available you can see a list of
different options this in here is
firebase services we are not going to
use that
i'm going to cancel this update you can
see that i also have some updates for my
emulator and hacksam installer
i will update them after this video but
for now let's just say remind me later
also if you remember from the
installation videos i've said that
always check the updates from a stable
channel
if you are not sure about your channel
you can always go to settings by going
to this file tab in here
by going to settings
in here if you check for
updates you can see that my updates are
being checked from inside the stable
channel
we have others as well these other
channels are for preview purposes and
it's basically for professional
developers to check new features in
android and report some bugs if there is
any to the android team but for you for
the starter it's probably best to check
your updates from a stable channel the
first thing that is different in this
newest version of android studio is the
way you go to full screen you can go to
full screen by going to this view menu
and by going to appearance
from here you can go to full screen
in previous versions this option was
somewhere down in here
let's go to full screen mode
the other change that you can probably
see in here is this component tree the
sliding here is a little bit different
there are not much changes in here just
the style but there is a very important
change above in here you can see that
down in here we no longer have that
design and text view mode instead above
in here we have three options right now
we are inside the design view we can
also select this one to go to the text
view
and in between these two we have this
splitter mode
as you can see it acts like a if you
have enabled preview inside your text
view but there is a difference
before that let's quickly minimize this
project pane
from here from inside this splitter view
you can also enable attributes
for example if i select this button
i can see the text view of this button i
can see the design view of this button
and also i can see all of the attributes
in here as well this is going to be
helpful especially if you are using
multiple monitors
for now i'm just going to minimize this
attribute pane you can also change the
size of this preview
beside attributes you can also enable
this palette from here in which you can
see all of different layout elements
and you can drag them directly into your
design view
once again this is going to be helpful
if you are using multiple monitors the
other thing that you can see in here is
this resource manager we had this
resource manager in android studio 3.5
but there has been some improvements in
this newest version
basically inside this resource manager
you can see all of the static resources
inside your project
previously if you wanted to see
different drivable items inside your
project you could have go to this
project training here
and inside the resource folder you could
have checked your drivers
now with this resource manager you can
have access to those drivers more easily
also beside that you can see different
colors you can see different layouts
mute maps strings and also if you click
on these three dots in here you can see
all sorts of resources in your project
also if you want you can use these
resources directly from here for example
right now in our layout file we have
this image view
which its source is this ic launcher
background which exists in our driver
folder if we want to change this to this
ic launcher mipmap file we can simply
drag this ic launcher
and we can paste it in here you can see
that the source of our image view has
not changed
similarly we can do the same thing for
strings
for example right now in our string
resources we have this app name string
we can drag that for example instead of
this hello
you can see that the text has been
changed
let's undo the changes
so from time to time this resource
manager can be useful
the other thing that has changed in this
newest version of android studio is the
font of my code i actually don't like
this font and i'm going to change it to
the previous font that we had in our
android studio for that i can go to this
file inside these settings
you can search for fonts
and in here you can change the font for
example i think i'm going to select this
one
let's press ok
and yes it is the previous font that we
had when we worked with different layout
files
also beside android the studio i've
updated my gradle tool as well
if you want to check that you can go to
your project menu you can go to this
gradle script
we have changed two things about the
cradle first of all if you take a look
at this cradle.wrapper properties you
can see that we have the latest version
of gradle in here and also beside that
if you go to this build.gradle project
module
you can see that we are using the latest
gradle tools version
so beside android studio i've updated my
gradle as well
probably you wouldn't see any difference
when you update your gradle in most
cases it's going to fix some bugs and
also it may improve some performance
once again my suggestion is to keep
everything updated and when you are
working with android studio
okay let's move on from this part and
let's talk about
recyclerview in android studio
for that i'm going to close this project
and i'm going to create a new project
let's say start a new android studio
project
now that we have in here android studio
has a new update in these templates as
well for example inside this tv you can
see that we have other options for
different operating systems
or for different devices some new
templates has been added but we are not
going to work with them like before we
are going to use this empty activity
let's name this project recyclerview
or let's say recyclerview example
it's interesting that in here we have
this new option in here
it says use legacy
android.support.libraries
so basically before androidx we had to
use support libraries for having
backward compatibilities in older
devices as you saw in the previous
videos the use of android x was
mandatory but now in here we have this
new option
i don't think we are going to use this
legacy support libraries in our course
but it seems like we now have this
option
okay let's create our project
and let's see how we can use
recyclerview for that we have two
options first of all we can go to our
activitymain.xml file
as you can see we have this recyclerview
option in here but before using it we
need to download its dependency into our
project we can click on this download
option in here and it will be
automatically added to our gradle file
or if you don't want to add it from here
you can always search for recyclerview
dependencies and add it manually into
your gradle file before i add this
recyclerview let's quickly open our
gradle script build.gradle module app
down in here in these dependencies you
can see that we don't have any
recyclerview
let's download this recyclerview by
clicking on this
you can see a warning in here would you
like to add this now let's say okay
it seems like we have added recyclerview
successfully let's check our
build.gradle file
and down in here you can see the
recyclerview
but as you can see the highlighting here
this is not the latest version for that
reason it's always better to check the
internet for the latest recyclerview
dependencies the highlight in here says
that you have a version 1.1.0 available
so let's change this one to 1.1.0
and let's sync our project
okay now that we have added this
recyclerview dependency we can add it to
our layout file
i'm going to switch to textview from
above in here
and i'm going to minimize this resource
manager
first of all i'm going to change this
constraint layout to a relative layout
after that like before i'm going to
delete this text view
and let's add a recyclerview
so you can say recyclerview
this option down in here
for the vids and height let's say match
parent i'm going to match the whole
relative layout
let's also give it an
id let's say contact recyclerview
as you can guess i'm going to show a
list of different contacts in my
recyclerview
after that we can finish creating a
recyclerview and if you enable your
preview from inside this split view you
can see that we have these options
inside this recycler view
i'm also going to add some padding to
this parent relative layout so in here
inside the starting tag
let's say padding and let's say 10db
that seems better
after that we need to initialize our
recyclerview in our java file
so inside this
mainactivity.java file first of all i'm
going to say private recyclerview
this one that comes from androidx dot
recyclerview widget
let's name it contacts recyclerview
and down in here inside oncreate method
let's initialize it
contact recyclerview is equal to find
view by id
r.id dot
contact recyclerview
then we have worked with list view right
after this point right after
initializing our list view
we could have created an arrayadapter
and after that we could have passed our
arrayadapter to our listview
but when we are using recyclerview we
need to create our own adapter
creating your own recyclerview adapter
is probably the most complex code that
you have written so far but we are going
to go through each step together
before creating our adapter we also need
a layout file
if you remember when we have used list
view for every item in our list view
we have passed a built-in layout
in recyclerview we need to create that
layout as well
so inside my project inside the
resources folder inside the layout
folder
i'm going to create a new layout
resource file
i'm going to name this one contacts list
item
i'm also going to change this root
element to a relative layout
okay let's create our layout file
and let's switch to our text view
if you remember from previous videos i
said that when you are working with
recyclerview you have all sort of
flexibilities
in designing your items layout files
we will take a look at more complex
layout files but in here i'm just going
to add a simple text view
let's switch to the split view so that
we can see the preview
okay let's say text view
wrap content and wrap content
for the text let's say
contact name
later on in our recycler view we are
going to change this text view
beside that let's also give an id to
this text view
let's say txt name
i'm also going to change the height of
this relative layout to wrap content
because we don't want to
occupy the whole screen for just one
item in our recyclerview for that let's
change this one to wrap content let's
also add some enters in here so that we
can see it better
and also let's add some padding
let's say padding and let's pass 10 db
sorry for that
let's also give an id to this relative
layout we will see how it can be useful
let's just name it parent
so this in here is going to be the
layout file for every item in our
recyclerview
now that we have created this contacts
this item.xml file we can create our
recyclerviewadapter
for that we need to create a java class
in our project so inside our package i'm
going to say new java class
let's name this class contacts
recyclerviewadapter
let's create our class and let's see
what do we have in here
so first of all before everything i'm
going to create an inner class inside
this class we will see what this inner
class is
this inner class needs to be public
let's say public class
i'm going to name it view holder because
it's the convention
this viewholder class needs to extend
recyclerview.viewholder
this class in here
but as you can see we are getting an
error in here and that's because we need
to create our constructor
let's quickly do that by pressing alt
plus insert
this inner view holder class is going to
hold the view for every item in a
recycler view for example in this case
it's going to generate a new contactless
item
in which later on we will see how we can
use this layout file and also all of the
elements inside that so basically this
inner class is responsible for
generating our view objects
if you want to have access to elements
inside your view object you can add them
as the fields of this inner class for
example in here i can say private text
view
if you remember we had a text view in
our list item
the id was txt name
let's name it txt name
and down in here inside the constructor
let's say txt name is equal to find view
by id
but because we are not inside an
activity we cannot use this find view by
id method like this
instead what we can do is that we can
use this view object that has been
passed to this constructor
for example i can say item view dot find
view by id
you can see that we have this method in
here
so the only difference is that inside an
activity you can simply say find view by
id but in here because we are not inside
an activity we can use this view we can
say item view dot find view by id
after that we can address our text view
i can say r dot id dot let's say txt
name
if you have other elements inside your
layout file you can add them like this
one by one
we will see that later on in few minutes
but for now we are done with this
interview holder class let's minimize
this
and now we can extend the recyclerview
adapter at the declaration of our
adapter class
the way to do that is like this we can
say extend
recyclerview.adapter
you can see that we have this option
also take a look at this vh in here it
stands for viewholder
if you import this adapter inside the
diamonds you need to pass view holder
there are also multiple view holders
make sure to import the one that is
inside this class this org dot maycode
that
your project name
you also have one in android
x.recyclerview so make sure to don't
confuse them
if you remember when we have used
arrayadapter for list views as the data
type of our adapter we have passed a
string this viewholder class is exactly
like that and we are saying that the
data type of our adapter at the end is
this view holder class
the class that we created inside our
adapter
okay now that we have extended
recyclerview.adapter we need to create
some methods or to be specific we need
to implement some methods for that i can
press ctrl i
and as you can see we have three
mandatory methods
oncreateviewholder
view holder and this get item count
method
let's implement all three of them
we are also going to need a constructor
for this adapter class let's quickly
create that by pressing alt plus insert
by going to constructor we can create
our constructor
before explaining these three methods in
here i'm going to create a model in my
project as i said previously in this
video i'm going to show some contacts
inside my recyclerview and i'm going to
create a model for those contacts so
inside my project i'm going to create a
new java class let's name it contact
for this contact i'm going to define
some features first of all let's say
private string name
after that let's say private string
email
after that i'm going to define a new
string let's say private string
image url
will see how this one is going to be
useful basically we are going to show
some images from the internet by using
their urls
after that we need to create our
constructor once again by pressing alt
plus insert we can do that
let's also create some getters and
setters i'm not sure that i'm going to
use all of them
later on if we didn't use them i would
delete them
let's also create a two string method
this might be useful as well
okay now we have our contact model let's
close this class
so once again inside my recycler view
i'm going to show a list of different
contacts because of that i need to pass
the list of different contacts to this
adapter class
for that before everything above in here
i'm going to create an arraylist or to a
specific a private array list
of different
contacts let's say private rally staff
contact let's name it contacts
is equal to new arraylist it's very
important to initialize your arraylist
if you don't initialize it you will
definitely get a null pointer exception
also because we have set these contacts
arraylist as private we also need to
create a setter method so that later on
for example from inside our main
activity
we can set the initial data for our
contacts for that down in here
after the get item count method i'm
going to press alt plus insert
and by going to this setter menu
we can create a setter for our contacts
arraylist later on from inside our main
activity we will pass our data we are
using this set contacts method
but there is a very important point in
here imagine that you are getting your
data for example the list of your
contacts from a web server from internet
the list of different contacts that are
coming from the internet may change
during the time
so the list of different contacts inside
your recycler view should be changed as
well
if you want at any time you can reuse
this set contacts method in order to
change the data inside your adapter
but in order to refresh the data inside
your recyclerview you need to use
another method inside the setcontacts
method
that method is called
notifydatasetchanged
this one in here
so basically the dataset for our adapter
in this case is our contacts arraylist
after changing the list of different
contacts at any time
we are going to notify the adapter that
the dataset has been changed this way we
can refresh our recyclerview
with the new data that we have received
or passed to this adapter class
okay let's move on from this part and
let's start working on these three
different methods
the simplest of these methods is this
get item count you can guess its purpose
it's just going to return the count of
different items in your adapter in this
case we know that the data in our
adapter is a list of contacts so we can
simply return the list of our contacts
we can say contacts.size
that's all we need to do inside this get
item count for some reason recyclerview
needs the number of items inside your
adapter and in here we can simply return
that
okay i think that's enough for this
video in the next video at the beginning
we will start working on these two
methods
after that we will see that how we can
have more complex layouts in
recyclerview
and after that we will see how we can
use that image url in order to show
different contact images in our
application
okay see you in the next video
okay let's continue our talk about
creating a recyclerview adapter but
before that let's quickly have a review
of what we have done so far
so first of all we have added the
recyclerview dependency in our gradle
scripts
if you take a look at build.gradle
module app inside these dependencies you
can see that we have added recyclerview
after that we have added this
recyclerview in our
activitymain.xml file
inside this relative layout we have this
recyclerview after that inside our
mainactivity.java file
we have initialized our recyclerview
after that it was the time to create the
layout file for every item in our
recyclerview we have done that by
creating a new layout file called the
contacts list item in our layout folder
if you want to take another look it's a
simple relative layout which contains
only one text view later on we will
change this after creating the layout
file for every item it was time to
create our adapter class we have done
that by adding a new java class
in our package the name of that class
was contacts recyclerview adapter
inside this class first level we have
created this inner class we have named
it viewholder because it's the
convention
after that we have extended the
recyclerview.viewholder
we needed a constructor so we have
created this constructor in here
as i said in the previous video this
viewholder class is responsible for
holding the view items for every item in
our recyclerview we can also instantiate
all of our ui elements from inside our
contacts list item.xml file inside this
viewholder class if we want
after creating this viewholder class
this inner class in here
we have extend extended the
recyclerview.adapter class in which as
its data type we have passed our
innerviewholder class
when we extended this
recyclerview.adapter we needed to
implement three mandatory methods
this oncreateviewholder
onbindviewholder and getitemcount
methods we are going to talk about these
methods in this video but before that we
also created a model for our contacts we
have added that in our package this
contact has a name and email and also an
image url later on in this video we will
see that how we are going to show an
image
based on its image url
after creating our model inside our
adapter class
we have created an arraylist of
different contacts in which we have
named that contacts
it was also important to initialize this
array list i said that we are going to
get a null pointer exception if we don't
initialize our arraylist
also later on when we create an instance
of this adapter class we are going to
need a constructor so for that we have
created this empty constructor
i believe later on we will change this
also in order to pass the data into this
adapter class in this case an arraylist
of contacts we have used this set
contacts method
in which we are going to call it from
inside our main activity
after passing the data to this adapter
we have notified the adapter that the
data set has changed
so that we can refresh the list of items
in our recycler view
also in the previous video we have
talked about this get item count method
once again it's going to return the
number of items in our adapter in this
case we have returned our contacts
arraylist.size
okay now it's time to work on these two
methods but before everything let's
close all of the extra classes and files
and let's start working on this
oncreateviewholder method
as you can see the return type of this
method is a viewholder it means that
this method is the place to generate our
view holder
the place to instantiate our viewholder
class that we have created down in here
in order to create our view holder class
first of all we need to create a view
object we can do that by saying view
this one in here
let's name it view is equal to
if we were inside an activity we could
have said get layout inflator but
because we are inside a class beside our
activity we can't use that instead we
can say something like this we can say
layout inflator with capital l
dot from this method in here
you can see that this from method is
waiting for our context
you can also guess by the style of this
from method that this is a static method
in here we don't have any context but we
can use this view group in order to get
the context
let's get the context from this view
group and i will talk about it you can
see that the name of this view group is
parent so i can say parent
dot get context as you can see in here
we are creating a view object and we are
using this layout inflator to generate
that view object the job of this layout
inflator is that to inflate a layout for
some reason this layout inflator needs a
context so we can say dot from and
inside that method we can pass our
context
the way to inflate our layout with the
help of this layout inflator is that to
use dot inflate method so in here after
this from method we can say dot inflate
and after passing some arguments we can
generate our view object
in here we need to pass three arguments
first of all we need to pass the address
of our layout file for every item in our
recyclerview i mean that
contactslistitem.xml file that we just
created
so for that i can say r dot layout dot
let's say contact list item
after that we need to pass our view
group in this case its name is parent
once again i will talk about it
and also after that we need to pass a
boolean i will talk about that after i
talked about view group let's pass false
in this case
and now we have our view object
okay let's talk about these two
arguments in here this view group and
also this boolean
basically the view group is the parent
of all of the layout files for example
it's the parent of relative layout
linear layout and also constraint layout
this view group can be used to group
different views inside it if you want to
make sure of that for example you can go
to your main activity just for testing
purposes
if we say private relative layout let's
name it relative layout from the
previous videos we know that if you want
to check some documentation in android
we can press down the control key
and by selecting the class name
we can have access to the relative
layout documentation and also
declaration
in here you can see that this relative
layout is extending view group so once
again viewgroup is the parent of all of
our layout files
but why we are passing this view group
as one of the arguments inside our
adapter class before talk about that
let's quickly delete this line of code
we have created this just to read the
documentation and declaration so in here
inside this inflate method we are
passing this view group
basically this tells that where do you
want to attach your view object for
example when we
create an instance of our adapter object
from inside our main activity
because in our main activity layout file
we have to find a relative layout this
view group is going to be a relative
layout and this view object in here our
layout file for every item
is going to be attached to that relative
layout inside our main activity
that's also the reason why this view
group has the name of parent in here but
what is this boolean in here you can see
that the name of this boolean is
attached to root
and also i'm passing false in here i
just said that i want to attach my view
object to its parent i'm passing false
in here because if we pass through it
will be a redundant job we already
passed our view group as the parent of
our view object
and if we pass through it's going to be
redundant
we have this boolean because we can also
pass null in here for example if you are
not sure about our parent
and about where our view is going to be
attached
instead of our parent view group we can
simply pass no
you can see that the name of this
argument has changed to root
so if you pass null you are not going to
be sure about the place that this view
is going to be attached to
but of course this is an option that you
have
once again i'm going to pass parent
and for the boolean i'm going to pass
false
so at the end of this line of code with
the help of this layout inflator dot
inflate method we have our view object
now it's the time to create our
viewholder object and after that return
it
if you take a look at the constructor of
this class that you have created
you can see that this constructor in
here is accepting a view
now that we have our view object we can
create an instance of this viewholder
class
so above in here before the return
statement i can say
viewholder
the one that exists in our adapter class
not the one inside the android x dot
recycler view
let's say view holder let's name it
holder
is equal to new view holder
and let's pass our view
after that let's return our folder
so once again the purpose of this method
in here this oncreateviewholder
is to create an instance of our
viewholder class for every item in our
recyclerview
later on this holder will be passed to
this unbind view holder method as you
can see in here and we can use it in
order to change the properties of our ui
elements
let's see how we can do that
so inside this unbind viewholder method
which i believe is the most important
method inside every recyclerviewadapter
we are going to use the properties of
our viewholder class
for example right now inside our layout
file we have only one text view
so if i want to change the value of my
text view i can say something like this
i can say holder
dot txt name
dot set text
and we can pass our text
you can see that in here we are able to
use holder.txt name if you remember
inside our viewholder class we had such
a field
but also this field was private if you
remember from the java session i said
that whenever you use inner classes
from inside the parent class you can
have access to all of the private fields
and methods of your inner class in this
case
inside this adapter class we can use
this folder.txt name even though it's
private
okay but what do we pass inside this
settext method as you can see beside
this holder we also are getting some
integer called position
it's exactly like the position that we
had inside list view adapters
this is going to be the position of the
item in our recycler view once again we
can use this position in order to get
the data for example from our contacts
arraylist
for example inside the settext method i
can say contacts
dot let's say
get
and in here as the index i can pass
position
also during the time i've seen that the
name of this integer was different
sometimes it was named i sometimes it
was position and also i think i've seen
others but basically this integer is
just the position of every item in your
recyclerview dataset okay after getting
the corresponding contact we can use dot
get name for example in order to set the
name of our contact
to this text view this is going to be
the simplest recyclerview that you can
create
you can have all sort of ui elements
inside your list item layout file and
after that inside this unbind view
holder method
you can also set different unclick
listeners for each one of ui elements
but more on that in few minutes so by
this time our adapter class is ready we
have done a great job and we have
created our recyclerview adapter class
now that we have created our
adapter it's time to switch back to our
main activity
and pass some data to this adapter class
so inside this oncreate method we have
instantiated a recyclerview
after that we need to create and
arraylist of different contacts for
example let's say arraylist of different
contacts
let's name it contacts is equal to new
arraylist
once again i'm
passing the data manually in here
because we don't know anything about
databases and web servers yet
in a real world application these data
are probably coming from a database or a
web server
let's quickly add some data to our
contacts array list
as you can see i've added some contacts
into my area list
for every contact i've selected a name
also an email
and beside that i've get these image
urls from the internet there is just one
point in here and that's regarding these
image urls sometimes when you are
copying the address of some image from
the internet
that address may not have an extension
for example like this dot jpg or dot png
those images are not going to be useful
in here so make sure to select the
images that have the extension of that
jpeg or that png
just because some students asked me
before how to get the address of these
images let me quickly show you one
example for example in google images you
can search for different images
and by right clicking on the image you
can copy the image address
for example in another tab you can paste
the address if it's ending with
jpeg or dot png you are good to go
okay after creating your contacts it's
time to create your recyclerview adapter
for that i'm going to say contact
recyclerview adapter
let's name it adapter
is equal to new contacts recyclerview
adapter
we didn't need anything for the
constructor so we are good to go
after that we can use the setter method
inside our adapter we can say adapter
dot set contacts and we can pass our
array list
after creating our adapter instance and
setting the data we can set this adapter
to our recyclerview so down in here i
can say contact recyclerview
dot set adapter
and i can pass my adapter in a list view
that would be the end of everything and
we could have test our application but
in recyclerview there is also one more
step
we also need to set a layout manager for
our recyclerview as well let's quickly
set that and we will talk about it
let's say contacts recyclerview dot set
layout manager
in here we have few options first of all
we can pass a linear layout manager and
we can pass that like this we can say
new linear layout manager
in which for its constructor we need a
context this time because we are inside
an activity we can safely pass this as
the context
by setting the layout manager of our
recyclerview to a linear layout manager
we are saying that display the items in
our recycler view in a linear fashion
the other option that we have is grid
layout manager we will take a look at
that
but in here this linear layout manager
is by default vertical
if you want to change that for example
if you want to have a horizontal view
and you can do that we will do that in a
minute after running our application so
by this point our application is ready
to test
we have created a recyclerview we have
instantiated down in here we also have
created this domain list of contacts
after that we have instantiated our
adapter class we have set the data
inside this adapter class after that we
have set the adapter to our recyclerview
we also have set a layout manager for a
recyclerview let's test the application
and let's see what does a recyclerview
look like
as you can see the list of different
contacts name are being shown inside a
recyclerview in my activity
if i had more contacts i could have
scrolled my recyclerview and i could
have access to all of them
right now they all can fit on the screen
so this is not a scroll view
let's quickly change this linear layout
to a horizontal linear layout and see
the difference
so in order to have a horizontal linear
layout
after this context you can say linear
layout manager
dot horizontal this one in here
this is a constant in which you can use
in order to have a linear layout manager
beside that you also have a boolean in
here
let's pass that i'm going to pass false
as you can see the name of this boolean
is reverse layout if you want to reverse
the order of items inside your recycler
view you can pass through in here but i
don't see any reason for doing that
so i'm going to pass false let's run the
application once again and let's see
what a horizontal linear layout looks
like
you can see that this time right now we
are seeing only one contact on the
screen and that's because when we
created the layout for every item in our
recyclerview
we have passed match parent as the width
of the item
but if you want to see other items you
can scroll the window horizontally you
can see that we are seeing other
contacts
so this is what this horizontal linear
layout looks like
okay let's quickly see the other layout
manager that i talked about and let's
move on from this part the name of the
other layout manager was grid layout
manager so i'm going to delete all of
these
and inside this set layout manager
method i'm going to say new grid layout
manager
for the inputs of this constructor we
need two arguments first of all we need
the context
after that we need the number of columns
for example i can pass 2 in here
this 2 in here is going to divide our
screen horizontally in two different
parts or to be a specific two different
columns and it's going to show different
contacts in those two columns
but before i run my application i'm
going to change one thing in the
application in the contacts list
item.xml file i'm going to change the
match parent attribute of my
relative layout to let's say wrap
content
you can see that for this bits we have
set it to match parent
i'm going to change that to wrap content
okay now let's run the application
you can see that the screen has been
divided into two different columns
horizontally
and we can see the
contacts name in two different columns
so sometimes you may want to use this
grid layout manager
okay now let's see how we can set an
onclicklistener for each one of these
items in our
view right now
if we click on each one of these items
they are not going to do anything
but if you want to set an unclick
listener we need to do that inside our
contacts recyclerview adapter
let's quickly open that class
it was in our java folder inside our
project folder
contacts recyclerview adapter
if you remember i said that this unbind
viewholder method is the most important
method in your adapter class and inside
this method you can set an unclick
listener for every ui element that you
want
also if you remember inside this
contacts list item i've defined an id
for this whole relative layout
if you want you can set the
onclicklistener on this textview but i
think it's better to define the
onclicklistener on the whole relative
layout because as you can see we have
this padding of 1080p and some places in
our relative layout are not going to be
clickable if we set the on click
listener on the text view but because
i'm going to define the onclicklistener
on this relative layout
inside my adapter class when i've
created this holder class
after creating the text view i need to
reference the relative layout as well so
i can say private relative layout
let's name it parent
we also need to instantiate it inside
the constructor down in here i can say
parent
is equal to item view dot find view by
id once again
let's say r dot
id dot parent
after defining this relative layout now
you can have access to that inside this
onbindviewholder method
so for example in here i can say holder
dot parent which is the name of this
relative layout
dot let's say set unclick listener
you can see that we have this option
let's pass our interface new
onclicklistener
[Music]
and in here i'm just going to show some
toast message
let's say toast
if you remember when we have used this
make text method on our toast we needed
a context but in here we do not have
access to any kind of context once again
we will talk about context later on when
we talk about activities in android but
inside this adapter class right now we
don't have any context
so we have to pass it inside the
constructor
for example i'm going to define the
context as the member variable above in
here
let's say private context
let's name it context
and after that i'm going to receive that
via this constructor let's say context
let's name it context
inside the constructor i can say this
dot context
is equal to context
but now that i have changed this
constructor if i switch back to main
activity i should see some red warning
when we have instantiated our adapter
class
we need to pass our context once again
because this time we are inside this
activity i can simply pass this
so this way inside our adapter now we
have a context
and when we create our toast message we
can pass that as the context
for the text i'm going to show the name
of the contact so i can say contacts the
arraylist that we had
let's say that get once again i'm going
to use this position as the index
let's say that get name
also if you have noticed that as soon as
i've used this position inside this
onclick method because we are inside an
interface
this final keyboard has been added to
the declaration of this integer
let's also add another text in here
let's say select it
let's quickly run the application and
let's see if we have correctly and set
the onclicklistener on our relative
layout
let's click on the first one
margaret is selected
social runoff social romance selected it
seems like our unclick listener is
working fine
okay i think that's a good point to stop
the video in here i did want to talk
about that image url and how to show
that in our recyclerview but it seems
like this video is getting a little bit
long so i'm going to talk about that in
the next video beside that we will also
talk about using a combination of
recycler view and card view
the combination of these two will
generate a really beautiful look for a
recycler view
okay see you in the next video
in the previous video we have created a
functional recyclerview
by functional i mean we have created a
skeleton of our recyclerview
but right now it's very simple if you
take a look at your contacts list
item.xml file
you can see that every item in your
recyclerview is just a simple textview
in this video we are going to work
around this and we are going to see how
much flexibility we have when we are
working with recycler views
the first thing that i am going to do in
here is that to use a card view instead
of this simple text view and its parent
which is relative layout
we are going to show our contacts in a
card view
for that first of all we need to add the
card view dependencies into our project
in previous videos when we wanted to use
card view in our project we have added
the material design library
and from there we have used the material
card view
instead of using the material design
library this time i'm going to use the
native android card view
let's see where we can find that
cardview dependencies
so if you search for cardview
dependencies
you will end up with a link like this
make sure to put android x in your
search because if you search for android
you may get
something like this
let's quickly take a look at that
in here inside these dependencies you
can see that you are using
com.android.support library
we are not using support libraries in
our project right now if you remember
when we have created our project
we have added the android x artifacts
if you want to make sure of that you can
always check your gradle file let's
quickly do that
so in my project pane inside this gradle
script in this build.gradle module app
in these dependencies you can see that
we are always using android x
if for some reason you are using the
support libraries you can implement this
support libraries version
but because we are using android x this
dependency is not going to be helpful
for us so make sure to include this
android x in your search
and the first link from the official
android developers website is probably
our needed link
down in here you can see the
dependencies you can see that this time
we are going to
add the dependency from android x
packages let's copy this line of code
and let's add it into our project
so once again inside this build.gradle
module app file
inside these dependencies we are going
to add our dependency let's quickly do
that in here
and let's sync our project
now that i've added card view
dependencies into my project i can use
it in my layout files for example inside
this contacts list item.xml file
instead of this relative layout i'm
going to use card view
you can see that it's coming from
android x packages
if you remember in card views we had two
attributes that can be helpful in here
the first one is card elevation
this one in here
which will give some 3d shape to our
card for example if i say 5 dp
we will get an elevation of 5 db the
next one is card corner radius
this one in here which once again i'm
going to say 5 db
i will change these numbers if it was
necessary
and also inside this card view instead
of this text view i'm going to use a
relative layout
the reason for the relative layout is
that because i'm going to include
multiple ui elements and i'm going to
use some of the attributes like layout
below center horizontal and attributes
like that
and those attributes are available
inside a relative layout
so for that first of all in here i'm
going to create a relative layout
for the bits and height let's say match
parent
and i think that's enough for our
relative layout
inside that first of all i'm going to
move this text view
first of all let's center this textview
horizontally let's say center horizontal
and let's pass through
beside that let's change the style of
this text
let's say text style
and let's change it to bold
after that i'm going to create another
text view and i'm going to show the
contacts email let's add that after this
text view
let's change the contact name to contact
email
and let's change the id to txt email
also move this to below our contact name
layout below let's say
txt name
let's also change the styling here let's
say italic
i think it's better to add some margin
top
margin top
let's say
7dp
also i'm going to delete this center
horizontal attribute
okay after these two texts i'm going to
show the contacts image for that i'm
going to create an image view
let's say image view
for the widths and height of this image
view because i want to have a consistent
image view i'm going to put the numbers
manually because my images are coming
from the internet and i don't know
anything about their size for example in
here i'm going to save 150 dp i think
that would be fine
for the height as well once again 150 dp
let's also give an id to this image view
let's just say image
i'm going to move this to below my
contacts email
let's say layout below
and let's pass the xd email
let's add the margin top
i think 10dp would be fine
i'm also going to center this image view
horizontally so let's say center
horizontal
and let's pass through
let's also add a placeholder i'm going
to say source
and let's address one of our images in
our package
i think this ic launcher background
would be fine
okay i think that's enough for our card
view i don't think we need anything else
let's just have a quick look of what our
card view looks like i think i need to
increase this corner radius for example
let's say 10 in here
that should be better beside that let's
increase this card elevation you can
play around with these numbers until you
are satisfied
i'm almost done with this contact list
item file i'm just going to reformat my
code so that when i publish this code
you and i have the same base code for
that i'm going to go to this code tab in
here
and down in here i'm going to select
this reformat code you can see that the
code has been rearranged
okay now that i have changed this layout
file we need to also apply the changes
inside our recyclerview adapter file as
well so down in here when we have
created our viewholder class
we need to address all of the new
elements in our contacts list item.xml
file
first of all we have deleted this
relative layout and we have replaced
that with a card view
so in here instead of using a relative
layout i'm going to say card view
and let's also add our email text i'm
going to add it in the same line with
this txt name
let's say txt email
and let's initialize it down in here
inside this constructor
so let's say txt email
is equal to
itemview.findviewbyidr.id.txt email
we also need to add some codes inside
this onbindviewholder method for example
we are going to show the contacts email
we need to do that in here let's say
holder
dot txt email dot set text
let's pass our contacts dot get
which for the index i'm going to pass
position
let's say that get email
before showing the image view i'm going
to run the application and i'm going to
see that if everything is working fine
so let's run the application
you can instantly see that with these
few changes how much we have improved
our layout
but right now this layout needs some
modification for example we need to add
some margin between these card views and
also we need to add a merging top for
this txt name
let's quickly apply them
so if i switch back to my contact list
item.xml file for this parent card view
i'm going to add a margin let's say
margin top or instead of margin top i'm
just going to say margin i think 10 db
would be fine
beside that let's also add a margin for
this text view
let's say margin top and let's pass
seven dp
let's also add a margin start for this
email
so in here for this txt email i'm going
to say margin start
this one in here and i'm going to say
5dp
let's run the application once again
you can see that it's much better now
you can also see the two attributes that
we have added for our chord views much
better in here first of all we have
added this corner radius you can see
that in here and also this 3d shape
with the shadow behind our card view is
for that card elevation attribute beside
that the reason that we are seeing two
columns in here is because of that grid
layout manager that we have passed to
our recircular view if you want to have
only one column you can change that for
example inside our main activity
down in here instead of a grid layout
manager we can pass a linear layout
manager
so in here let's say new linear layout
and let's pass our context before i run
this application i'm going to make sure
that i've centered my recyclerview let's
switch to our main activity layout file
and let's enter our recyclerview
let's say center horizontal
and let's pass through
also i'm going to change the width
attribute in here to wrap content
let's run the application once again
right now you can see that we have only
three contacts in our screen but we can
scroll our recycler view let's quickly
do that you can see that if our item do
not fit on the screen our recycler view
is a scrollable
beside that let's also check the unclick
listener
let's click on this card view and you
can see that social run on selected
it seems to be perfect okay now let's
work on this image view let's see how we
can show our images
for that we have multiple options the
easiest one is to use an external
library called glide let's add that into
our project and we will talk about it
so if you search for glide dependency
the first link from this github page
is the link to that external library
let's see what does it look like
down in here you should see the
dependencies
first of all we need to add these two
into our repositories let's see if we
have them in our gradle file
let's open our project pane in the
gradle script inside this build.gradle
project one
in these repositories we need to add the
maven repositories let's quickly add
them
i'm going to copy this one in here
and i'm going to add it inside these
repositories for all projects
beside that we need to add these two
dependencies into our project
inside this build.gradle design module
app we need to add the dependencies
let's sync our project
and while it's syncing let's also talk
about disk light
so glide is an image loader library in
which has developed by google so you can
safely use it in your projects
glide has a lot of functionalities in
which one of them is to load images from
the internet later on in the course we
will see other functionalities as well
but if you want to know more about glide
they have a documentation in here let's
click on this view collides
documentation
you can read this page if you want but
we will talk about glide more later on
in the course okay let's switch back to
our project
and it seems like we have added the
glide library successfully
let's close these two grada files
also let's close this
activitymain.xml file and let's go to
our contacts
recyclerviewadapter.java file
so inside this unbind viewholder method
i am going to show the images of
different contacts for that i am going
to use the glide inside this method
lets see how we can use glide
in order to show images with glide
library you can say something like this
you can say glide
with capital g
after that you need to pass your context
you can do that by saying that with
for the context in here i'm going to
pass my context as a reminder we have
get the context by the constructor of
this class
in the previous video i'm talking about
this one in here
now that we have our context we can use
it with this with method
after that i'm going to say that this
image is going to be a bits map so let's
say dot
as bitmap
after that we need to pass the source of
our image in this case we are going to
pass the image url for our contact image
let's say dot load
and let's pass our context image for
that i'm going to say contacts dot get
once again i'm going to use the position
as the index
let's say dot get image url after that
we need to pass the image view that we
want to show our image inside that
i'm going to say that into
and i'm going to address my image view
which i can say holder dot image but for
that first of all we need to add this
image inside this view holder class we
never did that
so inside this view holder class first
of all i'm going to say private
image view let's call it
and let's also instantiate it inside the
constructor
let's say image is equal to item view
dot find view by id or dot id dot image
this is the simplest way of using glide
first of all we need to pass our context
after that we need to say that it's
going to be a bitmap file
after that we need to pass the source of
our image with this dot load method
and after that we need to specify the
image view that we are going to show our
image inside that
this is going to work fine but before i
run my application i need to do one more
thing we are going to load different
images from the internet
for that we need to add a permission
into our manifest file for accessing the
internet
so far we haven't talked about
requesting a permission let's quickly
see how we can do that
so in our project pane inside the app
folder
inside this manifest folder
if we open this
androidmanifest.xml file we can add our
permission in here above the application
tag
in here i can open attack and the tag is
going to be user's permission this one
in here
and we need to specify the kind of
permission let's search for internet
permission
you can see this
android.permission.internet
let's close our tank
there are much more concepts regarding
these permissions we will talk about
them later on in the course for some
permissions you need to create a ui a
logic in order to ask the user to grant
that permission to your application
but this internet permission is a safe
permission
and if you add it to your manifest file
the android system is going to grant it
automatically
that's all we need to do in order to
request for an internet permission later
on we will talk more about permissions
let's just run our application and let's
see if we can successfully show
different images
you can see that we are seeing different
images in here but there was a problem
when i ran this application after adding
the permission for the first time
the first time i wasn't able to see the
images and that's because we have
changed our manifest file
whenever you change your manifest file
you need to uninstall the application
and install it once again
so if you are not seeing different
images make sure to uninstall the
application and install it once again
after that you should see different
images
let's also check the others you can see
that the images are loading from the
internet after a few seconds you can see
that our recycler view our card views
and also the glide library is working
perfect the combination of these three
will create a really beautiful layout
for when we want to show a list of
different items
and probably by now you can see the
flexibility and all of the
functionalities of recyclerview you can
see that we can modify our layout files
our list item layout files however we
want
okay i think that's enough for this
video just to see our recyclerview
better i'm going to change the linear
layout manager once again to a grid
layout manager
and after that we will finish our video
so let's change it back to
gridlayoutmanager and let's run our
application once again
you can see that our recyclerview seems
perfect
okay i think that's enough for this
video in the next video we are going to
see how we can use different fonts for
our textviews for example an external
font that we don't have in android
studio
okay see you in the next video
in this video we are going to talk about
different fonts how we can apply
different fonts to our text view
whether that font exists in our project
or whether we are going to add it
externally i believe this will be a
short video
first of all let's see how we can add an
external font into our project
before that i'm going to go to this
layout file
and give an id to this text view let's
just name it txt hello
in order to add an external font in your
resources folder you need to create a
new directory
you can right click on your resource
folder by selecting new android resource
directory you can create that directory
we have done this when we have created a
menu resource file
in here you just need to define the type
of your resource you can search for font
in here
and that's all you need to do
now you can see that you have this font
folder
and you can copy your external fonts
into this folder for example i have
prepared this font
but before adding this font into my
project i need to do some modifications
for example i need to change the name of
this font
in order to add this font into your
project you need to follow some rules
for example you need to
change all of the upper cases into lower
cases and also you shouldn't use hyphens
instead of that you can use underlines
so in here i'm going to change the name
a little bit let's change this upper a
to layer a
after you have changed the name you can
simply copy your font
and inside your font folder you can
paste it
the name is fine let's just press ok
now in your font folder you have this
amsterdam.ttf
if your font has some preview you can
see that by double clicking on your font
okay now that we have added this one
let's see how we can use it on our text
view let's switch to our text view mode
and on this text view we have one
attribute called font family
this one in here and now we can address
our font which is add font slash
amsterdam
let's switch to split view and let's see
if we can see our font in the preview
you can see that right now the font
hasn't been rendered but i believe this
will be changed when we run our
application
let's run the application and let's see
if we can successfully change the font
of our text view
you can see that this beautiful font has
been applied on our text view
beside using your own fonts in your
project you can also use some fonts
called google fonts let's quickly see
how we can use them
so for that i'm going to switch to
design view
and search for font family attributing
here
but before that i need to click on this
text view
let's search for font family
you can see that we have this attribute
and beside our font which is right now
at font amsterdam we have this drop down
icon if you click on that
you can see that in android we have some
fonts that we can use
but beside all of these
we have this more fonts option
and when we click on that you can see
that we have a list of a lot of more
fonts
also you can see the source in here it
says google fonts
these google fonts are free and you can
safely use them in your applications you
just need to add a license in your
application somewhere okay let's see
what do we have in these google fonts
for example we have this calligraphy or
something like that
that we can use in here you can see that
we have two options create downloadable
font and add fun to your project
the first option means that you don't
want to add the font to your project and
you want to use the online font every
time that a user uses your application
if you are creating an offline
application this option in here might
not be that useful
instead of that i'm going to use the
second option which will add the font to
my project
but it will increase the size of the
final apk file
also down in here you can see this
preview for some fonts you have more
than one preview
and you can select between them but for
this font we have only this regular
also down in here you can see the
license that you need to show somewhere
in your application for this simple
application i'm not going to do that
because this is not going to be a
commercial application
okay let's add this font into our
project by pressing ok you can see that
this category font has been added into
my font folder i believe this will have
a preview so if i click on that you can
see a preview of your font
now if i run my application i should see
this font instead of this amsterdam font
you can see that the font has been
applied successfully
for some fonts you may have different
styles for example regular or normal
italic bold and bold italic
let's quickly see a font that has those
styles and let's see how we can apply
those styles on our text views
so once again i'm going to
click on this drop down menu
and once again i'm going to click on
these more fonts
the font that i'm going to use in here
is called lobster 2.
if you click on that you can see that in
this preview pane you have four options
i'm going to add them one by one into my
project for the first one i'm going to
name it lobster to underline regular
and also i'm going to add it to my
project i'm not going to make a
downloadable font
let's press ok
and let's do the same for the other
three styles
you can see that now we have four
different lobster two fonts
if we want to apply them on our text
views we can do the same as we did for
the other fonts which we had only one
font
for example inside our text view
for this font family in here we can pass
the font manually
by specifying the name of our font
or we can pass this styling job to the
android for example we can add a text
style in here
and we can specify the style which can
be italic bold or normal
right now if i select text style as bold
and if i change this lobster to bolt
italic to
just lobster to regular
let's quickly do that
if i run my application i'm going to get
a bolder style for this specific font
let's quickly run that you can see that
we have this bold font but this in here
is not accurate because we have added a
style manually this actually in here is
using our
lobster 2 regular font and if we want to
use a specifically this lobster to bolt
font we can create a font family for
that
let's quickly see how we can create a
font family
so in my font resource folder i can
right click and by pressing new font
resource file
we can create a new font family
for the file name i'm going to put the
font name which in this case is lobster
2.
let's create that
inside this font family
i'm going to define four fonts
we need three attributes in here first
of all we are going to need the font
itself
for the first one i'm going to pass the
lobster to regular font
after that i'm going to pass a style for
this font let's say font style
you can see that in here we have two
styles italic and normal
in here i'm going to pass normal but if
you want to pass a bolder style you need
to pass that as a font weight let's
quickly see that we can see that we have
this font fade attribute in which we can
pass a number
basically for normal fonts this weight
should be 400 i will show a link for
where you can find the exact font weight
that you need
but for now let's just pass 400
and let's finish creating our font after
that i'm going to create three more font
elements and i'm going to pass the other
three fonts
let's say font
once again we need to address our font
this time let's say lobster to italic
for this style i'm going to say italic
this time
and once again because this is not a
bold font we are going to pass 400 as
the font weight
let's quickly add two more fonts for the
bold styles
you can see that for the normal bolt
font i fast normal as the font style
but for the italic one i passed italic
the only difference between a bolt and a
regular size font is in this weight for
the regular we have passed 400 but for
the bold ones we have passed 700
before we go further let's quickly see
where we can find the proper font weight
so if you search for font fade android
developer
you can see this font weight from the
developer.android.com let's quickly see
that
and in here inside this companion
properties
you can see different weights for
different fonts for example we have pass
400 for the regular fonts which is the
correct number
for the bold ones we also passed 700.
i believe in android you won't see much
difference if you pass for example 500
when the fonts are being rendered the
only difference is between this 400 and
so if you want you can check this web
page
okay let's switch back to android studio
now that we have created this font
family we can pass it in our activity
main.xml file but before that you can
see that we have a lot of warnings in
here
if we hover over one of them it says
that these attributes are only usable in
api level 26 and higher
so if your application is running on api
level lower than that
this font family won't be applied
i've seen that some people use app
namespace instead of this android for
example you can say app in here
of course you need to add the namespace
uh by pressing alt plus enter you can
see that this new namespace has been
added
i'm not going to talk about name spacing
here but basically it's like importing
in xml file in other programming
languages you also have namespaces
basically it will define that where this
app attribute is coming from
so some people are using this app
namespace they say that if you use this
app namespace instead of android the
font family will be applied in lower api
levels as well but honestly i didn't see
that difference
so i'm going to change this one back to
android
and in my
activitymain.xml file i'm going to pass
the font family
so in here instead of passing lobster to
regular i'm going to pass lobster 2
this xml file that we just created
and now this way we are passing the
styling job to the android system
so even though we are using this lobster
too because we have set a style to bold
in here
at the end our font is going to be
rendered to this lobster 2 bold let's
run our application and let's see if we
can see a bold font
you can see that we are seeing the bold
font once again the difference in here
is that this time we are using exactly
this uh lobster to bolt
but when we have passed lobster to
regular and we have set the style to
bolt only the android studio increase
the size sometimes there might be some
differences between different font
styles when the designer created the
font so this way of creating a font
family is much more accurate
okay just before finishing this video
i'm going to show you how you can apply
different fonts in java file for example
inside this layout file in the design
view i'm going to add a button
and by clicking on this button i'm going
to change the font of this text view
let's change the id of this button first
of all
to let's say btn change font
and also let's add some constraints
and let's change the text
i'm just going to say change
in our main activity first of all let's
initialize these two items
after that let's set an unclick listener
for our button
let's say that set on click listener new
on click listener
before this on click listener i'm going
to create a typeface and after that i'm
going to change the typeface of this
textview inside this unclick method so
above in here let's say typeface
you can see that it's coming from
android.graphics package
let's name it typeface is equal to in
here we are going to get a reference to
our font in our resources folder
if i try get resources in here let's
quickly see that
getresources.getfont
and if i pass my font address for
example if i say r dot font
dot let's say amsterdam
you can see that we are getting a red
warning in here and the warning says
that this method is only available in
api level 26 and higher
you can overcome this problem by using
resource compact instead of this get
resources method let's quickly see that
so in here i can say resource combat
dot get font
first of all we need a context which i'm
going to pass this
after that we need to address our font
let's say r dot font dot
amsterdam
so instead of get resources you can use
this resource compact which is a good
option for backward compatibility
after you have defined your typeface
inside the unclick method you can say
txt hello
dot set typeface
and you can pass your typeface
as simple as that you can change the
font of your text view let's run the
application and let's see if everything
is working fine
right now the font is lobster too if we
click on this button we can see that the
font is changing to amsterdam it seems
to be perfect
okay i think that's enough for this
video and also for that matter for this
section of the course
there are a lot more concepts and tools
that you have when you are designing
your layout files for example
you have navigation drawers you have
bottom navigation views you have
animations that you can apply in your
application
but i'm not going to talk about them in
this section of the course because there
are a lot more concepts that we don't
know anything about them yet
later on in the course we will see a lot
more tools for designing our layout
files
okay in the next video we are going to
have a quick challenge for this section
of the course so that we make sure we
have learned everything that we have
talked so far
see you in the next video
as i said at the end of the previous
video in this video we are going to have
a quick challenge the purpose of this
challenge is to make sure that we have
learned everything that we have talked
so far and here is our challenge i want
you to create this simple layout file
you can think of this layout file as a
simple registration form in which we are
receiving the user's name email password
gender and also country besides that we
have this image viewing here plus this
button which normally in a normal
application this button should navigate
us to the user's gallery or maybe the
camera in order to take a photo but
because we don't know anything about
that yet
this button and this image view are just
for showing purposes these are not going
to do anything just if you want you can
show a toast message after clicking on
this peak image button beside that we
have this license agreement text which
down below that you can see this
checkbox if everything works fine when
we click on the register we are going to
show a snack bar indicating that the
user has registered successfully but if
for example the user leaves one of these
edit texts empty you are going to show a
warning beside that we are going to make
sure that the user agrees to our license
agreement okay this is our challenge as
you can see this is a simple layout file
i'm sure that you can do it by yourself
but as you can see we are going to
practice a lot of things that we have
learned in this section of the course we
are going to work with a lot of ui
elements besides that as you can see we
are implementing material theming also
we are going to show snack bars and
beside that we are going to see how we
can initialize and work with our ui
elements in the java file feel free to
use any kind of layout file that you
want in order to design this simple
layout file in here i have used a
constraint layout but if you want you
can use linear layout or relative layout
okay pause the video in here and go
solve the challenge whenever you are
done come back to see my solution as
well
okay i hope you solved the challenge
let's quickly see my solution as well
i'm going to start by creating a new
project for the name of this project i'm
going to say ui challenge
i'm going to save with api level 19 in
this simple application it shouldn't
matter
okay let's start working on our layout
file but before that i'm going to close
all of my extra files and panes as i
said i'm going to work with constraint
layout but if you want you can work with
linear layout or relative layout before
everything let's remove this text view
and let's drag all of our items first of
all we need an image view for the image
profile for the sample data i'm going to
select one of the avatars we also need a
button
beside that we are going to need
material design components we will add
that in a minute but before that let's
quickly drag all of our ui elements we
need four edit texts in here the first
two are going to be plain text and the
next ones are going to be password the
first two are for the name and email
let's quickly add two passwords in here
the difference between this password and
this plain text edit text is that when
you type something inside the password
edit text it won't show the text itself
but you will see some dots also beside
that we need a text view for our gender
text
after that we need a radio group let's
quickly add that
inside this radio group we need 4 radio
buttons
also i'm not sure that if you have seen
this way of dragging radio buttons in
your radio group in the design view
previously we have seen how to add radio
buttons inside a radio group in the text
view but here is how you can do that in
the design view basically you can use
this component 3 for example i can drag
my radio buttons to inside this radio
group let's add two more
let's also quickly change the
orientation of this radio group let's
search for the orientation in the
attributes this one in here i'm going to
change it to horizontal beside that we
need a text view for the countries
and also we need a spinner in here for
selecting one of the countries let's
search for a spinner
let's quickly change the width of this
spinner to wrap content instead of match
parent this is not match parenting here
and it's just some dps we are going to
change that to wrap content also i think
it's better to put it above in here
beside our country's text and after
everything if you remember we had the
button let's quickly add that this is
going to be our button register beside
that we need a text view in here for our
license agreement
and also we needed a checkbox let's
search for checkbox
and let's change the checked value of
this checkbox to true let's search for
checked
or you can see that down in here also
i'm going to change the checked value of
this radio button to check as well
also let's quickly change the id of our
ui elements so that we can use them in
our java file i'm going to fast forward
the process of giving them an id
basically you can select your ui element
and you can change the attribute from
this top right pane in here
just to have a quick review let's
quickly see the idea of each one of them
because later on we are going to use
them in our java file this one is image
profile this one is btnp image edit text
name edit text email edit text password
edit text pass repeat txt gender this
one in here is rg gender for a radio
group the three radio buttons are named
rb male rb female and rb other this text
view is called txt country the spinner
is called a spinner country and this
button is btn register this text view in
here is called txt agreement and this
checkbox is called agreement check we
are also going to need four more text
views if you remember i said that when
we click on this register button we are
going to make sure that we have received
some input from the user and if for some
reason the user don't enter anything on
our edit text we are going to show some
warning and we are going to use text
views for those warnings so let's
quickly add four more text views
i'm going to add the warning for each
one of edit text above the edit text
let's quickly give some id to this for
example for the first one i'm going to
say txt var name
you can guess the rest of them this one
is txt one email this one txt barn pass
and the last one is txt var plus repeat
okay now that we have the id for all of
these ui elements let's quickly change
their initial values for example for
this text view i'm not going to change
anything but for this edit text i'm
going to delete the text and i'm going
to add a hint let's search for the hint
let's just say name
sometimes like this you can see some
options which can be annoying by
pressing the escape key on your keyboard
you can get rid of that suggestion let's
do the same thing for these three
remaining edit texts
for this text view i'm going to change
its value to
let's say gender
for the radio buttons let's change the
first one to
male the next one to female and the
other one i'm going to name other
this text view in here let's change it
to countries or country
let's change these buttons text to
peak image
and this one to
register also this checkbox too i agree
beside that we need to change the value
of this textview but we are going to do
that later on when we created our
constraints i'm not going to do anything
about this yet also i'm going to change
the color of these four warning text
views let's quickly do that let's search
for color
and let's change it to some red color i
think this one would be fine
now let's start constraining our ui
elements for example for this image view
i'm going to constrain it to the left of
my screen and also to the top of my
screen but of course i need some margin
i will add that in a minute beside that
the right of this image view to the left
of my button
and also the right of this button to the
right of my screen beside that i'm going
to constrain this button to the bottom
of my image view
similar thing for the top of my image
view also let's add some margin
for this image view for example margin
top let's say 32 i believe is fine and
let's move it to left
but as you can see when i move this
image view to left and this button do
not move i'm going to delete this right
constraint
and i'm going to drag it
from the left of this button to the
right of my image view now let's
constrain this image view to the right
of our screen
and now we can move it
it seems better now for these text views
first of all i'm going to add a
horizontal guideline so let's right
click on our layout and let's go to
these helpers and let's add horizontal
white line let's move this guideline
to somewhere about here i think it's
fine beside that we need a vertical
guideline let's quickly add that helpers
add vertical guideline and let's move it
a little bit now let's constraint our
edit texts for example this one to our
guideline
i'm going to constrain this text view to
this guideline as well
also i'm going to add a constraint from
the top of this edit text to the bottom
of this text view but as you can see
these are too close to each other what
you can do is that by pressing down the
ctrl key you can select both of them
and by right clicking you can use this
right click menu you can go to this
constraint let's say edit text name
let's say top to the bottom of our txt
warning name you can see that now we
have a constraint beside that i'm going
to add a constraint from the top of this
text view to our horizontal guideline so
once again let's select both of them and
let's right click constraint
dxd warning name top to bottom of our
guideline i think i'm going to remove
the margin in here you can see that we
have an 18 margin
let's decrease that to zero i believe is
fine let's do the same thing for the
rest of edit texts and text views
for these three remaining text views i'm
going to add a margin top to the top
edit text but i'm also going to add a
margin
let's right click constraint txt warning
email top to the bottom of our edit text
name let's see what is the margin in
here 15 i think i'm going to save it 60.
okay let's do the same thing for the
remaining two edit text and text views
you can see that everything looks better
now also if for any reason your computer
is slow you can always go to this eye
icon in here and you can disable this
live rendering or alternatively you can
work with the blueprint view which you
can show from this blueprint option in
here
let's quickly see that you can work with
this one as well but like before i'm
going to save it the design view okay
let's add a constraint for this gender
text first of all i'm going to
constraint it to the top of this edit
text
constraint txt gender top 2 let's say
bottom of our edit text let's also add a
margin
i think a margin
24 would be fine it seems too much let's
say 60. let's also add a margin to the
left of our screen let's add a margin in
here as well
for the radio group i'm going to select
the radio group from this component tree
for the left constraint i'm going to add
it to this guideline
also i'm going to add a constraint from
the top of this radio group to the
bottom of this gender text view once
again i'm going to use the right click
menu let's say constraint it seems like
i didn't select the radio group you can
always use this component 3 if you want
let's select both of them let's right
click constraint let's say radio group
gender top to bottom of our txt gender
that seems to be better let's also add a
margin
i think 16 would be fine for the country
text i'm going to do the same thing
for the left margin let's say 16 let's
constraint it to our radio group
constraint txt country top to
the bottom of our radio group for the
margin let's say 16 once again
for the spinner i'm going to constraint
it to the right of my country text view
and also its bottom and top to the
bottom and top of this country text view
as well but of course we need a margin
left
let's quickly add that
for this register button i'm going to
constraint it to the three edges of my
screen
but i need a margin button
let's add 32 for example i think that's
fine for this text view i'm going to add
another guideline in here let's quickly
add that
i'll first add a vertical guideline i'm
going to move this guideline let's move
it to somewhere about here and let's
constraint our text view to this one in
here
for the top i'm going to constraint it
to the vertical guideline
let's also constrain this checkbox
i'm also going to constrain the top of
this checkbox to the bottom of our
textview let's add another guideline in
here this one is going to be a
horizontal guideline
and let's move it down below this edit
text now i'm going to add a constraint
from the bottom of this checkbox to the
to this horizontal guideline it seems
like we don't have a proper constraint
in here for that i'm going to delete
this top constraint you can delete the
constraint by selecting the constraint
and pressing down the delete key let's
also add a constraint from and the
bottom of this text view
to the bottom horizontal guideline
also i'm going to move it a little bit
above
that seems better now let's also change
the text of this text view and also
let's change the visibility of this for
warning text to gone first of all let's
add the text for this text view
but you can see that as soon as i type
the text view in here the text of our
text view somehow occupies other layout
files and also it doesn't fit on the
screen if you want to fix that you can
click on these two arrow in here and you
can change the constraint to a match
constraint but we also need a margin
let's quickly add 8 in here
also for the right
okay that seems better also i think it's
better to move this checkbox to above a
little bit let's click on that
and let's move it above
okay that seems better let's quickly
change the visibility of these four
warning text views as well let's search
for visibility
and let's change it to gun similarly for
the next three text views
but now that i've done that you can see
that we have two small margins we can
increase that
for example let's say 18 here
similarly for the next two edit text
sorry for the repetition
okay that's about the size of our layout
file we also need to add some entry for
our spinner let's quickly add them in
our strings values in our resources in
values folder inside the strings i'm
going to add an array string let's say
array
let's name it countries
and let's add our items
now in our activity main.xml file we can
pass this as the entries of our spinner
let's search for entries
and let's address our countries array
okay that seems better beside that for
this image view we also need a source
let's search for sourcing here
for some reason we can't see source in
here let's switch to text view or this
split view
and let's add it in here let's say
source
and let's pass this mid map file that we
have in our project before testing the
application let's quickly add the
material design theme for that i'm going
to go to material.io
let's go to this developed app we have
seen all of this before in this android
in the documentation getting started
down in here you can see the dependency
let's quickly add that
in our project gradle scripts
build.gradle module app
down in here inside the dependencies
let's add that we also need to add a
version in here which as you can see in
the warning the latest version is 1.1.0
let's sync our project and let's go to
our styles and change the theme of our
application i'm going to delete this
theme in here
and i'm going to use
theme.materialcomponents.light this one
we have used this previously in previous
videos let's switch back to our activity
main file you can see that the style of
our buttons has changed
let's quickly test everything i'm going
to run the application on pixel 3 api 29
it seems like we have done a relatively
good job
we just need to increase the size of
this image view for that i'm going to
change the width and height of this
image view i'm going to add them
manually let's save 130 dp i think that
would be fine
let's run the application once again if
you want you can also decrease the size
of this text view as well yes that seems
to be better your design might be
different than mine
it's okay it's probably better than me
i'm not a designer but we just wanted to
practice everything that we have learned
okay i think that's enough for this
video in the next video we are going to
switch to our java file and we are going
to work on the logic of our application
see you in the next video
in the previous video we have created
this layout file which isn't that bad in
this video we are going to work on the
java file and the logic for this
application so for that let's switch to
our mainactivity.java file and let's
close our layout file first of all in
here i'm going to initialize all of my
ui elements before that let's quickly
add a log i believe it will be useful
let's say private edit text
we had four edit texts
i'm going to fast forward the process of
defining and initializing these ui
elements you can see that it's very
boring
i'm also going to define a constraint
layout element in here let's say private
constraint layout
i'm going to name it parent i believe
later on we will use this constraint
layout to show a snack bar i also need
to give an id to my constraint layout so
for that let's switch to our
activitymain.xml file in our split view
in the parent constraint layout i'm
going to give it an id let's say id
i'm going to say parent okay now let's
initialize all of these ui elements i'm
going to do that inside another method
let's name that method in its views
first of all let's create that method
down in here private void init views
first of all let's add a log let's say
it started let's minimize this project
vein and let's initialize once again i'm
going to
fast forward the process of initializing
these ui elements
i think i have a typo in here when i
have set an id for this vtn register
let's quickly fix that in our layout
file if i click on this register button
and here you can see my typo sorry for
that i also need to change it in here
okay now that we have initialized all of
our views i'm going to set an unclick
listener first of all for my btn peak
image i'm talking about this one in here
so after this method i'm going to say
btnp image
dot set on click listener new
onclicklistener let's just show a toast
message
we haven't seen how to pick an image for
example from a gallery or for that
matter to take a picture using the
device's camera for that we are just
going to show this toast message after
that let's define an onclicklistener for
our btn finish or btn register i believe
i named it set unclick listener neo i
click this layer i'm going to do the job
inside another method let's say init
register
let's create that method down in here
let's say private void
we need register
once again let's add a log
let's say start in here first of all i'm
going to check that if the user has
entered all of the data for that i'm
going to say if i'm going to create
another method i will create that in a
minute but let's say if validates data
if that's the case we are going to
continue let's quickly create this
method down in here and let's see what
we are going to do inside this method
private the return type is going to be a
boolean let's say private boolean
validate data
once again let's add a log
let's say if edit text
name.gettext
dot to a string
if it's equal to
an empty string
first of all we are going to show the
warning text so let's say txt warning
txd warning name
dot set visibility
let's pass visible
i believe we have seen this previously
in the course after that we are going to
return false it means that we didn't
validate the data so we shouldn't
continue our code in this method inside
this if statement let's create three
more if statement for the other three
edit texts
if edittextemail.gettext.js
is equal to an empty string
txt warning email
dot set visibility
once again visible
also we need to return false in here as
well
also in each one of these cases before
returning false we are going to change
the text of our txt warning because if
you remember
in the layout file we didn't change the
text of that burning text view so i can
say txt warning name for example dot set
text
let's just say enter your name
similarly for the other three cases
and after all of these if statements
after all of these cases if we reach to
this point we are going to return true
it means that the user has entered all
of the data so inside this validate data
method we are validating that the user
field all of the blanks after that
inside this init register method inside
this if statement we are going to check
that if the user agrees to our license
agreement so let's say if agreement
check
dot is checked this option in here if
that's the case we are going to continue
but in the else case we are just going
to show a toast message
let's say you need to agree to the
license agreement
but if the user reaches to this point
where the user enters all of the data
and also agree to the license agreement
we are going to show a snack for let's
do that in another method let's say show
snack form
let's create that method down in here
private void
sure snackbar
once again add a log
and down in here inside this method
first of all we need to change the
visibility of all of our warning texts
because those warnings are no longer
valid so let's say txt warning name dot
set visibility
let's say gone this time let's do the
same thing for the other three remaining
burning texts
after that we need to show our snack bar
if you remember we can do something like
this we can say
snackbar.make first of all we need to
pass our constraint layout which is our
parent in this case after that we need
to text in here right now i'm going to
show a dummy text for example i'm going
to say user registered but later on i
will change this text for example i will
show the details of the newly registered
user for now let's say user registered
after that we need a constant for the
length of our sniper i'm going to say
snagboard.length indefinite let's also
define an action button for our snagbar
i'm going to say that set action
for the text i'm just going to say
dismissed
let's also create an unclick listener
let's say neo and click listener for the
time being i'm not going to do inside
this onclick method later on we will
clear our edit texts let's finish
creating our snack bar but before that
we just need to show it
let's say dot show let's run the
application and let's see if we have
write everything correctly first of all
let's click on this big image button we
should see a toast message you can see
that yet to be talked about
let's enter some data and let's register
a new user let's say may sound
let's add an email
let's enter a password
let's retype our passport
we also need to check that if these two
are the same i forgot to do that i will
do that after the testing of this phase
of the application before registering
the user i'm going to uncheck this
license agreement checkbox let's say
register you can see that you need to
agree to the license agreement let's
check it once again and let's register
this time we should see the snack bar
user registered it seems like our
application is working fine if we press
dismiss
the snag bar will be dismissed also
let's delete this email in here
and let's see if we get the warning text
if we click on this register button you
can see that enter your email we are
successfully validating our data if we
enter an email in here for example
maysam at gmail.com
and if we click on the register button
we should see that the email warning
text disappears okay now i'm going to
change the application first of all i'm
going to check that these two are the
same after that i'm also going to empty
all of these four edit texts when i
click on this dismiss button so that we
can add a new user also i'm going to
change the text of this snag bar to the
details of our newly registered user
let's quickly do that first of all
inside this validate data method i'm
going to add another if case let's say
if edit text password this one dot get
text dot to string
if that's equal to our edit text
password repeat.gettext.2string
if that's the case or let's change our
logic let's say if that's not the case
first of all we are going to change the
visibility of this txt warning password
repeat and after that we are going to
return false let's say txt warning
password repeat dot set visibility let's
say visible after that i'm going to
change the text i'm going to say txt
warning repeat dot set text
let's say password doesn't match
and after that i'm going to return false
okay now that we have validated this
data successfully let's go to this
onclick method and in here let's clear
our edit texts i'm going to say
edittextemail or edittextname.settext
let's just pass an empty string
similarly for the other three edit text
next thing that i'm going to do is that
i'm going to change the text of this
snack bar first of all i'm going to
create that text above in here inside
this snack bar method before everything
i'm going to get the user's data for
example let's say string name
is equal to edittextname.gettext.2string
similarly for the email i'm going to say
string email
is equal to edittextemail.gettext
dot to string
i'm also going to get the user's gender
and also country let's say a string
country is equal to countries spinner
dot get
selected item dot to string for getting
the user's gender i'm going to create a
switch statement before that i'm going
to create a string
let's say string gender
is equal to an empty string after that
let's create a switch statement
on our radio group or radiogroup gender
dot get checked radio button id let's
say in case it's r dot id dot radio
button mail
we are going to change the value of this
uh gender string let's say gender is
equal to
male sorry about that let's also add a
break in here
another case r dot id dot female
let's say gender is equal to female
this default case should never happen
but just for security purposes if
something goes wrong i'm assigning
unknown to the gender string so after
the switch statement we have all of the
data about our user now we can create
the text that we want to show inside
this smack bar let's say a string
a snag text
is equal to and let's create our text
first of all i'm going to say name
plus the name that we created or we got
from the edit text name after that i'm
going to add a backslash n in order to
go to the next line
let's say email plus the email
once again a backslash n
let's also show the gender and country
let's say gender
plus the gender
once again backslash n and also let's
show the country
now that we have created this text we
can show it in our snack box so this
time instead of this text i'm going to
say snack text let's run the application
once again and let's see if we have
fixed our application successfully let's
test the different cases first of all
let's check that if we see the warning
if we enter different passwords in these
two edit texts
in the password field i'm going to enter
one two three four five six but in the
re-enter password edit text i'm going to
say one two three four five if we click
on this register button we should see
the warning text password doesn't match
okay let's add six in here now they do
match let's change the country to for
example switzerland and also let's
change the gender in here to female and
let's see if we can register a new user
in here you can see that we are seeing
the snack ticks that we have created but
we are not seeing all of it we are
seeing only the first two line if you
want to change the maximum line
attribute of your snack board you can do
that first of all you need to get the
instance of your snack bar after that
you need to get the text view of your
snack bar and after that you can change
the max line attribute on your text view
this way you can overwrite the maximum
line attribute of the text view of your
snack bar but that seems like a lot of
work and we are not going to do that in
here we will do that later on in the
course in other places when we use a
snack bar but in here if you want to
make sure that you have created your
snack text successfully you can simply
log it for example in here i'm going to
add a log let's say log d let's say
slack for text
and let's pass our snag text but before
i run my application and test this i'm
going to click on this dismiss button if
you remember we write the logic so that
we clear all of our edit text let's
click that and you can see we are now
ready to register a new user let's run
the application once again and let's
test this snack text for that i'm going
to open the logcat let's enter some data
in here
and let's click on this register you can
see the snack text in here name mesa
email messam gmail.com gender male
country norway it seems like we have
created our text successfully okay i
think that's enough for this video i
hope that you have solved the challenge
in the next section of the course we are
going to create the first of four of our
applications now we know about java now
we know about user interface and in the
next section of the course we are going
to combine these two and we are going to
create our first real world application
beside practicing everything that we
have learned so far we are also going to
learn a lot of new stuff as well so stay
tuned for the next section of the course
and as always see you in the next video
what's up everyone i hope you are having
fun before we start creating our sample
application i would like to remind you
that there is an extended version of
this course that you can watch by
enrolling in the extended course you
will have lifetime access to more than
60 hours of videos you can ask your
questions directly from me and i will
come back to you within hours you will
have access to all of the source codes
that i write in the videos and also you
can have access to all of the new videos
that i upload just check out maiko.org
for more details about the course and
don't forget to use freecodecamp as the
coupon code to get 20 discount if you
want to get serious in android app
development taking the extended course
is almost a necessity okay everyone i
just wanted to remind you that there is
an extended version of this course that
you can take without further ado let's
start creating our sample application
have fun learning
hello everyone and welcome back in this
section of the course we are going to
create the first application of the for
real world application that i promised
it's important to say that in creating
this application besides practicing
everything that we have talked so far we
are also going to learn a lot of new
stuff you will see them in action when
we create the application
okay now let's talk about the
application itself we are going to
create an application that will help the
user to manage his or her library
in this application we are going to show
a list of different books to the user
and the user can see the details of that
book later on if the user wants he or
she can add that book to different lists
for example a list that indicates that
the user has already read this book or
maybe a wish list or also a favorite
list
we will see all of them later on in the
course
in the process of creating this
application we are going to practice all
of our knowledge about user interface
and java
and beside that we are going to learn
about a lot of new concepts
after watching this section of the
course you can change the application
that we create together and you can even
publish it in the player store so i
highly suggest that you watch this
section of the course and don't skip it
okay without more talking let's create
our project and let's start writing our
application
i'm going to start with empty activity
as before
let's change the name of this
application to my library
for the other fields in here i'm not
going to change anything for the package
name once again i'm going to put my
website name in backward
org.maycode.projectname which is my
library
the save location is fine language is
java and we are going to save it api
level 19 for the minimum sdk
we are also not using the support
library so i'm not going to check this
option in here let's create our project
and let's start working on our layout
file
before everything i'm going to add the
material design library dependencies
into my projects because we are going to
need them for that let's go to
material.io
let's go to this develop tab
let's select android from here
documentation getting started
let's copy this line of code
we have done this previously so i'm not
going to explain it in here
in our gradle scripts build.gradle
module app in the dependencies let's add
that
and also the latest version is 1.1.0
so let's change this one
and let's sync our project
it seems like we have added the material
components successfully
first of all let's change the style of
our application
in values styles.xml
instead of this appcompat theme i'm
going to use
theme.materialcomponents.lite let's
close this
and let's switch to our
activitymain.xml file
our application is going to have
multiple pages later on we will see how
we can create multiple pages or to be a
specific multiple activities but for now
this is going to be the first page or
the first activity of our application
and let's quickly design that
first of all i'm going to have a text
view
for the name of this application
after that i'm going to add a few
buttons
one for the list of all books i'm going
to show the list of all of books by
clicking on this button
i'm going to add five more buttons and i
will talk about them
let's also add an image view above in
here for our logo
for now i'm going to stay with one of
our avatars
and also i'm going to add a text view in
here for licensing
let's give some ideas to our elements
for this one i'm going to name it img
logo because it's going to be our logo
for the text view i'm going to say txt
name
but i'm not sure that we need an id for
this one this button in here
is going to show a list of all of our
books so let's say btn all books
also let's change its text to show all
books or see all books
beside that i don't like that this text
is in all caps if you want you can
change that
you need to search for all caps
this text all caps
and you can change its value
let's change it to false now you can see
that this text is much more better
for the second button i'm going to
change its id to btn currently reading
because this button is going to show the
list of the books that the user is
currently reading let's say btn
currently reading
and let's change the text to currently
reading books as well
like before let's change the text all
caps value to false as well
for the third button i'm going to change
its id to btn already red because this
button is going to show the list of
books that the user already read
so let's say btn already read
let's change the text to
already red box
once again let's change the text all
caps attribute to false
for the fourth button i'm going to
change its id to btn one to read book
let's say btn
want to read
because this button is going to show the
list of different books that the user
wants to list basically this is the wish
list
let's also change the text
let's say your wish list
let's change the all caps attribute
that seems better the fifth button i'm
going to change its id to btn favorite
box
let's say btn favorite
and for its text i'm going to say
see your favorites
once again let's change the all caps
attribute
and for the last button i'm going to
change its id to btn about by clicking
on this uh about button we are going to
show a dialog in which we'll show some
information about this application
let's say btn about
and let's change its text to about
for this button i'm not going to change
its all caps attribute because i think
it's better this way
let's also give an id to this textview
as well
let's say txt license
i'm going to change its text to
developed by masam at mako.org
i'm also going to change the style of
this book to italic
let's search for a text style
let's change this font to italic
also let's change the text of the first
text view to the name of our application
i'm just going to put
my library in here
later on we will change the font of this
text view as well
okay let's add our constraints
also you can see that i'm using the
constraint layout in here but feel free
to use the relative layout or linear
layout
i'm more comfortable with constraint
layout so i'm using constraint layout
let's add our constraints
i'm going to add a margin top of maybe
70 db for this image view but before
that i'm going to move my text view
because right now i cannot see that
okay now let's add the margin top
i think 50db would be better
now let's constraint our textview to the
bottom of our imageview
and also to the both side of our screen
we also need a margin top
i think once again 50 db would be fine
it seems too much let's say
40 db
let's constraint all of these buttons
for this one i'm going to constraint it
to the bottom of my text view and also
to both side of my screen
i need a margin top let's say 30db
after that let's constrain the second
one i'm going to fast forward the
process in here
sometimes like this if the items are too
close to each other as before we can
select both of the items and by
right-clicking we can use this right
click menu
let's say btn currently reading top two
bottom uh btn all blocks
let's add a margin in here by selecting
our button
margin top i think 16 would be fine
it seems too much let's say 10 db
also for the second one
for this last text viewing here first of
all i'm going to constraint it to the
bottom of my screen
and also beside that i'm going to
constraint it to the both edges of my
screen so that it would be centered
also let's add a margin bottom of maybe
16 db that seems better
for this image view i'm not going to use
a sample data instead i'm going to show
the actual image
i have prepared an image in here on my
desktop let's use that i'm going to copy
this image
let's add it into our mid map folder
resources mipmap
right click and paste
i think the name is fine
and let's switch to our split view
for this image view if you click on that
first of all let's delete this last
attribute this tool source combat
and instead of that let's use source
let's address the image that we just
added into our project
it seems too large
we need to pass the width and height
manually
let's say 150 dp i think that's fine
and also 150 db for the height
that seems a little bit better
for this my library if you remember we
had an attribute called font family
let's search for that in the design view
front family
if you click on this arrow more fonts
let's search for a good font once again
these are the google fonts and you can
use them in your projects free of charge
i think this lemon font is good let's
add phone to our project and let's press
ok
you can see that the font has changed
let's also increase the size a little
bit
let's search for text size and instead
of 14 sp
let's say 18 sp
that seems better
the next thing that i'm going to change
in this layout file is the bits of all
of these buttons
i want my buttons to have the same bits
right now you can see that these have an
ugly shape
if we click on one of our buttons now
let's switch to a split view
once again let's click on that
for the width if we say 200 dp i think
that would be fine yes
for all of our buttons for the bits i'm
going to say 200 dp
you can see that it's much better now
okay this is going to be the layout for
the first page of our application let's
quickly initialize the necessary items
in our java file
by pressing double shift you can search
for mainactivity.java file
and in here let's initialize our ui
elements
let's also initialize these buttons down
below inside this oncreate method
i'm going to do that inside another
method let's say initial views
and let's create that method by pressing
alt plus enter
once again i'm going to fast forward the
process of initializing these buttons
by clicking on each one of these buttons
beside this python about i'm going to
navigate the user to another activity
up until this point our applications had
only one activity which was named main
activity
but if we want we can create another
activity in our application as well
we are going to talk about activities
and fragment in the next video but
creating an activity is really simple
there are a lot more concepts regarding
activities we will talk about them later
on but in here if you want to create an
activity
you can do something like this
in your project inside java folder
inside your project folder you can right
click on that
by saying new activity
in here you can see that you have few
options
the names of some of these activities
may be familiar from that gallery view
from where we created our project
but basically in here we need this empty
activity you can also select this
gallery in which you will get the same
dialog when you created your application
let's select empty activity once again
in here we can name our activities the
convention in here is that to use the
keyword activity in naming and also
you cannot use spaces and also other
strange characters
for the name of this activity in here
i'm going to name it all books activity
because this is going to be the activity
that we are going to navigate the user
when the user clicks on that see all
books button
so let's say all books activity
you can also see a checkbox in here it
says that if you want to generate a
layout file for your activities
it is possible to create an activity
with only the java file and not the xml
file
we will talk about that in the next
section of the course but in here we do
need a layout file so i'm going to leave
this one checked in here
you can see that when i change the name
of my activity also the layout name
changed as well in the layout name you
cannot use upper cases letter
and as you can see all the letters
change to lowercases beside that you
cannot have a spaces
you have another option in here to
indicate that if this activity is going
to be a launcher activity basically in
every application one of the activities
can be launcher
right now the launcher activity in our
application is this main activity it
means that when we launch our
application and this main activity is
going to be shown
and for that i'm not going to check this
option in here
also if you don't check this option in
here if you change your mind you can
change it in your manifest file later
but more on that later on in the course
the package name is fine we are going to
create this activity in our package
and for the language of this activity
once again i'm going to use java
let's finish creating our activity
and let's see what happened in our
project
so first of all a new java class has
been added into our package you can see
that we have this all box activity.java
file
beside that in our resources folder in
the layout folder
we have this activity all books.xml
both of this has been created by the
android studio
beside that if you take a look at your
manifest file this androidmanifest.xml
you can see that in here we have a new
line we have a new activity tag in our
application tag
it means that now our application has
two activities
if you want to create your activities
yourself without the help of android
studio that is possible basically you
can create a java file after that you
can create a new layout file and beside
all of these you need to add this tag
into your application tag inside the
manifest file
also you need to link the java file and
layout file in your oncreate method we
will take a look at that in a minute
but instead of all of these we have used
the help of android studio okay let's
close this manifest file and let's
switch to activity allbox.xml file
you can see that in here we have another
layout in which we can design for this
activity
in this video i'm not going to design
the layout for this activity instead i'm
just going to change its background
color
if we switch to a split view in here
once again you can see that we have a
constraint layout
and inside the opening tag of this
constraint layout i'm going to say
background
and i'm going to pass a color
for example i think i'm going to pass
this
color accent
i'm doing this because i'm just going to
indicate that we have
navigated the user from the main
activity to this outbox activity okay
now let's see how we can navigate the
user let's close both of these files
this all books activity.xml file and
also this outbox activity.java file
i said that we are going to navigate the
user to the other activity by clicking
on this btn outbox activity so we need
to create an onclicklistener in here
let's say btnrbox.set
let's pass neon click listener
and inside this unclick method is the
place to write the logic to navigate the
user
in here i'm going to use an object that
i have never used so far and that object
is called intent
you can see that it's coming from
android.content package let's import
that
let's name it intent is equal to new
intent
it's a simple java class that we have
defined it's like any other java class
the constructor of this intent
needs two things first of all we need to
pass a context in here
because we are inside this main activity
and hopefully by now we know that
activities are context
we need to pass mainactivity.this
let's pass that mainactivity.this
after that we need to pass the
destination activity
where you want to navigate the user to
for example i can say all books activity
dot class
so this way we are saying that this
intent is going to navigate us from the
main activity to all books activity
after that when we created our intent we
can call an inner method in here called
startactivity
you can see that this startactivity
needs an intent
and we can pass our intent safely this
start activity is an inner method like
this find view by id which exists inside
every activity
now if we run our application we should
see that when we click on this button
the user will be navigated to all books
activity let's quickly test that
right now you can see that we have few
issues with our layout first of all we
cannot see this license text view
for that we need to decrease the margins
from here
and also beside that
this currently reading box text does not
fit in our button we will increase the
bits of all of our buttons as well
but for now if we click on this see all
books button
we can see that we are navigating to the
other activity
beside that if we press this back button
once again we will be navigated to our
main
activity it seems to be working perfect
let's quickly fix the issues with our
layout and let's finish off this video
in our
activitymain.xml file first of all let's
decrease the margins
for example this margin top i'm going to
change it to 30 dp
beside that margin top of this my
library text
let's decrease that to 30 dp
that seems better
for all of my buttons
instead of 200 dp i'm going to say 230
dp
for example for the first one
let's say 230 db
let's run the application once again and
let's see if we have fixed the issues
successfully
the layout seems better okay i think
that's enough for this video just before
i finish off i'm going to say that you
can check the source code for this
application at mako.org code so feel
free to check that if you need i upload
the source code at the end of every
video
also would be very happy to see your
feedback okay in the next video first of
all we are going to create a model for
our books beside that we will create a
recyclerview and recyclerviewadapter to
show a list of different books inside
the second activity
see you in the next video